great you made it to day 4 of software
development week by simply learn let's
have a quick recap of the previous
sessions on the day one we learn the
data structures the building blocks of
software development
day two is where we learn the logic of
devising solutions to the problems using
algorithms day 3 was very exciting as we
learn a programming language all
together and explore the object-oriented
programming concepts
don't worry if you missed out on the
previous sessions
those will be available on our official
youtube channel the link to which is in
the description box below
brilliant now the next step is really
crucial as we are entering into the core
software development but before that i
would recommend you to be comfortable
with java
so taking into consideration the
importance of java programming language
for software development
we have dedicated our fourth session to
help you improvise your java programming
skills
in this session we will learn core java
where we will be dealing with object
oriented programming concepts in java
the exception handling concepts and much
more by the end of the day we can assure
you that you would have some sound
understanding of code java concepts
without any further ado our experts will
take over the session now
hello guys this is vikesh and let's get
started with the first topic of this
series which is about introduction to
java so when we talk about java it is
one of the most popular programming
language out there and it was created
way back in 1991 but it was publicly
released only in 1995.
it was developed by one of the famous
developers of our generation who is
james gosling at sun microsystems and
then later java was acquired by oracle
and today oracle owns java java is very
simple and easy to use and we will look
at different aspects of how it is easy
and simple to use it's a write once run
anywhere type of programming language
again we will look at details into into
into this particular concept as well and
when we talk about the usage of java you
can use it to build web applications
mobile applications desktop applications
even command line applications and at
the same time you can also use it to
build complex applications like gaming
applications building microservices or
building distributed computing etc let's
talk about the features of java so one
of the most prominent features of java
is that it's an object oriented
programming language which means that
everything which happens in java happens
around objects
objects enable the execution of the
program objects talk to each other to
exchange data and messages we will look
at a look at the concept of objects in
details in the upcoming lectures
it's a platform independent language
which means that
again going back to the previous point
of write once run anywhere
it basically enables the program to be
run on any platform once compiled so
once you have prepared your program and
you have compiled your program then your
compile program can be run on any
platform it is a strong type checking
language which means that it will
force you to respect the contracts of
the variables to the data types for
example if you have created a collection
which should accept strings
then
you can only insert strings in that
collection and it will not allow you to
add an a number or an integer into that
collection so it's a strongly type
checking language so when you run your
program it's a two-step process in java
you compile the program and then you it
then you execute the program which we
also call as interpretation so you have
a java compiler
and you have a java interpreter you
first compile your program and then you
run the program using the help of java
interpreter java also provides automatic
garbage collection it's a really
important feature and if you talk about
the languages prior to java like c or c
plus plus they did not offer this
capability and this capability made java
really popular because it could
automatically find the unused objects
and variables and remove them from the
memory to free up memory space for the
program execution it also provides
multi-threading support which means that
you can build multi-threading
applications like a gaming application
if you take the example of a racing game
for example so
there's they can be one thread which is
monitoring your leaderboard score there
can be another thread which is
displaying the speed of the car there
displaying the graphic there can be
another thread which is displaying the
sound so you see all of these threads
are working parallelly and java provides
the support to create such applications
using the multi-threading capability it
has
java is secure by default
because there are no pointers in java so
there are no possibilities of having any
memory leaks or any reference leaks from
the application again if you take the
example of programming languages like c
or c plus plus you had the concept of
pointers and we we witnessed a lot of a
lot of scenarios and a lot of incidents
where there was a memory leakage
happening in the in the production
application which was which was really a
bad experience for the organizations so
java removed the concept of pointers
totally from its programming language
it's also a very robust language because
it provides a really great exception
handling framework out of the box
which developers can use and implement
to build really resilient applications
so now let us understand how a java
program is run so at first you basically
write your java program
and you store your java program into a
dot java file then you compile your java
file with the help of the java compiler
once the program is compiled the
compiler is going to generate another
file which is a dot class file and this
dot class file is basically the compiled
file or also known as the byte code file
so this byte code or the dot class file
code can be run on any platform be it a
linux platform or a windows platform or
a mac os platform or any other platform
to give you some more context the first
two steps where you write your java
program and you compile your java
program can be run on any machine let's
take the example that you ran these two
steps on a windows machine so you ran
your you write your program and you
compiled your program on a windows
machine which generated a dot class file
then you transported this dot class file
to a linux machine and it also worked
there you transported your class file to
a mac os machine and it worked there as
well and that's what brings the platform
independence concept of java that you
can write the program once
on any platform and once you have the
bytecode available then you can run this
program on any other platform of your
choice
okay so that was about how the java
program execution works and how the
platform independence is actually
achieved now let us spend some time to
understand the anatomy of java so once
you download java and install java on
your local machine you will hear the
term jdk actually if you will see that
in the next lecture that when you try to
download the java it will say jdk
download jdk stands for java development
kit so the java development kit is the
installation of the java this is what
you're going to install on your machine
once the jdk or java development kit has
been installed the jdk will provide lot
of other components as well like java
runtime environment or jre java virtual
machine or jvm some class libraries and
some other supporting libraries so let
us understand what happens when your
program is run and how these components
work together to make sure that your
program runs as expected let's start
from here so you install jdk or the java
development kit you write your program
and then you compile your program with
the help of java compiler which is
provided by jdk once the program is
compiled your dot class file will be
generated and then you can
run that dot class file using gre in
fact if you just run your program on
your local machine jre will
automatically kick in and run your dot
class file so the java runtime
environment or jre runs your dot class
file with the help of these three
components
let's talk about first component which
is java virtual machine or jvm so the
java virtual machine is actually the
virtual environment inside which your
program runs this is the real main
environment inside your dot class file
is running so when
when this program is running how does it
achieves this environment
for achieving this virtual virtual
machine environment it would need some
runtime libraries and that is provided
by these class libraries for example
there would be a runtime jar or rt.jar
as a shorthand which will be supplied to
the program at the runtime to make sure
that the program runs smoothly then
there are other supporting libraries as
well which your program may be using for
example if this program this dot class
file is let's say a calculator program
then it might be using a square root
function from java.math package so how
do how does the java.math package gets
supplied at runtime it would be supplied
by the other supporting libraries which
are present inside gre so gre will make
sure that your program runs inside the
java virtual machine it gets the
required runtime libraries and it also
gets the libraries which are referred in
your program at runtime and this all
together will make sure that your
program is running so you can see jdk
basically
provides gre automatically and jvm
automatically but you can also install
gre separately if you talk about that
use case where you compile your program
on a windows machine using jdk and then
you exported your dot class file to
another machine and there you just
installed the gre you don't install jdk
there you just installed the runtime
environment and you can run the dot
class file just using the runtime
environment and that brings us to the
end of this lecture let's get started
with installing java we will basically
look at how we can install java on a
windows machine so the first step to
install java is to download it from the
official oracle website so for that
let's open a web browser and let's type
jdk
java download and hit enter then you
need to find the link which says
oracle.com because like we discussed in
the previous lecture uh java is owned by
oracle so we need to download it from
the official website only so we can
click on this link which says java se
downloads it will bring us to the
downloads page and we will see different
versions of java you can see the java sc
15 you can see java se14 you can also
see java sc 11 and all the previous
versions
under another thing which you will
notice that it says lts here which means
long term support basically long term
support are the releases for which
oracle is going to provide
long term security patches and updates
for the non lts releases java will not
provide long term support and long term
patch fixes and long term security fixes
so it's a good idea to analyze and
evaluate on which version you want to
develop your applications on for this
demo i think it is fine we can go with
the non-lts version and even for your
for your customer facing applications
you can start with a non lts version and
then upgrade to the latest lts version
whenever that is available so for this
demo we can download java se15 and you
can also do the same on your machine it
will work exactly the same way as an lts
works
so you can click on the jdk download
option here
let's click on that it is going to bring
up the downloads detail page and you can
see uh there are multiple options given
here uh in terms of what platform you
want to install java on whether it is a
linux platform or it is a mac os machine
or it is a windows platform so like i
said in the beginning of the demo that
today we are going to see how we can
install this on a windows machine so i
am going to download the windows x64
installer here if you are working on a
linux machine or a macos machine you can
download those respective installers as
well so you can see the exe here so
let's click on this
once we click on this we'll get this
pop-up which will ask us to accept the
oracle technology network license
agreement so we can hit this check box
and click on download jdk 15 and this
shall start the download and you will
see some some exe getting downloaded in
in your download box here but as the
download is going to take some time and
uh i'm not going to wait for that and
that's the reason i have already
downloaded the jdk 15 for this
particular demo and that jdk is is
sitting here on my desktop which i have
downloaded prior to this demo so we'll
just run this particular exe which is
exactly the same exe as the one which is
being downloaded so let us double click
on this it will ask you for this pop-up
in some cases so you can just hit yes
basically it is asking whether you trust
this exe or not but as we downloaded
this from official oracle website then
we can trust this particular exe so i
will hit yes
and now the installer is going to unpack
and you might get a screen like this
which will be an installation wizard for
the java sc development kit 15. another
thing which before i proceed i just
wanted to highlight that as well that
you might have noticed about jdk here
it's exactly the same term which we
covered in the last lecture that when
you install java you basically install
the jdk which is the java development
kit and this is also visible here when
it says java sc development kit 15. so
let's hit next
then on this particular page you have
the option to change the installation
location of java if you want to by
default it is going to install in c
program files slash java jdk 15 but if
you want to change the location and you
want to install java to a particular
custom location of your choice that is
also possible you just hit change here
and then you can choose whatever
directory or folder or place you want to
install this
java on and you can
basically select the appropriate
location for this particular case i
don't want to change that i'm happy with
the default location which is available
here so i'm just going to proceed with
this particular location here so i will
just hit next
and then java is going to install and
it's it's very fast installation it
generally takes few seconds as you will
see in this demo basically it is going
to unpack all the all the libraries and
all the runtime libraries and all the
class path libraries which we discussed
in the previous lecture and put all that
into the location which we specified to
install java it will also set up the
rest of the prerequisites which are
required to run java successfully so
looks like the java has been
successfully installed as is visible in
this message and there's also a next
step if you want to
access the tutorials or the api
documentations the developer guides the
release notes etc i don't want to do
that so i will just hit close here and
now if we want to just verify if java is
uh is installed or not then we can
verify that from the command line prompt
let me just exit this
and let's go to the command prompt to
verify to see if java has been
successfully installed so to do that uh
we'll we'll just open the search bar and
we'll type cmd it is going to show us
this command prompt here we'll click on
this
and it will open the command prompt for
you like it has opened for me and there
you just need to type
java hyphen
version and you hit enter if you get a
message like this it means java has been
successfully installed if you get a
message saying that java is not
recognized as a command it means that
java is still not successfully installed
and something has gone wrong in your
installation and in that case you might
want to restart you might want to go
back and reinstall this java exe again
so in this case it looks like it has
been successfully installed and we can
also get some interesting information
from here
we can see which version of java has
been installed it says java version 15.
we can also see that the jre is also
installed the java sc runtime
environment or jre is also installed and
we can also see that the jvm is also
installed which is java hotspot server
vm vm means the virtual machine so if i
connect this back to the previous
lecture we can see that uh the the java
jdk basically installed the jre as well
as the jvm as well and the complete java
package has been successfully installed
now we are ready to use java
a java program and run java programs on
this machine and at this step i would
like to conclude this lecture in the
next session we will be discussing how
we can install eclipse because that
would be the natural next step for any
java developer that they want to install
java and then they want to install
eclipse and start working let's get
started with installing eclipse on a
windows machine so the first thing which
we need to do is to download eclipse so
for that i'm just going to open my web
browser and type eclipse
download
press enter and then you need to find
the link which says
eclipse.org
downloads which is the first link in my
search results you can also see it says
eclipse downloads the eclipse foundation
and eclipse foundation is the one is the
organization which maintains the eclipse
installers so we can click on this
once we click on this we will be
redirected on to the eclipse downloads
page and there again you will see bunch
of options you will see the default
option highlighted which would be the
eclipse installer for uh for jre for mac
os windows and linux and then you have
some other tool platforms option as well
like eclipse g or orion which you might
want to use for advanced cases but for
running java applications all you need
is an eclipse installer which is coming
from here so based on your machine
eclipse will automatically detect
whether you want a 64-bit installer or a
32-bit installer and you can just click
on this particular link which says
download 64-bit here so i'm just going
to hit download 64-bit it is going to
open this particular screen where based
on your current location eclipse will
suggest the nearest possible
distribution mirror distribution mirror
is basically a server which is present
somewhere
in this world which contains this
eclipse installer exe and eclipse has
created these servers all across the
globes these servers are basically
called the mirrors and based on your
current location which will be deducted
taken taken from your isp from the
internet ip address from which you are
accessing this particular website so
based on your isp location it is going
to suggest you the nearest possible
mirror location so that your download is
the fastest so in my case the nearest
location is netherlands here as you can
see and i get a download option this is
the file name which says eclipse
installer jre windows64.exe
and if you think that this mirror
doesn't make sense just click on this
option select another mirror and then
you can choose another mirror but
generally it works really well it works
based on it works based on your ip
location and it's generally uh the
download speed is pretty good based on
the suggested mirror so i'm not going to
change the mirror location because i
think this works fine for me so and i'm
just going to click on this particular
button which is going to start the
download of the eclipse installer so now
i have i have hit the download button
and you can see right now an exe has
been download has begun to download uh
it is going to again take some time and
uh i have already downloaded this
particular exe just to save us some time
and i'm going to use that exe to
showcase how we can install it another
thing just wanted to highlight is that
eclipse is an open source organization
it works on donations so if you feel
generous about it and if you feel that
eclipse is doing really great work you
can also donate to it which will show
here so we can move to the next step
which is about installing so you can see
here i have an installer here an exe
file basically which i have
pre-downloaded to showcase this demo i'm
just going to double click on this and
it is going to unpack the installer you
can see this uh this icon will be
presented to you which says eclipse
installer by oomph
is basically the provider for this
particular installer who manages the
installer and based on your computer's
capacity and speed it is going to take
few seconds and
in the background what it is doing is
basically it is unpacking this installer
and creating all the installation files
which it needs to successfully install
it on your computer once that is done
you will be presented with this kind of
screen and you will see that eclipse
provides multiple different kind of ides
for different set of developer
communities you will see an option which
says eclipse ide for java developers you
will also see eclipse ide for enterprise
java developers you will see the ide for
c plus and c developers web and
javascript php eclipse committers who
basically contribute to the eclipse
organization or
rap tester scientific computing there
are tons of ides which eclipse maintains
for our use case throughout this series
i think we will be focusing on this
particular ide which says eclipse ide
for enterprise java developers you can
also use this particular ide but this is
a very bare bone ide with very limited
set of integrations like it says it
includes a java ide a git client an xml
editor a maven plugin and a gradle
plugin but if you look at the enterprise
you will get more integrations you can
use this particular ide to work on
whatever you work here so these all will
work here but in addition you can also
use this ide to build a web application
build a web service build a jpa
application data tools java server pages
faces etc so this is more
more advanced i would say and we will go
with this particular ide and
you can also choose this id if you want
to but for this demo we are going to
choose this one i will click on this
then it is going to show me which
virtual machine it is going to use so if
you remember in the previous lecture we
installed java 15 it has automatically
detected that location by reading my c
program files folder and it has
automatically taken that if you have
multiple jdk installations on your
machine you can click on this icon and
change a different java virtual machine
i'm going to leave it as is again the
installation folder is also by default
taken to your c users username slash
eclipse slash the jee
version number and again if you want to
change this you can also change a
different installation folder i'm going
to leave everything as default it will
automatically create a start menu entry
and a desktop shortcut and now i hit
install it might come ask you for a user
agreement so you can hit accept now and
now it has begun the installation the
installation generally takes a bit of
time to complete in some cases so again
it depends upon your in your computer's
capacity and the speed basically if it's
a good robust machine with with good
capacity the installation might be very
fast as you can see in my computer and
if you have a computer which is not very
strong on configurations you can just be
patient and wait for some time and the
installation will be finished once the
installation is finished you will see
this launch option here you will also
have an option to keep an installer if
you want to show the readme file but i
think the the main option here which we
are going to use is the launch option so
if you hit the launch option now the
actual ide is going to start up it's
again going to set up some configuration
files and some bootstrap configuration
files which it needs to and then it will
ask you to choose a workspace again
workspace is up to you where do you
where you want to create your workspace
the workspace is basically the location
where you
you will create your projects it will
store those project files and the source
code of those projects so it is up to
you where you want to create it again
i'm going to leave it as default here
but if you want to change it just hit
browse here and choose whatever location
you want to you can see you can choose
you can go to pc and you can choose
whatever location you want to i'm going
to leave it as is and you also have a
choice that you don't want eclipse to
ask this every time so you can check
this box and next time eclipse is not
going to ask you to choose a directory
as workspace and every time you start
eclipse it will automatically go to this
particular directory so you can either
check it or uncheck it based on your
convenience and hit launch
once you hit launch it is going to start
the actual ide as a desktop application
and you will get a nice interface and a
welcome screen from eclipse which will
which will basically show the basic uh
overview of the screen something like
this so now you can see that the eclipse
id has started it has a welcome page
which has multiple options you can check
out a project from git you can import an
existing project you can go to the
marketplace create a java web project or
whatever or you can just close this you
have a nice navigation project
project explorer bar here so all the
projects which you're going to create
will be listed here there are also some
quick shortcuts here for creating
different kind of projects and if you
don't want to use that just go to file
new and choose a kind of project you
want to create whether it is a maven
project or enterprise application
project or dynamic web project or just a
project if you just hit just a project
you can choose a basic java project to
start with click next give a project
name let's call it test demo you can
choose an execution environment here the
jre and currently this particular ide
has support up to 14 but i think this is
going to work fine we don't need to
worry about it we can also use a project
specific jre like in this case java 15
which is the current installation so i
can use this option because i want to
use java 15 environment because i have
java 15 installed so you can basically
choose whatever option you want to
choose it gives you flexibility in terms
of choosing the gre whether you want to
choose an external jre whether you want
to choose a project specific jre or you
want to use the default gre jdk
installation so you can use this option
as well if you want to project layout is
great either you want to create separate
folders for source and classes or you
want to create the use the project
folder again this is these are just
basic configurations which you can play
around with if you want to i'm just
going to leave it as is and hit next and
then it is going to just give me a
review screen here if i want to change
anything i can otherwise i can just hit
finish
i can create a module name here if i
want to but i don't want to create it so
just hit on don't create and open the
java perspective
and that's it you have a java project
here where you can create your java
files under this src and you can start
executing those files we will look out
on those details in the upcoming
lectures but for this lecture i think
this is what we wanted to achieve we
wanted to show how we can install
eclipse and how we can create a very
sample uh java cli project so this is it
for this uh this session in the next
session we will look at some of the data
types in java let's get started with
primitive data types in java we are
going to learn about the primitive data
types in java and we'll also see a short
demonstration of it so let's get started
let's first just learn about those
data types i've just opened the official
oracle documentation and don't worry if
you see how this link appears here you
can just open a browser window and just
type java primitive data types and if
you hit enter the first link which will
be given is this particular link and
this is the same link which i have
opened so let's learn about the data
types now so java has
these primitive data types which you can
see here some of them store numbers some
of them store boolean values and some of
them store characters so the data types
which store numbers are byte short int
long float and double these six
data types basically are used to store
any kind of numeric value let's
understand these a bit more byte is the
shortest possible data type value which
you can use in java to store numbers you
can only store numbers within the range
of minus 128 to plus 127. so you can see
the range is very small and java has
created this variable for use cases
where you want to store numbers which
have very small value in this range why
do we provide these kind of options just
to save memory because the smaller data
type will require less memory to be used
in the java program similarly the next
bigger data type is short which is a bit
bigger than byte and the range of this
particular data type where
variables will range from minus 3 to 6 7
8 to plus 3 to seven six seven so that
is the range for this particular
variable and you can see that it says it
has a very big range as compared to the
byte data type so if you want to store
very uh values which lie in this range
you can use short the next one is int
data type you can use this one to store
even larger values which range from
minus 2 raised to power 31 to plus 2
raised to power 31 minus 1. the next one
is long which is even bigger than int
and it can be used to store the values
within the range of minus 2 raised to
power 63 to plus 2 raised to power 63
minus 1. so as you can see as we go from
top to bottom from byte to long the size
of the value which can be stored using
this data type increases and that's how
you will basically take a decision of
whether you want to use byte or you want
to use short or int or long based on
what size of the value that variable is
going to contain then the next ones are
float and double these two have been
created for the use cases whether where
you want to store the values numeric
values which have decimals which are
precision values i should also mention
that byte short int and long are only
used for storing absolute numbers which
do not have any decimal representation
even if you try to store a decimal value
in these variables they will
automatically be trimmed the decimal
values will automatically be removed and
you will only be shown the absolute
values
and in case of float and double they can
maintain those precision and decimal
values so we use float for the use cases
where you want to store decimal
representations of the values and you
can see that the float value can store a
smaller precision value but double can
store even a bigger precision value so
if you have really big precision values
to be maintained very big decimal values
to be maintained you should use double
and the float is used for
storing a bit smaller size of the
precision values i mean its range of
values basically beyond the scope of
this discussion if you want to read more
about this you can go to this particular
links which will explain this in detail
but the basic idea is that float is good
for storing two precision values and if
you want to go beyond that you want to
use double in some cases some people
also use float to store even beyond two
values as well so it completely depends
the main the decision factor is how long
the value you are going to store in the
decimal and that will take the decide
whether you want to use float or double
the next one is boolean which is used
for storing the boolean values boolean
values can be either true or false so
there are only two possible values and
then we have care which is used for
storing characters it is
using 16 bit to store the value and this
is a very popular java question for
beginner level programmers that uh why
does it store uh need 16-bit to store
the character it's because it stores a
unicode representation unicode
representation is a representation which
can be accepted across platforms across
the world in different character
encodings so let's move on to eclipse
now where i have prepared a very short
and simple demo i'm just creating a
variable for each data type and i'm
printing them
you also see some things here like
these keywords and don't worry about
these keywords i will cover these
keywords in detail in the upcoming
lectures you also see this and you can
just for now you can remember that
system.out.println is used for printing
anything in java anything you want to
print on the console you would be using
system.out.println
what is system what is out and what is
println again we will cover these in the
uh upcoming lectures
for now i'm just creating a bunch of
data types here variables here basically
i'm creating a cat type variable a byte
type variable a short type variable an n
type variable a float type variable a
double and a boolean the way you create
variables is basically you put the data
type name
you put the variable name which can be
anything you put an equal sign and you
put the value actual value which this
variable is going to store and i've done
the similar thing for all of these
variables java wants semicolons to be
there when you write your statements so
please remember that your statements
always end with semicolons so i've
declared all of these variables here a
byte a short and int float double and
boolean and then i'm printing all of
them basically here i'm printing the cad
variable here i'm printing the byte
variable here i'm printing the short and
so on so forth so how do we actually run
this application or this program you
just double click on this or right click
on this you go to this run as option you
see this run as java application option
so you can hit this option it will run
the application and it will present all
the output here in the console tab let
me just bring this up so you can see all
the variables have been printed here and
this is coming from these print
statements like i said this is used
system.out.println is used to basically
print anything and i've used that to
print all the variables here first i'm
printing the car variable whose value is
a
then i'm using the byte variable which
is denoted by b and whose value is 2. so
you can see the value is 2 here then i'm
printing the third variable which is c
which is a short type variable which has
a value 22 you can see short and this is
coming here the next print statement is
int so you can see int here with the
value 45 and this value is coming from
here then we have float
we can see the float value being printed
here and you can see the float value
declared here you also see an f here and
this is the standard naming convention
with java proposes that whenever you
declare float and double you end them
with f or d based on whether it is float
or it is double then you see the double
value which is having which is having a
bigger precision than float so i have
printed the double value using
this particular print statement which is
printed here and then we have the
boolean value which is stored as g
and the value of g is true and the same
value is printed here so whatever i
write here basically is printed here
this is just a placeholder and this is
the actual value so you can see that we
are able to use all the variables here
all the primitive variables basically
which range from byte character byte
short int float double and boolean and
that's it for this session in the next
session we will be discussing about the
non-primitive data types in java let's
get started with non-primitive data
types in java in the previous lecture we
talked about the primitive data types
and now we'll discuss about some of the
data types which are not primitive first
of all let's understand what is the
difference between primitive and
non-primitive so the primitive data
types are the ones which are by default
supported by java and non-primitives are
the one which are a bit custom in nature
where you as developer have the liberty
to define the nature of that data type
we'll look at some examples of that as
well but when we talk about which all
are the non-primitive data types we
broadly talk about arrays we talk about
classes we talk about strings as well
and we will cover some of them in
today's lecture and we have the detailed
lecture upcoming about the classes as
well in fact in the and uh after few
lectures we will cover how we'll create
classes as well but for today's lecture
we are going to focus on string data
type and array data type and like i said
for classes we have a dedicated lecture
upcoming so don't worry about that and
again for this particular case as well i
have already prepared a demo for this
and we'll basically do some look at some
hands-on examples to see how do we
create these variables what is what does
these variables mean and the first
non-primitive data type we are going to
talk about is string and before i go on
further i should also mention that it's
very debatable in the java community to
call string as a non-primitive data type
and actually technically speaking string
is a special data type it neither fully
lies in the primitive category nor it
fully lies in the non-primitive
categories i'm covering this as as a
non-primitive data type because it's a
bit inclined towards the non-primitive
category why do we
do this is because java does provide
native support for string handling in
the jdk and that's the reason some of
the developers feel that string is a
primitive data type which is primitively
supported by java but at the same time
string is so customizable and it's so
special in nature it's the way it stores
the value the way it provides the
operations and handlings it's so
different than primitive data types that
it cannot fully be put in the same
bucket as the primitive data types so
that's why i said it's it's a special
data type a bit inclined towards the
non-primitive category so what is string
basically we covered about the data type
in the previous lecture and
in cad data type you can only store a
single character right but if you want
to store a complete name of somebody
then it's a list of character it's
basically lot of characters together
then in that case you would need a data
type to store that continuous sequence
of characters and that's what string
does string can store a continuous
sequence of characters
technically string is basically a
character array you can call string as a
character array and don't worry if you
don't understand about the word array i
will explain that in the same lecture so
basically it stores the continuous
sequence of characters that's how that's
how we define string and you see this
string this is a basically the keyword
the data type basically in java so
whenever you want to create a string you
need to write string with s capital you
need to give a name to the string this
can be anything and then you can provide
the value which is which this particular
string is going to contain so you can
see this is a continuous sequence of
characters t e s t
are the four characters which the string
is going to contain and after that again
i'm printing this particular value and
like i said don't worry about this we'll
cover this when we'll when we'll write
our first program in java so this is
just to print the string value i'm just
putting a string placeholder here and
then i'm actually printing the printing
the values of the string variable now
string can be created in multiple ways
in java this is one way of creating it
there's another way of creating a string
variable which is this one which says
again the string data type some variable
name a keyword called new again don't
worry about what is this new keyword
we'll cover this when we'll talk about
running our first program in java and
writing the first program from scratch
then we against a string and then we
provide the value so if i compare this
line number 4 to line number 7 you can
see the difference is that i'm still
storing the same value test but the
difference is that here there is no new
string keyword but here we have this new
string keyword so what is the difference
the difference is this that in this case
in this particular case string is going
to
reuse the same object multiple times but
in this case every time you call this it
is going to create a new object again
what is object it's just you can think
of it as for now you can think of it as
a memory block we'll again cover objects
in details but these are two different
ways in which you can create string this
is generally the most popular way of
doing it because this is memory
efficient because you can reuse the same
variable again and again so i'm creating
the string variable here and creating
another string variable str1 here and
printing both of them
then i've created this strange looking
thing here which is basically an array
array like i said is also an a
non-primitive data type in java and
array can store a continuous sequence
of anything
that anything can be a number
that anything can be characters that
anything can be or a floating number as
well so basic idea is that
if you want to store a collection or a
sequence of multiple multiple
values how do you do that you do that
with the help of arrays array is a data
structure a non-primitive data structure
in java which can store lot of values of
similar type we also call it as
homogeneous data structure which because
it can only store same data type values
or homogeneous data type values so the
the biggest way to identify array is
this square bracket whenever you see
this square bracket in java it means
it's an it's an array variable so here i
am creating an integer array variable
with the name arr this is the name of
this particular array it is only going
to store integer values because of
specified int and the moment i provide
the square brackets it's mean it means
that it is an array so you can declare
an array like this and then you need to
assign a size to the array size is
basically denoting how many values
this data structure is going to store so
i'm saying new again it's a keyword and
i'm saying that okay create
a
memory block for storing two integers so
this particular array arr can store at
max two values two values at continuous
locations the next thing about array is
that it stores the value in a zero index
based location so like i said it can
store two values so the first location
will always be array of zero and this is
how you specify the location or index of
the element which is going to be stored
so at the zeroth location of this array
i'm storing zero the first location of
the array i'm storing one and this is
just to show an error scenario but i
will just comment this for now you can
just put double slashes and comment any
line so i'm just storing filling up this
array for two values and the two values
location would be zero index and first
index these are just continuous memory
locations and we denote those memory
locations as zero and one array indexes
always start with 0 and i'm just putting
some values here you can put any values
and then i'm printing the whole array
and i'm also printing the first value of
the array and we'll see how this pans
out and we'll also see how we can change
this
so now we are going to run this
application so i'll just go to run as
and click on run as java application and
once i hit that i get this output here
so let's understand this output the
first one is i'm just printing the
string which has the value test and you
can see it has printed here it is coming
from this line
then the next line which is printed is
line number eight where i'm saying
another string str1 and str1 also had
the same value so you can see another
string has the same value and then
i have printed the array here the
complete array and you see this strange
value here it also tells us that if you
want to print the array then you cannot
just put the variable name and print it
the reason is because this is a
non-primitive data type and once you do
this it is basically printing the memory
footprint of this array the whole memory
location where this array is stored
that's why you see this strange looking
number which is the memory hash code and
if you want to print any particular
value or any particular element inside
this array then you can do that by
providing the index location of that
element so here i have said that print
the zeroth location element of the array
the zeroth location array element of the
array was zero so you can see the value
zero here let me put some other value
just to just for fun and show you how
this works so just change the values and
now let's see
what do we get for array zero you can
see now i get value three because now
that at the zeroth location the three
value is being stored and that is what
is being printed here we can also print
the first value i'll just go run as java
application you can see now the array of
first index is being stored which is
basically technically the second element
of the array but because array always
works on a zero index based value format
that's why when we say array 1 the
second element is printed when i say
array 0 the first element is printed so
always remember that array is a 0 index
based collection or data structure
basically what happens if i do this now
there is no third element in this array
because the array has the size only of
two elements and when i say ar of 2
which means i'm trying to print the
third element in this array which does
not exist so let's see what happens in
that case
i get an exception exception is
basically an error i get an error saying
that index 2 is out of bounds for length
2 it means that the array length was
actually 2 and index 2 does not exist
remember it's saying index 2 not the
element 2. index 2 doesn't exist because
only index 0 and index 1 exist this
makes two elements and the actual size
is also 2 it does not have capacity to
store third element it does not have
third element location anywhere that's
why it complains that you are trying to
print a non-existing value so this is
where i would like to conclude my
lecture about the non-primitive data
types so we covered about string we
covered arrays and like i said we'll
cover classes in the upcoming lecture as
well uh in the next session we are going
to talk about tokens in java let's get
started with tokens in java when we talk
about tokens in java these tokens are
basically some reserved expressions or
words or symbols which have a predefined
meaning in java and you cannot override
this meaning because this meaning is
already defined by java and you can use
those expressions those symbols and
those words in only the way java wants
you to there is no way you can change
the meaning of those terms or those
symbols so we will be covering those
tokens in today's lecture these tokens
are broadly divided into five different
categories these categories are keywords
identifiers constants
special symbols and operators so let's
talk about each of them one by one so
when we talk about keywords
these are the words which are reserved
by java and they have a predefined
meaning you might have already seen some
of these reserved keywords for example
we have used int when we were working on
the primitive data type lecture we have
seen this as well though we haven't
actually
found out the meaning of this but we
will find out the meaning of this in the
coming lectures so don't worry about
that we have seen boolean as a as a data
type again we have seen byte so these
boolean byte int uh class care catch
super switch synchronized all the all
the keywords which you see here these
keywords have a predefined meaning in
java and you use these keywords so that
you want to take an action an expected
action by java for example if you call
something as int then you want java to
treat it as int int will only have a
single meaning in java and there is no
other meaning of int in a java program
so that's the intent with the keywords
these are reserved words which have a
predefined meaning and we will cover
these keywords at length during this
whole course the next token is
identifier and identifier is is nothing
but just a variable name technically and
we have already covered this this kind
of identifier when we were showing the
demonstrations for primitive data types
and non-primitive data types etc it's
basically anything which you declare as
a variable is an identifier and when you
declare the variable name again java
puts some sort of restrictions as to
what you can or cannot do when you work
with java and you declare the variable
names for example these variable names
cannot start with numbers so you cannot
have a variable name which starts with
any number you cannot have a variable
name which contains spaces in between
them you either have to fill those
if there's a if there's a variable name
which you think has two parts for
example student name then you need to
write it as student underscore name so
that you can create the variable name
with the same impact and still does not
contain space so spaces will not be
allowed when you create the variable
names similarly you cannot have plus
hyphen and ampersand in the variable
names as well these are the restrictions
with java puts on the identifier tokens
whenever you create identifiers the next
one is constants and we will cover these
constants in detail in the coming
lectures as well but to give you an idea
of what constants are so constants are
basically exactly what they sound like
they are the identifiers which you have
declared in your program whose value
cannot be changed once defined so if you
write something as
final
int i equal to 5 then this value is
fixed you cannot change the value of i
again in the program java will not allow
you to change the value of i again
because i has now become a constant
because you have put a final keyword in
front of it and again final is a keyword
you see final is a keyword basically so
you so these constants are treated
specially by java that java will make
sure that their values will never change
during the course of the execution of
the program these can come really handy
when you have situations where you do
not want the certain variables values to
be to be modified for example if you
have an application where you are
counting the number of applicants and if
you have declared the number of
applicants as final then every time you
call the application we can do a plus
one to the previous value the value will
not be re-initiated so it is very useful
concept and and it can be very handy in
programs where you don't want to change
the values the next is special symbols
these special symbols are the symbols
which again have a predefined meaning in
java we have already seen this square
bracket symbol in our previous lecture
when we were creating arrays so whenever
you use these square brackets then java
would understand that you are trying to
either access or create an array or you
are trying to access or create a list
etc so this is predefined you cannot use
this anywhere else or with any other
meaning similarly when we talk about
these braces these standard brackets are
standard braces these again have a
predefined meaning in java generally
whenever you will write functions and
methods in java you will use these
brackets to define the parameters of the
function now you cannot use these
brackets
in any other meaning in java java will
not allow you to use this anywhere else
apart from using it in method parameters
similarly the next one is the curly
braces and the curly braces are used to
define a code block in java you might
have already noticed that when we were
looking at the previous demos you could
see some curly braces then some code and
then and then the curly brushes would
end for example if i show you here just
it's just a sample example and let me
open the example which we covered in the
last lecture so you can see this curly
brace here and this curly brace ends
here right so this defines a code block
in java any code block which you want
java to understand will always be
starting with a curly braces and ending
with a curly brace
remember i talked about the standard
braces you can see these are the
standard braces opening and ending and
this is where we are defining this
particular methods arguments now what is
method what is argument don't worry
about that we will cover in detail but
just an introductory concept whenever
you are trying to define a method and
you want to pass any argument to the
method we use these
brackets to do that okay uh similarly
this is semicolon is used to uh close
any java statement so you will see this
semicolon here every java statement has
to have a semicolon as ending otherwise
java will complain that it is a
syntactical error so it is part of the
syntax you need to put the semicolon and
semicolon has only one meaning in java
which is that your statement is actually
ending
then we have star and star is used for
multiplication and then we have equality
which is used for assigning any values
and again assigning any values is
everywhere you are seeing this equality
sign everywhere so these are all tokens
basically the last type of token we have
is operators and we will cover these
operators in the upcoming lectures in
detail with the examples but these
operators are basically some special
symbols like for arithmetic it would be
plus minus multiplication divide for
comparison it will be
greater than less than for logical it
would be ampersand uh and and pipe
operators bitwise again will have some
bitwise operation
operators they so they so these are
basically different categories of
operators and under each category of
operators there are certain symbols like
for arithmetic we have plus minus we
have com for comparison we have greater
than less than etc so these again
symbols are also reserved by java under
the operators tokens category you cannot
use these in any other meaning or in any
other way and like like i said we will
look at a detailed example of this as
well in the coming lectures so this was
a quick overview of what are different
types of tokens in java so we have
keywords
we have identifiers constants special
symbols and operators so this is it this
is all what i wanted to cover in today's
lecture and in the next session we will
be looking at data type conversions
let's get started with data type
conversions so when we talk about data
type conversion the whole idea is to
basically answer the question that
whether i can convert a int data type
variable into a long data type variable
or a long data type variable to a float
data type variable and also vice versa
can i go back can i convert a float
variable into a long variable or an int
variable and vice versa so this lecture
is about answering all of those
questions and we will basically look at
some examples to understand how the
conversion works but let me just explain
the basic principle the basic principle
is that smaller box can fit into larger
box but if you have to fit a larger box
into a smaller box you need to do
something else so
what do you mean by smaller box and
larger box here the smaller box is a
variable or a data type which has a
smaller range if you remember we talked
about the range of short byte int etc
and we could see that as we go from
short to byte to int to long to float to
double the ranges were increasing right
so we will follow the same kind of
analogy that if we have to store our
smaller range variable into a larger
range variable java will automatically
do that but if i have to store a larger
range variable into a smaller range
variable then i have to sacrifice some
quality of the value and we will look at
the examples of that as well so let's
first look at look at the example where
we can store our smaller range variable
into a larger range variable we call
this as implicit data type conversion so
here you can see i have declared an int
variable with the value 100 and i'm
printing the it variable then i have
declared a long variable and what i'm
doing that i'm assigning the value of
int a to the long variable b so i'm not
assigning a new value to this long
variable but rather i'm just passing on
the existing integer value into a
variable of type long similarly after
that i am taking the value of this
variable of long type and storing this
value into a float type so you can see
int is basically smaller than long and
long has a smaller range than float so
i'm just storing a smaller range
variable into a larger range and then a
larger range variable into the largest
range and then i am printing all the
variables values to see if this actually
is working can long automatically store
the value of a and can float
automatically store the value of b here
i'm just printing the variables and
again using the concept of the previous
lecture this is just to print the values
and i will cover this in detail in the
next lectures of how this works but here
you can understand that we can use
system.out.println
to basically print the values and here
i'm just printing a string and then the
value then again the string and the
value and here also the string and the
value so this is what is happening in
this program and again don't worry about
these details i will cover about what
these concepts are in the upcoming
lectures so let's run this and see if
the data type conversion actually works
so i will just right click and do run as
and go to java application and if i
click on this i get this output so the
first output is pretty straightforward
i'm just printing the int variable as is
so this works then i am storing the int
into a long and printing the long
representation of a which is b basically
and this also works without any errors
or any warnings by java similarly when i
talk about storing the long variable
into a float variable c this also works
but here you see an additional decimal
precision here because as we remember
from the previous sessions float is used
to store values which have decimals or
which have positions so it will
automatically convert your absolute
number into a number which has decimals
whenever you try to cast this into float
casting is also a word which is used
some people call it as implicit data
type conversion some people call it as
implicit data type casting so if you
hear the word data type casting or
implicit data type casting you can think
that it is exactly the same concept as
data type conversion so this is about
implicit data type conversion now let's
look at an example of explicit data type
conversion how does that work so using
the same analogy of the boxes now i will
try to store a larger ranging value
variable into a smaller range variable
and see how that looks like so i will
start with the largest which is which is
double variable so i have particular
double variable and as we know that
double is a is a variable which is used
to store decimal values so i'm storing
this value here and then i'm just
printing the double representation as is
without any changes then
i'm trying to store this variable's
value into a float variable so i'm
trying to go to a smaller box now i'm
trying to grow from double to float and
if you remember i told you that if you
have to do that it will not work out of
the box but you have to do a bit
something special as well and this is
the special part this is called type
casting type casting is basically a way
to tell java to explicitly cast this
variable's value into this data types
variables value and you always need to
do this whenever there is no implicit
casting happening if you are trying to
store a larger value variable into a
smaller value variable you have to do
this otherwise java will complain you
will get a compilation error so that's
what i'm doing i'm telling java to store
the value of a as a float and store the
value in f and this is where i'm telling
to store the value as float so you just
put brackets and you define float and
then i'm printing the float
representation similarly in the next one
i am trying to store the value of this
double variable into a long so you can
see now i'm trying to go even
from our precision data type to a
non-precision data type because long
does not understand decimal values so
i'm trying to store a variable which has
decimal values into a variable data type
which does not understand decimal values
and we will see how the output looks
like but here also you need to do the
explicit casting explicitly you need to
tell which data type this a needs to be
converted into that's what i do here and
then i print the long variable here and
then next i will again go down further
and i will try to store a larger long
variable type into a smaller int
variable type so again i'm trying to
store the value of b
into a smaller data type which is
integer and i'm naming the variable as c
here again i have to do this explicit
casting i'm telling that telling java to
explicitly cast the value of b which is
a long data type variable into an
integer c which is an int data type
variable and then i'm just printing the
value so this is what is happening in
this program that from double to float
to long to int now let's run this
program and see what happens so i will
right click and go to run as and choose
the java application option and this is
the output i get first of all for the
double representation the value gets
printed 0 is ignored then in the float
it works fine as well without any
precision loss because float can also
print values up to 1 to 2 decimal points
without any problems even beyond that
actually so it works fine then when we
talk about the long representation we
are trying to convert a double variable
into a long variable and we see that the
precision the decimal values are lost
this is expected because long does not
understand decimal values that's why
anything after the decimal or in fact
the whole decimal portion is gone when
you're trying to store double or float
into some absolute data type variables
like tint or long and then in in
representation since you already have
this long this long can easily be casted
to int by just providing this explicit
casting and the end representation also
prints 50. so we started from this value
and we ended up with these values when
we tried to store them as long or inked
so this is all i wanted to cover in
today's lecture so we covered basically
about the data type conversion or data
type casting concepts how does implicit
data type casting works and how does
explicit data type casting works and as
we know the concept the basic concept is
that the uh the value can easily be
casted from a smaller range to a larger
range without any changes or without any
extra code but when you have to go from
a larger value to a smaller value you
have to provide these casting
instructions to java to successfully
cast those variables in the next session
we will be looking at how we can write
the first hello world program in java
and there we will actually cover all the
all these things which which i have been
saying that we will cover so we will
cover all these ways of how we can write
the first hello world program in java
let's get started with how to write your
first program in java so i have been
talking about this lecture and the
details of this lecture in the previous
lectures as well and today we are going
to focus exactly on how do we actually
write a java program so as we have
already covered how you can install
eclipse and how you can create a sample
java project in eclipse if you haven't
seen that please go back to my previous
videos where you can actually see that
and once you have created your java
project so your java project might look
like something like this you will have
an src folder here so and under the src
folder uh you see some some namespaces
sort of things created here right we
call these as packages and in java you
can think of package as something which
can group multiple related artifacts
together this is simply a grouping
mechanism i can say it's a way to put
all the related artifacts to a
particular business problem into a
certain place for example if you are
working in an e-commerce application so
you have you might have created multiple
java files for
let's say for checkout and then some
more java files for the uh filters flow
i would say then some other java files
for designing the advertisements so you
have multiple java files and these java
files now below belong to these three
different domains so you want to group
them together for easy accessibility for
referencing each other
files with the within the code so if you
want to achieve that kind of flexibility
you would group the checkout code files
into a single package you can name it as
checkout package then you can similarly
do the same thing for the advertisement
package and for the filters package so
similarly i have created some packages
here which you can see you see a package
here which says are your github wikis
panda hello world and how do you create
a package you just right click on this
so you go to the src and you right click
to go to new and here you will see this
option which says package so you can
just click on this and write anything
which you want as the package name let's
call it as test package uh it says
invalid because the package is a keyword
so it is not allowing me to put package
here but let's call it test package one
and you can just click finish and you
will see a test package popping up here
then you can right click on this again
go to new and then you can create a java
class now what is a java class a class
is basically a blueprint for an object
it's basically the specifications of an
object like i covered in the very first
lecture everything in java is an object
or most of the things in java are object
i would say so
object is basically an instance of the
class so let's say you create a class
for if i take the same example of
e-commerce you create a class for
writing the business logic of checkout
and then you create instance of this
particular class to work for a
particular customer order so class is
basically a blueprint it's the
specification it's the skeleton of the
object so once you click on this you can
create a class now eclipse is a pretty
smart ide it will provide you with bunch
of options on how you actually can
create a class what and it will also
provide use with some sensible defaults
for example it will automatically select
a source folder in your project which
you have created it will automatically
select a package in fact the currently
selected package and if you want to
change the package just hit browse and
choose any other package which you want
to choose so your your class file will
be created in that package then you can
provide a name to the class so let's
call it as
test
hello
world and you can see i have followed a
sort of a naming convention here the
first character i've kept it as capital
and then any other new world which is
coming in my class file name is also
capitalized so java
would expect you and it would encourage
you to follow this naming convention
that whenever you are creating a class
always start with a capital letter then
small letters and every new word you are
writing can start with a capital letter
again java will not throw an error if
you don't do this
h capital or w capital but it's a good
practice the next thing is the modifier
we are going to cover the modifiers in
details in the in the upcoming lectures
but for now you can understand that
anything which is marked as public is
accessible to every other java class in
this whole project that's the basic
meaning of making a class as public
public as the name
suggests itself it means it's visible to
everyone you can select a super class
and again we'll talk about the super
class later but if this is the java line
object is the super class of all the
classes which are created in java again
interface is again an advanced concept
and there are some other interesting
defaults it provides for the for example
if you want to create a main method now
what is the main method we'll just cover
it in a while so i will not do that i
will leave everything as default and i
will click on finish so i have this new
file coming up here and you can see it
has automatically picked up the package
which i selected and it has also written
public class test hello world with a
starting and ending curly braces in the
previous lecture we covered about this
curly braces that all the code block
have to be in the curly braces whenever
you write a java class the very first
statement java would expect to have in
the class is package name so make sure
that you have package as the keyword and
then the actual package name as the
package name for that particular class
you can see the package follows a dot
convention and it always ends with a
semicolon like all the java statements
and with semicolon so that would be the
first thing which you will write in your
class second thing is the access
modifier of the class like i said you
want this class to be accessible to
every other file in this project then
you can mark this class as public the
next thing is the class keyword you need
to write this particular keyword as is
otherwise your class will not be
detected so you write this as class then
you write test hello world or whatever
name you want to write but make sure
that whatever public class name you
provide here that name should match with
the file name these two things should
match the file name and the class name
if they don't match you would experience
weird behaviors as the class will not be
compiled the class might not be able to
run etc so always make sure that
whatever file name you provide you
always have a class with that name in
your file so my class structure is is
ready but there's nothing here in this
class in fact you cannot you cannot even
execute this class because for executing
the class for executing any class in
java any class at all in java you would
need a main method in java main method
is the entry point method of the java
whenever you are trying to run any
application be it a very small or very
large java application you would always
and always need a main method in the in
the class in the project somewhere and
you need to tell the java uh runtime to
execute that class and then the class
will have a main method and the your
program will start executing so always
have a main method otherwise your
program will not execute and how do you
write the main method so you first write
public
then you write static
then you write void
and then you write main and then you
provide a parameter to this method as
this now let's understand what did i
actually write here first keyword is
public because this method has to be
public because like i said java runtime
needs to be able to access this method
so the similar concept which applied on
the class is applied on this method as
well that the entry point method has to
be public otherwise java will not be
able to find this method so you need to
make this method exactly as public the
next keyword is static you again need to
write this keyword as is and the reason
we write static here is because we
we want to run this particular class
without creating an object of the class
static is again a keyword which we will
cover in the upcoming lectures but for
now you can understand that whenever you
want to access
something within the class without
creating an object then you need to
create it as static the next is void
void is basically the return type of
this method the method name is main and
it has to be main it cannot be main one
or main two otherwise if you do that
java will not be able to run your
program because it will expect you to
write this particular method exactly as
what i have written here no changes at
all should be there if you make any
changes java program will not run
because it will not be able to find the
entry point method which is the main
method so public static void main
remember that you need to have this in
your program so white is the return type
which means that this particular program
it will not return anything back to the
runtime because a method can have this
capability to either return something or
not return something for example a
method which can uh add two numbers will
return the result of addition right so
we return the result return is the word
here in this case this method is not
expected to return anything because
there is nobody consuming it right java
runtime will not do anything with the
with the return value of this particular
method that's why java will force you to
write void here and main is the exact
method name which you need to use java
will expect you to supply a string array
argument if we covered arrays in bit
detail in the in the in the previous
lectures and we will cover arrays in
actually in the next lecture in very
detail but you can as we discuss that
array is basically a sequence of
characters or words or integers or
anything right so in this case this is
basically the mandatory parameter which
you need to write as is this parameter
name can be anything obviously it can be
a r g a r g s or whatever you want to
write it as but the basic fundamental is
that java will basically supply all the
command line arguments using this
particular string array that's why you
need to provide this then let's write
something in the program because this is
a hello world program so i will just
write
system
dot out dot print ln and i'll type a
string here which says hello
world and a semicolon so again i have
been saying that i will explain this and
now i will explain this why do we need
this and what does this mean so as i
have told earlier that whenever you want
to print something on the console in a
java program you need to write
system.out.println
now system here if you just go if you
just hover over it eclipse will show
what it is so system is basically a
class which contains several useful
class fields and methods it cannot be
instantiated means you cannot create an
object of it and it provides many
facilities like
standard input standard output and error
output exactly what we want to focus
here because we want to
use system class to print something on
the standard output the standard output
in this case is the console so if you
want to input something or you want to
output something or you want to output
an error then you need to use system
class and all of these standard input
standard output and error are streams
and that's what comes to the next word
what is this out how it is a stream to
print standard output similarly we have
system.err which is for printing the
error output streams similarly we have
system dot in for taking its standard
input streams so system dot in
system.out system.err these all are
these in out and err are streams and
then println is the actual method let's
hover over that let's first see out here
so you can see this is a stream object
which is used to print anything which is
ready to accept output data basically
and then we go to the println method and
it says print a string and then
terminate the line so like i mentioned
earlier as well this whole syntax is
used to print and actually this is the
core method this is the real method
which prints something on the console so
system class uses the output stream to
print something on the console using the
help of println method there is also a
print method so there are two methods
one is print and one is println the
difference is that in case of print
method the print method will not provide
you or terminate on a next line but in
system.out.println
the ln means line here it will print
something and it will bring the cursor
to the next line if you do not use this
and if you again use another print
statement then both of the statements
will be printed on the same line i will
show that as well but
and then we provide any random string
here which we want to print so you right
click on this particular program you go
to run as and you run as java
application and you want to save this so
you can say always save resources before
launching and you see the output here so
this is how you can run your first java
program now let's also see the
difference between
system.out.println and system.out.print
so i will just copy this here and i will
say hello world
1 let's say and this time i will not use
system.out.println
but i will use
system.out.print
just put a space here so that it's
visible so if i use print how does that
look like i go to run and i go to run as
java application so now you see both of
the outputs are printed on the same line
there is no it this output hasn't gone
to the next line and now if i run the
same program with
system.out.println methods now both of
these outputs will be divided on two
lines the first output then a line break
the hello world one goes to the next
line in the previous run the hello world
one was printing right next to it on the
same line so that is the difference so
this is how you can build your very
first program the hello world program in
java in the next session we will be
discussing about arrays in java let's
get started with arrays in java we
discussed about arrays uh in a bit
detail when we talked about the
non-primitive data types but this is a
concept and a topic which needs to be
understood well so that's why we'll go i
will do a deep dive on arrays in this
particular lecture so as i described
earlier that array is basically a
container which can store values or a
sequence of values or sequence of
numbers or sequence of characters into
itself we can think of it as a box which
can store all the values in a continuous
fashion as you can see here this is just
a pictorial representation and this is
coming from the official java docs and
you can see that we if we create an
array of size 10
then we have these 10 blocks created
here you can see 1 to 10 so the whole
length of boxes the number of boxes here
are 10 but the way arrays are designed
is that the index
index is basically used to access the
element in this particular box the index
of the boxes start from zero so it goes
from zero to nine so remember the array
length is ten it
in the array can contain 10 elements but
the index of the array starts with 0 and
will always end at length minus 1 which
is 10 minus 1 in this case which comes
as 9 so it will always be length minus
one it will always the index will always
start from zero and go till length minus
one length can be anything in this case
the length is 10 so the index ends at
nine if the length was 20 the last index
will be 19 but in total you have these
10 memory locations we also call them as
continuous memory locations because they
are continuously placed and array
basically blocks 10 memory locations and
creates a container over it so this is
how an array basically
looks like inside the memory and
whenever you want to access the elements
of the array you will say array of 0 or
array of 1 or array of 2 you basically
need to specify the index to access the
element at index for example if you want
to access the element which is sitting
in this box you need to say array of
index 8 and we'll see how we can do that
but this is the basic understand
understanding an idea of the concept of
arrays so let's try to understand this
with the help of an example i will
switch back to eclipse ide and i've
created a very simple program here to
demonstrate the functionality of arrays
here so
we already covered in the previous
lecture of what is package and what is
public and what is class how do we give
the class name and what is the meaning
of this particular method so i'm not
going to cover that again we'll start
directly from here so here the first
thing which i'm doing is i'm declaring
an array of integer this is a variable
name the identifier basically it can be
anything and this is the data type it's
an integer array and as we as we covered
this as well that whenever you put
square bracket in front of a data type
it becomes an array data type so this is
an integer array representation now we
just declared an array but we still
haven't allocated a size to it so you
can do that with this particular
syntax so you can put the variable name
of the array and say new int and put the
right size here this size can be
anything and once you do this now array
will actually allocate those memory
boxes which we covered here but the
moment you do new int 10 this box these
boxes continuous boxes will be placed in
the memory and the memory is allocated
to this array we call this memory
allocation this is how you allocate
memory to the array so we allocated
memory to this array for storing 10
integers the next thing is now we can
start storing elements in those boxes so
like i said that the array index always
starts with 0 so
if you have to store the first element
you actually have to store it at index 0
location so you give the array name you
provide these square brackets and you
put the index value within the square
brackets that is how you basically point
to a particular element inside the array
so we say an array of 0 and we put the
value 100 then we initialize the second
element which will be index 1 then will
be the third element which will be index
2 fourth element index three fifth
element index four sixth element index
five and so on until we store till the
last element so this is the tenth
element which is accessible as index
nine and the value is a thousand
basically so from 100 to 1000 we stored
10 values in this array and we stored
them by accessing the index and this is
actually the only way you can store
values in the array by pointing to the
indexes so we go from 0 to 9 and we
stored all the values 0 being the first
element and array of 9 being the last
and the 10th element remember the length
minus 1 concept okay so now we will try
to print all the elements one by one
that's pretty much what we are doing now
so as we covered in the previous lecture
that we use
system.out.println to print anything and
we understood the whole meaning of this
so i'm not going to repeat that now
we want to print the first element the
first element is sitting at index 0 and
we can access that element with this
syntax by providing the variable name
and the actual index value so i'm just
writing a random string here which says
element at index 0 and then i'm putting
this plus here and putting the variable
name this plus is basically used to
concatenate the output of a static
string with a random variable or
basically you can print anything
with using plus plus is used for
concatenation so i'm just trying to
print this whole value but here this is
a string value which is a static string
and then i have a value coming from the
array so whenever you have to print some
value from a particular data type or
variable or collection then you can use
this plus syntax to concatenate a string
static string with your actual value so
that's what i've done here by saying
plus and array 0 and similarly for index
1 i'm printing the
first index then for 2 3 so far and so
on so forth till the index 9 so
basically i'm just printing the all the
values of the array starting from index
0 to index 9 so
that's all which which is written in
this program now let's try to run this
program so i will right click go to run
as and go to java application and hit on
this and now if i just expand this
console you can see all the
system.out.println statements have been
executed and they printed this so this
is the static screen a string part in
fact including the colon this is the
static string part element and index 0
printing exactly as is and then
dynamically the
0th index element of an array is printed
here similarly we have printed the index
1 location element index 2 location
element index three location element and
so on so forth till the index nine
location element so in total these are
the ten elements but the index always
works from zero to length minus one in
this case it will be going from 0 to 9
so this is basically all which i wanted
to cover in this lecture the whole idea
was to give you more understanding of
arrays and remember this is just an
integer array you can similarly create a
character array you can also create a
string array for for you as well so it
it's completely uh it's completely
related to the data type you are using
if you create a care array then you can
only store characters into it if you
create a string array then you can only
store strings into it and now you can
probably relate back to this particular
thing which i explained in the previous
lecture that we create this string array
for the reason that when you run this
particular program and if you want to
provide any command line values command
line arguments to the program those
arguments will automatically be stored
in this args and then you can access
this as args of 0 or gsf1 etc in your
program that's the whole concept so
these are this is the basically the deep
dive one array which i wanted to cover
and in the next session we are going to
cover about operators in java let's get
started with operators in java when we
talk about operators in java there are
multiple types of operators like
assignment operators arithmetic
operators unary operators then we have
conditional operators and logical
operators and we also have bitwise
operators and we will cover all of these
operators one by one we will understand
what how what these operators are and
how they work and we will also look at a
demonstration of it so let's get started
the first operators we are going to
discuss is about arithmetic operators
and assignment operators and we will
also see if we can cover unary operators
so
when we talk about assignment operators
i have again opened the official java
docs here if we understand assignment
operators we have been using this
operators all the while in all of the
demos so far and the basic idea is very
simple whenever you assign a value to a
variable you use the assignment operator
which is nothing but the equal sign we
have already covered this in multiple
demos so i will not cover this as part
of the demo but what i am going to cover
in detail is about these arithmetic
operators so arithmetic operators are
basically used to perform any kind of
arithmetic operation on a java program
it can be an addition operation it can
be a subtraction operation it can be a
multiplication operation a division
operation or an operation by which you
can find the remainder of the division
so we will look at each of these
with an example and as you can see the
symbols are expectedly what you
generally use in mathematics so you see
the plus sign here which is for addition
you see the minus sign which is for
subtraction you see the star sign which
is for multiplication you see the slash
sign which is for division and you see
the percentage sign which is for finding
the remainder of our division so let's
see an example of each of these and how
we can use them in a java program so for
the arithmetic operations i have
prepared a demonstration of it in the
eclipse ide again i'm using the same
java project which i've shown you we
created in our previous lectures so i
will for all the demonstrations i will
just continue on the same project so
again the way to create a class remains
the same exactly the same as how i
covered in the previous lecture in the
hello world program where we created a
class so here also i created a class i
named the class as arithmetic demo and i
have a public static void main method
inside this particular class and i have
basically tried to demonstrate each of
the operation so let's start with the
addition operation first
so i create an integer variable here
named as result and then i try to use
the addition operator to make this
variable store the result of this
edition so it's a simple one plus two
you can also create two different
variables for one and two let's say x
equal to one and y equal to two and you
can also do end result equal to x plus y
it will have the same effect but just
for simplicity i have put the literal
numbers here so result is storing the
the expression value of 1 plus 2 and
then i'm printing this value here you
can see i'm printing the result variable
here with using
system.out.println then i'm storing this
result into a variable into a new
variable original result with using the
assignment operator and then i'm trying
to subtract something from it so now i'm
saying result equal to result minus 1 it
means whatever the current value of
result is subtract minus 1 from that
value so the value was 3 here and here 3
minus 1 becomes 2 so the new value of
result becomes 2 the original result
still holds 3 because it is storing the
old value the new value of result has
now become 2 so i'm printing the
original result and
then what i'm doing that i'm again
assigning the new result which is 2 to
the original result so now original
result and result both are at 2 then i
move ahead and i try to demonstrate the
multiplication operation so i take the
same variable result and i say multiply
it by 2. so whatever the value of result
was which at this place should be 2
multiply that value by 2. so 2 into 2
the new value of result should become 4
after this multiplication operation and
again i'm assigning the value of
original result to this particular
variable and then i am showcasing the
fourth mathematical arithmetic operation
which is division so you can see result
by 2 here so basically i'm whatever the
current value of result is i'm dividing
that value by 2 so 4 divided by 2 should
become 2 so again the new value of the
result variable should become 2
then i am printing the value and again
storing the value back into the original
result then the next operation is again
an addition operation where i whatever
the value of result is at this
particular point which is 2
add 8 to that particular value so the
new result value becomes 10
and then i'm printing that particular
value again assigning the original
result to the result and then to
showcase the remainder operation i'm
doing result
we call this particular operator as mod
or modulus so result modulus 7 so the
current value here is in this case would
be 10 so i'm saying 10 mod 7
so 10 mod 7 would become 3 because if we
divide 10 by 7 the remainder should be 3
and this modulus operator is used to
calculate the remainder of a division
operation so that 3 will be stored in
this result variable and then we print
that particular variable so that is what
i am doing if i take you back up there i
will just minimize this window and this
window as well so if i take you back to
the starting i'm doing an addition first
here at line 7 then i am doing a
subtraction at line 12
then i'm doing a multiplication at line
17 and a division at line 22
and then again an addition at line 27
and then a modulus at line 32 and i'm
printing the respective values so let us
run this program and see what results do
we get so i right click i go to run as i
go to java application there is also a
shortcut for it if you want to use the
shortcut you can use that so i click on
this and the output is displayed here so
you can see let me bring this output
back to its original position yeah i
just dragged it here to the top to the
bottom so if we start from the top and
see what all results did we get printed
so line 9 says 1 plus 2 equal to the
value of result so 1 plus 2 equal to at
this particular point the result value
was 3 because 1 plus 2 equal to 3
moving on the next variable here is
minus so the current value was 3 we said
3 minus 1 which becomes 2 and we store
the value of result or 3 into this
result variable and we print that value
at line 14. so original result plus
original result is 3
then a string here minus 1 equal to so
this is just a string
and then the actual current result value
which is 2. so far so good we move ahead
and then at line 19 we are multiplying
the current value of result by 2 and
again displaying the original result and
the current value so
2 is the original result here because
here 3 minus 1 had become 2 so original
result value was 2 multiply that by 2
becomes 4
then moving on to the line 24 2 by 4 by
2 should become 2 so 4 by 2 equals 2 the
current value of result then again
moving on to the next variable
at line 29
now the result value should become 10
because 2 plus 8 is 10 and again we are
printing the original result and then
the current result value so the original
result was 2 then we added 8 to it and
the new result value had become 10 which
is coming from this particular variable
moving on to line 34 we are again
printing the original result which was
10 here and then we are saying this
particular string which is modulus 7 and
the current value of result is coming
from this expression which is 10 modulus
7 and like i said modulus or mod
operation is basically used to calculate
the remainder of a division operation
which so 10 divided by 7 remainder is 3
so that becomes 3 and that's why you see
the value 3 so this is a demonstration
to show you how we can use the addition
multiplication subtraction division and
modulus operators which are all the
arithmetic operators so in the next
session we will be discussing about the
other operator types which are unary
operators and we will also discuss some
other interesting operators which are
popularly used in java let's get started
with junary operators so when we talk
about unary operators technically they
are also arithmetic operators but they
provide us a shorthand or they have a
more advanced meaning
so if you see on the screen these are
the
unary operators we call them as unary
plus unary minus
increment operator decrement operator
and logical complement operator so when
we talk about the unity plus operator
basically it is used to indicate a
positive value so whatever value you are
having it will just make that number as
positive number you might be wondering
that this plus has an addition meaning
as well right which we saw in the
previous example yes that's correct but
when we use that addition symbol we use
that between two variables but when we
talk about unary operators they are used
with a single variable that is why the
name unary because they are used with a
single variable they require only one
operand so
unary plus basically makes any number
positive usually minus negates an
expression and makes that number
negative
increment operator increments the value
by plus 1
decrement operator decreases the value
by -1 and logical complement operator
inverse the value of the expression from
true to false or false to true let's
understand this with the help of an
example so i have created a class here
called unary demo and i have a static
void main method here and i have created
a variable called result and the first
example is about using unary plus so i'm
creating a variable called as result
assigning the value as 1 and just
putting one plus in front of it which
makes this as positive value though we
can argue that this also has the same
effect as this and yes that is true but
in case if this value was written as
something like minus 1 instead of plus
then
we could basically make that number
positive by just putting plus in front
of it so that's basically the power of
unary operators and that's how you
generally use unary operators so i just
put it back to plus one the next example
is about decrement operators so the
current value of result was one because
we did this now we are saying result
minus minus which means whatever the
value of result is just decremented by
one so the current value was one so now
the new value of result after this
evaluation becomes zero
so at line 14 we print the current value
of result which is 0. moving on at line
16 we are using the increment plus plus
operator here which means whatever the
current value of result is just
increment it by 1
so the current value of result was 0
till this line so it becomes 1 because
this means increment by 1 so line 18
will basically print that value 1 and
then at line 20 i am using the unary
minus operator which means whatever the
value of result is just negate it just
put a negative in front of it just make
that number negative so if i just say
minus result the current value of result
was 1 so it became -1 and then to
showcase the negation operation i
created a boolean variable
named it as success assigned the value
of this variable as false and printed
the value of success variable as is
first
and then printed the value of success
with a negation in front of it with an
exclamation mark which will basically
flip the value or invert the value of a
boolean variable so if this was false
line 28 should print true if this was
true
line 28 should print false in this case
this is false so the line 28 should
print true so let's right click on this
and run this program and see if we get
the expected output and yes we see the
output here so let's try to interpret
the output now the line 10 should print
yes then line 14 should print 0 we see 0
here
line 18 should print 1 because we use
the increment plus plus so 0 plus 1
became 1
then we use the unary minus operator so
the value should become minus 1 yes we
see minus 1 here and then for boolean
variable we should see first the false
because the value is printed as is and
then we are printing a negated value so
we should flip the value from false to
true and yes it is printing the value as
true so this was about unary operators
now when we talk about this increment
and decrement operators what if i put
this particular value in front of result
what effect is that going to happen
let's analyze that part as well so for
that i have prepared a separate demo
again i've created a class called pre
post demo and it has a public static
void main method i'm declaring an
integer variable i with the value as 3
so the i becomes 3 here and then i'm
saying i plus plus as we have already
seen in the unary demo example this
should increment the value of 3 to 4 so
it will print 4 expected right then
at line number 9 i am putting this plus
plus in front of i
now what will happen
now it is going to increment the value
of i
and then basically assigning the value
of i so the whole difference between i
plus plus and plus plus i is that
in this case
the value of i is assigned first and
increment later
in this case the value of i is
incremented first and assigned later so
here the value from 4 becomes 5
so at line 11 if you see if we print i
it will print 5 because we have we are
saying that first increment the value
and then update the value of i so
increment happens on i equal to 4 and i
becomes 5.
at line number 13 it it becomes more
interesting because here inside the
system.out.println statement itself i'm
saying plus plus i now what will happen
like i explained first the value will be
incremented
and then the value will be assigned so
before printing the value is getting
incremented so the value from 5 becomes
6 here at line 13 but if i try to do
this
now i am saying
first assign the value of i
and then increment it so i at this line
is still 6
because i has already been assigned 6
and as the post increment says
if you put this plus plus after the
variable it means that you are first
assigning the value and then
incrementing the value so anything which
happens after line 15
the value of i will become 7 but at line
15 the value of i is still 6 because we
are using a post increment operator so
the value is still assigned to i as is
and then incremented and when we do
system.out.println the assigned value is
printed not the incremented value
so like i said after line 15 the value
of i will become incremented by 1 and it
will become 7. so hope you understood
this example or and the difference
between the pre-increment and post
increment remember the thumb rule that
if we put plus plus before a variable
like at line number nine the value will
be incremented first and then assigned
so at line 13
the updated value will be printed
because the first we are doing the
increment and then we are printing the
value for assigning the value similarly
at line 15 we are first printing the
value and then incrementing the value so
when the value is printed at line 15 the
old value of i will be printed but after
line 15 the new value of i will be
accessible to the program so let's right
click on this and run this program
and now if we see the values we assigned
i to 3 we did a post increment here so i
becomes 4 we print the value of i so
here the value of i is 4 we see 4 here
then at line line
9 we are saying plus plus i
so 4 plus 1 becomes 5 though this is a
pre increment but since we are not
printing this plus i as is
it does not have any any change so the
value of 4 becomes 5 at line 11 we print
5 then at line 13 we are saying plus
plus i which means increment the value
of i first and then assign it so the
value of 5 becomes 6 and then i gets
updated and printed similarly at line 15
first the value of i is assigned and
printed and then incremented so at line
15 the value is still 6
you see this 6 here and then the value
is incremented so after line 15 the
value becomes 7 so that's how we are
basically using the unary operators and
this is where i would like to end this
particular session in the next session
we will be discussing about other type
of operators which are comparison
operators and logical operators etc
let's get started with equality and
relational operators when we talk about
relational operators they are sometimes
also called comparison operators and the
basic idea behind using these operators
is to compare things or compare the
values of variables or compare the
objects in java so in java if you need
to compare anything for example if you
want to compare if something is less
than the other thing or something is
greater than the other thing or
something is equal to the other thing
then you need to use the comparison
operators which are provided by java
here you can see i have opened the
official java docs and you can see a
bunch of comparison or relational
operators both of the terms are used
interchangeably some people call them
comparison operators and some people
call them relational operators
so you can see if i want to compare if
an object or a value is equal to another
value then i use the double equal sign
if i want to compare for non-equality i
will use exclamation with an equal to
which means not equal to if i want to do
a greater than comparison then i will
use the mathematics greater than symbol
if i want to do the greater than equal
to or less than or less than equal to
they again follow the same kind of uh
terminology as we see in mathematics so
this is all we have in terms of the
relational operators so let's understand
the usage of these operators with the
help of some examples so as you can see
i have created a class here which is
called comparison operator there is a
public static void main method inside
this class and this method has two
variables of integer type called value
one and value two value one has a value
one and value two has the value two and
then i am trying to compare the value 1
and value 2 variables using the
different relational operators we just
covered for doing that i need to use a
conditional operator as well we will be
covering conditional operators in much
much detail in the upcoming lectures but
for now you can understand that when we
talk about conditional operators we talk
about if an else statement so if is
again a keyword in java which can be
used to compare things and the syntax is
very straightforward you write the if
keyword and then you write the actual
comparison syntax or the actual
comparison expression so in the first
example we can see that i am writing a
condition which says evaluate if value 1
is equal to value 2. i should put a
curly braces around here you can see
there are no curly braces here but that
is for a case when you have only one
statement under it but again i will
cover this in detail and i don't want to
confuse the audience here so i will just
put curly braces around all of these if
statements so that it becomes easy to
interpret what is actually going on in
these code blocks as we know that these
curly braces are used to define a code
block so the first if block says compare
if the value 1 is equal to the value 2.
if yes then this condition will become 2
and the control of the program will go
at line number 10. if this condition is
not true then the control will not go
inside 10 because this condition is
false so it will never go to line 10 and
it will move to line 11 or 12 instead
similarly the next condition is we are
comparing the value 1 is not equal to
value 2. so this condition will only be
true if these two values are not equal
or unequal and if that is the case then
line 14 will executed otherwise line 14
will not be executed similarly in this
condition i'm saying compare if value 1
is greater than value 2 or not so if the
actual value holded by value 1 variable
is greater than the value 2 variable
then this condition will become true and
the line 18 will be executed otherwise
it will be skipped then similarly at
line 20 i am doing the reverse i'm
comparing if value 1 is less than equal
less than value 2. if that is the case
then line 22 will be executed otherwise
it will be skipped and at last i'm also
showcasing an example of less than equal
to operator that you put less than and
equal to together and again you compare
the two variables similarly you can also
use greater than equal to variable
comparison operator as well in this
example so we have an example of
equality not equal to greater than less
than and less than equal to let's run
this example to understand so for
running the example i will just right
click here go to run as and click on
java application and we can see the
output here so as the value 1 holds the
value 1 and value 2 variable holds the
value 2 obviously 1 is not equal to 2 so
the first condition is not going to be
evaluated to true so line 10 will never
be executed because 1 is not equal to 2.
similarly if i talk about the next
condition which was if value 1 is not
equal to value 2 then execute statement
14 and yes 1 is not equal to 2 that's
why we see this particular
system.out.println here you see this
printed moving on is value 1 greater
than value 2 so is 1 greater than 2 no
it's not so line 18 will never be
executed then the next one is is value 1
less than value 2 so yes 1 is less than
2 so line 22 will be executed and we see
the line 22 output here
system.out.printer and output moving on
is 1 less than equal to 2 yes 1 is less
than equal to 2 so this particular
condition is also true and line 26 will
be executed and that's why we see this
here and that's all so we can see that
we are able to use these comparison or
relational operators to evaluate
different conditions and we write those
conditions using the if block and again
if you do not understand the if block
fully don't worry we will be covering
the if blocks in detail but the focus
here is in using the operators the not
equal to operators the greater than
equal to operators less than equal to
operators etc so i hope these operators
give you a better understanding of how
to use them now moving on to the next
section of this
comparison operators sometimes we also
use some logical terms to do the
comparison for example if i just move
down here and i show you these
conditions here we call them conditional
operators conditional operators are used
to evaluate the conditions like and or
or and we use them in two two ways
either we can use it as ampersand or
double ampersand or we can use them as
pipe or double pipes so the idea is
basically to evaluate if one condition
is true and other condition is also true
or one condition is true or other
condition is true so whenever you want
to combine two conditions together
that's where you're going to use these
logical operators or conditional
operators you can also use the simple
english keywords like and or or or you
can use the logical representation of
these keywords for example ampersand
ampersand or double ampersand is
equivalent to and similarly double pipe
is equivalent to or so we can use these
as well interchangeably you can use
either of these operator representations
to run a conditional check in
composition meaning you can compare two
conditions saying okay if one is true
and second is true or one is true or
second is true so the whole focus is
here in and and or comparisons so let's
switch back to the ide and let's look at
an example of this to understand this in
detail so i will again take the similar
kind of example again i have created two
variables here value 1 and value 2.
value 1 has value as 1 and second
variable value 2 has value as 2 and then
i'm writing two conditions this time in
the same if block you can see i am
writing first condition saying is value
1 equal to equal to 1 and is value 2
also equal to equal to 2 so this whole
if condition is only going to be true
only if both of the conditions are true
that's the property of and and will
force that both the conditions on the
left hand side of it and the right hand
side of it hold true and then only the
whole expression is going to hold true
even if one of the conditions evaluate
to false the whole if expression will
evaluate to false similarly for or
conditions we again write a left hand
condition and a right hand condition and
in between we write this double pipe we
can also write or or in english that
will also have the same effect and this
will evaluate in a way that this whole
expression this whole expression will
evaluate to true if even a single
condition either on left side or right
side of it becomes true so r will just
need one expression to be true to make
the whole if condition true whereas and
will force both of the conditions to be
true to make the whole expression as
true so and will require two truths to
actually become true but our condition
will require only one true to become
true so if we try to do uh understand
this logic here i am saying that if
value 1 is equal to equal to 1 which is
correct and value 2 is equal to equal to
2 then make this condition as true so
yes in this case this condition will
evaluate to true because value 1 has
value 1 1 and value 2 has value as 2 so
it will print the line 10 whereas in the
next condition i am saying evaluate if
value 1 is equal to equal to 1 or value
2 is equal to equal to 1 so either of
the expression if becomes true
either the left side this expression or
the right side this expression either of
the expression becomes true this whole
condition will become true and line 14
will be executed line 14 will not be
executed only in a case when both of the
conditions here become false for example
if i write it like this
then we know that value 1 is not equal
to 4 because it's 1 and value 2 is not
equal to 5 because it's true in that
case both of the expression will become
false and then line 14 will not be
executed if i write it like this then
the left hand expression is evaluated to
true because value 1 is 1 but the right
hand expression is false but it's fine
the line 14 will still be executed
because either of these side is true so
the whole expression becomes true
similarly here and will require both of
the expressions to be true and if either
of them becomes false the whole
expression becomes false so in the
current state line 10 will be executed
but if i change this to this then the
left hand side of this ampersand will
evaluate to false and the whole
expression will evaluate to false in
that case and line 10 will never be
executed let's try to run all of these
scenarios to make a better understanding
of this
so in this case both of the conditions
should work fine so i will just right
click and run as java application and
yes we see this line 10 being printed
and we also see this line 13 being
printed so both of the lines are printed
correctly both of the conditions are
evaluating to true now let's try to play
around with it let me change this value
to 4 so now value 1 this left hand side
expression is false which should make
the whole expression as false and it
should not print the line 10 which is
this statement so let's run this program
and see if that works yes we see that
this particular line is not printed now
because this whole expression became
false because the left hand side of this
expression became false similarly in the
r case either of them have to have to be
true you can see currently value 2 equal
to equal to 5 condition will actually
result in a false condition because this
is not a true value 2 is actually 2 not
5 and still we see this particular
expression because either of them have
to be true if i make both of them as not
true now both of the conditions on the
left hand side of pipe and right hand
side of pipe are false conditions what
will happen now nothing will be printed
the reason for that is that value 1 is
also that this condition is also false
and value 2 condition is also false so
the whole expression became false and
this was already false so this is all i
wanted to cover in this lecture we
covered our about the comparison
operators and how to use them and in the
next lecture we are going to talk about
the bitwise operators let's get started
with bitwise operators now bitwise
operators are very less commonly used in
the java programming world generally we
don't use them and generally we don't
need to use them you would generally use
them when you are doing really complex
bit wise calculation where you need to
manipulate the bits now what are
actually bits so if you remember when we
talked about the integer type variables
we talked about how much memory each of
the variable type or data type was going
to consume we said that this will take
one byte and this will take two bytes
etc one byte is basically made up of
eight bits and bits are nothing but
positions where either a zero is stored
or one is stored actually the whole
machine will convert your whole program
ultimately in zeros and ones which are
nothing but bits so if you want to do
the manipulation at that level so now
you can understand you are you are
actually working at right at the machine
level understanding so if you want to
manipulate the bits which are going to
be understood by the machine at that
level then you can use bitwise operators
but like i said generally we don't need
to use them now when we talk about
bitwise operators there are multiple
ways in which we can use them we can use
them with the standard and or operations
if you remember we covered this and or
operations in the previous lecture you
see a difference here that in case of
and we are using a single ampersand or
and not double ampersand this is one of
the concept which we did not covered in
the previous lecture and i would just
like to brief you about this concept
that if you use double ampersand that is
also called a short circuit operator and
if you use a single ampersand that is
called a standard operator to build an
understanding about this i will just
quickly recap of what we covered in the
last lecture and we'll try to explain
these concepts as well so let's go to
the logical operator demo and here if
you remember there were two ampersands
and two pipes
this is also a valid expression a single
amp percent is also a valid expression
the only change is
in this case
even if the left hand condition
evaluates to false
still the right hand condition will be
evaluated although we know that in case
of and either of the expression needs to
be false and the whole expression
becomes false so java provides an
advantage or with that if you use double
ampersand and if the left hand operation
becomes false then it will not cover the
right hand operation it will not even
evaluate the right hand operation
because it doesn't matter if the left
hand operation has already returned to
false or evaluated to false then no
matter whether right side is true or
false the whole expression is still
going to be false right that's the
property of and
one of these side has to be false and
the whole expression becomes false so
why why evaluate two sides why waste the
memory in evaluating the right side when
the left side has already turned as
false java takes advantage of that and
that's why if you use double ampersand
you save a bit of processing power of
your computer by just evaluating the
left hand condition and if the left hand
condition is false it will skip
evaluating the right hand condition and
just make the whole expression false but
if you use this
a single ampersand then both side of the
expression will be evaluated
irrespective of their output so in this
case even if the left hand expression is
false it is still going to evaluate the
right side expression and similarly it
works for the or case as well in this
case in our case as we know if one of
the condition is true the whole
condition becomes true the whole
expression becomes true so if the left
hand side becomes true and if you use a
single pipe then it will still evaluate
the right height side but if you use
double pipe like this then if the left
hand side becomes true then it knows
that it does not matter if the right
hand side becomes true or false because
ultimately the whole expression is going
to be true if either of the side is true
so the left hand side is already true it
will not evaluate the right hand side
and it will say the whole expression is
true that's why you see the
single ampersand being used for bitwise
just to explain why it why it is used
and how it is used for or operations in
bitwise you use this cap or whatever you
want to call it as and for
the inclusive bitwise or
operation you're going to use a single
pipe you also use some shift operations
where you shift the value of bit of a
particular variable to either left or
right again these are again very complex
calculations if you want to use that
please read about this and use that but
in the in today's demo what we are going
to cover is the and and or examples of
bitwise operations
so here i have again created a class
called bitwise operator i have a public
static void main method
i have two variables here which are int
a equal to 5 and into b equal to seven
now these five and seven
are actually stored as bits
as zeros and ones in the computer's
memory so how they are actually stored
they are stored in a standard bit
representation which you may have
studied in your mathematics if to give
you a recap this 5 will basically be
written in a memory as this
0 1 0 1 and it starts from here 2 raised
to power 0 into 1 becomes 1 2 raised to
the power 1 into 0 becomes 0 2 raised to
power 2
into 1 becomes 4 and 2 raised to power 3
into 0 becomes 0 so 4 0 plus 4 plus 0
plus 1 becomes 5 and that's how 5 is
displayed to you similarly for 7 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 plus 2
raised to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 1 plus
2 3
plus 2 raised to power 2
into 1 which is 4 so 1 plus 2 plus 4 7
and 2 raised to power 3 into 0 is 0. so
0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1 which is 7 and
that's how this 7 is built and stored
and now if you try to do this if you try
to write this condition you can also
write the condition into a
system.out.println block and it will
basically evaluate this condition so now
if you say a and b
in this case this is going to do a
bitwise operation because this is
bitwise operand it is going to do a
bitwise operation and what would be the
result if you do an and on this so again
use the same logic as if in case of and
if one is false then the whole
expression is false so 0 and 0 becomes 0
and 1 becomes 1
and 1 becomes 0 because 0 means false
and 1 means true so if either of them is
false the whole evaluation becomes false
so that's why 0 or and 1 becomes 0 and 1
and 1 is always 1. the value of this is
again 5 as we already have evaluated
similarly if you do a bitwise or and if
you do this again we are doing an or
operation so 0 or 0 or basically false
or false becomes false true or
true becomes true false or true should
be true because one of them needs to be
true so this is false but this is true
so the whole value becomes true and the
finally true or true is also true so
this is the final bitwise or result and
if we convert this into an integer
representation that becomes 7 because 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 2 raised
to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 2 plus 1 3
plus 2 raised to power 2 into 1 which is
4 so 4 plus 2 plus 1 which is 7 and plus
2 raised to power 3 into 0 which is 0.
so 0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1 becomes 7 and
that's how you get actually 7 so let's
see if we get 5 or 7 in this bit wise
operation yes we can see the values as 5
and 7 so this is a bit wise operation
happening similarly you can also use the
shift operations where in case if you're
using the this particular kind of
representation or this particular kind
of representation they are called which
they are called left shift and right
shift operations so if you use this in
front of a variable then for example
this one will be shifted here and this
zero will be shifted here and this one
will be shifted here so that's how the
whole value is going to shift all bits
are going to shift one by one towards
left similarly if you are using the
right shift then all the bits are going
to be shifted towards right by one bit
that's the whole concept of left shift
and right shift bitwise operations and
if you want to know more about this
please read some official examples from
the java doc and some other examples
available on the internet to build an
understanding on this so this is all i
wanted to cover in this lecture so in
the next session we are going to talk
about the control flow statements like
if else etc let's get started with
control flow statements so what are
control flow statements and why do we
need them control flow statements are
the ones which can help you control and
define the flow of execution in your
program now why do we need them is
because if we want to evaluate some
conditions or we want to create some
branches of execution saying that if
this condition becomes true do this and
if this condition becomes false do that
so you can see there are two different
branches of execution of a program in
this kind of approach and that's where
control flow statements can help us
there are a lot of different types of
control flow statements like if then
else and switch and for and while and do
while and we are going to cover all of
them in detail in this series so let's
get started with the first one which is
the if statement we covered briefly
about this when we talked about
operators and i promised you guys that i
will be covering this in detail and this
is the session where we will go deeper
into this concept as we have already
understood that if condition is
basically used to evaluate a condition
if it is true or false the result of an
if statement will always have only two
values it can either have a true value
or it can have a false value there is no
other possibility or there is no other
value of an if statement or of an if
expression now like i explained if you
want to do a simple programming
execution where you say if a particular
condition becomes true do this
and if this becomes false then do that
it means you need to write this else
condition as well that if this doesn't
hold true what do i do and how do i
write that so let's understand that with
the help of an example for this
particular example i've created a class
and there is a public static void main
method which is the entry point of this
program's execution i have a variable
which is called test score this is an
integer variable with the value 76
and i have a care variable which is
grade basically what i'm doing that
based on the test score marks i'm trying
to define the grades which a student
will get so for that i have built a
condition here so you can see it starts
with if which is a keyword then you put
these standard braces or brackets and
you write your condition inside it in
this case i am writing the condition
saying that if test score is greater
than equal to 90
then the student should get an grade a
so here i've defined this grade variable
and here i'm just assigning the value to
the grade variable at line 11 if the
test score is greater than 90 the grade
should be a but what if the score is not
90 what if this condition becomes false
and you want to do something in that
case you can write this else block here
we call this else block so you write
else as the keyword you start the curly
braces and then you define the grade if
the score is not greater than 90 what
should be the grade of the student so in
this case we are saying the grade is f
so if we try to run this example in our
in our mind we see that the value is of
the test score is 76 so 76 is not
greater than equal to 90 so this
particular condition will not be true so
line 11 will not be executed but instead
else block will be executed because if
the condition goes false then else block
should be executed as per java so this
block will be executed and grade will
get a value of f and then we are
printing this grade value by just
writing a
system.out.println a string plus the
value so let's run this particular
program and see what happens
we get a grade equal to f here in this
cis out or system.out.println
because this condition was false so the
control the flow of the control of the
program went to line 12 and then to line
30 because this was the else block so
this is one understanding where we can
write an if and else logic you in some
cases you might not need an else block
so else block is not mandatory it's an
optional block if you want to remove
this and if you just want to do a sis
out here that is also fine cis out means
system.out.println
for shorthand we sometimes call it
sysout so you can
do something here as well if you don't
need dell's block if you need this block
feel free to write it but this is an
optional block but in some cases your
conditions will be more complicated than
just a single condition if you try to
understand it from a real world example
in real world you will not have only two
grades as a and f you will have more
grades right a b c d so on so forth
so what are you going to do in that case
for that kind of case
java provides us with an keyword which
is called
else if else if is just a continuation
of if saying that okay if this condition
doesn't hold true evaluate the next one
with an else if so i've commented out
this code let me put this code back into
its place and then we will walk through
this code to understand it okay so i
have put the code back to where it
should be and this is how it looks like
so let's just walk through this the line
10 and 11 doesn't change it's still the
same but then i have added some
additional conditions saying that okay
if the score is greater than equal to 90
the grade should be a
but if the score is
not greater than 90 but
greater than equal to 80 then the grade
should be b
similarly if the score is not even
greater than 80 but greater than equal
to 70 then the grade should be c
similarly if the score is nev not even
greater than equal to 70 but greater
than equal to 60 which means basically
between 60 to 70 then the grade should
be d
and if the score is even below 60 then
the grade should be f so you can see i
have basically defined the whole logic
for defining the grades here and it
always works in a top down approach one
by one the way in the sequence in which
you will define the else if block will
be the sequence in which they will be
executed so after the condition at line
10 and if this condition fails
line 12 will be naturally executed if
this condition also fails line 14 will
be executed and so on so forth it will
never be the case that if this condition
fails then suddenly line 16 is executed
and then again line 12 is executed it
will always work in a line by line
fashion so make sure whenever you are
using the else if statements
write it in a sequence in which you want
the natural program to be executed so
this is all we have here and now let's
try to run this example let me just
bring the
system.out.println alignup save this
file right click run as
java application so we see the value is
grade equal to c which means
this particular code block was actually
executed only this condition held true
now now let's try to understand how this
happened the value was 76 so 76 greater
than 90 no this condition becomes false
so line 11 is never executed it
naturally goes to line 12 because that's
where we have defined the next else if
block
is 76 greater than equal to 80 no it's
not so line 12 condition also becomes
false line 13 never gets executed and
the control shifts to line 14 and there
we have the condition saying that is 76
greater than equal to 70 yes this
condition is true so the line 15 gets
executed and once this condition gets
true
none of the further conditions will be
executed because you only need one true
statement one true execution in the
whole if else if block if that one code
block gets true that code block is
executed and then the execution jumps
out of the
if else if blocks and it will directly
go to line 22 and it will execute that
had it been the case that this
particular block was also evaluated to
false it would go to line 16 and if this
was also false it would go to the block
which is else block let's see that let's
make this value as 56 so now
56 is not greater than 70 so line 15
will never be executed because this
condition will evaluate to false 56 is
greater than 60 no so this will also be
false and ultimately the grade should
fall to
else block where we are assigning the
grade as f let's see yes we get the grid
f because ultimately this block was
executed because all of the above
conditions evaluated to false
so this is all i wanted to cover in this
if else if demo there is another edition
of another way of writing if statements
which we call as nested if where we have
an if block inside an if block inside an
if block and so on and so forth how do
we write that and how does the control
flows in that kind of an execution we
will cover that in the next session
let's get started with using nested if
statements in java now in the previous
lecture we saw how we can use an if else
block and also an if else if else block
but there is another case where we can
use these if statements and that is when
you have nested if blocks when would you
use it let's take an example let's say
you have multiple conditions to check on
a particular program and where the
output of the first condition is the
input of the second condition and the
output of the second condition is the
input to the third condition and so on
so forth if you have that kind of
situation you can write it in a nested
if statement kind of block so let's
understand this with the help of an
example as you can see i have opened an
example here which is about nested if
statements i've created a class which
which is named as nested if demo and i
have created a public static void main
method inside this particular class and
now i have declared an integer variable
with the value 50 then i am checking the
first condition saying if i equal to
equal to 50. if that condition is true
then i will check the next condition
which is if i is less than 75 and then i
am adding one more hypothetical
condition saying if this is true then
also check if i is less than 55 so you
can see if i equal to 50 holds true then
only this condition will be executed
similarly if i is less than 75 then only
this condition will be executed so they
are dependent upon each other this
condition block is dependent upon the
previous block to be true and this if
condition block is dependent upon this
if block to be true if either of these
if blocks don't go true the next
subsequent nested if block will not be
executed so in this case i am checking
it for first equality condition saying
if the value is equal to 50 then execute
this statement at line number 10 then
check if i is less than 75 if that is
also true execute the statement at light
number 12 and then if i is also less
than 55 then also execute line number
14. i can also add an else block as well
anywhere in this nested hierarchy if i
want to if i add an else block here that
else block will be corresponding to this
block if i add an else block here and
that else block will be corresponding to
this if block and if i add an else block
here then that else block will be
corresponding to this particular if
block so you can also use those elsif
and else blocks as well with nested if
blocks and make it as complicated as you
want it to be so that's about this
program and let's see if we run this
program what output do we get and let's
interpret that output so i'll just right
click run as java program and i see some
output in the console first i get i is
50 so line number 10 gets printed
because i is 50 then i also see the next
line
output as i is smaller than 75 it means
this condition was also true because 50
is less than 75 so line 12 also got
executed and then i'm checking if i is
less than 55 so yes 50 is less than 55
so line 14 also gets executed and we get
this statement on the console so this
was a simple way to see how we can
implement the nested if conditions now
we are also going to talk about another
concept which is used in writing the if
conditional blocks which is called
ternary operators so ternary operators
are used as a shorthand of writing if
else block as you can see that these if
blocks are quite verbose we have to
write a lot of code to actually write
some conditions in this case i'm
executing three conditions but the code
is
almost seven lines or eight lines so we
will see how we can simplify this if we
use a ternary operator and for that i
have created another class which is
called ternary operator demo and this
particular class again has a public
static void main which is the entry
point of this particular program and
then i have declared couple of variables
first is int a equal to 1 and second one
is int b equal to 2 i have also declared
a result variable and we will see how we
can use this result variable and at line
10 i have written my if else expression
so you can see this if else expression
doesn't look like the one which we have
seen before so let's understand how do
we write it if you're trying to write an
if else expression with ternary
expressions or ternary statements then
the first thing which you need to
understand is the structure of it so
here at first you will specify the
actual condition which you want to test
in your if block so this is my condition
then after that condition you are going
to put a question mark and after the
question mark you are going to put the
actual result which you want to be
executed if this condition becomes true
so if the if condition becomes true what
do you want to do whatever is that you
will write it here and then if the
condition becomes false then the logic
should go into the else block and the
else logic should come after this colon
so all you need to remember is this
question mark and this colon before the
question mark you are going to write the
condition after the question mark you
are going to write the statement which
is going to be executed if this if
condition becomes true and after the
colon you are going to write the else
block condition which is going to be
executed if this condition becomes false
another thing to notice is that ternary
operators can be used only in cases when
you have only one statement to execute
in if block and one statement to execute
in else block it cannot be more than one
statements so instead of this you can
also write
system.out.println here which will also
be fine if i just write this system dot
out dot print not print f but i want to
write println so i'll just write println
you can also do this this is also fine
you don't need to store the result
obviously uh but but you can also write
this condition in a way but this all
this only has to be a single statement
it cannot be more than one statement
because this expression can only hold
one statement at a time so use it in
situations where you have to check a
condition and do something in the if
block which is only one statement and
again one statement in the else block
the same expression can also be written
in a verbose if else way in which we
have been saying it before and we'll
also i will also show that to you and
here where this a and b is going this is
getting stored in this variable called
result so if this if condition holds
true then the result is a and this is
going to be stored here and if it is
going into the else block then b is
going to be stored in the result block
let's run this program so we can see we
get the value 1 because we have set the
condition as a less than b so yes 1 is
less than 2 so this particular statement
gets executed and this value gets stored
here in the result variable so that's
how you can use the ternary operators to
write shorthand if else statements the
same expression can also be written in a
verbose way for example you can write it
in this way saying if a is less than b
then result equal to a else result equal
to b this code has exactly the same
effect as this one line of code so you
can see this is this is pretty
simple to write pretty short to write
the code which i'm writing here in four
lines can be written here in one line
and that's the power of ternary
operators so this is all i wanted to
cover in today's session so we talked
about nested if statements and the
ternary operators here how to use them
in the next session we are going to
discuss about switch case statements
let's get started with using switch
statements in java so let us first
understand why do we need switch
statements generally whenever you want
to check a condition you can use an if
else block but what if you have multiple
conditions to check what if you have so
many possible execution paths that it
becomes too verbose to write it into an
if else kind of block what if you have
to check on constant values of certain
expressions how do you do that it
becomes even more challenging and the
code becomes even more verbose so in
such cases switch statement can be used
in which you can write switch statement
to have as many possible execution paths
as you want and it will work with
constant values as well so let's
understand this with the help of an
example as how and why will we use the
switch statements so for that i have
created this class which is called
switch demo and it also has a public
static void main method which is the
entry point and in this program what i'm
doing is i'm trying to accept a number
as the month number in the program and
then with that particular number i'm
trying to print the corresponding
month's name so that's the logic pick a
month number and you should get the
month's actual name so now in this case
you can you can imagine there will be at
least 12 if else if blocks which is a
long line of if else statements at the
same time if we try to do this for other
conditions where the value is constant
please understand that the value of
month is going to be constant it's going
to be the same number so it's not
similar to you evaluating a condition
it's similar to you evaluating a
condition to a particular constant value
imagine if you have to do some sort of a
classification of employees in higher
salaries and lower salaries and there
are hundreds of salary bands in the
company so are you going to write 100 if
else logics that is going to take a long
time and then what if new bands get new
bands get introduced then it gets even
more complex so we will use switch case
statements in cases where there are lots
of if else conditions and the expression
evaluates to a constant value remember
in the if else cases the expression
evaluates to a boolean value so here i'm
supplying the month value as six then
i'm also creating a string month one
string variable just to print or store
the name of the month and then the way
you write the switch statement is to
write the switch keyword and then in the
brackets you supply the month integer
value and then you start writing your
conditions so you can see you write the
case as keyword and then you write the
number or the possible values this
particular variable or this particular
expression can hold so all the possible
values this particular expression can
hold will be written individually as
cases so case equal to one here one
means the value of month is one in that
case the month string which we created
here shall store january and then we see
a statement called break so break is
again a keyword java and this keyword
has a special meaning it has a special
usage you will use the keyword break to
abruptly break the control of execution
from the current code block and the code
block is identified with curly braces so
here you can see the curly brace starts
from here and it ends
down to line number 51 at here so the
moment your java program is going to
encounter this particular statement it
is going to jump out of the current code
block execution and continue thereafter
that's the basic logic and usage of
break statement so use it whenever you
want to skip the rest of the code after
the break statement if you don't want to
execute the rest of the code you will
write break and the moment the java
program sees this particular statement
it will jump out of the current code
block specified by the curly braces and
will resume execution after the code
block so in this case it will resume the
execution after the line 51. that's the
usage and meaning of this expression
called break so in this case we are
saying that if the month value is 1
which we denoted as here case 1 then
store the value of the month string as
january and break out of this particular
code block because we don't need to
execute any further we have found a
match then another case would be if the
month value is 2 so you write case which
is a keyword and then the exact
expression value the constant value
which is 2 and if that's the case then
one string becomes february and again
you break because in this particular
case there will only be one condition
true at a time there will never be a
case that month with the value 2 will
have two meanings will have two month
names a month with the value two will
always have a meaning called february it
will never have two meanings or two
month names attached to the same integer
value and that's why you do not want to
execute any further and that's why you
write this break statement if you do not
write this bake statement it is going to
evaluate all of the cases one by one
even if the cases are not going to be
true but it is going to waste lot of
processing time evaluating all the case
conditions which you have written here
which does not make sense because we
know that only one condition at a time
can be true here because we are
evaluating and checking for a constant
value which is an integer value so
that's the reason we put a break in each
case if intentionally if you want to
check multiple cases do not put a break
statement but the program can become
really confusing in that case so take
your wise call so here we put a break in
each case similarly case 3 the month
string becomes march case 4 the month
string becomes april case 5 becomes may
case 6 becomes june case 7 we have one
string as july case 8 month string is
august case nine we store the monstring
as september case 10 as october case 11
as november and case 12 as december
after that you will also see an
interesting block called default this is
the another capability of switch
statement that what if none of the above
conditions hold true what if we specify
a value which is not between 1 and 12
and it will not match any of the cases
which we saw just above and if you want
to execute some code in that case if
none of the conditions matches you may
want to execute some default execution
also in such cases you are going to use
default default is the code block which
will be executed if none of the case
matches so here you can see that if none
of the cases match then we are going to
store the value of month string variable
as invalid month and then we'll
eventually break out and once we break
out of this program we just want to
print the month string that's all we are
doing in this program that we take an
integer value as the month number and
then we print the corresponding month
name here by looking at the case blocks
and we also default define our default
case block if none of the conditions
hold true so let's run this program we
have specified the value as 6 which
should result in the month name as june
and yes we can see we get june let's
change the value and let's put the value
as 10 and see what do we get so right
click run as java application and we got
october yes exactly correct let's put an
invalid value as 13 and let's see what
happens now now we get invalid month so
our default code block just got executed
because we entered a value which is not
matching any of the case conditions
which we have specified so this is how
you are going to use the switch and case
statements while writing your conditions
whenever your condition evaluates to
multiple constant values remember the
the key here is to understand if your
expression is evaluating to multiple
constant values which do not change and
in those cases using a switch case block
is a better idea than writing if else
statements so that is all what we are
going to cover in today's session and in
the next session we are going to
understand something about
two-dimensional arrays and
multi-dimensional arrays as well let's
get started with understanding arrays in
detail we have been talking about arrays
throughout this course of java in the
previous sessions as well and we have
covered some basic understanding of how
to create arrays how to declare them how
to fill values in the array and how do
we print the array with positions as
well as the array as whole but whatever
examples which we took previously were
one dimensional arrays because arrays
can have more than one dimensions as
well you can create a one-dimensional
array you can create a two-dimensional
array you can create even a
three-dimensional array and you can go
up to as many dimensions as you can
handle in your java program so it
depends upon the kind of complexity you
want to have in your program and the
kind of values the kind of structure you
are going to store in your arrays and
based on that need you can choose
whether you want to use a 1d array or
one dimensional array or a 2d array or a
3d array and so on in these sessions we
are going to talk about 1d arrays 2d
arrays and 3d arrays and after that
we'll leave up to you to try out more
dimensionals if you want to we have
already covered the basic array
structures which were one-dimensional
arrays so i will just give you a quick
walkthrough of how we actually handled
one-dimensional arrays so this is a
sample program to demonstrate
one-dimensional arrays if you remember
this is how we use to create arrays we
write the data type of the array and
then we write the square boxes which
denote that this is an integer array
data type we assign a variable to this
and then we initialize the array with
the size 4. so new is the keyword which
is used to initialize anything in java
and we are going to use this heavily
when we talk about classes and objects
and even collections literally any
object which you want to create in java
requires a new keyword so here i'm
writing new and then int4 which means
create an array of size 4 and then i'm
filling the value of the four positions
which i have created as part of this
array and if you remember when we create
these kind of arrays we store them in a
zero index based position the first
value gets stored at zeroth index
position and then so on so forth so it
will always start from zero and never
start from one remember that and after
that we just print all the values of
individual positions of the elements in
the array and if i just run this program
all of the elements of this particular
array should be printed one by one so if
i just show the full console of the
output we can see that element in index
0 was 10 element index 1 was 20 element
at index 2 was 30 and element at index 3
was 40. so this was just a quick
refresher of how one-dimensional arrays
can be written and whenever you declare
a very simplistic array it will
generally be a one-dimensional array now
let's look at the two-dimensional arrays
and how do we write them when do we need
them for that i have created another
example which is says two-dimensional
array i just created a class and it has
a public static void main method and
i've created a two dimensional array
this time so let's understand this two
dimensional array in a bit detail and
when do we need that generally you would
need to use two dimensional arrays
whenever you are trying to do any matrix
calculations
if you if you understand what do you
mean by matrix it's basically a two by
two structure which stores the values in
the form of rows and columns so imagine
a table of two rows and two columns then
it will be a two by two matrix so if you
want to store that particular table in a
java program you would need to store
that as a matrix as a two-dimensional
matrix rows being the one-dimensional
and column being the other dimension and
that's what we are doing here and if you
want to
store that 2d matrix in a java program
the approach and the procedure for it is
pretty similar to how you create a
one-dimensional array with slight
changes
the first change is instead of a single
square bracket you are going to write
two square brackets because it is a two
dimensional array so remember the number
of square brackets you are going to put
while initializing and declaring the
array is the number of dimensions which
your array is going to have since this
is a two dimensional array example
that's why you see two brackets here if
this was a three dimensional array
example you will see three array three
square brackets here and so on so forth
so that's the first part of it second
part to understand is to how to store
the data remember i told you always
imagine the structure of rows and
columns whenever you are trying to store
a two-dimensional array in java so what
are rows and what are values and how do
you represent them while you declare and
initialize a two-dimensional array so
you start with the curly braces as a
normal 1d array but inside the curly
braces you create nested curly braces
blocks we can see three blocks here they
start with their own curly brace and end
with their own then this curly brace
starts here and ends here and then this
curly brace starts here and ends here
idea is that you provide this outer
curly braces to define the overall
structure and then inside each of the
curly braces is going to represent a row
in your two-dimensional array so each of
these values these blocks is going to
represent a row so i can say that this
is the first row this is the second row
and this is the third row and if i try
to visualize it in terms of columns then
this is the first row first column first
row second column first row third column
similarly second row first column second
row second column second row third
column and third row first column third
row second column and third row third
column so individual values are going to
be represented as columns and the whole
curly braces is going to be represented
as arrays that's the basic mental idea
or mental image you should have while
declaring a two dimensional arrays
remember to declare the rows inside the
nested curly braces and whatever
elements you have will automatically be
indexed as columns
another thing to remember that since
this is an array data structure
everything starts from 0 and nothing
starts from 1 so this will be row 0 this
will be row 1 and this will be row 2 i
am talking about the position we can
still call it as first row 2nd row and
3rd row but the position of this
particular row element is 0 the position
of this particular row element is 1 and
this particular row element is 2.
similarly for column as well this is
column 0 column 1 and column 2.
similarly column 0 column 1 and column 2
and so on so forth once you understand
this data structure well and you have
defined it correctly then everything
should fall in place if you want to do a
matrix addition or if you want to do a
matrix multiplication or a dot product
all of the kind of calculations can be
performed using the 2d array concept
here in this program what i'm doing is i
am printing the values of this
particular 2d array into a matrix style
and you see some strange code here which
is for etc don't worry about this i'm
going to cover in detail what this 4
means and how do you write this for now
what we can understand that we just want
to print this you might not need to
print this in your java programs when
you write a production grid application
but you might want to do manipulations
on these arrays as metrics maybe you
want to create a transpose of a matrix
or you want to do a dot product or
addition or subtraction or whatever be
your use case in this case just for
demonstration purpose i am printing the
values as rows and columns nothing else
so this all of this code from line 8 to
line 14 or in fact line 13 is just
showing how to print the values you can
see some system dot out and you can see
some construct here and like i said
don't worry about this i will cover this
in detail let's run this program and see
if my java array is stored correctly and
how can i represent this so you can see
i have represented it in a style of a 2d
matrix where this is the first row this
is the second row and this is the third
row similarly this is the first column
containing the value 237 so column 0
will have value 2 and
column 1 will have this value 3 and
column 2 will have this value 7 for row
0. let me also do something here which
can help you understand this concept
better let me do a
system.out.println and let's print an
individual value because like i said the
for loop can be confusing here to
understand so let's say i want to print
arr of
zeroth row first column and see what
kind of values do we get let me comment
this code comment is control backslash
and this code will be commented and this
code will not be executed and now only
line 15 will be executed instead of the
four block so if i run this i get the
value 7 so row 0 and first column row 0
first column is 7. let's try with 1 1 i
want to print the
row at z one position remember not the
first row but the one position row which
is basically technically the second row
so second row second column and see what
kind of values value do i get in this
case i get six so second row second
column similarly if you change this
value to two then third row second
column which should point to four yes we
get four similarly you can write a value
here as 0 and you can write a value here
as let's say 2 this will print this is a
simple demonstration of how you can use
two-dimensional arrays and in this
session we also did a refresher of
one-dimensional array so that's all for
this session and in the next session we
are going to be discussing how we can
define three-dimensional arrays and
we'll also see an example of it let's
get started with how to create and use a
three-dimensional array or how to go
about using multi-dimensional arrays in
java so as you can see from this image
we talked about 1d array which is having
just one axis then we talked about 2d
arrays in the last session where we had
rows and columns basically an x-axis and
a y-axis and then we can also have a 3d
array which will have three axises which
will have an x-axis a y-axis
and also a z-axis
think of a simple box which every box in
this world will always have at least
three dimensions and from from here you
can go even build more complex arrays
which can have four dimensions or five
dimensions or as many dimensions as you
want it to have and today we are going
to look at an example of how can we
build a 3d array and how do we access
those elements but this picture is just
to show you the mental model of when you
will be creating a 3d array so for
example generally an image data is
stored in in three dimensions so you can
you might want to store the image data
into a 3d array and there can be many
other use cases in the mathematical and
research computational use cases where
you might want to use a 3d array so but
remember there's an x axis there's a
y-axis and then there's a third axis
which is called the z-axis
so let us look at a java program to
understand how we can build a
three-dimensional array and for that i
have created this class which is called
multi-dimensional array it has a entry
point method which is the public static
void main method and then i have created
an integer array and this time instead
of one or two square brackets i have
three square brackets and if you
remember i mentioned this in the
previous session as well the number of
square brackets which you're going to
put while initializing the array is the
number of dimensions of the array and
since in this particular program i'm
going to demonstrate a three dimensional
array that's why you see three square
blocks boxes let me just minimize this
yep so we have three square boxes here
and we have created the variable name as
arr or short form as array then we start
with the outermost curly braces as is
then we put another curly braces which
starts from here and it ends here then
another set of curly brace which starts
from here and end here so this is the
this is the first dimension this is the
second dimensions and these are the
third dimensions that's how you're going
to define the different dimensions
remember this is the first dimension
when the first curly brace starts then
you have this second dimension which
covers this hole and this hole and then
you have third dimension which are these
so that's how you are going to visualize
and and put the three dimensions in use
while declaring a three dimensional
array and the values work in the same
fashion it's it's a zero index based
position so since we do not have an
official name for the third dimension so
i'm just going to use x-axis y-axis and
z-axis to refer to the three axises so
this would be x of 0
this would be y of 0 and this would be z
of 0. similarly x of 1 y of 1 and z of 1
and so on so forth so now if i try to
access the value which is at zeroth x
position
first y position and second z position
what's the value do we get here let's
run this program and understand and
interpret the output okay
so when we ran this program we got the
output as 11 so let's understand this
output so when we say the zeroth
position on x the first position on y
and the second position on z
so this is the zeroth position on x
and this is the first position on y
and then
this element is 0 1 2 is the second
position on the z axis so to to describe
it in a nutshell this defines the x axis
so we have two elements on the x axis
here this one and this one then we have
two elements on the y-axis on each
x-axis so this is one this is two on the
first x-axis and this is one and this is
two on the second y second x-axis
so two x and 2y and then on the z-axis i
have three elements each
so hope this helps you understand and
visualize this so
x-axis and this one is other x-axis and
then y-axis y-axis and then elements
inside this are z-axis
so i'm saying zero with x-axis in this
block first on the y-axis which is this
block and then second element or the z
or second position element on this
particular axis in this particular block
which is 11 and that's why we get 11. if
i print
0 let's say
i change this particular value as 1. so
now the output should be coming from
this side so
second x position because it's one
second y position so this will go here
and then the two position which is the
third element of the z axis which is 13.
so let's see if we get 13. yes we get 13
here so this is just to show you how you
can interpret this particular array and
always be mindful of how you are
structuring this array if your structure
is gone wrong then your program will
become useless and it will give you a
lot of unpredictable outputs which might
not make sense and which may introduce
errors in your program so be very
careful how you define the structure of
the elements here that's the key and
after that you just need to understand
the x-axis the y-axis and the z-axis
always remember all the accesses start
from zero so when i say two i'm
basically referring to the third element
and not the second element so this is
all i wanted to cover in this particular
session where we describe how we can use
a three dimensional array and from here
you can go to any lens like i said you
can add more square brackets here and go
to four dimension or five dimension or
six dimension but remember the more
dimensions you add the more complexity
of the program will be having the
program will become more and more
difficult to debug and understand so
always try to take a wise call as to how
many dimensions you want to use in your
array and that's it for this particular
session in the next session we are going
to talk about the different loop
statements in java let's get started
with today's topic which is about how to
use do while loops now in the previous
session we covered the usage of while
loops but we have another type of while
loop which is called a do while loop so
let's understand when do we need that
and how do you actually use that let me
switch to the java documentation and if
i can find some syntax of it as well yep
so as you can see here if i just
highlight this portion this is how you
actually write a do while statement
block so you write do you start a code
block you write some executable
statements and then after the code block
ends you write a while expression and
end it with semicolon this is the syntax
basically it starts with do or curly
braces some executable statements a
while block or a while statement
basically with an expression ending with
a semicolon let's understand this with
the help of a program to understand the
structure better so for this i have
created a sample program here which is
called do while demo again having a
public static void main method and it
has a variable
which is count and it is initialized as
one then i write do i write this code
block or the curly braces and then i am
just printing the value of count then i
am incrementing the value of count and
then i am writing a condition which says
while count is less than 10 and
semicolon if you compare this with the
previous demo we ran if i just put them
side by side we had while condition
statement
and
the state change condition here we have
do statement condition change statement
and then we check the condition at the
end so the idea is that if you have a
use case
where before you even evaluate the
condition you want to print something
even before you evaluate the condition
if you want to do something in that case
you will use the do while loop even
before the while actual while loop
starts if you want to execute a
statement you will use do while loop for
example if you want to print the initial
value of the count even before the
condition checks then you can use do
while loop if that is not your use case
you can use a simple while loop which is
just described here in this program so
coming back to the do while so i say do
and then i'm saying print this
particular statement without checking
anything this condition will be executed
for the first time without any condition
check at all this will just work as is
like a normal java statement after that
i am incrementing the value of the count
and then i am checking the condition so
remember when this particular condition
is being checked the first increment has
already happened but in the while case
we
did the comparison before even the first
increment the first comparison happened
with the original value of count but
here the first comparison is happening
with the incremented value of the count
hope you get the difference in a better
context now that you will use this when
you want to do some write some
initialization code before you actually
hit the condition so this condition will
be evaluated with 2 less than 10 and
then the value will be printed let's
print this example and we'll also try to
play around with this example a bit more
to bring to build our understanding
better if i run this program there is no
difference in output if you compare this
with the previous program we ran for the
while so it prints the count value so
this is coming here then it increments
the value then it checks the condition
saying is 2 less than 10 yes that holds
true if that holds true it will go back
to statement number 9 again print this
again do an increment on the count and
again check the condition with the
updated value of the count which will
say 3 less than 10 now similarly print
the value increment check this will
continue to happen till this particular
condition becomes false and once this
condition is false it will exit out of
this whole do while loop and it will go
to the line number 12 and if you have
any statement written there you can that
statement will be executed in this case
so let's try to change some values here
and let's see if if we can make sense of
this program if we change the value
let's say if i put 11 here what will
happen now let's run this program you
will see the
now you will see that this particular
output is displayed which says count is
11. so what happened here that count was
11 it entered the do while block it went
to this particular statement which said
count is 11 then it incremented the
value so the value became 12 and
obviously 12 is not less than 10 so it
did not print it again it only printed
once even if the first time the
condition was checked the first
condition execution itself resulted in
false
still line number nine got successfully
printed and that's the whole that's the
whole idea behind using the do while
what if i change this value to 10 let's
see what happens and after that we'll
run one more combination to just make it
more interesting
this time again count is 10 line number
10 will be printed as count is 10 then
at line number 10 the count is
incremented to 11 and 11 is not less
than 10 so in this case the loop ends
and it will move out now what happens if
i do this
if i say less than equal to here let's
run this program and interpret the
output now again only one statement is
printed because in this case the count
is 10 10 is printed here and we are
saying 10 plus 1 11 11 is still not less
than equal to 10 and that's why the loop
just exits let's make it 9 and see what
happens now you see two values so count
is 9 it enters the do while loop goes to
statement number 9 prints the current
value of count which is 9 then
increments the value to 10
then at line number 11 this while
statement is executed and the condition
is checked is 10 less than equal to 10
yes 10 is not less than but 10 is equal
to 10 so this condition will hold true
it will go back here print count is 10
make count 11
again check the condition is 11 less
than equal to 10 no it's not and then
the condition will return to false and
loop will be exited so hope this will
give you a better understanding now
since we ran different permutations and
combinations of the values and we saw
when this will be executed and when this
will not be executed but the bottom line
is very straightforward that whenever
you want to write some pre-processing
logic even before checking the very
first condition of your loop then in
that case you will be using a do while
loop otherwise a normal while loop or a
for loop will absolutely work fine so
that's the takeaway i would like you to
take away from this particular session
and that's all for this particular
session we talked about do while and we
also try to give you some sort of a
comparison between while loops and
do-while loops in the next session we
are going to be discussing about for
loops in detail let's get started with
understanding the loop statements in
java so first of all understand why do
we need loop statements so generally
whenever you are dealing with some data
structures in java which can store
multiple elements for example we saw
array which can store multiple elements
string is also basically technically a
character array which is storing
multiple characters so whenever you have
these kind of data structures where you
have multiple elements being stored in
the same uh
then in that case you would like to have
a way to iterate or access all of the
elements in a seamless fashion one of
the ways is to access them individually
one by one but that's too much of work
that's too much of code there has to be
a simpler way of accessing all the
elements one by one if i want to and
that's where the majority of the use
cases for using loops coming to picture
now java provides multiple constructs to
write loops in java there is a while
loop there is a do while loop there is a
for loop there is also an enhanced for
loop and in the previous versions of
java a use case of iterator was also
very popular so there are multiple ways
in which you can actually iterate over a
collection and access all the elements
of the collection one by one and you can
use it to multiple useful cases for
example if you have a huge i of employee
salary and you want to give bonus to
each of the employees and add the bonus
to the salary then you need to do this
edition for all the employees it would
be nice to have to return a while loop
and the while loop can automatically
access all the employee salary one by
one and keep adding the bonus to the
salary this would be an easier way to do
this rather than individually updating
each employee salary and the first loop
statement we are going to understand is
a while loop so
the syntax of while loop is very
straightforward you write the y keyword
you enter the actual condition which
will be evaluating to a boolean true or
false so you write the expression which
will be a boolean expression exactly
similar to the conditions which you are
used to write in your if statements so
you write your condition which will
evaluate to either true or false and
then you write your statement and these
statements will keep executing till the
time this particular expression
evaluates to true so generally the way
it works is that it will enter the while
block it will evaluate the expression if
the expression becomes true then the
statements inside this particular while
block will be executed and after the
execution of the statement it will again
go back again evaluate the expression we
call them steps basically so it will go
to the next step again evaluate the
expression if this again if this still
holds true it will again go inside
execute the statement move on to the
next step it will again go to the
evaluation so this this loop will
continue to go till the time this
condition will hold true if it still
doesn't make sense for you don't worry
we will have a demo of it to make you
understand how to use the while loops
and maybe it's a good idea to switch to
the ide and look at an example of it so
i have already created while demo for it
here it is it looks very small and
simple but it will get to the point
where we can understand how and why we
will be using the while loops so i've
created a while demo class i've added a
public static void main method here
which is the entry point i have declared
a variable which is int count equal to 1
so the count value is 1 right now and
then i'm writing a condition here i'm
saying while count is less than 10 do
this so it will print the current value
of count and after that i'm using the
post increment unary operator if you
remember we covered this in the previous
sessions what is the meaning of this it
basically will increment the value of
count by one this expression is is
equivalent to if i write it in this way
if i write count equal to count plus 1
this is exactly the same as this no
difference so this will have the same
impact i will just remove this line
because we already have the count plus
plus here so if we try to understand
this we are basically incrementing the
count and then checking the condition
again so at first time it will be 1 less
than 10 yes that is true it will go
inside and print the count value the
current count value which will be one
and then it does count plus plus so now
the count value becomes two it will
again go back here again check the
condition saying is two less than ten
yes that is true so the while condition
again becomes true it will again go
inside this print the current value of
count which is 2 then do count plus plus
so it will again increment the value of
count so the now the count value becomes
3 again go back here at condition and
saying is 3 less than 10 yes that is
still true again come here print the 3
again go here make count as 4 4 less
than 10 prints 4 again count plus plus
count becomes 5 and so on so forth it
will keep doing that till the value
becomes 10 so at a step when count plus
plus results in the account value being
updated to 10 it will go here and say is
10 less than 10 now that is not true
because 10 is equal to 10 but 10 is not
less than 10 so this condition will
become false and it will exit of this
while loop and it will come here and it
will execute if there's if there was
anything written after the while loop
that will be executed so that's the idea
that you want to do something till a
particular condition holds true then you
can use the while loop define your
condition and execute the statements and
try to do something which changes the
state of this condition here i'm
changing the count so that every time a
new evaluation happens if i comment this
this will result in an infinite loop
because 1 will always be less than 10 i
will not be incrementing the count here
and it will keep running forever it will
never stop it will just keep printing 1
1 1 every time till your computer
program runs out of the memory so always
remember not to end up into an infinite
loop that's probably one of the biggest
mistakes any beginner programmer does so
please try to be aware of that
particular
loophole not try to run an infinite loop
always try to write something in the
code block which can change the state of
the condition and also make sure that
that state condition sometimes sometime
should become false you should also make
sure that that all that always becomes
false because if i do this if i do this
then this condition will always remain
true because it is already 1 then it
will become 0 then it will become minus
1 minus 2 minus 3 so and so forth but
that value of count will forever be less
than 10 and again you will never be able
to exit this loop your program will be
stuck in this loop till your program
runs out of the memory so always
remember to write a statement or a
statement of execution in your in your
code block which can change the state of
the condition which results in some
eventual time when this condition
becomes false this condition has to
become false eventually otherwise you
will never come out of the loop always
remember that so if we run this program
now let's observe the output so we can
see here this particular statement is
printed for 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and that's
it after 9 the moment the count plus
plus resulted into the count value
becoming 10 it checked that condition
and then it just came out of the loop
because 10 is not less than 10 and the
condition became false so always do
something inside your code block which
results at least of one scenario where
this condition becomes false and that is
how you can use the while loop now you
can see this is a pretty generic code
and you can write any kind of condition
here write any code you want to execute
here and then do something to change the
state of the condition as well in a
positive way in a way which results this
particular condition to be false at some
point of time and then your while loop
will run fine so this is all i wanted to
cover in terms of the while loop we have
lot of more exciting stuff coming in in
terms of different loops and in the next
session we are going to understand how a
do while loop works let's get started
with for loops in java so so far we
covered about while loops and do-while
loops and we also saw different examples
of using different types of data
structures like arrays but one of the
core requirements whenever you are
working with any kind of collection is
to iterate over it exactly similar to
what i explained in the do while and
while lectures that you would often
require to iterate over a collection or
a data structure and for that one of the
most sophisticated and easiest way to do
that is using for loops so let's
understand the syntax of for loop first
and then we will also look at an example
of it in the in the eclipse ide
so i have just opened the official java
docs here so if you see this is
basically the syntax of a for loop
statement so let's understand it and
let's also try to compare it with a
while loop so that we can understand how
it compares with the while loop
so if we see the syntax we first see the
term initialization
then we see the term termination and
then we see the term called increment
now if i try to compare it with a while
loop there also you basically did these
three things you first initialized a
variable outside the while loop which is
called initialization and then you wrote
a condition
which is your termination condition you
wrote a condition saying let's say while
i is greater than 10 or while i is less
than 10. so that is the condition which
is also the termination statement the
loop will continue to execute till that
condition
evaluates to false and that's when the
loop terminates that's why we call it as
termination and then the third piece of
it is the increment the i plus plus
which we used to do in the while loops
so these three portions together
make or constitute any kind of loop in
any kind of programming language and for
loop if you see the the kind of code
which you use to write in a while loop
in multiple lines where you first
initialize a variable then you write a
condition in the while block and then
inside the while block you use to
increment the variable all of that can
be done in a single line in the for loop
and that's why i said it is the most
sophisticated and easiest way to write
loops in java so you write all of these
three things the initialization the
condition and the increment or decrement
values in a single line and then you
start with a curly braces and you write
the code which you want to keep
executing till the condition evaluates
to false that's the basic syntax of it
so let us try to understand this with
the help of an example so here i have
opened a class which is called for demo
and this is a class which will
demonstrate the usage of a for loop so
again we have a public static voidbain
method which you can see here which is
the entry point and then i use the
keyword for i put standard
braces for the brackets and then i do
the initialization so this part is the
initialization part you initialize the
variable so i just say in i equal to 1
initialization done you end it with a
semicolon so that it is a single
statement understood by java and then
you write this condition which is your
evaluation slash termination condition
so this condition is basically the the
deciding factor of how long your loops
should run it's exactly similar to what
you used to write in the while block if
i just show you the example this is what
we used to do so we did the
initialization at line number seven then
we wrote this termination condition
inside the while uh syntax or the
construct
and then we did the increment here so we
are doing all of these three steps but
we are doing it in a single line so this
is the condition and then we write our
increment or decrement
values which are going to change the
evaluation condition every time at every
step so we are saying i plus plus
so technically what i am saying here is
that start with i equal to 1 and then
check the condition i less than 10 so in
the in the first step it will be
checking if 1 is less than 10 if the
condition holds true go inside the for
loop execute the statement at line
number 7 and then go back to this
particular statement so we do y plus
plus so i becomes 2 and then you again
go back to the condition and again you
check if 2 is less than 10 yes it is so
again you go inside inside the for loop
and do whatever is written there there
can be multiple statements here for now
i have just written one
system.out.println
so that happens and once all the
execution is finished inside the block
it will again go back to the increment
does the increment so 2 plus 1 becomes 3
again does the evaluation exec and if
the if the condition holds true it will
again go inside so this will continue
this condition checking execution and
increment will continue till the time
this condition holds true the moment
this condition becomes false the control
will come out at line number nine so
that's the basic anatomy and control
flow it's very important to understand
the control flow of a for loop otherwise
you might end up into a program which is
forever running and which will just eat
up all the memory available in your jvm
so be very sure of what you write in
your for loop be very sure of specially
these two parts the condition and the
increment or decrement so this is very
important piece the initialization
happens only once and then this
condition evaluates if the condition
holds to true some code executes
goes back to the changing statement
which can be an increment to decrement
whatever and again compares the updated
value with the condition so this will
keep happening let's run this code to
interpret the output
so i will right click go to run as java
application
and if i
interpret the output here i can see that
it started with count is one two three
four five six seven eight and nine it
stopped at nine so what happened there
let's try to evaluate the termination
condition
so let's say i has become 9 and 9 is
less than 10 so it goes inside and it
prints count is 9 which is i then it
goes here and it says 9 plus 1 i plus
plus means 9 plus 1 the current value of
i plus 1 it becomes 10 and then it again
compares the condition so now 10 is not
less than 10 10 is equal to 10 but it is
not less than 10 so the condition
becomes false and count is 10 is never
printed because this condition has
become false it will jump out so let's
say if i do this
if i put an equal to here and if i now
execute the same program
this time i will see 10 here and because
i have said that okay check the
condition if 10 is less than equal to 10
that will become true it will print
count is 10 then it will increment and
the count will become 11 the i will
become 11 and then it will check 11 is
less than equal to 10 no it is not so
condition becomes false and the control
comes out of the loop so that's how you
should always try to interpret the loops
you can also run some infinite loops for
example if i say i equal to 1 i leave it
that and i say i minus minus so what
happens i equal to 1 1 is less than 10
yes it goes here prints the value and
then i decrement the value i don't
increment the value i decrement the
value so whatever value comes out will
always be less than 10 and this loop
will run forever for fun let's try to
run this and i will i will have to kill
this program manually but just to show
you what happens and what you should not
do in your java program so you see it
will continuously keep printing the
values till the program runs out of
memory till it eats up all the available
memory it is cut it is forever running
it will never stop because the condition
will never remain never never evaluate
to false this condition will forever be
true so the loop will run forever so i'm
just gonna kill the program but this is
something which you should avoid
whenever you are writing java code and
this happens quite often with beginner
programmers
so this is all i wanted to cover in
today's session we talked in detail
about the for loop and in the next
session we are going to talk about
another interesting way of writing for
loops which is also called enhanced for
loops let's get started with enhanced
for loops in java so we covered about
the for loops and the structure of it
and the control flow of it in the
previous session and today we are just
going to talk about another way of
writing for loops which is a bit even
more smarter than the traditional for
loops which we call as enhanced for
loops we generally use the enhanced for
loops for scenarios whenever we have to
iterate over a collection of items or an
array of items those are the most
popular and common use cases of using
enhanced for loop and this for loop is
even simpler like i said it's even
simpler than writing a classic for loop
and the syntax is
simply like this you again start with 4
put the standard brackets and then let's
start from the right most because then i
will be able to explain it better you
specify the collection in the right most
side of the bracket the collection can
be an array it can be a list can be a
map so whatever different kind of
collections which are available in java
and we are going to cover collections in
detail so don't worry if you don't
understand what our lists and what are
maps and what are sets we will go into
detail of each of these one by one in
the upcoming sessions but the idea is
that you put the collection to the
rightmost then you put a colon and then
you put a representation of the member
of this collection so for example here
this numbers is basically an int array
so this int array means that this array
can only hold integer numbers and that's
why we write int here because this array
is only having integers then we put any
placeholder variable name this can be
anything you can even write it as i if
you want to you can write it as anything
any variable name which you want to
write this is a temporary variable so
now this code is going to execute in a
manner that it is going to iterate over
this array one by one starting from the
first element going till the last
element you don't need to write any
initialization code you don't need to
write any termination condition code and
you don't need to write any increment or
decrement code also and how these three
how these three values are actually
taken care of let us understand that as
well so when we talk about the
initialization as i have put an array
here a data structure here the automatic
initialization index is going to be the
first index so when we do the iteration
when this for loop is going to execute
it is automatically going to initialize
a temporary variable with the value at
the first index which is the index 0 as
you know that array is a 0 index based
structure then comes the condition part
so the condition evaluation is going to
be again based on the size of the array
or the size of the data structure which
you are using it is going to start from
the first index which is the index 0 and
it is going to iterate till the arrays
last element is reached so technically
start from the index 0 and go till the
last element that's your evaluation
condition and then comes the increment
part so at each step after it has
successfully accessed the first element
automatically the index is going to be
updated to pointing to the next element
so if it starts from here once the first
step iteration is complete i is
automatically going to be incremented to
index one and then it will basically
this i will be holding two then in the
next iteration the same i is going to be
holding 3 similarly i will keep holding
the new value of the collection item one
by one till the collection items last
element is reached so this is the basic
premise that you can write a collection
variable here and keep iterating over it
and this whatever variable you write
here will hold the current item's value
one by one so in the first step this i
is going to hold one in the second step
this is going to hold two in the third
step this i is going to hold three and
so on so forth that's the basic idea so
now let's run this program to see what
kind of output do we get so you can see
we
basically are able to print all the
elements of the array and that's
probably one of the most popular usage
as well that if you want to just print
all the elements or access all the
elements of
array or a collection one by one then
just use enhanced for loop so you can
see at each step it is printing the
value of i and the value of i is
basically the subsequent elements of the
array that's the whole idea with
enhanced for loop under the hoods if you
talk about how does it work under the
hood it is actually using the classic
for loop construct itself but for
developers it is making it easier
because it knows that if you are
iterating over a collection you will
start with the first element and you
will go till the last element so it
knows the initialization value the
termination condition and it also knows
the increment condition and that's the
reason you will use enhanced for loops
in java for iterating over collections
and in the next session we will be
talking about the nested for loops
concept and we will be looking at an
example of how to implement nested for
loops and when do we use nested for
loops let's get started with nested for
loops in java so we talked about the
while loops the do-while loops the
classic for loop also the enhanced for
loop so now we are going to look at a
variation of the classic for loops in a
in a condition where we have to use more
than one loop in a nested fashion and
how do we do that what are the use cases
when we use that so in front of you you
can see an example which i have prepared
for nested for loops and in this
particular example i have created a two
dimensional array as you can see on the
line number six i have created an
integer array and i have put two square
brackets here which are basically
symbolizing that this is a two
dimensional array so this two
dimensional array is going to hold
technically a 2d matrix and we are going
to use the concept of nested for loops
to print this 2d array in a 2d matrix
style where you will be able to see the
rows and columns clearly let's first try
to
interpret this particular 2d array so we
have a curly braces outside and then we
have these three inner elements which
symbolizes three rows basically so this
is the first row this is the second row
and this is the third row and then each
of the rows have three elements each
which symbolizes the column values or
the item values so it's basically a
three into three 2d array which has
three rows and three columns so so we
can say that this is basically a three
into three array which has three
dimensions on the row side and three
dimensions on the column side or just a
three by three matrix or three by three
2d array so as we know that in case of
arrays everything starts from 0 so
technically if we talk about the indexes
it would be the index 0 index 1 and
index 2 on the row side and similarly
index 0 index 1 and index 2 on the
column side so that's that's something
which you should remember because we are
going to use this particular concept
when we write the for loop so let's try
to write the for loop now if you look at
line number 8 we put this keyword called
for
and then we write the initialization so
we say int i equal to 0 then we are
writing the termination condition and we
are saying
run this particular loop run this whole
loop which ends at line 13 till i is
less than 3
and keep incrementing i at every step
that's what i'm doing in the line number
8 then inside the for loop i'm writing
another for loop which has another
different variable called j it can be
anything you can name it anything you
want and this also starts with 0 and
this also has a similar condition which
is which says run this particular loop
the line 10 basically or this loop which
is signified by this curly braces run
this particular loop till the time the
value of j
is less than 3 and keep incrementing j
at every step and at line number 10
print the element of array which has the
current value of i and the current value
of j these are basically the positions
these are not the elements the element
would be represented by this hole but
print the element which is at current i
and j's position values that's what this
code means so let's try to do a dry run
on this particular code to understand
how this is going to work so at first we
have i equal to 0 0 is less than 3 and
it goes inside it initializes j as well
with zero and j is zero is also less
than three so this condition went true
that's why we went to line number nine
and line number nine condition also went
to true so we went to line number ten
remember that in this particular case at
line number 10 the values of i and j are
0 and 0 respectively and we are saying
print the array of 0 and 0 so 0th rows
0th column element should be printed so
this is the zeroth row because this is
the first uh first sub block and this is
the first element so in this case in
line number 10 2 should get printed then
it goes here and it increments the j to
one so zero plus one becomes one it
again checks the condition is one less
than three so yes one is less than three
it goes here remember it did not go up
at line number eight it just came back
from line number nine so when it comes
here i is still zero but j has moved
from zero to one so now we are trying to
access the element which is at zeroth
row first column which is going to be
seven so seven is going to get printed
similarly on the next iteration
j is going to get incremented from 1 to
2 and again the condition will be
evaluated so 2 is less than 3 all good
it will again come back to line number
10 and now it will say print the value
of zero row third or the second column
or the third element so zeroth row third
element which is the nine so nine will
get printed then again j will be
incremented and j will become 3 2 plus 1
3 and now the condition will be
evaluated is 3 less than 3 no it is not
less than 3 the condition becomes false
so it breaks out of the loop goes to
line number 12 prints an empty line
because we are not writing anything here
so it will just print a blank line and
now it will go back to line number
eight's condition and it will do an
increment of i and now i will move from
0 to 1 and now the evaluation will
happen is 1 less than 3 yes 1 is less
than 3 so it will again go to line
number 9 again initialize j with a fresh
0. the previous j got destroyed the
moment you came out of the loop so this
is a new j so this j again gets
initialized to 0 0 is less than 3 it
goes here remember i was 1 in this time
so now it will print the value of this
2d array which is sitting at
1 comma 0 basically second row first
element so second row first element
which is three again j is going going to
get incremented and it will become from
zero to one so one is less than three
yes it will again come here and it will
print the value of the array which is
sitting at array of 1 comma 1 for row
equal to 1 and column equal to 1 which
will be 6. similarly j will get
incremented again again 2 is less than 3
come back here we'll print 1 then again
we'll increment j j will become 3 3 is
less than 3 no it's false the condition
is false so it jumps out of the loop
goes to line number 12 prints a blank
line again goes back to 8 line number 8
increments i and i now becomes 2
2 is less than 3 yes it will again go
here initialize j again with 0 and again
does the same thing for the row 2 and
column 0 1 2 and again it will come out
of the loop this time again when it will
go here the value will become from 2 to
3 and 3 is not less than 3 so then it
will break out of the outer loop so the
idea is
execute the inner loop for every value
of the outer loop remember this line
because that is how you will be applying
your knowledge of nested for loops to be
used in certain condition so whenever
you have a scenario where you have to
iterate over a collection
based on a certain value of another
collection then you can use nested for
loops or you have a scenario where you
have to iterate over 2d or 3d arrays for
example if we were dealing with 3d
arrays then you would have seen three
nested for loops here and where it will
apply the same logic that iterate over
all the collections all the values of
the inner loop on our particular value
of the outer loop then increment the
value of the outer loop and do the same
thing again iterate over all the values
of the inner loop based on a fixed value
of the outer loop so let's run this
program and let's see what kind of
output do we get
so like i said our our motive our target
was to print this in a metric style and
you can see that it is printing in it in
a sort of a matrix representation so the
first row gets printed here then the
second row gets printed here
and then the third row gets printed here
if you try to decipher it it will work
exactly the same way as i explained so i
equal to 0
0 less than 3 condition becomes true
comes here j equal to 0 j less than 3
condition becomes true comes here prints
the array of 0 comma 0 which is 2 then
prints the array of 0 comma 1 which is 7
0 comma 2 which is 9 then j becomes 3 it
breaks out of the loop goes up here i
becomes from 0 to 1 1 is less than 3 yes
again comes here reinitializes a fresh
for loop with a new j setting to 0 and
it will it will print the array of 1 0 1
1 1 2 then similarly array of 2 0 to 1
to 2. so that's basically what we are
doing we are iterating we are picking
the first row and hydrating all elements
of it picking the second row hydrating
all all elements over it and so on so
forth you can do this for any
n-dimensional kind of array or a
collection so this is all i wanted to
cover in today's session where we
discussed about the nested for loops
concept and how and where we will use it
and in the next session we will be
discussing about the java collections
framework let's get started with
collections in java or the collections
framework in java i must say that this
is probably the most important concept
of the java programming language which
you will be using heavily whenever you
are working in any production grade
application so let's understand the
collections framework and the different
classes and the utilities available
inside the collections framework this is
going to be a theoretical lecture
because there is a lot of ground to
cover in this lecture so we will only
focus on understanding the relationship
between the classes why those classes
are created because each class has a
different purpose in this framework and
we will obviously talk about the
hierarchy as well in the upcoming
sessions we will go into the hands-on
exercise of some of the most popular
collections we will not be able to
provide hands-on of all the collections
classes which you which you can see on
the screen because then it is going to
take a very very long time to complete
this concept but we will cover the most
popular ones or the most used ones out
of this particular framework so let's
get started as you can see
let's first understand some of the
symbols here and let me just zoom this
in a bit so that it's visible yep now
though i have just increased the
resolution a bit so you can see there
are three different symbols or legends
here you see this oval shape which is
called interface so you can see some
interfaces here then you see this
rectangular blue box which is called
abstract class and you can see some of
these blue boxes and then you see the
purple box which is called the class and
you see some classes here these ones
so
for now we are currently we haven't
covered the concept of interfaces and
abstract classes but we will cover that
in the coming lectures and for
understanding the collections hierarchy
right now the at least the concepts of
it you don't need to be fully aware of
the concept of interfaces or abstract
classes so let's dive deeper into the
framework i table is basically an
interface uh to give you a very simple
definition of an interface interface
basically is sort of a declaration which
will tell you what kind of classes will
be present under the interface for
example if you have to let's say store
all the cars and all the bikes and all
the bicycles and all the trucks from all
around the world then you can create an
interface called vehicle and create all
of these classes under the interface and
these classes will be about cars
about trucks
and about other kind of vehicles so an
interface is a generic blueprint
of specific class implementation that's
a very simple definition of an interface
and like i said we will go deeper into
this concept in the upcoming lectures
so that was about interfaces similarly
when we talk about abstract classes the
next legend here abstract classes are
also similar to interfaces where they
provide you a generalization but at the
same time abstract classes provide you a
way to also write some concrete
implementation for example if we take
the example of a bank account so there
in a bank you have different kinds of
accounts you have sales accounts you
have recurring accounts you have current
accounts and there are many other
different types of accounts so
there would be some common
implementation and logic which will be
applicable to all the account types for
example an account must have an account
holder that account holder must have a
valid kyc done for example so there
would be some sort of common logic which
will be applicable to all of these right
so that common logic so you have two
options either you can write that common
logic again and again in the savings
account class in the current account
class in the loan account class etc etc
or you can write it at a central place
and just refer it from there so that's
where you will you will use abstract
classes so you will create an abstract
class of an account and then you will
create these child classes under this
account class which will be the savings
account class the loan account class the
current account class etc so this is a
very lightning introduction to you about
interfaces and abstract classes and
class as we know is basically a concrete
blueprint which holds data and logic
together so here i table is an interface
which will just specify that all the
kinds of data structure which can be
iterated which can be looped over should
be present under this particular
interface that's why we created this
interface so
under i table we have this collections
interface and this will govern that
everything which will present under the
collection interface will be
holding
some sort of a collection of items
now we look at the next set of
interfaces we see a set interface we see
a list interface and we see a queue
interface when we talk about the set
interface
these three different types of
interfaces represent three different
properties of collection and these
properties are exclusive of each other
for example if we talk about set so set
has a property that everything which you
put into set will be unique it will
never ever tolerate or contain any
duplicate elements that's the property
offset so now you can see whenever you
have a scenario where there is a strict
constraint that your collection should
never have duplicates you will use sets
when we talk about lists list is
probably the most lenient representation
of a collection it can store anything it
can store duplicates as well it will not
raise an error or a warning if you store
same element multiple times it will
happily store it but at the same time
the list is basically an index based
collection you can access the elements
starting from the index 0 till the last
element that's the basic value
proposition so whenever you have a
requirement where you want to access the
elements into a predefined sequence and
one by one then you should use list
also the order is fixed here the first
element will always come after the
zeroth element the second element will
always come after the first element so
whenever you iterate over this
particular list you will never have a
scenario where you do not know the order
of the elements being accessed they will
always be accessed in a predefined order
so it's basically we can call it as an
indexed ordered collection which can
hold duplicates then the third one is q
here so q is basically as you can this
is basically inspired from real world so
think of any queue if you if you go to
buy something at a grocery store or if
you go to buy a ticket at a railway
station or you go to the check-in
counter at the airports so you stand in
a queue and the concept of queue is that
it works on a concept of first in first
out the person who first went into the
queue will be the person first being
served and coming out of the queue and
if the second person come that has to be
standing behind the first person and
once the first person is served and goes
out of the queue the second person comes
at the front of the queue and that that
particular person is served so you can
see it's
if you have to store that kind of
behavior or if you have to implement
that kind of behavior in a java program
then you would use cues
so so this was about the top level
interfaces which are set list and queue
and out of these list and set are very
very popularly used very heavily used in
any kind of java enterprise grade
application now there are more
interfaces like sorted set navigable set
and dq sorted set is basically
forcing additional constraint on the set
that the elements will be unique at the
same time you can also have the elements
into a sorted order the sorting can be
an incremental sorting or decremental
sorting that depends but the whole idea
is that it will be sorted similarly
navigable set brings another navigation
kind of properties dq is basically a
double ended queue where the elements
can be inserted and removed both from
the front and from the back so there are
the different properties of these
interfaces but like i said the most
popular ones are these three ones now
let's talk about the abstract classes so
the abstract classes you see here are
abstract collection abstract set
abstract list abstract queue abstract
sequential list generally you will not
be using these directly you don't need
to use them directly but you should be
aware that they exist if you have a very
specific case where you want to use
these abstract classes you can use them
in java program but most of the time you
don't need to use them and most of the
times you will be dealing with either
the interfaces or you will be dealing
with the concrete classes now this
lecture is getting a bit long so i would
like to stop this lecture here so we
covered about the interfaces part of the
collection and we also understood a bit
about the abstract classes though we are
not going to use abstract classes in
much detail in the programs in the next
session we will cover the second part of
this collection framework or the
remaining part of this collections
framework which is around the classes
let's get started with discussing the
concrete classes in the collections
framework in the previous session we
talked about the interfaces part of it
where we discussed about sets the lists
and the queues and we also touched a bit
upon the abstract classes and like i
mentioned earlier you don't need to
generally use these abstract classes
directly in your java program but you
must be aware that they exist you see
some arrows here right if you see if i
just scroll up you see multiple kind of
arrows here these arrows mean that if
the arrow goes from bottom to top it
means this particular element is a type
of the parent it's basically a denoting
a parent child kind of relationship so
for example here you see tree set is
basically
a navigable set and also extend extends
abstract set which extends sept so
similarly you can see all kind of
complex relationships here and generally
you don't need to remember all of those
you only need to remember the few and
those few are basically easily can be
spotted for example whenever you see a
tree set it means it's basically a type
of set whenever you see a word called
list that means that it is a type of
list and you all whenever you see a word
called queue then it means that it is a
type of queue so let's understand these
classes let's first go to the list
interface so you can see list interface
has the relationship with abstract list
and from there it goes down to arrow
list abstract list has another child
which is called abstract sequential list
which is another abstract class and
which has a concrete class which is
called linked list so let's understand
these two collections or these two are
types of list right now so when we talk
about arraylist let's understand this we
already have covered arrays
so what are arraylist they are very
similar to arrays in in a way that they
are also indexed based collections so
you can store elements and access them
based on the index position starting
from 0 going till the length minus 1
index and this is an ordered collection
you can access the elements only in a
predefined sequence it can obviously
accept duplicates as well and these all
our properties are also applicable to
arrays the differentiating factor here
is that arraylist is a dynamic array
it's not a static array if you remember
when we talked about arrays we had to
initialize it or we had to specify a
fixed size of it while we initialize it
once you have initialized the array size
you cannot change the array size it is
static it is fixed so if you have
created an array of elements 10 and if
you are trying to store the 11th element
you are going to get an array of array
index bound of exception but in case of
array list it dynamically updates its
size based on the number of elements
stored you can still initialize it with
some some initial size let's say you
initialize an array list and you say
that you want to initialize it with a
size of 10 elements absolutely fine but
the moment you start you try to store
the 11th element arraylist is going to
dynamically update its size from 10 to
something else so it will keep updating
its size based on the number of number
of elements which are coming to the
collection that's the whole property of
arraylist so remember it's it's used in
the cases when you have an ordered
collection to store and you want to
access them based on the index
and you want a dynamic update of the
size
the second sibling of it which is linked
list is also a type of list but it has
slightly different properties than
arraylist in case of arraylist it was an
indexed based collection you access the
element based on the indexes but in
linked list you access the elements
based on the previous and the next
element that's pretty much what it knows
so an item can only be accessed in a
particular sequence starting from head
to the tail and when we talk about
linked list the idea is that you have an
element which will have a data and it
will also have a pointer or up basically
a reference that reference will be
pointing to the next element in the
linked list similarly the next element
will store the value the actual data and
it will also store a reference to the
next element so you can see if you have
to go to the fifth element you cannot
directly say link list of five the way
you can say this in arraylist because
arraylist is an index space position uh
list right so you can access the zeroth
element or the fifth element or the
tenth element directly just in one line
or one go but in case of linked list you
cannot access the fifth element or the
last element of the linked list directly
you have to start from the first element
and keep jumping the references till you
reach the last element that's the
property of linked list so these are the
two types of list now let's talk about
the type of
set a type of set which is not mentioned
here is hash set which is a very popular
type so a set generally has two popular
types hash set and preset so let's talk
about both of those if i talk about hash
set the property is that it will inherit
the existing properties of set which is
that element should be unique that's
good but along with that hash set will
not remember or honor the order in which
the elements are inserted into it it
will if let's say if you insert 15 or 20
different elements inside hash set and
then if you try to iterate over the hash
set every time the order in which the
elements are accessed and printed will
be different every time the order of
accession will be different every time
act the way in which the elements are
accessed their order will be different
you cannot predict that and that's the
property of hash set whereas when you
talk about reset in case of tree set you
can have a sort of fixed order and a
tree hierarchy so a tree hierarchy if
you know about the tree data structure
from the data structure and algorithms
section you already would know what a
tree looks like basically it has a root
and it has child this is basically you
can call this artery as well right so
whenever you have to store the values in
a in a tree fashion where you can
navigate through the parent and childs
then you would use the preset and
remember since it is a set it will still
inherit the uniqueness property of set
so that's about hash set and preset so
we covered about list we covered about
sets now let's talk about these ones
which are vector stack and parity queue
so let's first understand about priority
queue so you would use a priority queue
when you need a fifa arrangement but at
the same time if there are few elements
in the queue which cannot wait to be
executed or processed when their turn
comes they wanted to be executed on
priority so whenever you have such use
case where you want to to maintain a
fifo fashion collection but at the same
time you also want to allow few elements
of it to override this fifa arrangement
and get processed ahead of their queue
number so you can use priority queue in
those cases
talking about stack let's understand
stack first and stack is a lifo
arrangement last in first out
so remember in your house when you when
you put plates
uh the the normal dinner plates over one
or one over each other you are basically
creating a stack so the property is that
the plate which is put first on the
table will be picked up at the very last
and the plate which is put the last on
the stack let's say you put five plates
on top of one uh one on top of other
then the fifth plate will be consumed
first anybody would pick the plate from
the very top they will not pick the
bottom plate because it's it's almost
impossible if you have a big stack you
cannot pull out the bottom most plate
the stack will fall down so you will
always pick out the elements from the
top so it has a leaf arrangement so
whenever you have to create a last in
first out kind of arrangement in your
program for storing collections you will
use stack talking about vectors vectors
are very similar to lists they are
exactly similar there is
basically one major difference is that
vectors are thread safe and lists are
not thread safe now list has provided a
way to be thread safe we will cover that
later but for now you can understand
that whenever you have a program in
which you want to access a collection in
a thread safe manner where two threads
cannot modify the same element at the
same time then you will use vectors so
we covered about the complete
collections framework classes the
interfaces and the abstract classes and
always remember the
the reason why you will use arraylist or
linked list or a hash set or a tree set
or a vector or a priority queue or a
stack that is the most important concept
i want you to take away from this
session let's get started with array
lists in java so when we talk about
error list we are technically talking
about a list
in the previous session i covered in
detail about the various implementation
of list interface which were arrow list
and link list and in today's session
we'll be focusing only on the array list
i have opened the api documentation of
the arraylist class
so if we just scroll down we will see a
nice description which is provided by
java and it broadly covers all the
points which i described in the previous
session which were that an error list is
basically an array based implementation
of a list it's an indexed based
implementation so you can access the
elements based on their index position
you can directly access any element if
you know its index it accepts any kind
of duplicates as well and by default it
is not thread safe if two threads are
trying to access the same collection at
the same time or maybe trying to modify
the collection then you will get
inconsistent behavior so that was about
the basic description of arraylist there
are it provides lot of interesting
utility methods as well for adding
elements for adding multiple elements or
removing elements for fetching an
element from the error list and we will
cover those methods in detail in the
demo and with that maybe let's switch to
the demo so for this i have created a
class which is called arraylist demo it
has a public static void main method and
it has an error list example written
inside it so at line number 10 you see
that there is an initialization
happening for the error list and this is
how you basically initialize the array
list to start with you write the
interface name you can obviously write
arraylist as well here instead of list
you can write error list that is
absolutely acceptable but the reason i
have written list here is because it is
a better practice or i would say it is a
best practice to always initialize the
concrete implementations with the
interface type i am making a very
generic statement which is applicable to
collections and at any other type of
classes and objects you might be
creating in your program always try to
declare it with the type of interface
and then define the concrete
implementation on the right hand side so
the lhs on the left hand side will
contain the interface declaration and
the right hand side will contain the
concrete implementation the reason for
this is that if tomorrow if you have to
change the representation of this error
list to let's say a linked list then you
don't need to do a lot of work because
the linked list is also a child of the
list interface so since list understands
and knows about both of the classes you
can interchangeably use this reference
to point to any of those implementations
that's why it is considered a best
practice to basically
write the left hand side as the
interface and the right hand side as the
concrete implementation that's the first
bit of it second interesting thing you
notice is this so you see these
expressions here and this basically
encloses any kind of generics or class
type what are generics we will cover
this in detail in the upcoming sessions
for now what you can understand and what
you should know that these are denoting
a class type of which the objects will
be stored inside this particular list so
once i say list of integer it means that
this particular list is only going to
hold integer objects
if you try to insert a string object or
if you try to insert a character object
or if you try to insert a float object
or any other kind of object it will
create an error because
it remember in the very first lecture we
said that java is strongly typed
language
it has very strong checks for these kind
of data type mismatch so if that's why
it will expect you to specify the object
type here and whatever type you have
specified here that's the kind of
objects which are going to be stored
inside this list i have been using these
terms called classes and objects
interchangeably but for now what you can
understand that this is a type
how we how we write classes and how we
write objects and how we create objects
again i will cover this in detail in the
upcoming sessions so we have specified
the list interface and i'm saying that
this particular variable should hold any
list of integer type then on the right
hand side i'm specifying what type of
list
this error list is and this error list
will be an arraylist class type and
again i have to specify the class type
specifications and then i'm specifying a
size here this is the size of the error
list the initial size of the error list
you can obviously write it without this
as well this is also a perfectly fine
statement in java and in this case the
error list is going to be initialized
with its default size if you specify a
value then the error list will be
initialized with only that size it is
also considered a best practice to
always initialize the array list with a
some known initial value let's say if
the serialist is going to store only two
elements and the default size is
definitely way way bigger than two
elements then you're going to waste lot
of memories so that's why it is a best
practice to specify explicitly specify
some sort of an initial size this is
also acceptable because it is
automatically inferring the type from
the declaration you don't need to
specify it again here in fact some of
these modern ides will also show you a
warning if you write it here so the next
thing i'm going to do is basically going
to add some elements to this arraylist
so i've created an error list which
should hold only integer values and it
should hold to start with five values
but it will not complain if you try to
add the sixth value so for that i have
just written a small loop here let me
just put curly braces around it for
readability so i'm saying in t equal to
one i should be less than equal to 5 i
plus plus and i keep doing arraylist dot
add so this add method is the method
which is used to add elements to the
array list so whenever you have to add
an element to the error list remember
you need to use the method add and then
specify the actual element which is
supposed to be added so i'm adding one
two three four five in this error list
one by one using this loop and then i'm
just printing the whole array list
that's what i'm doing here after that to
showcase another operation of this error
list i'm removing an element and if you
have to remove an element from error
list just simply call error list dot
remove and specify the index from which
you want to remove the element remember
you need to specify the index and as i
said in the beginning this is an array
based implementation so this is going to
start from 0. so when i say remove the
element at index 3 technically it's the
fourth element of the array list after
that once we have removed the element i
am again displaying the modified error
list and then printing all the elements
of the
error list one by one and for for
fetching the element if you see here if
you if you observe this particular for
loop i'm using couple of more
interesting methods of the error list
let's understand those methods as well
and then i will run the program so here
you see that i'm saying i int i equal to
0 and then i'm saying i less than
error list dot size
so if this error list has
a capacity initial capacity of storing
five elements and i've just added five
elements to it then the error list dot
size will be five but it says less than
so it will start from 0 and run till i
equal to 4 because the moment i becomes
5 5 is not less than 5 and it will come
out of the loop so basically i'm trying
to start this loop where i i's value
starts from 0 and goes till 4 and here
i'm calling another error list method
which is used to fetch an element from
the error list so whenever you have to
get an element from the error list just
called dot get on the error list so
arraylist dot get and i'm specifying the
i value so error list dot get off 0 get
off 1 get of 2 get of 3 and get a 4. and
that's technically the 5 elements which
are stored in this array list so let's
run this program so and now let's
observe the outputs here let me just
bring the outputs down yeah so at first
i'm just printing the error list so
nothing nothing
i'm just adding the elements and
printing the complete error list so if
you want to just print the whole error
list just put that inside
system.out.printlet and the whole
arraylist will be printed that's line
17. then i remove the element at index
3. so if i traverse through this
particular list this is index 0 index 1
index 2 and index 3 so index 3 has an
element which has a value 4 and i'm
saying array list dot removes the
element at index 3 so this particular
element should be removed from this
particular list when i call the line 20
and then if i print the modified error
list at line 24 i can see that 4 is gone
now it's only one two three five that's
the remaining list you also need to
notice that whenever i call
system.out.println
with arraylist i get this square
brackets which is the representation of
an arraylist if you don't want that you
might not want that always right if you
want to print this nicely without the
square brackets then you have to iterate
over the array list and that's what i'm
doing here i'm going from 0 to error
list dot size and i'm doing get of 0 get
off 1 get of 2 and get off 3 and that's
how i get these values without 4. we can
also write the same loop using for
enhanced loop so let's say if i write
for
int i
colon array list
and then inside it i can just say
system dot out dot print ln i and if i
comment this particular loop for for a
moment and run this program
i see the values one by one because it's
ln so every output comes on on a new
line but you can pretty much see the
same output if i remove
this
and if i write it like this just adding
an extra space
it will look a bit more nice a bit more
formatted like this
so as you can see that we can get the
pretty much the same output either using
a classic for loop style which is a bit
verbose or you can use an enhanced for
loop which is a much simpler and shorter
and uh less verbose way of doing exactly
the same thing you don't even need to
call the arraylist.geti but i the reason
i put this example because i wanted to
show you the get functionality as well
so that's all we are going to talk about
in this session in the next session we
will be discussing about linked list
which is the another implementation of
the list interface let's get started
with linked lists in java in the
previous session we talked about array
lists and today we are going to talk
about the another type of implementation
of the list interface which is called
linked list if you remember from the
previous sessions we discussed about the
properties of the linked list and all
those properties are listed here as well
so basic idea is that whenever you want
to have a kind of implementation where
the order of the elements is strictly
maintained where the first element can
refer to the second element the second
element can refer to the third element
and so on in those kind of cases you are
going to use linked list
another property of linked list is that
you cannot randomly access an element
directly as you as you could do in case
of error list in case of error list you
just say you just write arraylist dot
get and you provide the index location
and you get the element right away
that's not possible in linked list in
link list if you have to access the
let's say the second last element or the
fifth element in a 10 size element
list in that case you have to start from
the head which is the first element and
keep traversing till the fifth element
that's the only way possible to access
the fifth element or any random element
so that's the property of linked list it
is also not synchronized so if multiple
threads are trying to access a linked
list concurrently at least one of the
threads and and one of the threads tries
to modify the list then it must be
synchronized externally by some other
ways otherwise you will get
unpredictable results
and again this also provides a bunch of
utility methods and we will cover some
of those methods as you can see add
method for adding an element add all add
first
contains get first get lost we will
cover some of these methods in the
demonstration which follows this
particular documentation and with that
let's jump to the implementation
so i have prepared an example here for
the linked list which is called linked
list demo i've just created a class for
it and we have created a public static
void main method here and here you can
see at line number 10 i have declared a
linked list
so this looks very similar to the way we
declared an error list you see if you
have noticed on the lhs i have i have
written the concrete class and have not
written the interface reason being i'm
using some concrete methods and actual
methods which are only available in the
linked list class so i am not looking at
the reusability aspect in this
particular example if you are then you
have to add extra code for it but here
i'm just writing linked list and again
in this particular linked list i'm
saying that i would only store string
objects so that's why inside this basis
i write string and then i say new linked
list string
again i have not specified the size so
it will take the default size as per the
jvm implementation now i have declared
my linked list and it's time to add some
elements to the link list for that i
have the method add which is available
in this linked list class
which will provide me with the
capability to add elements
so at line number 12 and line number 13
i'm adding two elements and if you
remember i told you that it works in a
reference based implementation so at
first an element a will be added and
when you try to add element b element
a's reference will be updated to point
to b
that's what will happen in this linked
list and then at line 14 i am using
another interesting utility method of
this linked list class which says add
last
what this method does that specifically
it will add the element at the very end
of the linked list
so that was about add last and if i talk
about line 15 i'm using another
interesting method of linked list class
which is called add first
so what this will do that this is going
to insert this element d at the very
beginning of this linked list like even
before a d will be inserted so whatever
your linked list looks like whenever you
call add first
that element is going to be inserted at
the very head of the linked list or the
very beginning of the linked list link
list also provides another variant of
the add method so there is one way to
just add the string element directly
because this is a string a linked list
you can also add it based on the
position so you can say add e
at the second position
inside the linked list so let's observe
this output let me comment all the code
below line 18 because we will be using
some more methods here so we'll cover
that in a while but let's first
understand the output at line 18 if we
run this program so right click run as
java application and this is the output
we get so let's understand the output or
maybe let me do this let me put this
here one by one so that we can interpret
the output so i'm adding two elements
and printing the list then calling add
last and printing the new list then
calling add first printing the new list
and then calling list dot add 2 comma e
and printing the list again so let's
observe these outputs one by one i'll
comment this and let's run this now
so if i run this particular program the
program till line 14 is executed because
rest of the code is all commented let me
comment this as well and if i run it
again yes this is the output i get so at
line 12 and 13 i've added two elements
and i print the list there are only two
elements and they are printed in the
fashion a comma b
everything is good here now let's
uncomment this code and now i'm calling
add last method and add adding an
element with string c which should be
added at the very last of this
particular list so let's see now what
happens
let me comment this one so that we only
see one list at the output
okay we see a comma b comma c so c has
been successfully added to the end of
the list now let's interpret this
particular method which is called add
first so i'm going to uncomment this
and comment the previous cis out so now
there's only one cis out here so i'm
adding two elements adding c at the last
and now adding d at the very beginning
and printing out the list
let's see what happens
okay so the d has been added at the very
beginning of the list even before a so
now it looks like d comma a comma b
comma c so far so good now let's move to
this particular code
and now i'm saying add an element call
called e
at the second position inside this list
remember second position so let's run
this list now this program now
so now i see d comma a if you remember
the previous output was d abc if i just
uncomment this for a while
just to make it more clearer and if i
run this program
the previous list was d comma a comma b
comma c and the new one says d a e e has
been inserted at the position 2 so 0 1 2
position 2 has been added with this new
string e and my list is modified now
it's time to
find some interesting operations about
the removal so what happens if i try to
remove elements from this list and then
we will observe the output again
so let's say if i say list dot remove b
and so i'm saying just drop this
particular element so you can directly
specify that particular elements value
and that element will be removed from
the list
and let's see what output do i get if i
just call list alt remove b and i
comment the rest of the code we should
see a new output here which should not
have b
so running the program again yes
so this was the
old collection and this is the new
collection from which b is gone because
i have called list dot remove b
now you can also remove elements based
on the index position instead of
specifying the element explicitly you
can specify the index position and what
happens if i call list dot remove 3
let's observe the output here as well so
i'm just going to copy paste this is out
and we'll see what output do we get if
we remove the element at third location
okay so this was the previous output
after removing b and if i call list dot
remove 3 so 0 1 2 3
c is the element which is at third
location and it is gone when i call list
dot remove 3 c is gone and d comma a
comma e is only remaining
now let's try to understand this
particular line which says list dot
remove first
expectedly this is going to remove the
element from the very beginning so
whatever element is present at the
beginning it is going to remove the
element and then we are going to print
the list the modified list so we were
here till d a e and d was the
element which was at the beginning and
if i called remove first d is removed
and now only a comma e
is
available and now i use another
interesting method which is called list
dot remove last and then i print the
list the modified list so this is the
list remaining and i am calling remove
last so e should be dropped and only a
should be
left in this particular list
yes we only see a here so this is
basically what i wanted to show you in
this program that we can perform
different kind of operations using
different methods like add add first add
last remove remove first remove last
obviously there are more interesting
methods available in this particular
class do check out the api documentation
for it and there you can see all the
different interesting methods which you
can use while implementing linked list
so this is all i wanted to cover in this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to cover an
interesting framework class which is
called set we are going to learn about
sets in java in the next session let's
get started with hash set in java if you
remember i covered in the collections
framework session that has set is part
of the set interface hierarchy and sets
have a property that they keep the
collections element unique if you try to
add duplicate elements to the asset it
will not accept that and it will still
maintain the uniqueness property of the
collection hashset provides some
additional features to the set which is
that in this case the elements would be
accessed in a random fashion they will
not be accessed in a fixed sequence
rather they will be accessed in a random
fashion hence the name hash set so if
you read about this particular class in
the documentation it will basically
cover all the things which i just
described it also accepts null elements
if you want to insert null but why would
you try to insert null that's the first
question which you should ask it again
provides similar kind of utility methods
to the list interface collection
hierarchy we covered like some utility
methods to add the elements to remove
the elements to check the size of the
collection and to check if an element
exists in the collection or not etc etc
and we will cover some of these methods
in the demo this is again not
synchronized so this is not a thread
safe collection which you should know so
let's look at a demonstration of hash
set and how do we actually create a hash
set how do we operate upon a hash set
using different utility methods
so as you can see i have created a class
here which is called hash set demo
there's a public static void main method
and then at line number 10 you will see
that i have created the hash set and
again it starts with a concrete class
here which says hash set and you can
obviously write it as set as well which
will also work fine so we write the set
type as string so this particular set is
going to hold only and only string
objects and nothing else and this set is
basically a type of hash set again this
is not mandatory so you can remove that
it will still not complain and the
program will run fine if you want to
specify a size please do that if you do
not want to specify the size nothing
goes wrong and it will be initialized
with the default memory footprint but
remember doing this wastes a bit of
memory so if you are running this
program on a machine which is really
tight on memory always put some kind of
initialization size based on your
knowledge of how many elements are going
to be stored in this collection so after
that at line number 12 we start adding
elements to this collection and for
adding the elements the method which is
provided by the hash set class is add so
you use the add method to add new
elements so at line number 12 line
number 13 14 and 15 i use the method
again and again to add some elements if
you observe the line number 14 and the
line number 15 these two lines are
adding the same element so i am trying
to add c twice to this particular hash
set and we will observe the output to
see what happens if we try to add
duplicate elements in the hash set
because if you remember the sets are
supposed to be unique they should not be
storing duplicate elements that's the
property of sets so that's what i
demonstrate by by adding duplicate
elements to see how it behaves and let's
do that let me comment the rest of the
code for a while and let's run just this
part of the code where i add c twice and
i print the hash set and let's see what
happens
so i go to run as and i click on java
application and i only see three
elements even though i added four i only
see three and c has been added only once
not twice
now you might be wondering whether the c
is
the c added at line 14 or the c added at
line 15. so
to understand that we need to understand
how hash sets add method works
so this add method is basically
returning a boolean value if the element
is added successfully this add is going
to return true and if the element could
not be added successfully this add
method is going to return false so let's
do that let's store the result of these
add methods let's call this r1 and let's
call this one as r2
okay and now we will try to print r1 and
r2 and see what happens
so if we write system dot out
dot println and i say r1 and then i just
copy this
after line 16
and write r2 and now we will observe the
output of these to see which
when
we did the add at 14 and when we did the
adder 16 which actually resulted in c
getting added did c get overwritten or
did c did not add twice what happens
so we see that uh when we do the add at
line 14 we get true so it means that
this ad was successful and c was added
here and when i did the add again at
line 16 this returned a false it means
the hash set rejected this add operation
so this c was not added so the actual c
was never overwritten the original c was
maintained and when you try to add a
duplicate value with the same value a
duplicate element with the same value
hashtag is going to reject that
so that actually
proves that the set will maintain the uh
the uniqueness property and it will
reject all the duplicates subsequently
that was about the ad
property now let's understand another
interesting property of the contains
method contains method of the set class
is used to find if an element exists in
the set or not so you can just use the
hash set variable name dot contains and
just type the actual element and this is
going to return true or false based on
whether this element is present in the
hash set or not present in the hash set
if it is present then this contains
method is going to return true otherwise
it is going to return false
so let's run this method and observe the
output at line 21.
so it says list we are writing this
particular string which says does list
contain c or not and it returns true
because yes my hash set does contain c
now coming to line 23 i use another
method of the hash set which is the
remove operation which you can use to
remove an element from the set and then
i'm again doing a sound and i'm asking
the to print the set this should be set
and not list
so then i'm checking if
what happens to my hash set if i call
the remove method and i'm just printing
the modified hash set at line 24. so
let's see what happens with the effect
of remove operation okay so after
removing a this is what remains in my
hash set and a has been successfully
dropped if i call the remove method and
then i try to just iterate over the hash
set to show you how does this iteration
work it again works on exactly the same
way it has been working for the list
implementations that on the rhs of this
colon you write the collection name so
hash set and on the lhs of this colon
you write the representation of the
element so this hash set is going to
contain string and this is just a
placeholder it can be anything this is
just a temporary variable to store the
current value at the current step of the
hash set iteration and i'm printing all
the items one by one
so if i run this
i'm able to print b and c because that's
all which is remaining in this hash set
so this was a very quick demo to show
you the functionalities of the hash set
how does hash set maintains uniqueness
how do you remove elements how do you
add elements how do you check for an
element's existence using contains
there's also a method to get the element
of the hash set if you want to so these
are all the different properties and
methods available in the hash set and do
check it check out the api documentation
of the hash set to learn about more
methods so that's all i wanted to cover
in this particular session where we
focused only on hash set and in the next
session we are we'll be discussing about
presets and we will also see an example
of how do we implement presets in java
let's get started with three sets in
java so in the previous session we
talked about about hash set which is one
of the implementation of the set
hierarchy and today we'll be focusing on
preset and if you remember when we
talked about this collection framework i
discussed briefly about preset that the
main reason you will use tree set is
basically when you want to maintain
natural ordering of the elements if
you're adding your custom elements then
you need to tell java how to compare and
sort and order the elements but that's
for another day when we'll cover about
the detailed comparable and comparator
interfaces for now what you can
understand that whenever you have to
maintain the natural order of the
elements automatically then you should
use preset along with that the set
property still holds true that this tree
set cannot have duplicate elements
we should also know that tree set is not
synchronized so it is not a thread safe
collection so be remember be aware that
whenever you are trying to use preset in
a multi-threaded environment you need to
write more wiring code around it so that
preset works as expected okay that was
about the brief theory about the preset
you can read about
about it in detail in this tree set
documentation class and with that let's
switch to a demonstration of the tree
set class
so i have prepared a class here which is
called reset demo as you can see it has
a public static void main method and at
line number eight i am initializing the
reset again it's again the standard
representation of initializing a
collection which we have been using
throughout the different examples of the
collections so preset of string so this
particular preset is going to hold only
an only string elements if you try to
add another element it is going to
through a compilation error and the on
the rhs i'm just saying new preset and
again this is not mandatory so i can
remove that and it will still work you
can specify the size whenever you know
about the scope of the collection you
should always specify the size for this
demonstration it's a lightweight program
so it's fine
after that from line number 10 till line
number 13 i'm again going to add some
elements and again if you see i'm adding
elements in random order i'm adding b
and then i'm adding adding a then i am
adding c twice just to show you the
uniqueness property of the tree set does
it still hold true or not we will be
able to figure that out from this
particular example and we will also see
if i'm adding b before a will it be
printed in a fashion called bac or will
it be printed in a fashion called abc we
should also know that so let's try to
run this program and understand the
output
so if we look at the output we see a
before b
but here when we added the elements we
saw b before a we added b first and then
we added a and then we added c twice and
as per the uniqueness property of this
set the second
addition statement at line number 13
returned false and set rejected this
edition because it could see that c was
already present in this particular
collection so c is added only once but
what's interesting is that b is added
first but b is added b is printed after
a so the natural order of the elements
in this collection is automatically
maintained by tree set so what under the
hood reset does here that it looks at
the type which is a predefined type in
java string is a predefined class in
java so it will use its own sorting
algorithm to sort the strings based on
their natural order of sequence and in
the natural order of sequence a will
always come before b and b will always
come before c so it will automatically
apply that sorting and will present the
result to you if you're using a custom
class here let's say your own student
class or your own customer class or your
own account class in that case that
account class or student class or
customer class needs to tell java how to
sort elements and for that you need to
write comparable and comparator
implementations which we will cover in
detail in the future sessions but for
now you must understand that whatever
the type of class you are specifying
here should
tell java how to sort the elements
either java should know it automatically
if it's a predefined class like string
or integer or float or double then java
would automatically know by default how
to sort the elements but if you are
creating a custom class of yours in the
tree set and specifying that as a tree
set type then you should also tell java
how to sort the customers whether you
want to sort them based on your first
name whether you want to sort them based
on their age their salary java doesn't
know that so you need you need to tell
java about that if you're trying to use
a custom class as the type entry set in
this particular example i'm using string
here and it will apply the natural
ordering
let's put c here in the very beginning
to see what happens and i can comment
this as we have already maintained and
verified that c is only printed once and
added once so i'm adding c b a and let's
run this program
i still get abc because again the
natural order is implemented contrary to
this when we talked about hash set
remember i told that hash set is a
random access
element collection list so if you run
the hash set if you try to print the
hash set again and again and again you
might see a different order sometimes if
i use a hash set here sometimes it will
print abc sometimes it will print bac
sometimes it might print cab any kind of
sequence any kind of random sequence it
will pick automatically that's the
property of hash set but in case of tree
set no matter how many times you run it
you will always get the same order based
on the sorting implementation available
in the class type so that's all i wanted
to cover about preset please read about
read about its java documentation in the
api docs to understand what all other
methods and utilities tree set provides
but it's pretty much similar to what we
saw in the hash set example like remove
or get etc etc and contains etc so all
this all similar methods are available
in the tree set class as well and that's
all we'll focus on on this particular
session and in the next session we're
going to talk about an interesting
framework called maps let's get started
with maps in java
so first of all before we understand
this particular diagram and the classes
in this map framework let's understand
why do we need map
so
there would be instances when you would
write a java program or any kind of
program there would be always be
instances where you would need to store
a key value kind of arrangement a very
simple example can be that you want to
maintain a company database and you want
to just bring the whole mapping of the
employee id to the employee name into
the java program
how do you do that you need a key value
sort of arrangement where you can store
the employee id as the keys
and each of the employee id key would
correspond to an employee name which
will be called the value so you need a
key and value
arrangement in a java program to store
that kind of information and use that
kind of information in your program and
that's where map comes into picture
whenever you have to store a key value
arrangement remember you would always
think about maps maps should be the
right collection or the right data
structure to be used if you want to
store any key value arrangement in your
program so that's about map and here you
can see a nice uh framework
representation of map and this is going
to be a theoretical lecture where we
will understand how this map framework
works what is the property and what are
the different implementation classes and
then in the future sessions we will
again look at some examples of the most
popular map implementation classes which
are used in the java world
so again uh the orange oval are
interfaces the blue boxes or the light
blue boxes are the abstract classes and
the purple boxes are the concrete
classes
so map is an interface which will
provide this kind of a blueprint that
every class underneath it would be
working on a key value arrangement when
we talk about this key value arrangement
so we have these keys and we have the
values
so the keys here
are supposed to be unique the values can
contain duplicates remember this is a
very important concept that in map the
keys will be unique and the values can
have duplicate and because we want to
maintain the uniqueness in the keys part
that's why the keys are technically
stored as a set because we know that set
cannot contain duplicate sets are by
designed made to be storing only unique
elements so map uses the set class to
store its keys and to store the values
it generally uses a list class so you
can see map is basically reusing
the classes from the collections
framework sets for storing the keys and
lists for storing the values that's the
basic anatomy and basic idea of how map
is working now you see some classes here
called abstract map and sorted map and
again similar to the set hierarchy
whenever you see the sorted world and if
you look at the
concrete class which is called pre-map
this is going to provide you some sort
of an order sorting order automatically
and then you have the hash map class and
this class is going to be providing a
random access this will not maintain the
insertion order this will not provide
you a natural sorting order this is just
to store elements in random order and
the element here a single element here
is basically consisting of two parts
which is key and value always remember
that you also have hash table here hash
table is basically a synchronized
representation this is a thread safe
hash map and tree map are non thread
safe so multiple threads if you try to
work in a multi-threading program with
these hash map and pre-map you're going
to get very unpredictable results but if
you use hash table then it is inherently
thread safe so it will only allow one
thread to be to access the hash table at
a particular time
you will also you will also be thinking
then it's always better to use hash
table right because you will never get
into those weird errors and you don't
have to migrate your program
to a multi-threaded environment whenever
you are trying to use hash tables yes
that is true but hash tables are slower
for the same reason because only one
thread can
can access it at a time and that's why
hash tables are slower and hashmap and
tree map are way way faster because they
allowed multiple access at the same time
so you have to always be mindful of what
kind of collection type you're using
there are some external ways as well to
make these hash maps and tree maps and
hash set and preset and
array list and link list as synchronized
as well and we will talk about that in a
future session but for now you can
understand that hash map entry map are
non-thread safe and hash table
are thread safe there is another class
which is
which is coming out from the hash map
class which is called linked hash map
and linked hash map as the name shows it
will basically carry two properties it
will carry the property of hash map
where the elements are stored or
displayed or accessed in random order
and at the same time it is also
providing the linked
property of the linked list where the
sequence is maintained so you can see
you can actually get the insertion order
if you use a linked hash map the way in
which you insert the elements would
always be the way in which the elements
will be accessed so you are getting sort
of a ordering property but the order is
the insertion order it's not the natural
sort order it's the insertion order
that's why the name linked hash map
because it brings the linked list part
of the link property inside the hash map
where the elements would be presented to
you in the order they are inserted when
you call the add method so that's what
we covered here we covered about map
interface we covered about hash map
class which is going to store the values
and the access will be random the value
means the element means a key and value
we sometime also call this as an element
you will see that representation
sometimes some some people also call it
as i treble element it's all the same
thing but it's a key and value
arrangement tree map also stores the key
value arrangement but it will provide
you a sorted representation and here the
sorting will happen on the keys
not on the values the sorting will be
happening the natural order of salt
which will be maintained by the tree map
is only applicable to the keys here
similarly link hash map it will insert
the elements but when you try to access
it it will maintain the insertion order
no matter how many times you access it
it will only be presented to you in the
order the elements were inserted and
hash table is very similar to hash map
with the difference that hash table is
thread safe multiple threads cannot
manipulate the hash table at a time it
will only let a single thread access
itself at a time so that's the property
of hash table the most popular classes
are generally these ones hash map tree
map and linked hash map very rarely you
will also see hash table but since we
have some ways to
get these synchronized so generally you
would not see much of the hash table
implementation and that's all i wanted
to cover in this particular lecture
where we walk you through the concepts
and the theory of the map framework and
in the upcoming sessions we'll go deeper
into the concrete classes and in the
next session we'll specifically be
discussing about hashmap so we will
understand how hashmap works we will
create a hashmap and we will again look
at some utility methods which are
provided by the hashmap class through
the demonstration let's get started with
hash maps in java
in the previous session i covered about
the theoretical concepts of map and the
key value arrangement and the keys being
basically are set and the values
basically being a list
and now we are looking at the api
documentation of the hashmap class you
can see the k comma v here these are the
types of the key and the value which the
hashmap will accept you can see k is
basically the type of keys and v is
basically the type of mapped values
uh like i explained it's basically keys
are stored in a set fashion and values
are stored in a list collection fashion
this is not by default synchronized so
if you want a thread safe collection
then you would have to do something else
which i will cover in the future
sessions
this is a very brief overview of what
hash map is but let's look at the
example to understand better and then i
will be able to explain it in bit more
detail so now we are looking at an
example which is basically a class which
is called hash map demo i have a main
method here and then at line number 10
i am initializing the map and as you can
see that on the lhs we see the concrete
class hash map and i can do this
and this will still work provided you
have the import here i had the import
here so it will work fine and i'm saying
that this map is going to contain a key
value arrangement where the keys are the
string type
and the values are of the type integer
and it's ultimately a hash map here i i
don't need to again provide the generics
because i have already provided the
generics here
the name of the map is just simply a map
and again you can specify a size or you
can skip the size based on the memory
requirements and the program
requirements
now coming to the point where you want
to add elements to the map
now since this is a key value
arrangement here the name of the method
through which you are going to add
elements is put so you call map.put and
then you provide the key
comma you provide the value
that's the syntax for adding an element
or we technically call that element an
entry this key value together is called
entry so if you have to add an entry to
the map you have to write it in this way
where key comma value is the convention
so i'm adding three elements or three
entries here which is
a comma 10 b comma 20 and c comma 30 abc
are basically the keys and 10 20 and 30
are the corresponding values of these
keys respectively
after that i'm showcasing another
utility method of this particular class
which you can use to find the size of
the map so you can just call map dot
size and it will print the size of the
map
after that i'm printing the actual map
the whole map and then i'm using some
more methods but again let's comment
this code and let's understand this code
one by one so that there is no confusion
so to start with i'm going to add some
elements some entries and i'm going to
print the size of the map and the map
itself let's run this program
so here
you can see the size of the map is
printed as three because i've added
three entries
and then when i call
map inside the
system.out.println method i get the
whole map printed here and this is how
the map will look like when it is
printed we can see key equal to value
syntax here where a equal to 10
b equal to 20 and c equal to 30 are the
key value representations or the entries
here separated by comma enclosed by the
curly braces
that's how our map looks like so far so
good the next thing which i am going to
showcase to you is the contains method
and since the map has this set which is
the keys basically that's why map
provides a method called contains key
basically you can check if a particular
key is present in the map or not and if
you know the key is present then it's
very easy to get the value from the key
map will provide a method also where you
can supply the key and get the value so
knowing the key is the most important
part and that's why map provides a
method called contains key so you can
call this method specify the key which
you want to check for the presence in
the map it is going to check whether a
is present in this maps key set or not
if the a is available in this keys we
can see a is available then this
condition is going to hold true and then
like i said if you want to fetch the
value then you can call the get method
providing the key you can fetch the
value from the key that's the that's the
core idea which you should remember so i
call map dot get specify the key and
this is going to spit out the value
which is being pointed by this
particular key in this case a is
pointing to 10 when i say pointing it's
not pointer remember it's just a
reference so map dot get of a is going
to get the actual value which this key
is pointing to which is 10 and then i am
printing this integer a which is the
actual value pointed by this particular
key so let's run this program and see if
this works
so we get these two outputs from the
above and then this is the output which
is coming from the if block so it
checked whether the map is containing a
key with the name a yes it was able to
find that and then we asked the java
program to fetch the value corresponding
to this particular key so we just called
map dot get off a and it fetched 10 and
it printed 10 here that's why you see 10
here okay so that's how you can
basically use the contains key method
and the get method now what if you want
to iterate over all the keys what if you
the yeah what if you have to use uh the
all the keys and you have to make some
pattern or make some observation about
all the keys in your map you can do that
by iterating over the key set and for
that map provides a method called key
set so you just called map.keyset and
this is going to fetch all the keys
in a set representation and will be
provided to you so here when i call
map.keyset this is basically giving me a
set which is containing all the keys and
then i'm iterating over the keys one by
one you would be familiar with this
syntax by now which is the enhanced for
loop syntax and inside this i'm printing
the key which is the current temporary
variable holding the current key and the
value pointed by that particular key at
that particular step and i'm again using
the same method get which is which i
showed you
here
same method so you provide the key and
you will get the value so i'm going to
get all the keys hydrate over the keys
and then print the key and the value
let's see how this looks like
so till this we were good and here you
will see the output which is coming out
from this particular for loop from this
particular for loop line 25 to line 27
where i'm iterating over the key set
printing the key and value one by one so
this is how to show you if you just have
access to the key set you can still
hydrate over the whole map but what if
you know everything you have access to
the key set you have access to the
values and if you was if you just want
to iterate over it then you can use this
particular
way and instead of map dot key set
you're going to use map dot entry set if
you remember map treats each key value
arrangement as a single entry entry is
the key word here so map dot entry set
is going to give me all the entries in
the map
and then
each entry is basically of type entry
class
this is the representation of each entry
and we know how this representation
formed entry is the class basically
which is coming out of this map
our collection hierarchy
and then let me just save this and then
string is the key and integer is the
value held by each entry inside the map
so that's what we are going to do we are
going to pick up all the entries in the
map and going to iterate over the
entries one by one by writing this
enhanced for loop and entry is the
temporary variable which is going to
hold each entry one by one at each step
and then it's very simple you call
entry.getkey you will get the key and
you call entry dot get value and you
will get the value so it's much much
simpler than this one where you had to
do map dot get to understand it's very
implicit get key is going to get you the
key and get value is going to get you
the value so you just need to call
map.entry set hydrate over the entry set
and get each entries key and value and
print them or do whatever your program
requires to be done that's how you will
use it so let's run this one as well to
verify if this works okay so this is the
output which is coming from the last
loop this loop basically you can see key
i did not put any space that's why you
see key a key b and key c together let
me put a space here and put a hyphen so
that the output looks better and let me
rerun this yep this is much better so
you can see the key a value 10 tb value
20 and key c value 30. this is coming
from this particular for loop which i
just showed you so this is all i wanted
to cover in this particular session we
went deeper into the hash map
representation and we saw a bunch of
methods contains key key set entry set
get put etc and we showed how we can use
the hash map for different purposes in
the program in the next session we'll go
deeper into the tree map concept and
we'll also look at a demo of tree map
and we'll understand how it works let's
get started with tree maps in java now
if you remember in the last lecture we
talked about hash maps in java and we
also had a look at an example where we
saw how a hash map works and how we can
use a hashmap we also had a look at
different utility methods of the hashmap
as well now in today's lecture we are
going to focus on tree maps which is an
another type of map as we discussed when
we were discussing about the map
framework and the main property of a
tree map is that when you enter elements
into a map they will naturally be sorted
or naturally be ordered now when i say
naturally ordered what it means that if
you put the
keys as let's say integer then the tree
map will automatically sort all the map
entries in an integer sorted fashion
where you'll see the natural number
sorting behavior like 1 2 3 and so on
similarly if you
store alphabets or strings then they
then those will be sorted in a natural
sorting alphabetical order starting from
a to z so these are the uh these are the
data types which the java is already
aware of on how to sort them like
integers doubles floats strings etc but
there can be a case where you have your
custom key this particular key is your
own custom class if that is the behavior
or if that is the scenario then in that
case you will have to provide an
implementation to java to know how to
sort those elements because java doesn't
know for example a student class or an
account class java doesn't know how to
sort that so if you have that kind of
scenario then in those cases you will
have to provide your own sorting
implementation and we will cover about
what kind of sorting implementation you
can provide in those kind of scenarios
in the upcoming lectures for now we will
look at have a look at an example of
treemap where you can see that i have
created a class which is called tree map
demo and i have initialized a tree map
with the keys as integer and the values
as string so this means that each entry
of the map will have key as the integer
value and the value of that particular
entry will be of string type so
basically an integer to string mapping
is what each entry of this tree map is
going to store so nothing different here
you would have already seen this kind of
uh this kind of initialization for any
kind of map and after that at line 11 i
used the standard put method of the map
and i i started storing the values so at
line 11 i'm saying store 3 and a so 3 is
the key and string a remember this is
not a character this is a string because
i have specified string here if you
specify a character here and if you try
to store a string this is going to throw
an error and you need to fix that so i
store 3 as the key and a as string as
the value similarly at line 12 i store 2
as the key and
b as the value and at line c i store 1
as the key and c as the value so these
integers are the keys and the string are
the values
and if i just put them and if i just try
to print them what happens
what kind of order can we expect let's
try to analyze that so i right click on
this i go to run as
and i go to run as java application
it will run the program because i have a
static void main method and now you see
that the map is printed in a different
fashion
than the way it was added
we added the map elements in this
sequence that we added 3a first 2b
second and 1c as the third element
but when we started printing them we saw
1c printed first 2b printed second and
3c 3a printed third so what this denotes
that this tree map because the key was
integer here it automatically
sorted these keys into a natural order
sorting and it provided when i tried to
access the map it provided the access in
that sorted sequence only no matter how
many times you run this particular
program it is always going to return the
map in the same format in the same
sequence the sequence of representation
of the elements is not going to change
and you can basically do the similar
behavior for example if i just
change this to string and integer let's
do it like this
and if i again swap the elements here as
well i say a comma 3 and i say b comma 2
and here i can say c comma 1. if i do
this i just switch the keys in values
position now the string is the key and
the integer is the value and let me just
put these two
before a so that
we can demonstrate the behavior of the
tree map properly so i'm inserting b2
first and c one second and a three third
and i just save this file and now let's
run this file and let's see how the
output comes so now you can see that
since the key is now string it has
applied it has automatically applied the
natural sorting ordering of strings
which is starting from a going till z
and that's why you see a entry as the
first entry b entry as a second entry
and the c entry as the third entry again
no matter how many times you run it or
you iterate over it you try to access it
you will always get the sequence in the
same fashion so this is a basic overview
of how tree maps work now you can and i
would strongly recommend you to go and
read about all the other methods which
are available in the tree map which you
can use for example how can you remove
elements how can you uh how can you
iterate the elements of the tree map etc
in fact the iteration is is going to be
exactly the same way as we have seen in
the case of hash maps because iteration
behavior doesn't change but to uh if you
want to see what all different kinds of
methods pre-map support it supports a
lot of different methods we can't cover
all of them in this short tutorial but i
would strongly recommend you to go and
read the javadocs api of the tree map to
get familiar with those methods so that
you know what kind of functionalities
pre-map can provide in the next session
we are going to have a look at how we
can use stacks and we will look at a
hands-on example of how we can build
stack and how we can use them in a real
life scenario let's get started with
stacks in java
now if you remember when we were
covering about the collections framework
i walked through a complete hierarchy of
interfaces abstract classes and concrete
classes
and i briefly talked about what are
stacks and what kind of functionality
they provide
in which scenarios you would use them so
let's do a quick refresher of what
stacks are and why do you need them
so stack is basically a kind of list we
can say technically a list but it's not
exactly a list so never say that stack
is a list it's it's just uh because it
is extending the list interface that is
why you can say it is a type of list but
actually it's not a type of list it has
its own representation you will use
stack in the cases where you will have
to maintain a lifo representation of the
objects now what is a lifo
representation it means
last in first out that's the
basically the full form of the lifo
acronym and what it means
that the element which goes at the last
in the inside the collection will be the
first to come out
think of it as a stack of plates at your
dining table
where you you put plates over one
another and the last plate which you put
on that plate stack will be the first
one to be picked up by somebody who
wants to eat something because people
will not take out the bottom most plate
otherwise the whole stack will fall
that's why they will take the top most
plate and that's why we call that plate
representation as stack of plates and
this representation in java is exactly
inspired from that and we call this
stack
you see a bracket here you see a generic
representation here which says e which
means that stack you need to define what
kind of stack it will be whether it will
be a stack holding integer values or
string values or any of your custom
class values so that is the basic
property that the the last element to be
going inside the collection will be the
first element to be coming out
so let's have a look at an example of
how you can use stack and what are the
different properties which we can
leverage while working with stacks so
for that let me switch back to eclipse
and you can see i have a class created
here which is called stackdemo and it
has a public static void main method
which is making this particular class
executable and here
you can see i have created the i have
initialized the stack so stack of the
class type so you provide the class type
as string which means that this
particular stack is going to store
string objects
and then you just say new stack and you
provide the same
generics here actually you can skip that
if you do this as well this is going to
work fine so that is how you can
basically initialize a stack you can see
the import here which you need to import
to make this work it's basically part of
the java.util package
what are packages again we will cover
that in detail when we'll cover classes
and constructors and etc
so now
at line 11 i'm using a method called
push
now the push method is used to insert
elements inside the stack but we call it
push because like i said stack is a
special type of collection that's why it
doesn't use the add method rather it has
a method which is called push which is
used for inserting elements or pushing
elements on the top of the stack
so at line 11 you say stack.push
basically this stack is holding the list
of all the countries or the entries of
all the countries so you say america at
line 11
then at line 12 i'm again doing
stack.push and entering germany at line
13 i'm again doing another stack.push
and entering india
so basically i have added three
countries names inside this stack
now if you if you can think about the
mental representation or if you try to
build a mental representation of this
then stack dot push america is basically
the first entry
then when you added germany this entry
went on top of america because that's
how the the stack of plates work right
and then
india entry will come on top of germany
so the america is the bottom most entry
then we have the germany which is
sitting in the middle and then at the
top we will have the entry for the india
string
and after that at line 15 i'm just
printing the stack
so
if if you want to just observe the
output till 15 let's comment this
particular section
for now and we will just focus till line
15 and once we have figured that out
then we will move to the rest of the
code here so let's run this particular
program and observe the output
so you can see this is the
system.out.println which is getting
printed so i'm printing a stack string
and then i'm printing the stack as is
and you can see it's printed in the
sequence in which the elements were
inserted so when you print the stack you
will not be able to figure out which is
the bottom and which is the top because
you don't need to know that while you
are just printing the whole stack when
you actually want to understand and
observe that behavior is
when you will start taking elements out
of the stack at that time it would be
critical to know which element is at the
top and which element is at the bottom
but for now we can see that we are able
to successfully add elements or push
elements to a stack and we are able to
successfully print the stack now let's
uncomment this particular code and
understand what is happening here
so at line 17 i'm using another method
of the stack which is called pop
so
the push method was used to push
elements or insert elements into the
stack
and the pop method is used to take
elements out of the stack
and remember the lifo property of the
stack
which means that if i call the pop
method which is basically i'm telling
stack to remove an element it is going
to remove the top most element from the
stack and it is also going to return the
element remember that part
if you want to remove the element and if
you want to see
which was the top most element which got
removed then you can actually store the
output of this particular
execution into a variable and you can
see which element was popped or removed
and
and that's the basic property of a lifo
right that when you have a lefo
collection
when you pop the element when you call
the pop method on the stack you would
expect the top most element to be coming
out
and that's why we store that into this
particular string and then we print that
popped element to verify and see which
element was actually
popped and after that because i have
removed one element here then i print
the modified stack to just see what all
is remained in the stack
so let's run this particular program and
now we'll let's comment the first part
maybe this particular cis out is not
needed because we have already observed
the output of this so let's observe the
these two output after pop which was the
element which was popped and how the
stack looks like after the removal or
popping of one element from the stack
so i right click run as java application
and now
if you remember when we inserted the
elements we inserted the elements in
this fashion america germany and india
and when i called pop the topmost
element of the stack should get removed
so it it so the basically the java
looked at this particular stack and it
could see that the element india was
added at the very last which means this
element was sitting on the top of the
stack
and when you called stack dot pop
this method or this string basically got
popped out this element got removed from
the stack and we stored that element
into this particular variable we printed
that element and here you can see that
output that the popped element is
actually india because india string was
at the top of the stack in this
particular case at line 20 now i'm
printing the modified stack basically
printing what is remaining inside the
stack after we called this pop and we
can see that the string india is gone
from the stack and now germany is the
new top
if i call this again let's call this
again
to verify if germany is at the top
actually
so i'm calling the stock stack dot pop
again let's just call it popped element
1 for simplicity
don't do that a production code always
give nice variable names but for the
sake of demo uh we can do this
so let's see what happens if after we
have these two elements left in the
stack and if i call pop again
which element gets popped
so i right click run as java application
and we can see that
this was the representation here at line
20 then i called popped and the popped
element was germany because now this
germany was the new top and after
germany has been removed from this
particular stack then this stack has
only one element which was which is
america so this is how you can work with
the stack and these are the most two
popular
methods which are push and pop which you
would basically require to uh to be
to use in your program if you're working
with stack
and let's say you have a scenario where
you just want to view which element is
at the top you don't want to remove it
because pop is also going to remove the
element right so if you don't want to
remove it but just want to view which
element is sitting at that at the very
top of the stack then you can call the
peak method so this peak method is
basically going to return the topmost
element but it is not going to remove
the element from the stack so let me
just verify that as well for you
ctrl c and after we do the peak i'm
going to print the element again let me
just call it as peaked or let's say just
call it as top element
and then we print the stack again
so
let me just comment out this one as well
and now we'll run the full program let
me call this as original stack
so we'll first print the original stack
then we'll remove one element
and we'll print that element and we
print the modified stack then i call the
peak method
and and then again i print the stack to
see if peak also removed the top element
or it just returned the top element so
let's run as java application and
observe the output so the original stack
was this where india was the topmost
element and germany was in the middle
and america was at the bottom of this
particular stack and then we popped the
top element which was india and then the
star stack got modified and we had only
two elements left into it
then
here we called peak at line two in line
22 and we just at line 23 we printed
the peaked element or the top element so
in this particular stack if we call peak
we got germany
but if we printed the stack again we can
see that germany is still there because
peak just returned the top element but
it did not remove the top element
whereas pop will remove the top element
and also will return that element to you
if you want to store it
so that's all i wanted to cover in this
particular session where we talked in
depth about the stack features and like
i always say please also go to the
javadoc api and
read about all other methods and
functionalities which are provided by
the stack collection in the next session
we are going to focus on cues and we
look at a hands-on demo of queues as
well let's get started with queues in
java so again taking it back to the time
when we discussed about the collections
framework we briefly discussed about the
queue interface and what is the property
of the of a particular queue
so cues were again inspired from real
life cues which you found when you
whenever you try to go to a particular
place where you want to get your things
done you generally stand in a queue
and this q interface is directly
inspired from that particular scenario
itself that it works on a fifo
arrangement
so now if you think about the fifo
arrangement and let's connect it back to
the previous lecture where we discussed
about stacks and we said that stacks are
a lifo arrangement so in case of a lifo
arrangement you had the last in first
out philosophy but in case of queues you
have the first in first out philosophy
it means the first element which enters
the queue will be the first element
removed from the queue that is the basic
premise around which the queue
interface or the queue collection is
formed so remember that particular
concept whenever you have a situation in
your project where you need to
implement this kind of mechanism that
the element which got inside the
collection should be the first one
coming out of the collection then you
should be always thinking about cues
whereas if you have an arrangement where
the last element inserted should be the
first element out of the collection then
in that case you should think about
stacks so remember the value proposition
of each of these collection types which
will help you take a decision as to
which particular uh collection to be
used in which scenario so talking about
queue queue is again an interface again
like i said uh we are
very soon going to cover the concept of
classes and interfaces and abstract
classes so just hold tight on that
particular concept but connecting it
again back to the theory lecture where
we talked about the collections
framework you can think of an interface
as a just a blueprint just a skeleton
with nothing concrete implementation
details inside that interface so the
queue is again an interface and there
are few implementations of it one of the
most popular implementation of queue
interface is a priority queue class so
the priority queue class is again
technically it is a queue which
basically works on the concept of first
in first out but at the same time it
also works on a priority you can assign
a priority to the elements
which will decide when uh which element
is going to come first and which which
element is going to come second and that
concept is basically again governed by
the same natural ordering logic which we
have been seeing in other ordered
collections like tree set and tree map
so that's the basic idea about priority
queue and let me take you to a hands-on
example so that you can relate it better
so here i have a class which is called
queue demo it has a public static void
main method
and then at line number nine i'm
initializing the queue i'm saying that
this particular queue should hold only
string objects and it is a type of
priority queue and like i mentioned if
you use priority queue you can see the
import of it here
if you see the priority queue then you
get that natural sorting or natural
ordering logic phenomena out of the box
because we are using strings here so
java already knows how to sort strings
and it is going to sort strings in the
alphabetical sorting order if you are
providing a custom class of yours maybe
let's say queue of students then in that
case you need to tell java how to sort
those elements and like i mentioned in
the previous sessions we are going to
cover in detail about how do we write
that sort if we provide that sorting
implementation or sorting logic to java
in case of custom classes but we'll
cover that when we'll cover about that
sorting logic
for now for the demo sake we are just
taking a string or a queue of strings
basically which is of type priority
queue and then again
following the same example as we saw in
the case of stacks just so that you can
build some sort of similarity i'm again
inserting few strings here which are
country names
so at first i'm inserting india then i'm
inserting germany and then i'm inserting
america so i have basically added three
entries into this particular queue then
at line 15 i'm just printing the queue
and i just wanted to see if i inserted
elements in this order where india with
an i go first germany with a g goes
second and america with an a goes third
and if it is a priority queue does it
automatically sort the elements or not
so let's first observe that part and let
me comment the rest of the code we will
cover the rest of the code slowly so
that we build a sort of cognitive flow
so let me comment this code and let's
just print the queue for now so i'm
inserting the elements into the queue
and just printing the element q has a
concept of head and tail remember that
so the very first element in the queue
is is basically the head and the very
last element is the tail so whenever you
see the term head and tail you can
remember that head is the first element
and tail is the last element
so now let's try to run this code and
see what happens if you just print the
queue as is you're not iterating over it
you are not accessing any particular
element but you are just printing it
so if you do this we see the output here
which says original queue this
particular one says america india and
germany now this might be looking
confusing right because if i apply
natural sorting then america should come
first which is okay then germany should
come because after a the g is the is the
next natural alphabet starting point and
then india should come but we see india
in the middle here the reason is because
when you call is call this inside the
system.out.println method let me just go
back if you print it inside this
particular
system.out.println method automatically
when you try to print a variable its two
string method is called so technically
under the hood this is what is getting
called though we don't need to write the
tostring but the moment you try to print
any variable inside the
system.out.println
automatically its two string method is
getting called and in the interesting
part is if you call the tostring method
it will call the abstract collection
classes to string method which does not
understand sorting so remember that very
well if you are working with priority
queues then in that case if you just try
to print the queue you will not get the
natural order but once you try to add
elements or remove elements or peak the
elements in those cases you will get the
natural ordering sequence but if you
just print the queue as is you will not
be able to get the natural order and it
will be random order that's why you see
a random order but let's try to build
our understanding around the natural
order so once we have printed the queue
now let's understand the other method of
the queue which is the remove method
and if you remember i told you that this
is a fifo queue so if you try to remove
an element the head of the queue is
going to get removed the head in this
case is this string america which should
be removed from this particular
collection if i call remove method so
i'm just calling the remove method and
then printing the remove remaining queue
again this queue will be printed in
random fashion but if it is respecting
the priority queue's natural ordering
sequence then america should get removed
when psychology move so let's verify
your understanding
so i can see the queue after removing
the head element remains as germany and
india these are the elements which are
left now and america is removed from
this particular queue now so that
verifies our understanding that when you
call remove
the head of the queue will be removed
and the head will be the alphabetically
sorted first element of the queue
there's another interesting method in
the queue similar to stacks we have a
peak method if you just want to view
which element is sitting at the head of
the queue if you just want to view it
you don't want to remove the element but
you just want to view the element in
that case you can call the peak method
so i'm just calling q dot peak and
storing the output of q dot peak into a
variable called head and then just
printing the head so let's see what
happens in this case okay so i'm getting
this message which says head of the
queue is germany because germany is now
the new head after america was removed
from this particular collection so that
is our head and like i said whenever you
call these methods
these will respect natural sorting order
cis out will not respect natural sorting
order remember that another interesting
method is pole
so pole method is basically used to
remove the element and also return the
element so you can see which is the uh
head and it will also remove the head
both at the same time but in case of
remove you were just removing the
element you were not able to see which
element was removed in this case you
will be able to see which element is
sitting at the head and also at the same
time the head will also be removed so
for that you need to call the pole
method so i'm calling q dot poll and
storing this again in the same variable
head so the head variables value will
get just overwritten if i reuse it again
and then i'm printing the removed head
let's see so i'm right i'm just running
this application again and i see this
message removed head germany which is
coming from here so when you call the q
dot poll the current head of the queue
got removed which was germany and it
also was returned from the poll method
so you can store the removed element and
use that removed element for further
processing in your program and after
that only one element in the queue
should be remaining which is india so at
the last line number 26 i'm just
printing the remaining parts portions of
the queue so yes now only india is
remaining so you can see all the outputs
here this was where we started from uh
then we removed the head element of the
queue so this element got removed and we
were left with germany and india you can
see here india germany was in this order
and here the order was changed because
it is random order when you use it on
the cis out then we wanted to just get
the head of the cube but we did not want
to remove it so we used the peak method
and we got germany then we wanted to
remove the head so we removed the head
with the help of pole method and it also
returned the removed element which is
germany and after the removal the queue
looks like this which is having just one
element left in the queue and in this
case the head and the tail both is india
in this case so this string will be both
the head and the tail this is a special
case if the queue has only one element
left so this is all i wanted to cover in
the case of uh queues and like i
mentioned in the all the previous
sessions as well do go and check out the
java docs api of the queue interface and
the priority queue classes learn and
just get familiar with all the different
methods which are available in this
class so that when you start using these
queues types or these collection types
you you know what all utilities and
methods are available and even if you
don't know like i always mention if you
just do dot here it will automatic any
any good ide will automatically show you
all the methods which are available here
which you can read about in the
documentation here and understand what
each method does and you can use that
method as well so that is also possible
so that's it i wanted to that's all i
wanted to cover in today's lecture and
in the next session we are going to talk
about classes and objects let's get
started with classes and objects in java
so like i have been promising in the
previous sessions that i will cover this
in a dedicated session and this is a
session where we will go deeper into the
concept of classes and objects
you have been seeing this keyword all
along in the all the sessions wherever i
ran the different examples and let's
understand what this means
technically if you go by the definition
a class is basically a blueprint of an
object which brings the question as what
is object an object is basically an
instance of the class
i know this becomes more confusing so
let's break it down into simpler
definitions
a class is technically a logical entity
it's you can think of it as any entity
in the world if you have to let's say if
you have to build
a student management system or a college
management system then all the real life
objects which you see we always say that
java is heavily inspired from real life
examples and classes and objects are the
reason we say that because whatever you
see in the world is always basically
some entity human beings are an entity
cars are an entity students are an
entity lecturers are an entity so who
are all the actors all the actors which
you see in the world are basically
entities and you can map them as classes
in the java program
now why do you want to map them because
these entities have basically
two
kind of specifications
one is every entity will have some
attributes and it will have some
behavior and actually that is how you
identify an entity for example human
beings have attributes like we have
hands we have eyes we have ears legs etc
these are our attributes then we have
our behaviors behaviors are actions you
can think of them as a human being can
speak so can speak is an action it's a
behavior can listen is an is an action
it's a behavior can walk is an action is
a behavior
similarly can eat is also an action or a
behavior so that's how you basically
represent an entity that's how basically
you identify an entity that an entity
will have
some attributes and some behavior if you
see those two specifications in any
entity you can map that entity or you
can write that entity inside a java
program as a class because a class in
java will exactly have these two
properties
it will have some attributes which we
call as properties
and it will have
some behaviors which technically are
called as methods so it will have
attributes and it will have properties
and
methods similar to real world entity
where we have attributes and behavior
behavior our methods and attributes are
properties that's how it is
if you if you apply this simple
philosophy whenever you are taking
requirements from a customer for a
particular project always try to
identify these entities these actors in
your program once you have identified
those you will be able to write a
corresponding java class in your java
program which can represent those
entities without representation of those
entities you cannot write the program so
java will kind of force you to think in
this direction to find entities which
will have attributes and behaviors
so taking that philosophy further and
taking that example further here for you
i have prepared an example where i am
creating a student class so basically
let's say if you have to build a college
management system or a student
management system then student is
probably one of the main entities which
will be
talked about when you take the
requirements
so if you think about the attributes and
the behavior concept a student will have
a name will have an age will have an
address
and at the same time a student
can also have some behaviors
like can enroll in a particular course
can attend a lecture can take a leave
can take exam etc these are all
behaviors
let's understand this in a more detail
with the help of this example where i've
created a class which is named a student
and you see the public keyword here
again i will cover access modifier
public is basically an access modifier
and i will cover this in very detail in
the upcoming sessions for now let's
focus on this part so we have created a
class to represent our entity you put a
curly braces around it it ends here and
after that you provide the attributes
so here i'm saying that a student will
have a name it will have an age and it
will have an address it has three
properties so the technical name of
attributes is properties
after that let's skip this part and i
will come back to this part once you
have declared these properties
you would want to provide a way for
the name to be filled or replaced or
received for example if you have created
the student class how do you insert the
name inside the student class or how do
you insert the age or how do you insert
the address or modify the agent name or
address properties
for that we have these
setters and getters methods we call them
setters and getters because they start
with this keyword not keyword but they
start with a string called set it is not
a keyword you can actually write it as
anything you can call it as modify name
that will also be absolutely fine java
will not give you an error but the
standard naming convention given by java
is to start the methods as starting with
set and
get
this is the st this is the standard
naming convention and like i said it's a
naming convention it's not a compulsion
but if you write this way your
co-developers and the people who are
going to maintain this project in the
long run will be very happy otherwise
they will be very angry if you use
strange methods because like i said this
is the standard naming convention
so now you are going to write a setter
method for each of the properties in
this particular class for name age and
address
so we call set name
again you put public void because this
is not supposed to return anything this
is just supposed to set the value of
name with whatever value you specified
then you call set name
and then you provide the value which you
are supposed to set
against the name so whatever value like
any random name john or jane whatever
you need to supply that name here value
while you call this method and that name
uh whatever you name you supply will be
set against the name property of this
particular class
and
remember i use the word this here
intentionally because the way you are
going to represent this is with the help
of this keyword this keyword means
current object it means that you are
when you use this dot name it is
referring to the current object's name
property and this name is basically
corresponding to the name which is
coming in when somebody
is trying to set a name similarly for
set age age is a numeric number if you
if you observed it's basically an
integer then i'm saying in age and
whatever value of age will be coming
will be set in this particular object's
age
then similarly for set address we have a
string address
argument being passed into into this
method and this gets set inside the
current object's address property so i
have provided a way for the external
world to set the values of name age and
address because for each student you
would need to set these values
now you also need to provide a way to
receive the values or to return the
values or to read the values for reading
operation you need to provide the getter
method so you see this get again this is
not a keyword it's a standard naming
convention so similar when you when you
wrote set name similarly you will write
a get name method this get name method
is supposed to be reading the current
object's names properties value and will
return that value since name is a string
that's why you see the return type as
string here
similarly get age is going to return the
age which is an integer and
address is going to return the address
you can also
write it like this which is absolutely
fine it is not going to complain because
technically it is returning the current
objects name properties and age property
and the address property
now let's talk about this what is what
is this section so this section is
basically called a constructor and i
have a whole session dedicated on the
constructors but let's understand why we
need this
remember when i told you the definition
of the class i said that class is a
blueprint of an object
so you have created a student class and
you have 5000 students in your college
now you need to create a new student
object for each of those student you
need to initialize this student class
5000 times how do you do that
to do that
we do that with the help of constructors
we call this constructor this is a
special type of method remember this is
a special type of method which is
provided by java to initialize any
classes objects
if you want to create multiple objects
of the student class you can repeatedly
call this student constructor we call
this constructor so you put public here
because we want this constructor to be
accessible to the outside world then you
put the exact class name so whatever
class name you have provided here you
need to put the exact last name here if
you don't do that java is going to raise
an error
if i do this here it is going to you see
a red line here because java failed to
compile this constructor it does not
understand what is student triple one
but it does understand what is student
so this is how it is going to be and
then you provide all the properties
which are going to create the student
object so you're going to create the
name the age and the address so the name
age and address and then you set those
values again similar to the setter
methods we have seen the reason we need
to use this here because
if you don't if you write it like this
then java doesn't understand the
difference between the current object's
name and the name coming from the
argument so to differentiate that you
need to use this here if you use n here
and if i just use n here then this is
fine because there's only single name
variable in this whole class then but if
i write it like this
then and if i write it like this then
java doesn't know if this name is
basically the student class's name or
this name is student classes name it
will get confused like you are getting
confused if you if you try to just find
this in mind mapping so that's why
we need to write this here so that it's
clearly differentiable that whenever i
use this dot name i'm referring to the
classes name property and when i'm just
using the name i'm referring to the
method argument
that's what we do in doing this in this
constructor so you basically initialize
all the properties of your class with
some values with the help of constructor
so we have the constructor we have the
setter we have the getter we can cover
about this two string basically this two
string is to print print something but
we can cover that later now uh let's
initialize this particular class so i'm
similar to the initialization we have
seen so far you just write student you
write the object name this can be
anything and then you use the new
keyword which is used to initialize
anything in java new is a keyword in
java which you can use to initialize
literally anything in java so you use
new student and when you say new student
you can provide all the values which
should match its constructor so here we
have three values
string
integer and string
and here also we are supplying three
values string integer and string again
so remember to match this exactly with
one of the constructors which is
available in the class if it doesn't
match it is going to fail it will not
work so if i for example if i do
this then i'm supplying four arguments
to the student class but there is no
constructor matching four arguments so
it is going to complain you see this red
line and the code is not compiling
if i remove this then it is matching it
and that's how you basically create a
student object so an object is basically
an instance of the class remember that
very well an object is an instance of
the class once you have created an
instance of the class then you can call
any method like say let's say you want
to read the name so you can call get
name you can read the name similarly if
you want to
so if you if you want to read the age of
the
student then you can do that as well so
let me just copy this
and do this
let's call get
age
i want to print the name i want to print
the age
and i also want to print the address so
get control space i get suggestion
address yep so i'm printing the name i'm
printing the age and i'm printing the
address after i have initialized the
object successfully by using this
constructor representation using the new
keyword so now let's run this method or
run this class basically
okay so when i run this class the whole
class got compiled the constructor the
getters and the setters and the
properties and their types everything
was set then the main got called and i
created a new object from this classes
blueprint the object name was john then
i called john.getname to print the name
which is stored inside this particular
instance of the student class
similarly the age of
age which is stored in this particular
instance so we stored the name as john
so when we call john.getname we get john
we got when we call john.getage we get
the age 25 and we call john dot get
address we call we get this particular
address whatever values you specified
here the constructor got called here and
the name john got set to the student's
name value the age value which you
supplied got set against the students
age and the address value which you
supplied got set against the student's
address and that's how you are going to
create a class so remember whenever you
create a class identify the properties
and the behaviors like setups and
getters
write a constructor which can cover all
the values which you want to initialize
and after that
just initialize that class create an
object of that particular class
basically and once you have the object
then you can call getters
you can also call this in this way if i
don't supply any of this
then it currently it complains and why
it complains i will cover that in the
following session when whenever when i
will cover the multiple constructors
concept but remember you see this
behavior here that if you have created a
constructor which accepts some arguments
and if you supply this
kind of initialization then
student class does not have a
constructor which is parameter less
student class has only one constructor
which is taking three parameters and
that's why java complains because it is
not able to find a representation of a
constructor which accepts no parameter
but like i said we will cover this we
will find a solution to this particular
problem in the in the coming in the
coming session but for this session this
is all we are going to cover we covered
about classes we covered about objects
and we also saw how we can write getters
and setters we can initialize those
methods uh initialize those objects and
we can access the properties of those
objects using the getters and we can
also call the setters to modify the
values as well similar to this
so this is all i wanted to cover in
today's session and in the next session
we are going to dive deeper in the
concept of constructors and how we can
write different types of constructors
let's get started with constructors in
java now if you remember in the previous
session we covered about the concept of
classes and we walked us through with an
example student class where we had a
constructor if i just open this back
this is the class which we covered in
the last lecture and we had this
constructor where we supplied the
required the necessary number of
arguments which can match my students
properties and then i set those
properties calling this dot property
equal to the argument like this
but what if you have a use case where
some of the values are mandatory and
some of the values are optional in these
properties section for example what if
all the students have same address
although this is a very hypothetical
situation but let's assume if if you
have a scenario where you have a
particular entity you have identified
the entity but there are certain
properties in the entity which remain
constant for all the objects if you have
such case then it does not make sense to
supply an argument for that particular
property which is going to remain the
same for all the objects what if you can
just initialize it with with some
default values that would be simpler
right because let's say for example if
this property is going to remain
constant for all the student objects
then you can just supply these two
properties these two arguments in your
constructor and you don't need to supply
the address let's go further what if you
have a class where you have more than
one property let's say if your class has
10 properties and eight of them are
remaining constant or are optional and
only two are changing and mandatory then
how would you write that and what if you
have a different use case for the same
class let's make it even more
complicated that you have a single class
the same class or entity is being used
by different consuming applications
one application would expect let's say
these two to be mandatory and this one
to be optional other consumer
application wants these two to be
mandatory and this one to be optional
the third consuming application wants
all three to be mandatory the fourth
consuming application wants none of
these to be mandatory then how are you
going to do that the answer is multiple
constructors you can write multiple
constructors for each of those consuming
applications and whichever application
wants whichever constructor they can use
that constructor to initialize the
object of the class
so taking that concept further i have
created a class called cuboid
and i have three different properties
written in this class as we know that a
cuboid has basically three properties
which are width height and depth
so i'm taking that example here creating
a class for a cuboid providing the width
height and depth for simplicity i'm
taking this as integers but generally
you will see this as doubles probably
because the values can be in decimal
points but for simplicity's sake i'm
just keeping everything as integer here
then with the standard use case if you
have to create an object of this cuboid
class you would need a constructor where
you can supply all these three values
and here it is this is the constructor
which can be called to provide these
three values so i'm supplying the width
i'm supplying the height i'm supplying
the depth depth and then i am setting
all of these values with the this
keyword say this dot width equal to the
coming width this object's height will
be the height which is coming from here
and this object's depth will be the
depth which is coming from here
now for another use case where let's say
there's another consumer application
where it would expect the depth to be
constant for all of its objects let's
say a value 10
and it only wants
width and height to be supplied then you
can create another constructor java does
allow the use of multiple constructors
in the same class remember that concept
so you can create another constructor
for that representation where you supply
only the width and height
and you keep the depth constant now if a
consumer application calls this
constructor 100 times
all of those 100 cuboid objects will
have the depth as 10 only that will be
the fixed value and only width and
height will be the changing values
similarly if there's another consumer
application which wants to have the same
height and width and depth for the
cuboid then it would just require a
single parameter whatever value the
consumer application is providing you're
setting the same value to the width to
the height and to the depth and to the
depth so technically this is basically
becoming a cube because then the three
dimensions the height width and depth
are same
and what if you have another consumer
application which does not intend to
supply any of the values because for it
all the objects are going to hold the
exact same values for all the properties
let's say there's a consumer application
which would always expect the width the
height and the depth to be 10 then you
can create a constructor with the new
arguments you can see there is no
argument here you can create a
constructor like this and you can supply
all the default values which are static
values so in this case i have created
four constructors i have created this
constructor here which accepts all the
values and whenever you call this
particular object you will have to
specify three values and each object
will have the width height and depth
different
second use case where a consumer
application wants the depth to be
constant with the value 10 and only
wants the width and height to be
variable for each of the objects then
this particular constructor can be
called similarly for another consumer
application which
would want to create just supply a
single value and it would want whatever
value it supplies it would want the
height the width and the depth to be
exactly the same as that value supplied
then it will supply only one value and
the same value is going to be set
against height depth and width
and the fourth use case is where the
consumer application does not intend to
supply anything at all but it would want
the class to set some static values for
all of its objects so then it can call
this
constructor and then i define a behavior
remember the concept of behaviors i
define a behavior here i have not
defined the getters and setters here but
you can definitely do that there is
nothing stopping us from doing that but
for simplicity i just skipped that here
then i define a behavior to basically
this class will provide a behavior which
will be to create the calculate the
value of volume based on the values
which you supply so whatever
value you supply based on that the
cuboid is going to calculate the volume
and as we know the formula of volume is
width into height into depth that is how
we are going to calculate the volume of
a cuboid based on whatever values of
width height and depth are supplied so
let's see this in action i've created a
public static void main method i've
initialized a variable called volume
which is an integer variable we'll see
how we can use that variable and first
let's create a standard cuboid so i call
this particular constructor with three
arguments so when i do this this
particular constructor gets called
and the width height and depth values
which i supply here three values will
get set and i get a standard cuboid and
then i can call the standard cuboid dot
volume then this particular method will
be invoked and the volume will be
calculated with this formula
with these values
that's how we are going to calculate the
volume for a standard simple cuboid and
i am printing that volume value exactly
here so this is basically the
standard constructor being called with
three arguments calling the volume
method and then just printing the volume
second use case where i'm calling the
constructor with two arguments and the
third value should be set automatically
so i'm just applying two values here
when i call the constructor with two
values a matching constructor should be
found here with two values here it is so
width and height will be set with the
values which i am supplying and depth
will automatically be set to
this is what is happening here cuboid
with some defaults and then i again
calculate the volume and print the
volume
i'm just using the same volume variable
here in the third use case i'm calling
the constructor with a single parameter
so i'm just providing one value and the
same value should get be should be set
against all the width height and depth
values and technically it becomes a cube
so i'll just call it as cube here
then i'm calculating the volume of the
cube and printing the volume of the cube
and then at last
i'm using the constructor with the new
arguments i'm calling this as default
cuboid because i'm not supplying any
values and then i'm again calling the
volume method on this and printing the
volume so these are the four constructor
invocations so this class is
demonstrating four different kinds of
constructor invocations let's run this
class and observe the output
okay so let's start from here i called
this particular constructor with three
arguments 10 20 and 15 and then the
volume was calculated which would be 10
into 20 into 15 which is 3 000
so this sysout basically prints this
output
then move on to the next one where i'm
saying cuboid with defaults which is
having the value 10 and 20 and the third
value of depth is automatically being
set to 10 so technically when i call the
volume it will become 10 into 10 into 20
which is 2000. and that's how the volume
of the cuboid default depth is printed
from the line 47. going on to the next
one at line 51 the volume of the cube is
basically the volume which is calculated
after calling this particular
constructor and calling the volume
method so here the height the width and
the depth all three are set to 10 so it
will technically be when we call the
volume method it will be 10 into 10 into
10 which is thousand and that's how you
get this output it says volume of the
cube is thousand
and then i call the default cuboid
method which is
simply providing no values and we expect
everything to be set with some defaults
and the default constructor is setting
the value as 10 for height width and
depth so in this case if i'm calling the
volume method and if i'm printing the
volume it should be printed as 1000
because 10 into 10 into 10 is thousand
so this is basically to showcase you how
you can use different constructors
there's another thing which you should
know is if you do not provide any
constructor to this particular class
let me just comment out all the
constructors in this class
and let me
comment out
most of the code here as well
so now if you see i have not provided
any constructor in this particular class
right there is no constructor let me
just
maximize this so there is no constructor
being called here there is no
constructor being left here everything
is commented so there is no constructor
in this class but this line still passes
there is no compilation error there is
no red line on this particular line the
reason is
if you do not provide a constructor to a
class java by default will provide a
constructor which will be the no
parameter constructor so remember that
whenever you don't supply any
constructor you can still create objects
of that class with this
non-parameterized constructor
representation like student student
equal to new student without any
parameters that will work if you have
not provided any constructor
implementation inside your class and if
we do that let's see what what value do
we get because i have commented the
default constructor everything here
right so let's print the value
if i go to run as i get the value as 0.
so what happened here
when i call this particular line the
default constructor provided by java
gets called and java will set the values
of all the properties to the default
values which are supported by the data
type and integer primitive data types
default value in java is zero if you do
not provide any if you do not assign a
value to an integer variable by default
it is going to be initialized with 0.
that's the java's behavior and that's
what is happening here because we did
not provided a default constructor so
when we call this new cuboid here
without any parameters without any
arguments
the default constructor of java gets
called and it sets everything with the
default values which is 0 0 0 and then
if we call the volume method it's
basically 0 multiplied by 0 multiplied
by 0
which will eventually be the output as 0
and that's how you get this 0 output
let's try one more thing what if i
enable one constructor let's enable any
one constructor which is non which is
having at least one parameter let's say
this one
so i have enabled one constructor i have
commented in i've just removed the
comments from one constructor which
takes a single argument and let's go
down
now you see an error so this is
something again a java's behavior that
if you provide even a single constructor
in your class which is non
which is having at least one parameter
i just repeat that if you create any
constructor in your class
which is having at least one parameter
then the default constructor
implementation of java will not
automatically work
in this case you will have to explicitly
provide a default constructor as well
the default constructor will only and
only work if you have not provided any
constructor at all in your class the
moment you provide even a single
constructor which is having even a
single parameter in your class
then the default constructor out of the
box will not work and you will have to
explicitly provide a default constructor
so to make this work i have to just
enable the default constructor code and
then only it will pass so if no
constructor it will work without any
parameter but the moment you provide
even a single constructor with even a
single argument then you have to either
use that parameterized constructor or
you have to provide your own default
constructor implementation because java
will not use its own default constructor
implementation in that class
so i hope you find this particular
concept useful and remember this concept
because this is again this can be
confusing when you are reading somebody
else's code you need to always
understand what all constructors are
there and in the next session we are
going to talk about another very
interesting and exciting concept in java
which is about streams let's get started
with streams in java before i go any
further i just wanted to clarify that
when i say stream i am not talking about
the input output stream but i'm talking
about stream as a concept in general
this is a slightly newer concept which
was introduced in java 8 and has been
there and it is extremely popular and
the reason java introduced this the
concept of streams to uh to the jdk was
to promote the functional programming
paradigm what we have been seeing so far
is basically an object or the same lines
of code which you would write in java in
an in a classic object oriented way in
like let's say 10 lines the same line of
code that whole 10 lines of code can be
written in a single line using the
functional programming paradigm so let's
understand the concept of streams first
so the basic concept of streams is to
help you hydrating and manipulating
collections so remember all the classes
which we covered in the collections
framework the list the set the map etc
streams provide you with a better and
optimized way to basically allow you to
manipulate those collections iterate
over those collections change the
representation of the collection types
etc so to understand why we need streams
let's understand what is how the
streaming works so let's take a very
simple example if you if you watch a
youtube video it is basically streamed
to your device and when we say stream it
means the whole object the whole video
size is not downloaded at once on your
device and it is being downloaded bit by
bit to your device piece by piece to
your device this is better in lot of
ways your device does not need the full
memory to store the complete video
because it is only going to process one
bite at a time and just throw it away
once it has been watched so the
streaming will basically
help you
work on a very large size item you know
where using a very small memory
footprint that's the power of streams
contrary to that you can also let's say
if you are if you're watching a one
gigabytes video then you can either
download the whole one gigabyte video on
your mobile which is going to consume
complete one gigabyte space on your
memory or you can stream that one
gigabyte video onto your mobile device
where maybe only a few megabytes will be
required to watch the whole video
because at a time it will only consume
few megabytes and it does not need one
gigabyte of complete space to stream
that video so that's the basic idea and
that's why streams are very popular and
very optimal way to work with
collections and let's understand with
the help of an example actually i've
prepared multiple examples of multiple
capabilities of the streams api so
streams is basically an api which is
provided after java 8 and you can use
that to iterate over collections or
manipulate collections let's see that
and let's also compare that with how you
have been doing this before java 8. so
here i have created a list you can see
it's basically an integer list and i
have created an array list here i have
added few numbers to this particular
error list so numbers are 10 20 30 and
40. so precisely four elements are
inserted into the list
now you have a requirement in your
project that you need to basically
calculate the square of each of the
elements of the list
and prepare a new list that is the
requirement
so if you were not using streams you
would write code something like this
you will initialize the list a new list
basically which will which you can call
it as anything for example you can call
it as squares list and then you are
going to call an enhanced for loop here
hydrating over the numbers list one by
one taking each element calculating the
square of it and then adding that
element to the new list and that's how
you are going to write this logic if you
were not using streams so you can see
it's basically technically one two three
four lines of code just to get the list
if you were using streams then you can
do this with a single line let me just
comment out the
old code
and let me just bring this
to the same line to show you that it's a
single line code so the same logic which
you wrote here can be written just like
this
you can see it's so optimal so simple
for the processor to compile this code
is also very fast because they can
process a single instruction very fast
and very quickly and streams do utilize
the multi-core capabilities as well so
now is the time and that and the era of
multi-core processors and that's why
streams are more beneficial to use
rather than writing the verbose
instructions so let's understand how
this works to convert a particular
collection into a stream you need to
call the collectiontype.stream so here
the numbers list was the collection
variable so once you call this dot
stream you will get a stream
representation now the elements of the
list are being streamed one by one they
are not being sent at all at once they
are streamed one by one now so you get a
stream the moment you call stream then
now the stream api has multiple methods
or utility methods which you can read
about for example if i just write a dot
here you will see lots of utility
methods which the stream api provides
you which you can use in different
conditions
we are going to cover few of the very
important and very popular methods but
again please do read out the streams api
documentation to get the hang of all the
other methods so once we have the stream
then the first method which i'm going to
showcase to you out of the stream api is
the map method
map method can be used to change the
representation of the elements one by
one and that's what we need to do right
we need to change the representation of
these elements to the square of these
elements so remember that that line
which i said whenever you have to change
the representation of the elements
inside the collection think of map think
of the map method this is not the map
collection this is not the map
collection this is the map method of the
stream api so if you're using stream api
you have a use case to convert the
representation of the elements of the
collection think about maps always
so i call the map method here and then
you see the strange syntax here this is
basically a lambda function syntax so
lambda function is another concept which
java introduced in java 8. uh lambda is
as a concept has been there in in some
other programming languages like scala
for a very long time but it's been
introduced in java of late in java 8
only and lambda is basically you can say
is the paradigm which will enable you to
write functional programming constructs
in java and the syntax of lambda is very
straightforward
you provide
a representation of the element here so
each element here one by one is going to
be represented to x
then you write this arrow here basically
a hyphen and a
greater than sign and after that you
write what is the
final value which you want to see for
that particular element so here my
requirement was that i want to convert
the representation of the element to the
square of its element so i just do x
into x because x is the current element
i want to change this to this so
whatever destination representation you
have in your mind write that on the
right hand side of this arrow on the
left hand side it will be the element on
the right hand side it would be the
representation which you want to work
with
so you have written your conversion
logic inside the map method with a
lambda function representation under the
hood if you want to know more technical
details about it it's basically working
on the concept of functional interfaces
do read about the functional interfaces
concept as well that will help you build
the cons the usage of lambda functions
and how this whole construct is written
so read about functional interfaces and
lambda functions to understand map in
detail and what but for to to work with
it like i said this the left hand side
will be the element and the right hand
side would be the uh final
representation which you want to have
for that particular element once you
have done that still this until this
particular point you have converted the
collection into the stream it is
streaming the elements one by one and
you have successfully also calculated
calculated the square of each element
but this is still a stream
now you need to convert this stream back
to
a list which can be used further in your
program so to do that you can use the
collect method which we also call as the
terminal methods this is another uh a
concept which i'm just introducing to
you right now so there is an
intermediate method concept and there is
a terminal method concept
this is what streams understand java
stream understands when you say
intermediate method those methods are or
those operators are basically the ones
which are used before the final
collection is prepared like the map
method is basically a intermediate
operation and then you have some
terminal operations like collect once
you call the terminal operations after
that the stream has been concluded the
stream is dead so once you call this
collect method
and if you try to
do something here again let's say if you
want to do something it will not work
because the moment you use the collect
method stream will expect this to be the
last method which you want to use in
this particular instruction after that
the stream is dead and you will get
strange exceptions if you try to write
any further operation after collect so
do so also do read about what are the
all the different terminal operations
available and what are all the
intermediate operations available i'm
going to cover a bunch of these in this
in the different examples i've prepared
in this particular class but because i
will not be able to cover all of the
methods so do read about those methods
what are the intermediate operations and
what are the terminal operations and the
concept i just explained you
intermediate operations can be used in
in a chaining fashion after this dot map
you can use another dot map another dot
map another dot map you can again type
like do this this will
this will work fine you can keep
concatenating multiple map methods and
multiple filter methods and any of the
other intermediate operations which are
available but once you have called the
collect method after this you cannot
call another map if you try to do this
it is going to fail it will not work
because collect is a terminal operation
and what i want to do in the terminal
operation is i want to convert this new
stream which is having the square of the
elements
convert that back into a new list and to
do that i can call the collectors.to
list method the moment you write this
method inside the collect method it is
going to take the stream of the elements
one by one
just collate that stream into a single
stream into a single collection and then
return that collection back into the
list which you want to store is it in so
remember the correct method terminal
operation and the moment you do
collectors dot 2 list the whole streams
elements is going to be
converted into a list and that list is
going to be stored into whatever left
hand variable you have written and that
is how you can basically write this
whole code which we wrote in four lines
into just one line and then you can
print the squares list so let's do that
let me comment this particular code as
well so that we don't get any strange
errors or strange outputs
let me comment this part as well we will
cover this one by one
and let me cover all of this as well i'm
just going to comment everything here
and we'll focus on only the squared list
which we have prepared using the streams
api so right click run as java
application
there you go you have the output here so
the first number was 10 the square of it
is 100 so yes you get 100 second number
is 20 the square of it is 400 third
number is 30 the square of it is 900
fourth number is 40 the square of it is
1600 so you get all the values squared
by using the stream api and like i said
you can write the same code in the old
way as well but this is the efficient
and the better way of writing the same
code in a single line
this is all i wanted to cover in today's
session let's get started with streams
api in java in the previous session also
we covered some basic functionality of
the streams api of how we can convert a
list of numbers into the squares of the
numbers of the same list today we are
going to look at an extension of the
same kind of functionality let's say you
have a requirement where you have a list
and you are asked to convert that list
into a set and while you convert the
list into set you also have to calculate
the square of each number so instead of
just converting the list of numbers into
a set you have to convert the square of
those numbers into a set collection that
is our objective so i'm going to use the
same list which i had created in the
previous example which you can see here
i have a numbers list and i've added 4
elements to it 10 20 30 and 40
and then if i did not have to use stream
or if i did not have the option to use
stream this is how the code would look
like where you would explicitly create a
set of type hash set
and then you will iterate over the
numbers list and then you will pick each
item of the numbers list and multiply it
by itself hence calculating the square
and then you will be adding those that
that result into the destination set
this is what i'm doing here just to show
you that different comparison of how do
you write it in the classical day and
then in a while we will look at how we
can write the same kind of functionality
using the streams api
so let's first run this particular
approach where i'm adding all the square
of all the elements into a set which is
a hash set type so the order of the set
is not guaranteed because i'm using a
hash set and then i'm just printing the
hash set
so let's try to run this program
so i go to run as java application and i
get the output and you can see if you
look at the list here the results are
not in the same sequence in which the
elements were added into the list it is
because of the nature of the hash set
but we do get the result as expected now
if i have to write the same kind of
functionality
using the streams api then this is how i
will write it i will just uncomment this
one and will comment out this one
so now if i look at this new code it's
doing the exact same thing but in a
functional programming approach and
using the streams api approach so i'm
again calling dot stream hence
converting the list into a stream then
calling map which is to use to change
the representation of the elements of
the collection so i'm changing the
representation from the single number to
the square of it and then calling dot
collect which is a terminal operator
where i am converting this stream into a
set by calling collectors dot two set so
two set is the method here which is
going to convert this into a set
and then i'm printing the square set
so let's run this program and observe
the output
if i run the program i get the same
output so i can achieve the same kind of
functionality but much more efficiently
using the streams api
so this was an example where i could use
the collectors.2 set method to create a
set out of a list
now let us move forward to another
interesting and very popular
functionality which is filtering so let
me comment this code again so that we
don't get multiple outputs and let me
uncomment this code here
so what i am doing here is i am creating
a list of languages which is an
arraylist and then i am adding three
elements to this particular error list
which are java python and scala and this
is a string of
the list of strings here so i'm adding
three strings here these strings can be
anything i've just taken the example of
programming languages here but this can
be anything so technically we have a
list of string objects and then my task
is to
get a new list out of this existing list
which will have the elements which start
with the letter p let's say that is your
requirement that you have to get only
the elements of this list where the name
of the element starts with the letter p
if that is your requirement
probably this is how you will be writing
the code if you are not using the
streams api where you will create a new
list an empty list basically and then
you will iterate over the old list which
is the languages
so you will iterate over the languages
list and then you will pick the each
element of this particular list and
check if that string starts with the
letter p
if yes then you will add that particular
string element into the new filter list
by calling the add method and then you
can print that particular list that is
how you will be doing it if you were not
using streams
so let's run this program and understand
the output so i'm again going to right
click run as
java application
and the output i get is python because
that is the only string in the list
which starts with the letter p so we get
the expected output now let's try to
write the same code using the streams
api so let me comment this code and i
will save the file and let's look at how
we can do the same thing in a single
line using the streams api so to use to
write the same kind of logic using the
stream api we start with the same kind
of syntax where we take languages.stream
to convert the list into a stream and
then we call a new method called filter
so filter is the method which you will
be using whenever you have to write any
conditional logic on all the elements of
the list remember whenever you have to
write a filtering or a conditional logic
on a particular list then you will be
using the filter method of the streams
api so you will convert the collection
into the stream and then you will apply
the filter method to apply the condition
this condition can be anything in this
case the condition is that the elements
should start with b it can be anything
for for example it can be based on the
string length if you want if it's a
numbers collection it can be if a number
is greater than 100 or not so any kind
of if logic which you might have to run
on a particular collection can be run
using the filters method
so we call the filter method and we
again follow the same lambda function
syntax where we here this particular s
denotes each element one by one and this
arrow represents the lambda notation and
then what we want to do that we want to
run this condition
on each of the element of the stream one
by one and the condition is that the
element should start with the letter p
if that is true then
whichever elements satisfy this
particular condition will be getting out
after this execution so the block which
i have selected once the filter method
has completed its execution after that
only the elements which have satisfied
this filtering condition will be left in
the stream rest of the elements have
been filtered out so once you have the
filtered result then you can again call
the collect method which is the terminal
operator and you call collectors dot to
list same as the example in covered in
the previous session so i'm running the
filtering logic and getting a new list
which will have only the elements which
satisfy this condition so i get the
collectors.2 list result back into our
new list which is called filter result
and then i'm printing the filter result
so let's see if we get the same kind of
output if we use this logic yes we do
get the same kind of output and this is
something which validates how we can use
the filter operation seamlessly by
applying exactly the same kind of logic
which we used to apply by writing this
much verbose code another benefit is
that the streams api are more efficient
in using the multi-core processors which
are common nowadays on any machine
so this is all i want to cover in
today's session i don't want to last
this session to be even more longer so
we will conclude today's session at this
particular point and in the next session
we are going to have a look at some more
functionalities of the stream api seeing
how we can sort the collections how we
can iterate over the collections because
even this code is a bit too much for the
uh for for the streams api to iterate
over a collection so we will look at a
smarter way of the streams api by which
we can hydrate over the collection we
will also have a look at how we can sort
collections let's get started with how
we can use the streams api to sort
collections and also to iterate over
collections and i'm going to use the
same collections which we have used in
the previous sessions just to build some
sort of continuity here so i'm going to
use the same array list which i created
in the previous session which is storing
a string of elements which is having
three strings which is java python and
scala these are just three strings which
i am storing into a list which is called
languages and now my task is to sort
this particular collection i have to
sort the elements of this particular
list so that when i access the list i
get the elements accessed in a natural
sorting order so i should get the result
java first then python as a second
result and scala as the third result
let's make it a bit more interesting let
me put this at the beginning so now i
have and let our elements starting with
s
being added first then an element
starting with j being added second and
the third element being added which
starts with p let me add one more string
to it just to make it bit more
interesting and practical so let me add
a new language here which can be let's
call basic so now i have four elements
here and now i want to sort this
particular collection so for sorting
streams api provide a very
straightforward way to sort any kind of
collection which is to use the dot
sorted method and we will follow the
same kind of semantics which we have
followed in the previous session which
is you pick the current collection call
the dot stream method on it which will
convert the collection into a stream and
once the stream has been created then
you call the dot sorted method on the
stream which is going to sort all the
elements of the stream in a natural
sorting order remember we are using
strings here so java already knows how
to sort strings if you were using a
custom class let's say list of students
or list of customers then you have to
specify your sorting implementation to
java because java doesn't know how to
sort customers or how to sort students
so you in that case you will have to
provide your own sorting implementation
and we will cover that in the upcoming
sessions but for now let's understand
this example by using one of the
pre-built data types which is string and
we call the dot sorted method which is
going to sort this particular stream and
then we use the terminal operator which
is dot collect to convert this stream
back to a list and we do that by calling
collectors dot to list we do that and we
get the list out we stored that list
into a variable called sorted list and
then we print the sorted list so let's
run this program and understand the
output remember that we have these
strings added here
so right click run as java application
and this is the result i get i get basic
as the first element when i get the new
list which has all the sorted elements
then i get java with a j then i get
python with a p and then i get scala
with an s so you can see that these
strings are presented in a natural
sorted sequential order here and that is
what is happening because we call the
sorted method and this is how you can
use the streams api to sort any kind of
collection hope this is helpful to
understand the concept of sorting now
let's move on to another concept which
is about how do you iterate over
collections using the streams api we
already have a way of iterating over the
collections using the enhanced for loop
remember we covered this at length in
different sessions in the past so we can
definitely use this particular logic it
doesn't break it will not stop us from
using this we can still continue using
the enhanced for loop logic to iterate
over any kind of collection but streams
api provides even a smarter way to
iterate over the collections let's see
how we can do that so let me uncomment
this particular code here and now if i
look at this particular code and if i
try to understand it i will see a sort
of similarity with the way we have been
working with streams so we'll follow the
same drill we'll pick up the existing
collection called the dot stream method
on it this is going to convert the
collection into a stream and then we
call dot for each method this is the
method which you need to use whenever
you want to iterate over a collection
using the streams api so we call the dot
for each method again follow the same
lambda construct where this is each of
the element y represents each of the
element here and then i write the code
which is supposed to be executed for
each element so in this case i want to
just print every element that is my
requirement when i am hydrating over
this particular collection so i can just
put this arrow here let me put the
spaces here to make it more legible so
each element
should be applied this particular logic
on and we are printing each of the
element one by one if i do that let's
observe the output and let me comment
this particular code which we just
covered for the sorting logic so we get
only one output let's run this code now
so here we see we get some output here
first of all this sysout gets printed
which says printing all elements one by
one yes that's there and then
here we are saying element is which is a
static string and then every element one
by one is supposed to be printed and
that is what we see here we get all the
elements one by one and here it's not a
sorted order because we are not doing
any sorting here it's just printing all
the elements so this is how you can use
the for each method to iterate over any
collection in a single line of code
instead of writing all of that code now
you might be wondering what if i don't
have to i have to do more than just
printing the element what is it is a
multiple lines of code which i have to
run for each element how do i do that
it's pretty straightforward we just put
curly braces here in the starting and in
the end of the code block inside the for
each method and let me just put an enter
here just to make it more readable so
here you can write the code whatever you
want to in terms of the kind of logic
you want to apply on each element so
once you have put this curly braces you
can write as many lines of logic as
required inside this code in the inside
this curly base braces block and this
code is going to be executed for each of
the element one by one if you have just
one line of code you do not need to and
you should not put the curly braces if
it's just one line of code just drop
this curly braces completely remove the
semicolon as well along with the curly
braces and this is how you will run a
single line of code but if you have a
multiple lines of code which suppose
which is required to be run for each of
the element then you put the curly
braces and then you follow the normal
java construct which is to end every
statement with a semicolon the usual
java programming code basically which
can go inside the curly braces so that's
how you can use for each for any simple
and complex iteration logic which you
want to apply on a particular program
and this is all i want to cover in
today's session so we talked about how
we can use the dot sorted method to sort
a particular collection and we also had
a look at how we can use the streams api
for each method to iterate over the
collections in the next session we are
going to talk about a very interesting
method of the streams api and a very
popular one which is called the reduce
functionality let's get started with
using the reduce functionality in the
streams api
before we go to the implementation of
the reduced functionality let us
understand why do we need it and how the
constructs of the reduced functionality
work so let's understand first about the
requirement why do we need it
so imagine a requirement where you have
a list of numbers and you are asked to
calculate the sum of all the elements
inside the list a very straightforward
requirement that you have a collection
and you are asked to calculate the sum
of all the elements of the collection
now if you do not use the streams api
you can go ahead and very well write a
complex for each logic or enhanced for
loop logic to basically run that code
and write the logic where you pick one
element all the elements one by one and
keep adding them to the new element
but we can do the same kind of thing by
using the reduce method and to put it in
a generic way if we have to understand
why we need reduce methods so whenever
you have to change the whole collection
representation into a single result
remember that line whenever you have to
change the representation of the
complete collection into a single result
in those cases you will use the reduce
method of the stream's api and if you
apply this definition to the example i
gave you i have a collection of numbers
and i want to calculate the sum of all
the elements of this collection which is
a single result which is a single number
so yes my example does apply correctly
to the generic definition of the reduced
method so remember this generic
definition this will help you understand
when to use the reduce method in your
program
so how does the reduce method work you
can see i have shown you an example of
the syntax of the reduce method and it
looks a bit complex here so let's try to
understand what is happening here to
understand the functionality of the
reduce method we have to understand
three terms which are identity
accumulator
and a combiner
let's understand each of them one by one
identity is basically an element which
is the default or the initial value of
the reduction operation
this value will be used if the stream
itself is empty or it will be used as
the first value of the result which you
want to get out eventually so in this
case if i have to submit all the
elements of a collection the initial
value can be set as 0 and that is the
first thing which you have to pass
inside the reduce method so you can see
0 here the next thing is the accumulator
so accumulator is a function which will
take two parameters the first parameter
would be the ongoing partial result
let's say if you have to calculate the
sum of the all elements and let's say if
you have iterated two elements so far so
the sum of those two elements is your
temporary or partial result right so you
need to store that partial result
somewhere and that is the first argument
of the accumulator method in this case
it is this variable which is shorthanded
as ans or answer so the first argument
is the partial result and the second
argument of the accumulator function is
the next element of the stream so
whatever the next element is which is
supposed to be added to the existing
result is going to be the next argument
of the accumulator function which is i
in this case
so we talked about the identity we
talked about about the accumulator
function then we have a third one which
is called combiner
and this is sort of an optional not in
all cases but in in some cases it is
optional let's understand why do we need
combiner so combiner is an optional
function which you will be required to
use if
you want to sum the two elements which
do not have the same data type what i
mean is here this ans or answer and i
both are integer if both of the
arguments of your accumulator function
are of the same data type you do not
need a combiner and that's why there's
no combiner here but
if there is a requirement where you are
let's say adding a a correct sum to a
student object then it doesn't work
right because a student object is a
custom object and the current sum is a
number object so a student object cannot
be just added to a number object
it can work if you can do student.getage
which is a number object so a current
answer plus the student dot get age
might work but current answer comma
student will not work in those cases
where you have mismatching data types in
those cases you will have to write a
combiner function but for this case you
don't need to write a combiner function
because both of the elements or the
arguments of the accumulator function
are of the same data type so you specify
that argument function for functions
arguments basically and then you provide
the implementation of the accumulator
function which is this one this is the
implementation again using a lambda
construct here so you provide the
implementation of this particular
accumulator function and then there is
no comma here to provide further
combiner functions specifications so
there is no combiner here if there was a
combiner there would be a comma here and
then you will write the combiner
specification where you will cast the
current object into the type
which is the same as the partial result
so you don't need that here and you can
just say the partial result plus the
current element and that should work
fine so this is how you will write the
reduced logic and if you have written
this logic correctly then it should
automatically just submit all the
elements one by one and produce a single
result and remember i'm using the
numbers list here which is
written here in the very beginning where
i have four elements to it which are 10
20 30 and 40. so if the reduce operation
works fine with with my intended
objective then 40 plus 30 which is 70
plus 20 is 90 plus 10 is 100 so i should
get the 100 as that as the final result
of this reduce operation you will also
notice that after this particular method
you don't need to call any collector
method or any collect method at all the
reason is because this particular
function itself will return a single
result which we can store in the desired
variable so now let's try to run this
particular example and see the output
so right click run as java application
and i get the result as 100 which is
coming from this particular sysout where
i'm printing the sum so yes this is
working as per our expectation where it
basically
created the sum of all the elements of
this particular collection so remember
when you will use the reduce operation
remember the generic definition whenever
you have to convert the whole collection
into a single result that would be the
use case where you will use the reduce
operation that's one thing remember the
identity operators definition remember
the how the accumulator function works
and also remember when to use that
combiner function a reminder of when to
use the combiner function is whenever
you have these two arguments of
different data types that would be the
use case where you would need to write a
combiner function it is also used if you
have to write parallel streams but
parallel streams is an advanced concept
which we are not covering in this
particular tutorial but if you want to
learn about the the whole parallel
stream concept do check out the api docs
for that and you can also have a look at
some examples from the java tutorial
official website itself and that's all i
want to cover in today's session in the
next session we are going to talk about
the access modifiers in java let's get
started with access modifiers in java so
when we talk about access modifiers
let's understand what is the underlying
philosophy of the reasoning behind this
and the reasoning is very
straightforward it can be even wrapped
into a single word which is called
security the reason is that you will be
creating multiple kinds of objects and
variables while you write your java
program and you should always write your
java program or any program in a manner
that only the intended classes packages
modules or applications should be able
to see what they are supposed to see
so as a consumer application i should
only be able to consume the variables
which i am expected to consume i should
not get any variable or i should not
even have access to any variable which i
am not supposed to access so the idea is
providing the least privileged principle
give access to different functions
different variables different programs
only by providing them the the kind of
access which they need to run
efficiently and do not give them
complete access so with that notion in
mind java created the concept of access
modifiers and it created these three
modifiers which are called public
protected and private if you do not
provide any modifier then it goes to no
modifier or some people also call it as
default modifier which is also a type of
access modifier so let's understand
theoretically first how it works and
then we will try to have a look at an
example
let's understand the first one
first of all these modifiers are
keywords and you can use these keywords
in front of classes in front of
variables and also in front of methods
and you might have already noticed this
particular keyword called public in
front of all the classes i have created
or even when we talked about the public
static void main method we saw this
public as a keyword it is basically an
access modifier and whenever you put
public in front of a class or a variable
or a method that particular component
becomes available to the whole of the
program it will be available to the
whole world basically any subclass or
any package or any other class which
might have been written in your java
program will be able to access that
particular class or variable or method
if you put public in front of that the
second modifier level is protected one
of the other thing which you you will
understand as i explain this is that as
you move down into this particular table
the access level will start getting more
and more restricted by restriction i
mean that less and less components will
be able to get access to those modifiers
so if you write protected in front of a
class or in front of a method or in
front of a variable then everything
within that particular class will still
be able to access it
everything within the package will still
be able to access it i still haven't
covered the concept of package but i
briefly touched upon it showing you how
whenever we write a class we have a
package in front of it and package is
technically is just an aggregation of
the classes if you have to write write
multiple classes and wrap all of those
classes into a single logical bundle
that would be called a package just to
show you an example these all are
packages which you see here you see this
square box here and you see these names
these all are packages and these
packages contain multiple classes and
technically that's all the packages mean
that you can wrap multiple related
classes into a single package so coming
back to the access modifier whenever you
write protected in front of a class or a
variable or a method then that
particular component will be accessible
to everybody within the same class
everybody within the same package
it will also be accessible to everybody
which is a subclass of the class this is
again a new concept which i have not
covered but this basically means a child
of this class now what is a child of the
class we will cover at
that concept in detail when we will talk
about inheritance but for now you can
understand that it is a basically an
extension of the class so
when the moment you declare something is
protected it can easily be accessible
within the same class in which this
protected component was declared it can
be accessed in the package it can also
be accessed in the subclasses of the
class but anything outside the package
will not be able to access it because
you see an n here then we have the
default access modifier or no modifier
if you do not write anything in front of
a class or a method or a variable it
gets the default access modifier
privileges and that privilege mean that
anybody within the same class will be
able to access that default variable or
a default component anybody within the
package will also be able to access it
the sub classes of the class where the
default component was declared those
subclasses will not be able to access it
and anybody outside the package will
obviously not be able to access it
then comes the last one which is the
most restricted privilege which is
called private so if you put private in
front of a class or in front of a method
or in front of a variable
that component will only be accessible
within the class where it was declared
it will not be accessible in the package
it will not be accessible in the
subclasses and definitely not be
accessible to anybody outside the
package
so private is the least privileged or
least access permission level you have
in java
once you write private in front of any
component that only the the classes
other variables the the same class in
which you declare this particular
private variable only that class itself
will be able to access it and nobody
else will be able to access it and as
you move above the accesses become more
and more lenient you can see there's
just one y and three n here the moment
you move a bit above to the default
modifier you get two y's so everybody in
the class and everybody in the package
will be able to access that particular
component rest of for the rest of the
other world it is still unknown when you
write something as protected then
everything in the class everything in
the package and everything in the
subclasses will also be able to access
it rest of the world cannot access it
and if you write something as public
then anybody can access it it's like why
everywhere so that is how the access
levels work now let us understand this
with the help of example
so i will go here and i've just written
a very simple dummy class here which has
uh which is a class called test and i
have a method here which is a display
method so very simple class nothing
fancy here and if you if you notice i
have not put any kind of public private
or uh or protected modifier in front of
the class so this will get the default
privilege if something has default
privilege then the whole world will not
be able to access it so let's go to a
different package let's go to this
package which is here
and let's try to access this particular
test class so we will try to access this
test.java here in the main class
so let's try to do that let's say test t
equal to new test i'm just initializing
the same class so what do i get i get a
compile error let me try to fix it if i
can and i cannot fix it if you see i'm
just trying to use this particular test
class into a different package but that
package is not able to see the class at
all i am getting a compilation error and
if i try to click on the error generally
eclipse provide me suggestions to fix
the to import this particular class but
eclipse is not able to find and find any
class with the name of test which can be
imported in this package which is a
different package than the one of the
test class so we cannot access it
because it's in the default access
now let's go back to the test class and
let's make it public
so i've just made it public here and now
if i click on this again i get the
suggestion if you see this suggestion
was not there earlier now it says import
test and if i click on this double click
it gets imported and everything is happy
so you can see the whole access modifier
in effect here the default walls is
versus public you can also try the other
other kind of uh
access modifiers let's try private as
well i think private will also have the
same effect because it will still not be
accessible from the package or from the
sub classroom or from the uh from the
whole world we already saw this
particular in effect but we will see the
private in a different way now
so going back to the test class i have
made the class as public but the method
here is default i have not exposed this
method to be used outside the class
let's see what happens if i try to call
this display method from the main class
so i have successfully initialized the
class and if i say t
dot
and if i look at the suggestions here
i do not get suggestion of the display
method
why because it is default
if i go back
make it private
can i now access it let's try again nope
still we can't access it eclipse is not
even able to find it inside this package
because it is private
let's go back and make it public
so i've made it just public now going
back to the main class and again saying
t dot now i get the display suggestion
as the first suggested method here and
now i am able to use the display method
once i have made it public so you see
the moment you change the uh the access
modifiers the changes are propagated
immediately and you can see the public
versus default versus private in play
here we can even go into further detail
by using the protected but for protected
i have to explain the concept of
subclasses so i will cover this
protected versus subclasses concept when
i talk about inheritance and there we
will see the usage of protected
variables and the protected access
modifier but we saw the usage of public
the default modifier and the private
modifier do check out the documentation
for these access modifiers and i would
strongly suggest you to play around with
this get more comfortable with this
concept of different kind of modifiers
let's also run an example for for
understanding the default modifier in a
better sense because we can see that for
the package it says why right so let's
go back to eclipse and within the same
package where we created test class
let's create another class let's call it
test
demo
so i will just click finish i get a new
class let me also
write the public static void main method
here so i get the public static void
main method here and let's try to access
the test class here within the same
package so let me again go back to the
default privilege here
so i put the test class access as the
default class or default access and same
goes for display so can other classes in
the same package access the test class
now let's see that if i go to test demo
and here if i try to get the test class
initialize
does it work or does it give me a
compilation error yes it works it works
because the test class and the test demo
are in the same package and test class
has that default access
privilege
so let's try to run one more variation
of it to understand the usage of the
private method better going back to the
test class this display method has the
default privilege right now so going by
that logic if i say t dot i should be
able to get access to the display method
and yes that is possible if i run this
particular program i will be able to get
whatever is given out by the display
method which is hello world
now let's try to make this particular
method as private and let's try to
access this method from one of the other
class in the same package as of the test
class the class is default the method is
private and if you see this class has
already turned red there is a
compilation error because now the
display method is not accessible to the
test demo class even if it was in the
same package it's not accessible because
the display methods privilege or access
modifier has gone to private now exactly
the same as explained here because it
has become private so the package level
members cannot access it there's an n
here so this is this was another
variation to show you how you can use
public protected and private together to
only expose the members methods and
classes which are supposed to be exposed
to the consumer this is a very critical
and very important concept to be used in
java and it is used from a very simple
program to all the highly complex
application this is sort of the bare
bone or the for laying foundation for
any kind of basic security level premise
which you need to build your application
so that's all i want to cover in today's
session where we discussed about the
different access levels
in the next session we are going to talk
about the concept of inheritance let's
get started with inheritance
so inheritance is basically one of the
most important properties of any object
oriented programming language it's
basically a concept and the concept says
that what if you have a scenario where
you want multiple classes to share
similar behavior and similar properties
let's understand this with the help of
an example let's take the example of a
bank
when you go to a bank to open an account
there are multiple types of accounts
there can be a savings account it can be
a type of current account there can also
be a different offering for personal
account and commercial accounts such as
for businesses
then you may also have loan accounts
which are having different kind of
properties so all of these types of
accounts are still
technically accounts and they will share
some similar properties for example all
of them will have to maintain some sort
of an interest rate for example all of
them will be used to either deposit
money or withdraw money so there would
be some kind of similarity across all of
these types of account classes but at
the same time there will also be some
sort of differentiality amongst these
classes the way you will calculate the
interest rate for a current account will
be different from the way you will
calculate the interest rate for a
savings account and the same applies for
commercial account personal account loan
account etc so you see that we have some
common behavior but at the same time we
also have some different behavior so
whenever you have such scenario always
think about applying the concept of
inheritance in your application there is
another simple way to spot whether
inheritance can be used at a particular
place or not inheritance is also called
is a relationship so whenever you read
the requirements from a customer just
try to find the words which use this
particular phrase is a for example
car is a vehicle
savings account is a type of account
similarly you will find many other types
of similar examples so whenever you will
see that is a relationship between two
different kinds of objects or two
different kind of entities that means
that there might be an inheritance
relationship being applied between them
and that's how you will spot the usage
of inheritance
so so far we have understood this
concept that there would be some sort of
relationship between the two classes
what will be this relationship the
relationship will be of parent child
type there will be a parent class some
people also call that as base class and
then there will be a child class so the
child class will be inheriting the
properties and the behaviors from the
base class or from the parent class i
will be using base class and parent
class terms interchangeably during this
session but the basic idea and basic
premise is like that only that there
will be a child class and there will be
a parent class and the child class class
is extending from the parents class
remember the word extend because we are
going to use that and i've just shown
you the uh what you see here is
basically the official definition which
is given by javadocs here you can read
the definition as well and the basic
idea which i told you lies in the parent
and child relationship and this is how
you can conceptualize it that you will
have a base class or a parent class and
then you will you can have multiple
children of it and then those children
can again have their own children and so
on so forth so this hierarchy this whole
inheritance hierarchy can go as deep as
you want it to be and that's the basic
idea and basic conceptualization of how
you understand and how you visualize
inheritance now let's move to eclipse
ide and try to understand this with the
help of an example so for this
particular case i have created a set of
classes basically which we will be using
to demonstrate the relationship of
inheritance and i've taken the simple
example of a bicycle so a bicycle is
again a very generic definition of any
two wheeler and bicycles can have
multiple types there can be an
all-terrain bike there can be a mountain
bike there can be a city bike there can
be a bike which is specific specifically
made for ladies and similarly there can
be multiple different types of bikes but
all of these bikes will have some
similar properties
for example all of them will have two
wheels all of them will have a seat all
of them will have brake all of them will
have some sort of some sort of a
speeding mechanism whether they can
accelerate or deaccelerate so there will
be some commonality but at the same time
a mountain bike's features might be very
different from a city bike feature a
mountain bike features might
feature mountain bike might have gears
for example whereas a city bike might
not have gears because you don't need
that much of a variation in
in inclination and declination when you
drive down the road so i'm trying to
conceptualize the same example here
where i've created a class called
bicycle and this is my base class
i define two properties in the in the
bicycle class which is
gear and speed we will come back to
protected in a while but
let's let's leave that there so i have
two properties which is gear and speed i
have a constructor where i'm
initializing the starting speed and the
starting gear and then
i have three methods here which says set
gear apply brake and speed up when i
apply brake the speed is going to get
reduced so that's why you see minus
equal to unity operator
and when i'm trying to speed up the
speed is going to increase that's why
i'm using the plus equal to unary
operator so when you use the method
speed up the speed is going to be
increased by the value you supply in the
method similarly when you apply the
break the speed is going to get reduced
by the amount you supply in the method
argument and that is my base class
bicycle gear speed and three methods now
let's have a look at the child class
so the way you will define the
inheritance relationship in java is by
using this extends keyword remember i
told you to remember the extends keyword
so what you will do that you will write
your class name as usual and then you
will use extends keyword and then you
will use the parent class name or the
base class name so here i am saying
class mountain bike extends bicycle and
here i am providing an additional
property remember the whole commonality
versus differentiality equation so a
mountain bike might have an extra
property to adjust the seat height so
that's the extra property which mountain
bike is having
and then
since this mountain bike is extending
the bicycle class
this mountain bike class has the
responsibility to initialize the bicycle
class as well
and the way it will fulfill that
responsibility is by taking all the
arguments of bicycle class plus the
mountain bike class in its constructor
and that's why you see three different
properties here you see the start height
property which is the
property of this particular class which
is the seat height and then you see the
start speed and start gear property
which directly are not available in this
class but this class is inheriting those
properties from the base class remember
the keyword inheritance here and then
once you do that how do you initialize
the base class constructor is by calling
the super method this is again a keyword
in java and you will use this super
keyword to refer to the base class
constructor in this way so what you will
do technically is that you will write
super and you will supply the arguments
which is required by the base class
constructor if i go back the base class
constructor requires two arguments start
speed and start gear so i write super
and then i write start speed and start
gear so whatever i got from here in the
constructor of mountain bike i'm
supplying those values as is to super
and java will automatically take care of
invoking this particular constructor the
moment it
uh encounters this kind of statement
another another thing to notice is that
the super keyword or super statement has
to be the first statement inside your
constructor remember that whenever you
are dealing with inheritance and
whenever you have to initialize the
super class constructor or the base
class constructor use the super
constructor invocation as the very first
statement inside your child class
constructor otherwise java will not
compile the program and then you will
initialize the local variable i should
call this as this remember i we
discussed about this in this in the
classes session
okay and then it just has a method of
set height so there's no extra method
which this mountain bike is providing
but this mountain bike will have access
to all the methods which have been
provided here and all the properties
which have been provided here this
mountain bike can access everything from
the bicycle class and that's the whole
idea of inheritance that the child class
can access the properties of the base
class by extending the base class
now let's look at how do we invoke this
particular class so for that i have a
simple class name as inheritance demo
which has a public static void main
method and then i am initializing the
mountain bike class
i'm supplying three values as 20 10 and
so the 20 goes to start height
the 10 here goes to
start speed
and one here goes to gear or the start
gear
and that's how i'm setting the values so
when i call this particular constructor
here the mountain bike constructor is
going to this mountain bike constructor
is going to get called and which in turn
is going to call the base class bicycle
class constructor as well and everything
will be set accordingly and then let's
try to access the gear property remember
gear is not directly available in the
mountain bike class but i'm still able
to do mountain bike dot gear because
child class can access the parent's
class properties
similarly the same thing goes for speed
as well and seat height is the local
property of this particular class
mountain bike so it will anyways be
accessible so i can access all the
properties of the base class and the
child class itself seamlessly without
any differentiation now let's try to
call a method so here i'm calling the
method apply break remember apply break
was defined in the base class not in the
child class it's defined here so i'm
calling the apply break method and i
want to reduce the speed the current
speed by one and then i'm printing the
current speed saying that bike speed
after applying brake is mountain bike
dot speed so let's run this particular
program and observe the outputs
okay
so the the first statement which gets
printed is at line number seven which
says gear is
one because it's coming from here then
the seat height is mountain bike dot
seat height which is 20 which is the
first argument here and then the bike
speed is 10 which is coming as here and
getting printed here and then when i
apply the brake
let's go back to the apply brake method
the logic is that whatever is the
current speed reduce it by the value i
supply in the method
so if i supply 1 10 minus 1 becomes 9
and that becomes the current speed if i
supply 5 here the current speed will be
10 minus 5 equal to 5. let's assert that
particular assumption as well yes we can
see that and similarly you can access
other methods of the base class as well
if i just do control space here and you
can see apply break is accessible set
gear set height speed up all the methods
which are defined in the base class are
accessible in the child class as well
this is the power of inheritance one
more thing which i said i will come back
to is around the usage of protected
access modifier
remember when we discussed about the
access modifiers in the previous session
i said that protected is used when you
are dealing with inheritance that
whenever you define something as
protected it will be available to be
accessible in the child classes of the
base class so if i define this
particular variable as as protected then
this particular property will be
accessible in the child class mountain
bike as well
let's play around this let's make this
as private and see what happens
so if i make this private now when i say
private the scope of this particular
variable is within the class only and
nobody outside the class will be able to
see it
and you can see the effect of it i can
see an error being coming here in my
inheritance demo class because now
mountain bike object cannot access the
gear property because the gear property
is defined in the base class and now it
is private that's why the child class
now mountain bike class cannot access
the property gear
and the moment you make make it back to
protected it will be accessible the
error is gone there's no red line here
so that's how you can you can use the
protected access modifiers it is always
always recommended to use them when you
when you write any kind of inheritance
logic and in inheritance logic as well
intentionally if you want to hide a
particular
property from the child classes just
make it private and that's all i want to
cover in this particular session where
we uh dive deep into the concept of
inheritance we had a look at an example
using the bicycle and mountain bike kind
of construct and you can apply the same
kind of construct on any kind of other
other kind of business requirement
remember that is a relationship so
that's all i want to cover in this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to talk about
another very interesting concept of java
which is about encapsulation let's get
started with encapsulation so again
let's understand what is encapsulation
in general and then we will apply that
concept to java encapsulation if you try
to break that word if i just write it
here in the form of a comment it's n
capsule
just trying to break this word into to
make it more visual so you see you see a
word called capsule here so if you try
to imagine a capsule why do you create
that and what's the concept of a capsule
capsule tries to pack a lot of things
inside a small tube-like shape and the
concept of encapsulation is sort of
inspired from that not exactly not
literally but that's the basic idea of
of this root word which is called
encapsulation so encapsulation basically
means to restrict accessing the
properties of a class to the outside
world if you want to protect the
properties of your class how do you do
that you do that with the help of the
concept called encapsulation so here you
this is a sort of a security feature you
can think of a think of it as a security
feature that you want to protect the
properties of your class
and you will use encapsulation to
protect the properties how you implement
encapsulation let's have a look at that
now so basic idea is to encapsulate the
objects create sort of a capsule around
the object which can provide that
protection layer and you will define
how the outside world is going to access
the properties of the class if needed so
i've created a simple class here and
it's if you if you remember one of the
previous examples when we discussed
about classes i used the same class
which was the student class and i'm just
using the same class for continuity so
i've created a student class here and i
have created three different properties
of this particular class which is name
name of the student age of the student
and address of the student you see
intentionally i have used the keyword
private in front of these three
properties and that is the first thing
which you need to do to implement
encapsulation on your object that you
hide all the properties from the outside
world remember the moment you make
anything is private only the class which
is the student class itself only the
class itself can see these variables or
these properties nothing outside the
student class will be able to access the
name or age or the address directly from
the student class it's not possible
that's the whole idea of making it
private because you don't want the
outside world to access these properties
so you make those properties as private
then you create a constructor the
constructor has to be public so that
anybody can initialize the student
object because you want your object to
be accessible remember so you want the
objects to be accessible but you want
the restriction on the access
of the properties of the object
and these are the properties of the
object
so you have restricted them by making it
private but that doesn't solve the
problem because there will be some
illegitimate consumers of the student
object which should not have access to
the student properties but there will
also be some legitimate consumers of the
student object which should be having
access to the properties of the student
for example the payroll
application will need access to these
particular
properties the examination application
will require access to these particular
properties so how do you do that
you create getters we call them getters
because they start with the keyword
get so you create a getter method for
each of the property you create the
method called as get name and this is
the naming convention with java promotes
that you write get and then you write
the name of the property in camel case
so you write get name and this property
is supposed to return the name property
of this particular object and you here
you say return name so you're returning
the the name which is being stored by
the current student object whenever
somebody calls student object dot get
name and this is the way you have
restricted the access of this particular
object as well so remember you made it
private so that nobody can access it and
then you defined your own way of
providing access to the
name property of this particular class
now if anybody wants to access the name
value of your student object there's
only one and one way to do that which is
via calling get name so you have
provided restrictions and you have also
provided prescriptive guidance on how
you are going to expose the properties
of your class that's the second uh thing
which you need to do to implement
correct form of encapsulation on your
object that that is to provide the
getter methods with the right visibility
you want to make them public so that
anybody can call them but since you are
governing which is what is written
inside the method you have full control
on what kind of exposure you want to
give for this particular property
similarly you create a getter for age
calling getage which returns the age and
then you call get you write get address
and return the address here it is simply
returning it but if you want to do more
stuff here feel free to do that like i
said you govern the control of how do
you want to return the name maybe you
don't want to return the complete name
and you want to just return the initials
then you can split the string trim the
string and return only the initials so
that's the basic idea of getters
now after you have created the object
there might be use cases where somebody
needs to overwrite the values of the
properties like name age or address
whatever student's name was incorrectly
mentioned when they called the
constructor and now they want to
overwrite the name or fix the name so
basically they have to replace the
existing value of the name with a new
name
so in that case you need to provide what
we call as setters and they start with
set that's why we call them setters and
we follow the same kind of logic that
you provide the setters for all the
properties of your class so you had
three properties which were named age
and address and you provided the setters
for all three of them and how do you
provide that you write you again make
them as public because you want the
outside world to access this setter
method to overwrite the values of the
name this method is not going to return
anything so it is going to be void then
you write the name of the method which
starts with set and then the property
name in camel case and then you provide
the new value which is the value which
should be which should be the new value
and this is the value which should
replace the existing value
so whatever new value you want to supply
you supply that as the argument of the
setter methods for set name for set age
or for set address and then you write
this particular line which says set the
current name property of this particular
object
with the name which is coming in from
the argument so this dot name remember
this dot name represents the current
object's property because this
represents the current object so
whatever is the current object property
value of the name is just override that
value with the argument coming in do the
same thing for age and set age method
and do the same thing for set address in
the in the set address method so this is
how you are going to provide the setters
and the getters
so setters and getters can also be
generated in smart id is like eclipse so
you just right click you go to source
and here you will see the option of
generate getters and setters if you
click on this it will give you the list
of the fields which are available to be
had to be having getters and setters
currently it says no fields or all
fields have getters and setters already
yes because they have it let me just
comment this and show this how this work
so for example let me comment all the
getters and setters
so i'm commenting them and if i right
click
source generate getters and setters i
get all the fields available for which
setters and getters can be generated so
you can select them
and leave everything as default hit
generate and it is automatically going
to generate the getter and the setter
you see all the code of the getter and
setter is automatically generated you do
not even need to write it and this is
the power of the smart ideas let me just
revert what i did
so
you created everything as all the
properties as private
and then you define how you want to
replace the values by providing the
setters and you define how you want the
outside world to access your properties
so you have full control of the class
now you you control the visibility you
control how they are going to get
initialized you are you are controlling
how the properties are going to be
overwritten or set and you control how
the properties are going to be returned
so you have complete control of the
class
so you have created a perfect capsule
here a perfect form of encapsulation in
this class and this is how you can
implement encapsulation and that's all
i'm going to cover for this particular
session in the next session we are going
to discuss about abstraction let's get
started with abstraction let's first
understand the definition of abstraction
before we relate this to java
abstraction generally means hiding
something when you want to hide some
details of of a particular object from
the outside world you apply the concept
of abstraction for example when you
drive a particular car you just hit the
accelerator and the car speeds up now
it's not only one action when you hit
the accelerator the whole machinery of
the car and all the components different
parts of the car work together to speed
up they would be engine there would be
propulsion there would be fuel there
would be there might be some if it's an
electric car there would batteries uh
there would be whole different kinds of
pistons and plugs which will make the
car speed up it's not only a single
component it's a lot of different
components under the hood and that's the
concept of abstraction that we only show
the relevant parts to the user and we
hide all the internal details from the
user that's the basic idea of
abstraction so a car manufacturer
abstracts away all the inner technical
details from the driver and just gives
the driver a single pedal to speed up
the car for a user it's a very good
experience because he doesn't need to
know about all the internals of the car
but the car manufacturer can hide all
the details and provide a very simple
interface for the driver to interact
with which is just a gas pedal and
that's the basic idea of abstraction and
we try to apply the same kind of concept
to java in the form of abstraction and
java provides this kind of concept
implementation with the help of a
keyword which is called abstract now
abstract is a keyword which can be used
in front of a class or a method when you
use it in front of a class the whole
class becomes abstract abstract class is
a type of class so the class itself
becomes an abstract class one of the
things to remember is that abstract
class cannot be instantiated but can be
subclassed remember we talked about the
concept of subclass and the parent class
when we talked about inheritance so if
you make a class as abstract class you
cannot call the constructor of the class
because you cannot instantiate it but
you can extend the abstract class and
create a child class class out of it
that's the concept of abstract class
another concept is abstract method you
can also use the abstract keyword in
front of a method and when you use
abstract keyword in front of a method
then that method is only declared
without an implementation you are not
going to provide any implementation of
the method and you are just going to
declare the method something like this
we will see a similar example in the in
the hands-on as well but that's the
basic idea that you just declare the
method you are not providing an
implementation as to what does move to
method actually does because that's the
whole concept of abstraction and it is
the responsibility of the child classes
which inherit the particular class in
which the abstract method would be
sitting so that child class will be
having the responsibility to provide a
concrete implementation of the declared
method let's understand this better with
the help of an example so here i have
created a class called graphic object
and i have made the class as abstract
class this is the keyword which you need
to use in front before the class keyword
and the task becomes an abstract class
now when you create an abstract class it
automatically gets some properties the
first property is that this particular
class must have at least one abstract
method and this is how you define the
abstract methods where you just provide
the declaration but you do not provide
the implementation of the draw method or
the resize method and the way you will
create the abstract methods is by using
the abstract keyword before the actual
method declaration starts so general
method declaration would look like this
and if you use abstract in front of it
this becomes an abstract method
declaration abstract class can also have
concrete methods so that is the liberty
which abstract class gives you that you
can have abstract methods which are just
declared but you can also have normal
methods which are which
where you can also provide the
implementation so you can have normal
methods and abstract methods as well in
an abstract class
so this is the abstract class now if if
you want to provide an implementation of
the draw and resize method you have to
extend this abstract class so we extend
this abstract class by creating two
child classes out of this particular
abstract class which is circle.java
where you can see i create a normal
class and i use the extends keyword for
inheritance and i'm saying that circle
class is inheriting from the graphic
object class which was my abstract class
and once i use this extends keyword then
i have the responsibility of providing
the implementation of the abstract
methods actually java will force me to
provide the implementation of these two
methods if i do not provide all the
declared methods so there are two
declared methods here so if the circuit
class does not provide that the
implementation for both draw and resize
methods then java will throw an error
and it will ask you to take an action
which can be either define all the
methods meaning provide implementation
for all the methods or make the circle
class itself as abstract let's see if i
just comment this particular out i get
an error you see a red line here and if
you click on this particular balloon
here it will say either you can add the
unimplemented methods or you can make
the circle type as abstract so these are
the two options which you will get to
fix this particular error so an abstract
class can be extended by another
abstract class if the child abstract
class is not implementing all the
methods of the parent if you want to
implement all the methods then just
implement them and keep keep it as a
normal class and that's what i've done
here i've just created a normal class
here and provided the implementation and
once you provide the implementation of
both of the methods the error is gone
similarly i have also provided another
child class because it's
there can be
there can be multiple children of a
particular parent so rectangle also
extends from the graphic object and it
also provides its own implementation of
drawing and resize because generally the
way you will draw a rectangle and you
resize a rectangle will be different
than drawing or resizing a circle here
i'm not doing anything in the methods
because this is just to show you the
demonstration i'm just printing a cis
out saying drawing a circle and resizing
or drawing a rectangle and resizing a
rectangle and in the circle class
drawing a circle and resizing a circle
so one abstract class is the parent
class which is the graphic object and
two children circle and rectangle both
providing the implementation of the
abstract methods which were declared in
the base class now let's go to the main
class where i've defined defined the
public static void main method and here
you see i have created two different
kind of blocks of code here one block is
where i'm saying graphic object creating
a reference of the graphic object named
as circle and initializing the circle
object now you see a difference here
here is the abstract class and here is
the concrete class so whatever you
define on the right hand side whatever
is the type of object will be the type
of methods being caught so if you
created a circle object and then if you
call the draw method and resize method
these methods will be called from the
circle class if you initialized it as
new rectangle then you are creating a
rectangle class object and then the draw
and the resize method will be called
from the rectangle class that's the
basic construct and that's how you will
initialize a particular class which is
using an abstract class so i i call a
graphic object circle new circle and i
call circle.draw and circle dot resize
similarly graphic object rectangle equal
to new rectangle and rectangle.draw
rectangle dot resize let's run this
program and observe the output so when i
call this particular block of code
circle object gets initialized and then
circle.draw method prints drawing a
circle and circle.resize method prints
drawing resizing a circle similarly when
i create the rectangle class object
referencing it with the graphic object
class rectangle.draw prints
this particular line drawing a rectangle
and rectangle.resize prints this
particular line which is resizing a
rectangle and this is how you will use
the concept of abstraction this another
very interesting thing which which is
which is going on here remember i told
if i do this and i i create i just put a
system out here
base
abstract plus so if i do this here if i
create if i still write a constructor
though java says that it cannot be
instantiated if i still write a
constructor of it and i do not do any
changes here and if i run this
particular program let's see what
happens you'll see the base abstract
class being called here let me just
reformat it by putting ln here so that
we get a better output so if i run this
particular program you see base abstract
class is getting printed somehow though
we said that abstract classes cannot be
instantiated but still the constructor
of this is still getting called somehow
when i create a circle class the base
class constructor gets called and when i
cl create a rectangle class again the
base class constructor gets called this
is this is the power of inheritance
because in inheritance remember how it
works when you call when you initialize
a particular child object referencing it
with the parent object see the
references of the parent class and the
object is of the child class so whenever
you do it like this
first the default constructor because
i'm calling the default constructor here
the default constructor of the circle
class will get called which will go here
remember i told you that java provides
the default constructor automatically if
you don't provide it so the default
constructor of circle gets called but
java sees that you are writing this code
here which says circle extends graphic
object so java is automatically going to
call the parent class and going to
initialize the parent class as well
because that's how it will be able to
see these methods and so so that's why
it will automatically call the base
class constructor even if you don't call
it explicitly in fact you cannot call it
explicitly java will not allow you to
initialize the graphic object class
explicitly it can only and only be
called by java itself indirectly via the
concept of inheritance if you try to do
this let's try to do this for fun and
and also for better understanding so if
i write graphic object go equal to
new graphic object you see i don't even
get an option but let's write it and
let's see what happens so you see that
this particular it gives basically an
error because it's not able to find the
constructor of the graphic object class
though even i have defined the default
constructor here but still java is not
able to find it because this class is
abstract so hence proved abstract
classes cannot be instantiated
explicitly they can only be instantiated
by the child classes through the
internal mechanisms of java itself and
that's all i want to talk about in this
particular session where we looked in
detail about the concept of abstraction
couple of more things which i did not
cover in the previous session i just
want to call them out for clarity java
does not support multiple inheritance
when i say multiple inheritance what it
means that you will not have a scenario
where a child will be extending from two
base classes java does not support it it
does support it with the with the help
of interfaces but i will talk about
interfaces in the coming sessions but
here
just understand this that you cannot use
multiple inheritance with classes in
java a child cannot have two parent or
two base classes in java java will not
allow that it is also called the diamond
problem because the child class does not
know whether to follow the route of base
1 plus or the base 2 class if it is
extending from 2 different base 1 and
base 2 classes so a class can only
extend from one class in java we can
find a workaround of it by using the
concept of interfaces but that's
something which will be coming later
another thing to understand is that when
you create an abstract class here these
variables you can declare declare these
variables as well and these variables
will be accessible by all the child
classes as you access them so that's all
for this particular session and in the
next session we are going to talk about
interfaces let's get started with
interfaces in java now again let's
understand what do we mean by an
interface in general and then we will
see how do we apply the concept of
interfaces in java so imagine let's
let's take the same example of vehicle
industry because that's something which
we see every day around ourselves and we
can relate to it so imagine if all the
car manufacturers were creating a
different way of driving a car what if
in one car you have a steering but in
other car you do not have a steering but
you have something else which is which
may be called something else in one car
you have the gas pedal to speed up in
other car you have a button to speed up
similarly in in one car you may have
different kind of doors and in other
cards you may have different kind of
doors which are completely different
looking it's not even a single simple
handle to open it so you see the problem
here the problem here is that all the
car manufacturers are not working on a
single contract they are not respecting
a single interface which will create a
poor user experience because the users
whenever the users have to buy a new car
or they have to switch from one
manufacturer to other manufacturer they
are completely clueless as to how to
drive that particular class because the
interface they were using in the
previous car is completely different
from the interface they are being shown
in the other car and that's that's the
basic need for the concept of interface
think of it as a contract agreement you
see it is also mentioned here that
if you apply the same kind of concept to
programming world imagine if every
programmer was writing their own logic
in their own way without following a
single contract or a single guideline
soon it is going to create a problem and
that's the kind of problem uh interfaces
try to solve so interface is again a
keyword in java and the basic idea or
the basic construct is that the
interfaces are going to define the
specifications of how a class would act
let me repeat this in a more generic way
interfaces are going to define the
contract or the specification which is
going to govern how an application or
code or programming logic will behave
that's the basic idea of interfaces
so interfaces are their own type and the
basic property of interface is that it
can only contain constants method
declarations similar to abstract classes
and some default methods or static
methods or nested types what is nested
type we will cover that later default
methods will touch upon a bit here and
the static methods as well but the basic
idea is that when you create when you
create an interface in java you cannot
write anything concrete in terms of the
behavior of the interface when i say
behavior always think of that as method
so you cannot define a concrete method
in an interface you can only declare
methods you can also declare constants
you can create a particular type of
concrete method by using the default
keyword but use it in very special
circumstances you can also create static
methods as well which are only going to
belong to the interface and nobody else
now let's look at an example
and and also before we go to the example
let me also phrase this here that if an
interface cannot define a concrete
implementation of the methods then
naturally the interface is going to be
extended by a child class a concrete
class which is going to provide the
implementation of the methods declared
in the interface it does sound like
abstract classes but there is a
difference let's understand the
difference with the help of an example
this is how an interface will look like
i've used the same construct of bicycle
and mountain bike just to maintain some
continuity and less context switching
but this is how an interface would look
like you will not use the class keyword
but instead instead of that you will use
the interface keyword you can only
declare methods you cannot define
methods remember when we looked at the
abstract classes example we were able to
define concrete methods as well but in
interface that's a strict no no you
cannot define concrete methods let me
show you the abstract class in the case
of abstraction which we used this was
the abstract class and it did have a
concrete method right but bicycle.java
here which is because it's an interface
it is not going to allow you to create a
concrete method another thing is that if
you try to declare a variable inside the
class they will have to be constant you
cannot just declare them without any
value for example i cannot do this
if i do this it is going to give an
error you see an error here and it says
initialize field x at declaration
something like this public static final
so interface is going to force you to
declare all the variables as public
static final with some value if you try
to use them inside interface
so that is also something which
interface will mandate so you see
interfaces are more strict they are more
strict in terms of what you can do you
can only declare public static final
variables and you can only declare
methods you cannot define methods so
abstract class is less restrictive
interface is more restrictive and that
is the differentiation which you have to
keep in mind whether to use abstract
classes or whether to use interfaces
that is also a very common confusing
question in the interviews as well and
remember that interfaces are only for
contracts or specifications where in
case of abstract class you can write a
concrete behavior as well in terms of a
concrete method in the base class
interfaces there is no concrete
implementation in the base class
abstract classes yes there can be a
concrete implementation in the base
class that's the basic difference moving
on i have created a child class here
which is again mountain bike and it has
three properties seat height gear and
speed similar to the previous example it
has a constructor and remember in again
interfaces cannot be uh initialized
directly so you do not even need to call
a super method here because there is
nothing to initialize you initialize a
class to create a state state is denoted
by the properties but interfaces will
force you to write a public static final
property and initialize its value
automatically so you do not need a
constructor for the interface because
there is nothing to initialize
everything has been initialized in terms
of the variables and the methods are
anywhere just declared that's why you
don't need to call super here after that
the moment you write this particular
keyword here implements and that is how
you will basically extend from the from
the interface you will use the
implements
bicycle keyword here implements is the
keyword and bicycle is the name of the
interface if you write this here then
java is going to force you to provide
the implementation of these two methods
if i
if i do this implements bicycle and if i
comment out these two methods which is
coming from the base class it is going
to give an error and if i read out this
error it says either you add the
unimplemented methods or you make the
mountain bike class as abstract there
are two ways to fix this particular
class similar to abstract classes it
will force you to write the
implementation of the base class
declared methods another thing which
java will will suggest you and will also
force you via some ides as well is that
you use this particular annotation we
use this particular annotation to tell
java that we are overriding this method
from the base class since apply break
and speed up methods were defined here
in the base class and this child class
is supposed to provide the
implementation of the methods by
overriding them overriding is again a
concept which we will talk about in
detail in the coming sessions but for
now remember that you need to write this
annotation here on the methods which
have been taken from the base class to
provide an implementation and the
implementation is similar to what we
have seen before so whatever value you
supply in the apply break the speed is
going to get decremented by that
particular value and in case of speed up
whatever value you supply in the
argument that value is going to be added
to the current speed and the speed is
going to go up
let's look at the main class here which
is called interface demo it has a public
static void main method and here i'm
again initializing the child class
nothing's nothing strange here and then
i'm using the getter method here because
i have made everything as private here
and rest of the things are just here as
is i have the getters and setters here
for all the properties and i'm using
those here so i'm using the getters to
just get the value of gear seat height
and speed and then i'm applying the
brake and then i'm printing the current
speed after applying the brakes let me
just
expand this a bit more and then i'm
using the speed up method trying to
increase the current speed of the bike
by 10 and then printing the new speed
again so using the apply break and speed
up methods which are concretely defined
in the child class by using this
override annotation and these were the
methods which were declared in the
interface in the base interface and
that's all it which is happening in this
particular class let's run this
particular program
and these are the values i get i get the
gear as one which is coming from here i
get the seat height as 20 which is
coming from here i get the current bike
speed as 10 this was the value which it
was initialized with then i'm applying
the brake and after applying the brake
the speed of the bike gets reduced and
it becomes 10 minus 1 which becomes
9 and that's what gets printed here and
then i'm speeding up the bike by 10 so
the current value of the current value
of the speed of the bike is
9 and if i incremented it by 10 it
becomes 19 and that's what gets printed
here
and that's all i want to cover in this
particular session where we had a look
at an example of how we can use
interfaces in java and how we can use
interfaces with the concept of
inheritance and in the next session we
are going to have a look at the concept
of multiple inheritance using interfaces
let's get started with multiple
inheritance in java using interfaces if
you remember in the previous sessions i
said that multiple inheritance is not
possible in java and it is not possible
because of the diamond problem or simply
put of one child cannot have two parent
classes that's what java says and let's
understand why this is a problem so i
have created a very simplistic diagram
to to demonstrate the problem of
multiple inheritance and then we will
see how we can solve that so let's say
you have a class c a normal class
then you created two parents of class c
so basically class c is extending class
a and you also want the class c to
extend class b first of all it is not
possible in java and why it is not
possible is because of there can be a
super class which is
extending class a and class b as well so
you started with class c you wanted to
have you wanted class c to have two
parents which is a and b but a and b
also had a common parent which is super
class so now as you know that the child
classes can see the properties of the
base classes as well then if class c
wants to access something from super
class which route should it take should
it take this route or should it take
this route that is the problem which we
called as the diamond problem and that
is the reason why java prohibits using
multiple inheritance using classes so
that's the problem statement
that we don't have a clear route to
reach to the super class from class c
and we try to solve it using interfaces
so let's jump right into the eclipse ide
to understand how we can solve it so
here i have prepared an example for this
particular problem and the solution of
it so
again i'm using the same bicycle and
mountain bike example for the sake of
continuity i have created an interface
of bicycle which has two declarations
which is for applying break and speed up
this is my simple interface and then i
have a mountain bike class which is
implementing the bicycle interface and
providing the implementation of apply
brake and speed up this is something
which we have already seen in the
previous example so nothing new here and
then you have other getters and setters
and you have a main class where you can
initialize the mountain bike and get the
gear get the seat height get the speed
we have covered all of this there is
nothing new here but now let's say you
have a requirement that you have another
interface
which is called vehicle and your
mountain bike should extend or implement
this interface as well is that possible
let's try that remember mountain bike
was already implementing bicycle
interface what if you want to have two
parents of this mountain bike using
interfaces like i said previously that
interfaces does solve the problem of
multiple inheritance so let's see if it
does solve that problem so i can just
say vehicle here and see if the code
compiles the code doesn't compile here
and the reason is pretty expected it's
because vehicle has a declared method
which is called can drive and mountain
bike now needs to provide the
implementation of that particular method
so if you click on this balloon and hit
on add unimplemented methods just double
click on that and you will get an empty
method definition of that can drive
method and let's put asis out for
simplicity and say
mountain bike
can
be
driven so this is how you can see this
this code is working fine and now this
particular child class has two parents
it has a bicycle parent and it also has
a vehicle parent so if bicycle and
vehicle would have been concrete classes
then this would have caused an error let
me quickly show you that if i can so let
me go to bicycle and i just change this
to class and i
put an empty definition for both of the
methods and then let's go to the vehicle
class and convert interface and convert
that into class as well and again
provide an empty implementation so i've
just converted the vehicle interface and
the bicycle interface into classes and
now if i go back to the mountain bike
and if i change this to extends
i get whole lot of errors
if i go here
it says multiple markers and it doesn't
give you the right error but the right
error is happening because you cannot
extend from two concrete classes now
bicycle and vehicle are both classes and
mountain bike cannot do that because
java does not support multiple
inheritance from classes but if you go
back to the previous state if i just
quickly do ctrl z here
and control z here in case of vehicle as
well
converting both of them back to
interfaces and putting the implements
back here everything goes fine so using
interfaces you can implement multiple
inheritance but using classes you cannot
do that let's cover one more interesting
scenario what if you have a need to
extend from let's say one interface and
one more class is that possible because
we saw the comp we saw the combination
of two classes that was not possible we
are seeing the combination of two
interfaces
which is possible now is it possible to
extend from a base class and implement
an interface let's see what happens if
you try to do that and i have another
class this is not an interface but this
is a class called two wheeler so
technically speaking mountain bike is a
two wheeler and at the same time
mountain bike is also a vehicle and
mountain bike is also a bicycle so what
if you have a requirement that your
mountain bike should also extend from
two wheeler class can you do that let's
see if i can do that i will just write
extends
two wheeler and let's see if that works
it doesn't work here
but let's put it here if i put it here
does it work now yes it works there's no
compilation error here which means java
does accept this particular construct so
what happened here first thing when i
put this extends together after
implements java did not allow which
means that the extends keyword has to
come right after the child class it
cannot come after the implements clause
it has to come right after the child
class that's first thing second thing is
a normal class a normal child class
can extend from one concrete class
and can also implement any number of
interfaces you see i have two interfaces
so now technically this mountain bike
has three parents it has a concrete
class two wheeler as the parent it has
bicycle interface as the parent and it
also has vehicle interface as the parent
so three parents so this con this
basically uh justifies the philosophy or
justifies the concept that a class can
extend from only and only one base class
but can implement any number of
interfaces you can have more interfaces
here as many as you want so
number of interfaces is not a
restriction but number of concrete
classes is a restriction a child class
will have only one concrete base class
but can have any number of interfaces
being implemented from this particular
class that's the basic property and then
the main in the main method
you can access any of the vehicle or two
wheeler or bicycle interfaces methods
and the classes methods as well if you
want to so for example if i want to
just type this and if i just do dot here
i can see i can access can drive as well
now can drive was implemented in the
vehicle interface or declared in the
vehicle interface similarly if i look
for the two wheeler method can i see the
two wheeler method as well let's see if
i can yes and this you can see this is
the two wheeler class method which says
can rotate two wheels so i can call this
particular method which is coming from
the two wheeler class i can call the
vehicle class declared method which was
can drive so this is also possible and
this is possible because mountain bike
is implementing the interface of vehicle
so let's run this particular program and
understand the output
so at first i initialize the mountain
bike class and i print the gear the seat
height and the bike speed values we have
already seen this
then i apply the brake and i speed up so
after applying the brake the speed
becomes 10 minus 1 9 and after speeding
up the new speed becomes 9 plus 10 as
19. then i call mountain bike dot can
rotate two wheelers two wheels which is
going to invoke the method which is
defined in the two wheeler class which
is printing a simple sissom so i get the
same sysout here this method is being
invoked from the mountain bike object
due to the concept of inheritance
similarly when i say mountain bike dot
can drive the scan drive was declared in
the interface vehicle and then when
mountain bike implemented this interface
java forced it to provide a a definition
of this particular method and this is
the definition which is again assist out
and you can see that cis out being
printed here so this is how you can
implement multiple inheritance in java
using the power of interfaces and you
can also combine the classes and the
interfaces the condition is that only
one class should be the parent class and
then you can have any number of
interfaces as the parent entity if you
want to and that's all i want to cover
in this particular session in the next
session we are going to discuss about
method overloading concepts in java
let's get started with polymorphism so
polymorphism is a very generic concept
which means that a particular object can
take multiple form let's not even call
it as object let's make it more generic
a particular entity can take multiple
forms if any entity in java exhibits
that kind of behavior then we say that
polymorphism is in action that entity
can be a class or an object or even a
method and in today's session we are
going to talk about that type of
polymorphism which is exhibited by
methods so we will see how a particular
method in java can take many different
forms containing different logics but
still having the same name
and that concept is called method
overloading so whenever you hear the
word that you need to overload a
particular method or this is method
overloading happening technically or
conceptually it's basically polymorphism
in action and polymorphism is being
applied on a method here and that
phenomena we call as method overloading
so in today's session we are going to
have a look at how we can implement
method overloading in java so the basic
idea of method overloading is that the
name of the method should remain the
same so you see in this particular class
which i have created to demonstrate the
method overloading so this is the class
name and the method name which i am
going to overload is called multiply and
that is probably the first thing which
you need to remember to implement over
method overloading correctly that the
method name is going to remain the same
the type of the return of the method may
change here you see it's returning in
here in the first instance in the second
instance also it is returning int but in
the third instance it is returning
double so the return type of an
overloaded method can change another
another thing which which can be varied
between same method being defined again
and again is that the number of
arguments and the type of arguments the
first multiply method takes two
arguments of integer type the second
multiply method takes three arguments of
integer type and the third multiply
method takes two arguments of double
type so by using method overloading you
can vary the number of arguments and
also the type of arguments so the basic
idea is that you declare you define the
method using the same name but you do a
variation in the arguments or the return
types and that's how you technically
implement method overloading in this
case in this particular case the
multiply is the method being overloaded
and in the first case it is accepting
two integer arguments and returning the
result of multiplication of those
arguments in the second case the same
method name multiply here the same
visibility public and the same return
type but this time three different types
of integer values can be accepted and
this method multiply method is going to
return the multiplication of three
integer numbers in the third case at
line 15 i again use the same multiply
name the method name but this time the
return type becomes double and this
method accepts two double arguments and
returns the result of the multiplication
of these double values so the method
name is same but the arguments vary and
also the return type may also vary
that's the basic premise of how you
implement method overloading so whenever
you want to implement it keep the method
name same vary the
arguments and the return types and after
that i'm just created a public static
void main method here i have initialized
the class here this particular class
itself method overloading demo and then
i am calling the multiply method on the
object and based on the number of
arguments i supply the corresponding
method will get invoked that is
something with java will take care
automatically that whatever type and the
number of arguments you supply in the
call in the invocation based on the
number and the type of the arguments
java will try to find a matching method
in the overloaded methods if it is able
to find a method it's going to get
invoked if it is not able to find the
method you will get an error in fact you
will get a compile error itself while
you invoke a method which for which the
definition is not available for example
if i try to just copy this
and make an invalid invalid method
invocation let's provide four arguments
and if i do that here itself i will get
the error because java is not able to
find a multiply method in this
particular class which is accepting four
integer arguments so you will get the
compilation error itself before you can
even run the program but the basic idea
is that you use overloading with
multiple different types and the number
of variables so i'm calling multiply
three times let's run this particular
program and observe the output
so let me just bring this output down
yep so first i call demo.multiply and
pass two integer values 10 and 20. when
this happens this particular method gets
invoked and it results it returns a
result of 10 into 20 which is 200. in
the second invocation i'm calling again
the multiply method but this time with
three arguments three integer arguments
specifically and this call is going to
match this particular method signature
and it is going to execute whatever is
written inside this particular method
which is the multiplication of the three
arguments being supplied so 10 into 20
into 30 which is 6000 the third case
let's go back here at line 25 the third
case of invocation of the multiply
method is accepting two decimal based
arguments 10.5 and 20.5 so java is going
to look at the class and trying to find
a method which can accept decibel values
and there it is this is the method
signature which is going to match the
invocation java is going to do this
matching automatically for you and here
whatever logic you have written inside
this particular method we will get
executed so 10.5 into 20.5 returns
215.25
and that's the output you get so this is
how you can use method overloading in
java this is a rather fairly simple
example but you can make it as complex
as you want but a word of caution do not
use it too extensively in fact lot of
expert programmers do not recommend
using method overloading because it
becomes very confusing use it only when
you do not have any other way out use it
only where this is the only way to write
correct form of methods with the right
readability otherwise generally there
would be other ways to avoid method
overloading by writing concrete purpose
friendly method names themself maybe you
don't need to use the multiply name
again again we can call it as multiply
two numbers multiply three numbers
multiply doubles so that the method name
itself is more explicit and
understandable rather than juggling
around different signatures of the same
method especially it becomes more
confusing if you are creating an
interface which is to be consumed by a
third party developers or third party
application so try to use it with
caution that's what i'm trying to stress
here and that's all i want to cover in
this particular session and in the next
session we are going to talk about
method overriding let's get started with
method overriding in java so in the
previous session we discussed about
method overloading concept now in this
session we'll focus on another
interesting concept by which you can
have the same signature of the method
again and again be used in your code but
in a different way and this concept is
called method overriding method
overriding basically
is used together with the concept of
inheritance you won't you will not be
able to use the concept of method
overriding without using the concept of
inheritance remember when we talked
about inheritance i spoke about the
subclass and the parent class concept
sometimes we also call the parent class
as super class so the basic idea is that
if a super class defines a method
remember i'm using the word define here
if the super class uses the
defines a particular method and then the
subclass again tries to define the
method with the exact same signature
this phenomena is called method
overriding now when you do method method
overriding there are some rules to
follow and i'm showing you a tabular
structure here a table basically which
will show you what is possible and what
is not possible when it comes to method
overriding so let's try to understand
this table so if you try to define a
method with the same signature as a
superclass method the rules follow as
per this table let's go with the first
one if you have an instance method
defined in the superclass instance
method is the normal method which you
define in your in your classes so if you
have defined an instance method in your
super class
and if you define a method in the
subclass with the exact same signature
then that concept is called method
overriding and it will be a successful
override override also let me also
explain what override means here
override means that once you try to
initialize the subclass object you will
be able to invoke its own overridden
method definition if you call that
particular method the subclasses own
instance method is going to get invoked
rather than the super classes instance
method we'll look at that when we look
at the example as well but that's the
normal scenario when where your
superclass defines an instance method
and subclass also defines the an
instance method with the exact same
method signature that concept is called
method overriding what if your
superclass defines a static method
static method is is basically a method
which belongs to the class but not to
the object instance method is called
instance method a normal method is
called instance method because it
belongs to the object you can call the
method on the object but static methods
are called by class so you say class
name dot static method name but when you
when you call instance methods you just
call object name dot instance method
name so that is the basic difference the
static methods belong to the class once
you have defined our static method the
same static method will be available to
all the objects of the class but
instance method are unique to each
object so that was a short tour of what
static methods mean so if you define a
static method in the super class and
then if you try to define an instance
method with the same signature in the
subclass you will get a compilation
error it will not be allowed it's not
allowed in java to override a static
method from super class that's what it
says next one if your super class has an
normal instance method and then the
subclass tries to use the same signature
but creates a static method out of it
then again you will get a compilation
error so that the overriding of an
instance method to a static method is
not allowed and the last concept is
again a very interesting concept and a
very popular interview question about
method hiding so if the super class
defines a static method and the sub
class also defines the static method
with the exact same signature then the
superclass static method gets hidden it
basically hides the superclass method so
that's the basic idea behind over method
overriding so if you see technically
it's a form of polymorphism because the
same method is having multiple
definitions but when we looked at the
previous example the multiple
definitions were in the same class here
the multiple definitions are in
different classes and those classes are
having a parent-child relationship that
was about the theory of it let's go to
an example of it to understand it better
and i've used again the same construct
of bicycle and mountain bike which we
have been using in this in this series
just to maintain continuity so i have a
parent class called bicycle here which
has two
properties gear and speed it has a
constructor nothing unusual there and
then it has defined three methods
set gear apply break and speed up set
gear is just setting the new value as
the gear value apply break is going to
decrement the speed by the value you
supply and speed up is going to
increment the speed by the value you
supply simple this is exactly what we
have seen before now mountain bike tries
to extend bicycle so mountain bike
becomes a child class it defines a
variable called seat height defines a
constructor called super here nothing
unusual so far also defines a setter for
height center for the seat height not
exactly following the setter construct
but this is just to set the height but
here things just get interesting let me
just bring this down a bit yeah so here
it is overriding all the three methods
of the base class and by overriding it
is providing its own implementation of
the same methods let's compare them here
when it overrides the gear and whatever
value you supply it adds 2 to the plus 2
to that value and then sets that value
as the gear value but in case of base
class it was just setting the new value
as the gear value so for its for
instance if you supplied 1 here the gear
value becomes one but here if you
supplied one the gear value becomes
three similarly when you apply brake on
the mountain bike class whatever value
you supply will be subtracted from the
current speed and 10 would be subtracted
even more so if the speed is let's say
50 and your decrement you supply the
decrement value as 10 so it will be 50
minus 10 minus 10 equal to 30. but in
case of bicycle if the speed was 50 and
you supply 10 then it would be just 50
minus 10 40. so there is
and there is extra 10 being subtracted
from the speed when you apply brake in
case of a mountain bike similarly for
speed up its increment of 10 in addition
to what's what value you supply so again
if the speed was 10 and you supplied 10
here in the argument so 10 plus 10 plus
10 30 will become the new speed in case
of mountain bike but in case of bicycle
if you supply 10 and if the current
speed was also 10 then it becomes 10
plus 10 only 20. so that's the
difference so the basic idea i hope you
get the basic idea here is that you
override the methods and your own class
provide its own implementation of those
methods that's the basic premise of
method overriding all good so far and
you do not have a an
obligation to override all of the
methods because here we have the
concrete implementation of the methods
so here in case of mountain bike you can
skip overriding one of the methods if
you like to this is also fine there will
be no compilation error because speed up
has a concrete implementation in the
bicycle class as well so it's up to you
how much you want to override
so let's move to the main class now so
in the main class we have created the
public static void main method here and
let's look at what is happening inside
the class first we initialize the
bicycle class so bicycle class reference
and bicycle class object nothing unusual
here we supply the gear value and the
speed value then we print the gear and
the speed value we apply brake on the
bicycle and then we observe the new
speed of the bicycle after applying the
brakes let me comment out the rest of
the code and let's observe the output
for only this part of the code which we
just walked through for this section so
if i run this as a java application and
if i show you what i'm getting what i'm
getting here so bicycle gear is one
which is what you supplied in the
constructor bicycle speed is 10 which is
again what you supplied in the
constructor then you applied brake and
when you apply brake this logic gets
executed and you supplied 1 here so
current speed was 10 so 10 minus 1
becomes 9 and the new speed becomes 9
which is what you are printing here so
far so good let's move on to the next
section let me comment out the previous
section now and let me uncomment this
section so here i have a bicycle
reference but the object is of mountain
bike remember this concept this is this
is called dynamic object binding concept
or dynamic binding concept again this
might be asked in your interviews so
here i am initializing the mountain bike
with a reference of bicycle remember
whatever is written on the right hand
side will govern the variables and the
methods usage we'll we'll we'll see how
that works out what i just said so i'm
supplying three values here 50 50 and 3
in the mountain bike uh if i go here in
the mountain bike constructor so the
start height start speed and gear are
the three values which is supplied as 50
50 and three then i am accessing the
gear and the speed now remember gear and
speed are declared in the bicycle class
but they are accessible in the child
class due to the inheritance phenomena
which we have already covered so if i
print only this part i should get the
expected values
mountain bike gear is 3 which which is
what i have supplied here and mountain
bike speed is 50 which is which is what
i have supplied here then i apply the
breaks now let's move on to this section
i apply the break supply the value as
one and then i want to see what would be
the new speed after applying the breaks
so let's see what happens when we run
this particular code so if i run this
code after applying the brakes the speed
becomes 39 before applying the brakes
the speed was 50. so what happened here
is 50 minus 1 basically this this logic
is getting executed here 50 minus 1
minus 10 which becomes 39 that's why you
get the value as 39 as the new speed
similarly if you want to call another
method as speed up speed up method was
also defined here where i'm saying speed
plus the argument supplied plus 10 so
the current speed is 39 right now then
i'm speeding it up by 10 so
by this logic 39 plus 10 plus 10 which
will become 59 and then i'm printing the
new speed after speeding up so let's see
what happens so if i go to run as java
application and if i observe all the
outputs the speed was 50 initially after
applying the brakes the speed became 39
and after speeding up the speed became
59 so this was a quick demo to show you
the power of method overriding and how
you can override the behavior which is
defined in the base class so this is all
i want to cover in this particular
session let's get started with the
static keyword in java now let's first
understand the need of the static
keyword and then we'll talk about how
java implements the static keyword
imagine a scenario let's take the
example of a class which we have been
using in our in our different uh
tutorials in this particular series
which is about the student class so if
you are building a college management
system you have a student class there
and if you have an entry a property in
the student class which is storing the
name of the college then the name of the
college is going to be the same for all
of the students of that particular
college it's not going to change another
example let's say you are building a
employee management system for our
organization and you want to maintain
the employee numbers for the first
object the employee number should be one
for the second object the employee
number should be two for the third
object the employee number should be
three so on so forth so when you
initialize all the employee objects the
last employee object has the final total
employee count and you can also treat
this employee count as let's say the
employee number as the employee id so
starting from the first employee to the
last employee the employee number is the
employee id which is a way to uniquely
identify an employee so we talked about
two different cases in the first case we
had a particular value which was same
for all of the objects which was the
student and the college relationship and
then in the second example which i
quoted where all the employees objects
have to share
a particular property amongst them
because if the second object did not
know the previous value of the employee
number it will not be able to get to the
new number it needs to know what was the
previous value so that it can do plus
one so each of the object needs to know
the state of the previous object two
different cases two different scenarios
one single solution which is static
keyword so the static keywords are used
for those members which belong to the
class now apply this definition to the
examples which i gave you if i make a
member of the student class let's say
the college is the property of the
student class and if i make that
property as static now that static on
that member that static member becomes
the property of the class and not the
property of the object it means it
belongs to the class it also means that
all of the objects will get the same
copy of this static member variable and
that's that's one of the first usage and
you can you can make any property or any
member of the class as static by just
putting the static keyword in front of
it we also call the static member
variables as class variables like i just
described so use it for the cases where
the value across the different objects
doesn't change you can make those class
variables in those variables as class
variables or static variables similarly
also try to identify the cases where a
particular value has to be shared in
terms of knowing the previous state in
those cases as well you can use a
particular member in that particular
class and make that static for example
in this case we have a bicycle class and
we have a static variable which says
number of bicycles so every time you
initialize the bicycle object this
number will be shared and you can see i
mean this is here it is incrementing the
number of bicycles so every time you
create the object the id becomes plus
one to the previous count of the number
of bicycles exactly same example as they
gave you for the employee number so
every time you create an object you do a
plus one to the previous value next
object will take the previous value plus
one and so on so forth so you can use
the static uh keyword in front of a
property of the class and make it a
class level variable which will be tied
to the class and not tied to the objects
we can also make the methods as static
as well and the same kind of rule will
apply on the methods as well that the
methods will become will belong to the
class instead of belonging to the
objects let's say you have again a
common functionality which you want to
share amongst objects just make that
common functionality as a static method
and that would be shared amongst the
objects for example you want to get the
total number of bicycles for the
previous example which i just shared in
this particular dock here so you can
just create that method static and any
object which will call this method will
get the latest count of the number of
bicycles you can also make these uh
these static variables as constants by
putting the final modifier in front of
it so if a variable in a particular
class is static and final both then
technically becomes a constant so these
are some of the interesting
use cases and
constraints of the static methods and
static variables there's also a thing
called static block which is just a code
block which you can write inside your
class and we will have a look at that
example as well so let's shift to the
ide and let's have a look at how we can
use this static keyword so i have used
again the same class which i have been
using using in other examples which is
student.java and you can see i have this
same class you have you would have seen
these properties earlier as well and the
code below is exactly the same just
setters and getters and constructors and
it has an additional property which is
college and the college name xyz is the
same for all the students so i have just
hard coded it but you see what is
happening here is that every time you
create a student object this variable
gets initialized even though the
variable for all the objects has the
same value still it gets initialized
again and again and again so technically
it's a waste of memory you're just
wasting memory of an offer new
allocation every time even though the
value is same what if we create this
object once and this member variable
once and just use it across objects you
can do that by just writing static in
front of it if you do that then you see
this becomes sort of italic here and
that's java's convention to show that
this particular variable is a static
variable you can also see the static
keyword in front of it and then whatever
value you have specified this will be
initialized only when the class is
loaded remember i'm not talking about
the object initialization i'm talking
about the loading of the class in the
jvm
so the first time the class is loaded
this particular variable will be
initialized and that's it after that no
matter how many student objects you
create the same college reference will
be used again and again and the college
variable will not be initialized again
it will be initialized once and the same
college reference will be used again and
again that's the power of static
variables for example if i want to
access this particular college variable
how do i do that so let's look at a main
class where i have initialized this
particular student class with an object
named as john and i've specified the
name the age and the address and i'm
printing those values how do we access
the static variable if i say john dot
do i get access to the college variable
yes i do have access to it but does it
work let's see you see a yellow line
here and we will come to that yellow
line in a while but let's first see
if this works
yes it works i can see that the college
name is printed here as xyz which i have
set now let's look at the error or the
warning it says the static field student
dot college college should be accessed
in a static way because the way you are
accessing it right now is the instance
way of accessing a particular member
this is not a static way of accessing a
member so if you want to access a static
member of a class you should access it
with the class name and not the object
name why going back to my original
definition that the static variables
belong to class they do not belong to
object and that's why java will warn you
if you are not accessing the static
variables via the class because they are
supposed to be accessible via class it
will not give you a compilation error
but if you are working in an enterprise
project this is going to raise a lot of
violations and lot of questions for you
as to why you are not accessing it via
the class name so this is the correct
way of accessing it and you will get the
same output now no matter how many
objects you create of the student class
you can always access the
student.college and you can always get
the same value of the college name
that's the first use case
second thing is about static methods so
you will use the static methods in a
case where i described about the
counting the employee numbers and let's
say if we have the same kind of scenario
where you have to count the number of
students because you can use that
particular account as let's say the role
number of the student so if you have
that kind of requirement then you need
to create a static method because you
need to share the state of the object
across objects remember that so what you
can do simply is create a static method
so let's say i create a normal method
and then i just put static in front of
it saying static void student count and
now i want to count the student so i can
let's create a simple count variable and
let's start it with 0 and then i can
increment the count variable again and
again in the static method right
but you see i get an error here the
error is if you go to the balloon it
says cannot make a static reference to a
non-static field count this is one of
the properties of the static methods the
moment you make a method as static then
that particular method can only access
the static member variables of the class
the static methods will not be able to
access the non-static variables
count is a non-static variable count is
a normal instance variable so a normal
instance variable for that matter name
or age or address nothing would be
accessible here if i try to access let's
say i try to access name here so if i
just say this out and i say name it will
also give me give me the same kind of
error if i go here it gives me the exact
same error because static method cannot
access the non-static member variables
of the class
so you have to make this count variable
as static as well and then only this
compilation error will be fixed i can
remove this one and now this method is
fine now i can
increment the count every time that
object is created
and that is one of the use case of using
the static method that you can share the
state across the different objects
and if you want to fetch this particular
variable then you can simply write a
getter for this saying end count return
count
and then you can return the count you
can see that now an instance method can
access
the static member so
the reverse is is fine a non-static
method can access a static variable but
a static method cannot access a
non-static variable remember that a
static method can not access a
non-static variable but a non-static
method can very well access anything
including the static variable that's
second thing the third concept is of
static block
and static block also has a similar
usage that if you have a block of code
it's not just a variable it's not just a
method but you have a block of logic
which you want to execute only once when
the class is loaded into the runtime if
that is your requirement then you can
write a static block and the way you
will write it generally we write it at
the beginning of the class and the way
you will write it is it as you write
static and you put curly braces and you
start writing code here as to whatever
you can say initializer
and you can write whatever code you want
to write the only caveat is that in the
static block you will only be able to
access
only the static member variables of the
class so you will not be able to access
these variables you can only access
these two variables you can very well
move these two variables here if you
want to so if i go here i can paste this
and i can drop the static keyword
because everything in the static block
is automatically static so i don't need
to explicitly call out static variable
and now this code is fine you get some
warning because it's not used anywhere
in the class but that's fine because
this is just a simple demo but the whole
point is that you can write the static
block and you can write all these
initializer code which you want to write
here which you only want to execute once
during the whole execution of your
program just to show you the the reason
and
the way it works let's try to see if the
static block works
and let me comment all the static code
which he wrote here and let's go back to
the static demo and let me remove this
one as well so now i just will run this
student dot java i will i will create an
object of student.java and i will see if
the static block gets executed or not so
let's run this particular class which is
the main class and i have a main method
i have a student object initialized and
i'm printing the name agent
address if i run this you see the first
line of code which gets printed in the
output console is the static block code
which is what i wrote here and let me do
one more thing just for fun sake let me
create more objects of it
let me just call them one
two three and four
and let's see and let's see how many
times the initializer code gets printed
you see that the code still gets printed
only once even when i created five
different objects of the student class
and that's the property of the static
block that it will be executed only once
when the program is loaded into the
runtime and that's all and that's pretty
much all what i want to cover in this
particular session let's get started
with nested classes in java so so far we
have seen that we can create classes in
java and we can create objects of those
classes to interact between those
classes and objects and other properties
as well but what if you have a use case
or what if there is a need that you need
to define a class within a class so
that's the concept of nested classes
that java does allow you to create
classes within the classes now you might
be wondering as to why do you want to do
that and the simple answer is
encapsulation you would be facing some
scenarios while writing enterprise grade
applications where you have a class
which has its own scope but that whole
scope or the existence of that class is
justified by another class for example
if you try to design an object oriented
design for a house then a kitchen cannot
exist without a house because the
kitchen exists inside the house
right so
if you have that kind of relationship
then probably kitchen class has to be
inside the house class somehow and
that's where this nested class concept
will come into picture and that's why we
have this nested class concept here as
you can see what i'm showing on the
diagram that java programming language
allows you to define a class within a
class and that is called nested class
now when we talk about nested classes
you will hear two different terms
basically nested classes are divided
into two categories
which are static classes or static
nested classes and non-static nested
classes now static nested classes are
called simply static nested classes and
the non-static nested classes are called
inner classes because they are
non-static they are just normal inner
class exactly similar to the way we say
a normal method and a static method
similarly if you put a static keyword in
front of in front of a nested class that
becomes a static nested class and if you
do not put static keyword in front of a
nested class then it is simply treated
as a general inner class that's the
overall concept now there are some more
drivers of why you would like to use it
one example is i gave you about the
existence of an object within an object
or or technically speaking the existence
of a class within a class the whole
house and kitchen analogy which i just
shared with you but broadly you will see
three different reasons these different
reasons due to which you will be using
nested classes first of all it's a way
to logically group all the related
classes that are only used in one place
what it means is that if you have a
class
which is only serving the purpose for a
larger class then it's better to group
those two classes together inside a
single class or simply nest the smaller
class inside the bigger class we i might
be using the term inner class and outer
class to point out the static nested
inner class and the outer class that's
the first reason the second reason is
like i said it increases encapsulation
because now you have full control over
what you can expose and what you cannot
expose or what you should expose and
what you should not expose because inner
classes will also come with its own set
of visibility constructs like private
protected etc so you you get more fine
grain control in terms of what you want
to expose to the outside world
collectively from the outer and the
inner class and it can lead to more
readable and maintainable code though i
would honestly say that this is
debatable because in lot of programming
languages static nested classes are not
promoted because they drop readability
imagine if you have 10 classes if you
have a single class and if you have a
nested hierarchy of 10 classes it
becomes super confusing and super
complex to track the visibility of the
variables and also to understand the
code better so this is debatable whether
it improves to readability and
maintainability or not maintainability
yes to a sense because you have a single
class which is containing the logic of
our inner helper class and the outer
class readability yes or no it depends
if if the classes are small size then
yes it does improve readability if they
if they grow larger then it's better to
move the class outside and just make
that class maybe a package private or
something so this is the basic premise
of why we use nested classes now let's
talk about an example which by which we
can demonstrate how to work with the
static nested classes
so here i have created a class it's a
simple class but i've just named it as
outer class so that we understand that
this is the outer class so i have a
class here which is named as outer class
and at line five i am defining a static
variable inside the class you can see
the static keyword here and i just
called it as outer static member then i
have a simple instance variable this is
something which you have seen normally
in in all the different examples i have
given you and then i have another static
variable but this is private so this one
is a normal static variable this one is
a normal instance variable and this one
is a private static outer variable all
these three variables are sitting in the
outer class but this is private this is
static this is private static and this
is a normal instance method and we will
see how we can access these variables
inside the static nested class to define
the static nested class the way you will
write it as you will be inside the class
opening and closing braces and you will
start writing like this static class and
the name of your class that is how
you're going to define a static nested
class and then you put the curly braces
and whatever goes inside it is just like
any other normal class you would write
so let's say inside this static nested
class i have defined a method called
display and now i am trying to access
this particular variable which was a
static variable defined in the outside
class or the outer class we will see if
we can access this static variables from
the outside class or not so that is what
this
system.out.println is doing i'm just
accessing this directly you can see you
can directly access the outer class
static member variable inside the static
nested inner class then in the next
statement i am accessing the outer
private member this one so the outer
private member which is also static so
these two static variables are being
accessed here in these two lines
basically and then i have commented out
one more thing to try out if i can
access the normal instance member also
remember the concept which i which i
taught you in the previous session that
a static method or a static block can
only access static variables a static
block will not be able to access
non-static variables so these two are
static variables and this is a
non-static variable so we will see if
the same construct still applies on this
particular class or not so inside the
display method i have these two sys outs
and this one is commented out i will
come back to that later so you have the
you have your outer class and your
static nested class ready with a sample
method and now let's see how we can
invoke these outer and inner classes how
do we create the objects of an inner
class so for that i have this static
nested demo class it's basically
containing a public static void main
method as you can see here and let's try
accessing a static nested class so if
you want to initialize or access the
inner static nested class then you have
to follow this kind of construct where
you say outer class
dot inner class name then you give a
reference to it and again you follow the
same construct you say new outer class
dot static nested class name and a
simple parenthesis and this is how you
are going to create an object of the
static nested class which you have
defined inside your outer class remember
this syntax this is how you are going to
do this that you type outer class dot
static nested class once you have done
that it will call the default
constructor of static nested class and
you will get an object now you will also
see the dependency which i talked about
there is no way that you can initialize
this static nested class without
referring it from the outer class you
always have to write this outer class
dot to access the static nested class
you will not be able to access or use
this static nested class directly
anywhere in your program so the whole
concept of the inner class only existing
with the outer class holds true here
because you can the inner class only can
exist if you refer it from the outer
class once you have the object you call
the dot display method and let's see
what happens
so if i run this particular program
and let's see what kind of output do i
get i get two lines of output when i
call the display method so let's go to
the display method where i am doing a
cis out for the static member of the
outer class which was this variable so
that value gets printed as 10 and then i
am printing the private static member of
the outer class and that also is
accessible so it means that you can
access the normal static variable of the
outer class and also the private static
variable of the outer class inside a
static nested class that's one part of
it now let's uncomment this and see if
this works you see that you directly get
a compilation error and you don't even
have to wait for the program to be run
you see that this particular variable
instance member this instance member
variable is not accessible so this this
also verifies our
understanding which which was built
previously in the previous session that
static blocks can only access static
members and those static blocks will not
be able to access any non-static
variable or member and this was a
non-static member so that's all i want
to cover in this particular session
where we talked about the nested classes
concept the static nested classes
concepts basically and we also had a
look at what the static nested class can
access or cannot access and we also saw
how do we initialize an object of a
static nested class in the next session
we are going to talk about the second
category of the nested classes which is
the normal inner classes or the
non-static nested classes let's get
started with inner classes in java so in
the previous session we talked about the
static nested classes and in today's
session we are going to focus on the
non-static nested classes we also call
them simply as inner classes so whenever
you hear the word inner classes always
clarify whether they mean the static
nested inner classes or the non-static
nested inner classes because people may
use different terminologies but the
official or the standard terminology is
whenever somebody says inner classes it
means the normal nested class and when
somebody wants to convey static nested
classes they will use explicitly the
word as static nested classes so when we
talk about inner classes they look a bit
similar to the static nested classes
with the difference that you will not
see a static keyword when you define the
inner class that's the one type of the
simplest inner class you can create it
follows pretty much the same kind of
construct where you define the outer
class and you define the inner class and
you write the logic inside the inner
class so let's understand this with the
help of an example and we will also talk
about the other type of inner classes
which we have so with that i want to
switch back to the eclipse ide and let
me comment this one out because i will
cover this in a while and let me fix an
error here as well so i will comment
this as well okay so let's talk about
the demo which we which i prepared it's
a very simplistic demo just to
understand the concept and please do
practice all of these concepts in detail
to get get more confident about this so
i start defining a normal class just
naming it as outer class and then you
can create a class within a class i'm
calling it as inner class you can
obviously name it as anything you want
and you can write any logic which you
want to write inside your inner class
here i just have a display method where
i have a simple sysout which is
verifying if i can invoke this
particular method or not so if you have
this simple kind of construct of outer
class or inner class how do you how do
you initialize the inner class remember
when we talked about the static nested
classes and if you wanted to initialize
the static tested class i had to follow
this particular syntax where i said
outer class dot inner class on both
sides when i try to initialize the
object but if i want to initialize a
normal inner class or a non-stat
non-static nested class the way to do
that is like this so on the left hand
side you again follow the same kind of
construct where you say outer class dot
inner class you write a reference for it
and then you say new outer class here
you are creating an object of it dot new
inner class so you basically first
initialize the outer class create an
object of the outer class and then that
object of the outer class can be used to
create an object of the inner class so
this is the difference if i take you
back to the static nested classes
initialization here on the right hand
side it was simply outer class dot inner
class and then the parenthesis because
this was a static member so you access
the static members by the class name
that's why class name dot static member
but you access the normal instance
members via the instance and not the
class name so you need to create the
instance first and then once you have
created that instance then you can
access any member variable of this class
and inner class technically is just a
member variable which has been
initialized here so this is how you are
going to initialize an inner class then
you get an object of it and once you
have got the object of the inner class
then you can call the display method and
whatever is written in the display
method shall be executed let's run this
program yes i can see that the display
method is getting called and it is
printing whatever was written inside the
display method in the display method i
just simply had a cis out which said
this is a inner class method and that's
what is getting printed here that's one
type of the inner class which is looking
very simple another a bit more complex
and special type of inner class is
called method local inner class when i
say method local inner class the name
itself explains what it means that you
are trying to create a class
inside a method of the outer class so
let me just uncomment this part so this
is a normal method normal instance
method of the outer class and inside the
method i create a class you see inside
the method also you can create an inner
class that is also something which is
supported by java and that's what i'm
trying to showcase here that when i
define the outer class method i write my
whatever logic i want to write in my
method and then i can create an inner
class a method local class basically
i've just named it as method local class
to uh to just look it more readable and
then you can define anything you want to
write inside your method local class
here i have just defined a simple method
called local inner method and i have
just printed a statement inside the
local inner method which says in the
method local class method once i've
defined the class then within the method
i can also initialize the class if i
want you can see i'm creating an object
of the method local class within the
enclosing method that is also possible
so i create an object called mlc and
then once i have the object i can invoke
this method by the object and that is
what i'm doing here so this whole logic
can be just embedded inside a particular
method and we call this type of class as
method local inner classes this is also
a type of inner class but this is just
to show you that you can also create
method local inner classes so this is
what i've done here and if i if i invoke
this outer class method what happens
let's see that so here i have written
the code to simply initialize the outer
class nothing new here this is a normal
initialization and once i've done that
once i've got an instance then i say
outer class dot outer class method i
simply call the instance method and once
i call the instance method everything is
written inside the instance method gets
executed so first i should get this
statement
then the class will get loaded and
compiled then an instance of the class
will be created and then whatever is
written inside the local inner method
will be executed so technically i should
see this cis out and ultimately this is
out if i run those two lines let me
comment the first part so that we can
observe the output correctly and i run
this as a java application and i get
these two lines so i get the in the
outer class method statement which is
coming from here and then i this this
whole code gets executed and eventually
when this method gets called i get this
statement as well which is in the method
local class method so this is to show
you how you can invoke the method local
classes basically there's nothing new
here it's just a normal class you
instantiate the normal class and then
you call the
object you get an object and you call
the method on the object of the method
local class
now there is another type of inner class
which is called anonymous inner class
which we haven't covered so far
anonymous inner classes are not very
common but sometimes you you might need
to do that
you might need to create anonymous inner
classes but always first understand and
discuss with your teammates as to if
there is a way to avoid anonymous inner
classes because they are not very
readable but let me cover that as well
as part of this curriculum so if you
have to implement anonymous error
classes let's first understand why do we
need to implement anonymous inner
classes and i would like to do that with
the help of a demonstration so i have
again created a simple interface of
bicycle and i will create an
implementation class called mountain
bike so you see a bicycle interface
and i have two methods which says can
speed up and can apply brake just simple
to interface methods being declared here
then i create an implementation class
called mountain bike which implements
bicycle and if it implements bicycle it
has to provide the implementation of
those two declared methods in the
interface and that's what it does here
and for the sake of simplicity i'm just
printing assist out here all good so far
and then if you have to access or create
an object of this mountain bike class
the way you do that is simply by just
saying bicycle mountain equal to new
mountain bike remember i'm using the
bicycle reference here and but the
object is of mountain bike so when i
call anything on the mountain bike then
that implementation of the mountain bike
will be invoked so i'm just invoking the
can apply brake method and can speed up
methods nothing new here you have
already seen this when we were talking
about interfaces session but what if you
want to create an object of the bicycle
class itself you don't want to create a
mountain bike class at all is there a
way to avoid creating mountain bike
class and still being able to write this
logic yes there is a way and that is the
anonymous inner way so i can just say
bicycle bicycle equal to new bicycle if
i say new bicycle remember i'm not
seeing new mountain bike because
mountain bike does not exist or i don't
want to create mountain bike class then
you can write this instantiation right
for the interface class but the moment
you hit control space and you will get
this option where it will say okay i
will get you an object of bicycle
interface but it has to be of anonymous
inner type which is of which is lying in
this particular package so if you just
click on this this whole code will be
generated for you so you see the moment
you double click on this this whole code
was generated automatically for you
which is providing everything
technically everything which you wrote
in the mountain bike class so the whole
logic which you could write in a child
class gets embedded right into the
instantiation code itself and this is
your anonymous inner class you see it
automatically looks a bit ugly and
imagine if you're writing this for a
real production code where each of the
methods may have lot of logic and you
may have lot of methods then it can grow
very long and it can look very ugly
that's why i was saying always try to
create a child class instead
it can be a simple use case but try to
create a child class or try to avoid
writing anonymous inner classes if you
can if there is no way out then this is
the way you do it you can there's also a
bit nicer way to do this using using
lambda function for functional
interfaces but that is also something
which will not uh improve the
readability a lot though it will make
the code look smaller so here you can
write the exact logic which you want to
write in can speed up and can apply
break basically whatever you wrote in
the in those two methods in the mountain
bike class can very well be written here
and the code will still be executed so
let's let's just do that quickly so i
will just go here and copy this out from
speed up method i'll just put it here
and i will copy the can apply break
method and i will put it here and i will
comment the mountain bike code so i'm
creating i've created the object of
bicycle class here and now if i say
bicycle dot
can apply break and i can say bicycle
dot can speed up so now i can access
these two methods and the implementation
will be invoked from this anonymous
inner class implementation so if i run
this i will get pretty much the same
output yes you can see i get exactly the
same output it's currently printing both
of these outside the same because i did
not change the cis out here and yeah i
have written the exactly same text in
both of the cases so if i just change
text to say can apply break
and i do the same thing here i say can
apply break and if i run this
so you get the same output and if you
uncomment if you comment this back and
if you use the above code you also get
the same output yep so that's the basic
construct of anonymous inner classes
that you can use the interface
instantiation if you do not want to
create a child class of it just
instantiate the interface and java will
automatically generate the concrete
override implementation for all the
methods which are declared in your
interface and then you can provide the
implementation of those methods in line
and that's all i want to cover for this
particular session so we cover a whole
lot we covered about the normal inner
classes we covered the method local in
our classes and we covered the anonymous
inner classes let's get started with
packages in java now i have been using
the concept of packages all the while in
all the sessions but we never focused
particularly on packages and why we need
them how do we create them what are the
thumb rules so we will focus on all of
those questions in this particular
session so first of all just to get the
definition out a package is basically a
grouping of related types now these
types can be classes they can be
interfaces they can be abstract classes
they can be nested classes or what not
but the basic idea is that you try to
keep everything which is related to each
other at one place it's quite similar to
how you arrange your house or how you
arrange your office or how you arrange
your work desk you try to keep the
similar kind of stuff together for
example you might have a particular rack
in your almira where you keep all the
books you might have a different track
where you keep clothes generally you
won't mix books and clothes together in
a single rack right because they don't
belong together and that's the concept
basically which java packages try to put
you or give you to implement in your
programming language and your project as
well so it's a logical way of grouping
related classes and types together
that's what packages do and if i take
you back to the eclipse ide before i go
any further
you will see all these square looking
objects right these all are packages you
see the square icons these boxes these
are packages and the way you create
packages is basically if you just go to
the src let me go back to the src and
you right click on this you go to new
you will get an option of package so you
can go click here and write any name of
your package let's say test dot package
couple of things to note is that
packages follow this convention of dot
and that is how you nest a package into
other or that is how you create a
hierarchy of packages and sub packages
so you can create this as a package
which is fine and you can also create
dot something dot something else dot
something else dot something else and
you can go further as well other thing
to notice is that this will not accept
keywords you can see it says else is not
a valid java identifier because else is
a keyword a reserved keyword in java so
make sure that you are not using those
reserved keyword names in the in this
particular package name so it can be
test.test1.test2.test3
whatever so just make sure that you're
not using keywords here and you can
create the hierarchy now how do you name
them different organizations and
different project teams follow different
naming conventions this is your area
this is fully customizable so you can
write it write it the way you want it
generally what companies do is they put
their domain name from the backwards so
for example uh google.com might have a
package called com.google similarly
amazon.com might have a package called
com.amazon internally this this is
something which might have been there
but they can they they might have chosen
something else but this is sort of the
standard convention that you just
reverse the domain name of your
application and you write the package
name backwards that is the general
convention and after that once you have
written that let's say if you have
written com com.google this is the top
domain name now after that you specify
what you want to do let's say you you
are implementing a web package then you
can be even more specific okay web
package is a huge huge package what is
specifically your this package will be
doing inside the web package so let's
say html html might not be a right
example but uh let's say
some uh front end code front end auth
logic let's say so now this can be a
valid package because if somebody reads
the package they can understand what
would be lying inside the package this
hugely improves readability and please
do spend a good amount of time in naming
your packages right because once you
write the code the code is going to be
living for many many years to come and
many other developers once you leave the
organization many other developers will
be looking at that code and you would
like to make their lives easy by
by understanding the code by just
looking at the package name so please
name the package names correctly and
once you have written this package name
as for example in this case front-end
authlogic or let me say front-end dot
authlogic once you have written this
package name as authlogic then make sure
that only the classes which belong to
this particular business requirement are
present inside this package no other
unrelated class should go inside the
package that is something also which
developer have to take care of so this
is again the responsibilities of the
developers that they make sure that
whatever goes inside these this
particular package is only relevant to
the package there's no irrelevant stuff
which should go inside the package again
this is to improve readability
searchability maintainability and tons
of other
out-of-the-box benefits you get so that
is how you create the packages now let
me go back to the documentation and talk
about why would you use that let's look
at some of the more benefits of it so if
you scroll down in this official
documentation you will find bunch of
reasons and benefits of it first of all
you and other programmers can easily
determine that these types are related
because if something if some classes and
some types are sitting inside a package
then there is an expectation that those
classes and types serve the purpose of
that package only you also it also
provides a benefit that you and other
programmers can can easily find the
types that can provide a particular type
of functionality again the same concept
of aggregating simple single functional
classes into these packages that if you
are writing let's say a banking
application and if you have if you have
a package called
interest rates then everything inside
the calculation of the interest rate and
the specification of the interest rates
should sit inside that particular
package only similarly the names of your
type will not conflict with their type
names in the other packages that is also
a huge benefit of packages that you once
you start writing a particular class
inside a package and if you make that
particular class as private package then
that particular class will be visible
only within the package and you can
again recreate the exact same class with
the exact same name in another package
let me give you an example so if i go to
uh let's say the inheritance example
here i have a class called bicycle this
is a bicycle class and if you see
strategically i have not put public here
i have removed the public identifier
here so this class is only visible
within this package called dot
inheritance this particular class will
only be visible in this package to these
other classes now if i go
let's say if i go to method overriding i
have another bicycle.java here if i open
this this is also a class these two
classes are exactly the same but they
don't conflict with each other because
both of them are packaged private and
they live in different packages and only
those packages can see them this
particular class is present in this
particular package which ends with dot
method overriding and this particular
class ends in a package with ends with
dot inheritance so if i go here let's
see if i go to the main class and if i
try to type bicycle
and i put control space you see i only
get the suggestion of these
package private bicycle class which is
sitting inside the method overriding
package itself what if i change this the
visibility of this inheritance package
bicycle class to public let's make it
public and now if i go back to the
method overriding demo which is sitting
in the method overriding package where i
already have a bicycle class and now if
i type bicycle and i do control space i
get two options one is from the local
package and because i have made the
other bicycle class as public i get that
as well as a suggestion and if i import
this one you see now the inheritance
package bicycle class has been imported
in the method overriding package it can
create a lot of confusion that's why it
is always a good practice to work with
the access modifiers really well and try
to restrict the visibility of the
classes to what they should be
accessible at and that's why it's a good
practice to keep the classes within the
package private visibility so that
they're only visible within the package
this will help you in a lot of ways uh
providing any kind of
any kind of problems around ambiguity so
ambiguity is a big problem when you have
huge projects with lot of similar class
names so that's all i want to cover in
the in the session of packages and you
can obviously nest packages within one
another you can go as long as the
package name you want to be just make
sure that there are no keywords in those
package names so that's all for this
particular session let's get started
with recursion in java so let's first
understand what do we mean by recursion
and then we will look at the details of
the class which you are seeing on your
screen so recursion is the phenomena of
an a method calling itself so
so we we have the scenarios where we
call a particular method on an object
right but what if you have a scenario
where a method wants to call itself now
you might be wondering why a method
would call itself because this will go
into an infinite loop right if you write
a method called sum and then the sum
inside the sub method you again invoke
the sub method then this will keep
running into loops till your program
goes out of memory i will show the
example of that as well but the basic
idea is the use case where if you have a
need where the where the method wants to
call itself that is where you will use
the recursion concept another thing
whatever you can achieve with recursion
generally you can achieve the same
output using for loops as well but when
you use it for for loops it will require
you to write lot of code recursion will
reduce the number of lines you need to
write and manage in your code but on the
other side recursion can get a bit
complex because it requires an advanced
understanding of how methods actually
work in java so before i go any further
understand that methods whatever you
define inside the method that goes on to
a stack remember i covered about stacks
and it's a lifo arrangement so whatever
you define inside your method all those
variables and all those statements they
go on to a stack and then the stack gets
emptied one by one executing the
statement which is sitting on the top of
the stack that is the concept of the
method execution that under the hood it
is using a stack now when we talk about
uh the recursion it also follows the
same stack uh insertion and stack item
removal concept that how do you insert
elements into the stack and how do you
remove them so i'm we are going to walk
through an example of recursion with the
help of a use case called factorial now
if you if you have studied about
factorial in your in your school classes
you might remember that factorial is a
way where let's say if i have to
calculate the factorial of 10 then it
would be 10 into the factorial of 9 into
the factorial of 8 into the factorial of
7. so you see i'm repeating the concept
of calculating the factorial again and
again first i am calculating the
factorial of 10 in a 10 into factorial
of 9 then i say 9 into factorial of 8
then i say 8 into factorial of 7 then i
say 7 into factorial of 6 and so forth
so forth so this is the concept of how
do you calculate factorials another
example where you can use recursion is a
fibonacci series so when we talk about
the fibonacci series the basic idea is
that you sum the previous two elements
and that's how you create the next
element then this then you sum the
immediate previous two and you create
the next element so again you perform
the operation of summing the past two
elements again and again to calculate
the next element so you see again you're
repeating the same operation again and
again so try to identify that particular
thing where you have to repeat the
particular operation again and again on
the whole sequence that would be the use
case where you might be needing to use a
recursion concept so here i have
prepared an example for calculating the
factorial of a number so what you see on
your screen is a class called complex
function and then it has a method called
calculate factorial and inside the
method you supply an argument which is
basically a number for which you want to
calculate the factorial so if you supply
5 a factorial of 5 will be calculated if
you supply 10 a factorial of 10 will be
calculated now the first thing which you
need to do when you write a recursion
function is to know the exit condition
that is probably the most important
concept when you write recursion you
should know when to end the program if
you get it wrong then your program will
start will be stuck into an infinite
loop and it will only exit when there
would be a stack overflow basically
there will not be enough memory inside
the jvm to run your program it will
crash technically so remember always to
define a exit condition some people also
call it as a base condition but remember
the base case or base condition or the
exit condition either of the terms can
be used interchangeably but always
remember to first define the base
condition
so here when do you end calculating the
factorial you know the factorial of one
is one and it cannot go any further so
that would be your base condition that
once if if you if you encounter a
scenario where somebody inputs one as an
argument then you simply return one
because the factorial of one will be one
so this is your base case this is what
is going to make sure that your program
exits smoothly if you get it wrong your
program will never end it will go into
an endless mode then in the else
condition you write the factorial logic
based on the recursion so like i said
what does a factorial function does is
if you calculate the factorial of 5 then
it would be 5 into factorial of 4 4 into
factorial of 3 3 into factorial of 2 2
into factorial of 1 and that's when it
will end so here i'm saying let's say n
was 5 so you say 5 into you again call
back the same function 5 into calculate
factorial of 5 minus 1 so now again the
function will be invoked with an n equal
to 4 it will go here this condition will
not be met because n is 4 it will go to
the else block again the same thing will
happen 4 into
calculate factorial of 3 so you are
again invoking the same function but
this time supplying an as 3. so it will
go here n will be supplied as 3 it will
again check the base condition and is
still not 3 and is still not 1 so it
will go to the else block so 3 into
calculate factorial of 2 it will again
go up and again it will invoke the
calculate factorial method but this time
with n equal to 2 this condition is
still false because n is still 2 it will
go to the else block and it will say 2
into calculate factorial of 1 it will
again go up this time it will invoke
with n equal to 1 and it will go here
and it will satisfy the condition and
that's where your program will have its
first output you remember previous
execution of 5 into factorial 4 into
factorial 3 into factorial 2 did not
result into an output these were the
executions of the method call which were
just going on the stack so you were just
at first you had the calculate factorial
of 5 on the stack on top of it you had
the calculate factorial 4 on the stack
then you had calculate factorial 3 on
the stack then you had 2 and then you
had one but when you had one your
program did this uh
received or reached any particular end
so that was your first output once you
have your first output ready then you go
back to the previous one so the first
statement has been popped now you go
back to the calculate factorial of 2 and
you calculate that once you have the
output of that then you go back to
calculate factorial of 3 and so you
basically unpack the stack now you
basically try to remove the elements
from the stack to visualize this this is
how it will look like that you first
call the factorial 5 let me just change
the name of it just to make it
look exactly how it will go on the stack
so this is how it is going to go on the
stack so you first you call the
calculate factorial of 5 which in turn
called the calculate factorial 4 which
in turn called calculate factorial 3
calculate factorial 2 calculate
factorial 1 and once you had the
calculate factorial 1 you got the first
output and once you had the first output
then you start unpacking it because you
had the value of the calculate factorial
1 so you can say 2 into calculate
factorial 1's output calculate factorial
1's output was 1 so 2 into 1 becomes 2
and this is the output of calculate
factorial 2 right then it goes to the
next step basically this one sorry this
one and calculate factorial 3 was
demonstrated as 3 into calculate
factorial of 2 so 3 into calculate
factorial of 2 which is this one 2. so
this gets replaced here 2 and you get
the output as 6. now you have this one
also resolved the next one on the stack
was calculate factorial of 4
which was written as 4 into calculate
factorial of 3 so 4 into calculate
factorial of 3 is output so this
function calls output this functions
call output was 6 it goes back and it
says 4 into 6 24 and you have this one
also calculated now you go to the last
statement which was calculate factorial
of 5 which was written as 5 into
calculate factorial of 4 and calculate
factorial of 4 has been already computed
as 24 so now you can simply say 5 into
24 which is the output of calculate
factorial 4 and you get the output as
120 and this is the final return
statement which will be returned to you
so if you try to understand this till
this particular point you were just
calling function after function after
function with a different value of n and
everything started getting into a result
due to the base condition this was the
base condition and that's why the base
condition is very important now imagine
there was no base condition then this
would never return and it will keep
calling calculate factorial calculate
factorial and it will keep going down
the stairs it will never be able to come
up because there is no base condition
and that's why base condition is very
important at the same time also
understanding how recursion works is
also very important also always remember
that the output of the first execution
gets supplied in the second execution
the output of the second execution gets
supplied in the third execution and
that's how the stack unpacks or empties
itself so here i'm just doing the normal
drill here where i'm saying complex
function complex function equal to new
complex function and then calling the
calculate factorial method passing 5 to
it and then printing the eventual result
and if i run this i get the output as
120 which i just walked you through so
remember how to use the recursion why to
use the recursion how to define the base
condition all of these things will will
be of of very much importance when you
try to implement recursions practice
this a lot recursion is a concept which
takes time to to get used to so practice
many different examples and many
questions of recursion and you will be
more confident about it read more about
this concept in the java docs look at
different examples on the internet that
will help you build more knowledge
around this and that's all i want to
cover in this particular session and in
the next session we are going to talk
about how do we call methods basically
how the method calling works we will
look at different examples and the pass
by value concept etc when we look at the
method calling let's get started with
method calling in java now when it comes
to defining the methods i have been
talking about methods throughout this
particular series and the syntax is
pretty familiar where you first specify
the access modifier then you specify the
return type then you specify the actual
name of the method and after that you
specify all the arguments which this
method is going to accept and inside the
curly braces you do your calculation and
based on the return type you return an
appropriate value we have seen many
examples of it and let me show you a
quick example to just understand the
method anatomy better and then we will
talk about how do we pass arguments to
methods so in this simple class student
i have some properties i have
constructor and then i have methods
these all are also simply methods we can
see we have an access modifier which
will decide whether this particular
method should be visible to the outside
world or not you can also either remove
this particular access modifier or make
the method private if you want or you
can also make the method protected if
you want so all of the possibilities are
there and that and what what kind of
access modifier will you keep depends
upon upon your use case so that is the
access modifier and then if your method
is not supposed to return anything then
you would just say void void is the
default keyword in java which is used
for use cases when you do not want to
return something void just means empty
or nothing so when you have nothing to
return you are going to put void you
cannot skip this if you remove if you
remove this the method signature is not
complete so you have to provide this
there is no way around it so you need to
provide the method return type after
that you provide the name of the method
this is a free text string and you can
name it whatever you want just follow
the camel casing convention where you
start with a small alphabet and for
every new word in the method name you
start with the first letter as capital
after that you put normal braces and you
supply the arguments which this
particular method is going to accept for
example if this method was about
calculating interest then probably you
might supply the interest rate as the
argument and the principle as the
argument if this method was about
calculating the price of the car then
you might supply all the different
mileage details and the manufacturing
details which would decide the price of
the car so it depends upon what you are
doing and that's how you will understand
what kind of arguments your method is
going to need when you define the
arguments you need to define the data
type of the argument and again a name
which you can give it give it as
anything this is again a free text
string and after that it depends upon
you what kind of logic you want to write
inside the method the basic need for
writing a method is to not do the same
thing again and again at every place if
you have a functionality let's say if i
take the same example if you have to
calculate interest and the interest
calculation logic is required at let's
say 15 different places in your
application then just create a single
method for calculating the interest rate
or the interest and then just reuse that
method again and again
at different points in your application
just call that method that's that's how
we use it so that is the basic idea of
creating a method to keep reusing the
functionality over and over again across
all the different methods in your
application let's take another example
of this particular method because it has
a return statement again i specify a
public access modifier i specify the
return type which is string in this case
then i specify a name of the method and
i can also choose not to supply any
argument if the method does not need any
argument to do its computation or to run
its logic if you put a return type any
any other return type then y and then
void here then you have to provide a
return statement the return statement
will be the last execution step of your
method remember that the return
statement will be the last execution
step of your method execution this has
to be provided if you provide a return
type other than void inside your method
in this particular case this method
expects a string return type which means
when i call get name i should get a
result back which should be of type
string then i need to write a return
statement and return a variable which
should be of string type for example if
i just change this method to say let's
say if i say int i equal to 1 and if i
say return i this is going to give you
an error you see there's a compilation
error and if you hover over the balloon
icon it says cannot convert from int to
string it is trying to convert this
particular return type and trying to
match this into this particular return
type and it's not able to match into
string so you get you get an error so it
has to exactly match the return type the
data type of the of the return uh value
which you have put here it has to match
exactly with the with the return
statement variable type if it doesn't
match you're going to get a compilation
error that's the first thing now there
might be scenarios where you have
multiple branches of execution in your
method for example if you have if let's
say if i just
use this condition of i equal to 1 and i
write if i equal to equal to 1 then
return let's say a test string else
return the name i'll just cut this and
put it here and we'll change this to
name this is also possible and this is
possible because of the same statement
which i told you earlier that return
statement has to be the last execution
step of your method execution in this
particular method there are two branches
of execution this is one branch and this
is the other branch at a particular time
either the if block or the else block is
going to get executed there would never
be a case that both of the blocks get
executed in the same execution cycle it
will always be either this block or this
block and that's why if you use these
kind of statements then you have to
provide return type in each of the
branches you can also do something like
this let's say if i say string return
where equal to null and then i say
control c control v
i assign test string to the return var
and then here also i assign name string
to the return val and at the end i say a
single return and i say return where
this is also fine because here i am just
assigning different values in the if
block in the else block and then just
returning the placeholder variable which
is also absolutely fine so you can use
either of the way the better way is to
return from within the branch itself so
this was a quick tour for you to see how
methods work and what kind of anatomy
method represent now let me just quickly
revolt everything which i did here and
bring it back to return name that's good
and now let's talk about the method
calling patterns and how do we call the
methods so for that i have prepared a
class called method calling demo it has
a public static void main method and
here i have just declared a simple
variable i and initialize the value of i
as one then i am calling a method which
is named as change value and if you go
to this particular method it has a very
simple implementation it is accepting
the argument which i created here i'm
passing this particular variable as an
argument to this method and then
whatever argument i supply i'm
incrementing that argument by one and
just returning and not returning
anything from here just incrementing the
value of i and that's it and after that
i'm printing i so what would be your
guess here what would be the value here
i'm gonna pause here for a moment and to
let you think about what is going to
happen okay i hope you have uh you would
have done some calculations in your head
to see what is going to happen and what
is the value of i eventually at line
eight let's run this program to
understand that okay so i had
initialized i as one then i passed the
value of i
in this particular argument and i said i
equal to i plus 1 so it should be 1 plus
1 equal to 2 and i the new value of i
should be 2 but at line 8 i still get i
as 1. why is that happening it's
happening because of the concept of pass
by value remember that concept that in
java every argument which you pass to a
method is passed by value and not by
reference in simple language what does
it mean is that when you pass this
particular argument a copy of this
particular argument is a copy of this
particular variable is passed to the
method argument it's not the exact same
variable we are not passing the same
reference of i here we are passing a
copy of it a unique local copy of it
that's why whatever you do with i inside
this particular method is not going to
change the state of i which is defined
here because it is passed by value or
since simple language the object is
copied over locally to the method it's
not the same reference which is being
passed upon that's why you see this
value if you want to get the return
value then the one way is to just change
the return type and say return i and
then just store this return i value here
saying end result
equal to whatever is returned from here
and we are returning the new i here and
then you can print the result and you
will get 2. if i run this now i get is
2. so this is to just to validate that
this everything in java is passed by
value there is no concept of pass by
reference when we talk about method
calling in java let's take a more
complicated example this was a simple
variable let's go back to the
student.java so i have the student class
here let's create some objects of it and
try to follow the same pattern so here i
have created an object of the student
class named john age 25 address 23 east
california i'm doing some sis outs which
are not really important here but let me
just uncomment this particular method so
here what i'm doing is i'm calling a
method i'm basically defining a method
which says change name in the same
object and i'm supplying the student
object so the student object gets here
and then i'm overwriting the name in the
student object that's what i'm doing
here so now let's just call this
particular method and see what happens
so i'm going to call this particular
method here and pass the object john
inside it and then let's try to print
the name of the object referenced by
john if i say get name so i'm calling
this particular method passing the uh
john object here where i'm overwriting
the name john with jane and then i'm
printing the new name of the john object
let's see what happens now so if i run
this particular program yes i can see
that the name has been overwritten from
john to j now this happened because you
passed the reference pointed to the
object inside the method and then you
overwrote the name ins
on the object which was pointed by this
particular reference so here you might
think that this is passed by reference
but this is still passed by value
because this reference is not the same
reference as this one this is a
different reference but both references
are pointing to the same object that is
the only commonality here so you can
mutate a particular object inside a
method and be very careful of that do
not ever try to do that because it is
going to create a lot of unpredictable
results for you because it might be
possible that you are calling a
particular method from some other
application which is doing a lot of
changes in the same argument object
which you supplied and then you don't
know what is the state of it so it's a
very dangerous pattern and very
dangerous way to mutate the objects do
not do this let's find another way to
deal with this problem if i don't want
to mutate the same object how do i solve
that problem so we can solve that
problem simply by creating a new object
and changing whatever we want to change
so i have one more method here which
says change name in a different object
it is also accepting the student object
and then here it is creating a new
student object and here it is
overwriting the name but getting the age
and the address as the same values from
the argument so we keep the age and the
address same but we create a new name
but we don't overwrite the same object
we create a new object and then we can
return this particular new object if we
want to i can do clear this and i can
say return
new student and then i can store the
value of this particular method calling
i can call this method here supply the
same argument as
john let me comment this one and then i
can store the value of the result
student result obj
and i get the value here and then i can
say result obj.get name and if i run
this program now remember i'm calling a
different method now which is going to
create a new object and then
change the value i do get the same
effect but now my previous object john
is not touched at all it is safe and
sound i can reuse this john object
anywhere in my method in my application
and i can be assured that nothing is
changing in terms of the state of the
object so always follow this particular
pattern whenever you are calling methods
and passing arguments to the method and
if those arguments happen to be your
custom classes and even java classes in
fact then always try to create a new
copy of the object inside the method if
you intend to mutate or change the state
of the object let's get started with
today's topic which is about exceptions
in java let's first understand what are
exceptions and why do we actually need
this concept the simple reason for
having exceptions existence is that
developers make mistake we do create
bugs and errors while we write code it's
natural it always happens that whenever
you write code you might miss out some
condition or the other which creates a
bug in the application which creates a
defect in the application and then the
testing team finds that defect and then
we fix that defect and that's how a
normal software development life cycle
works so to handle those kind of
exceptions and errors every programming
language provides their own exception
and error framework to support the
developer in spotting those errors and
fixing those errors and handling those
errors instead and java also provides
its own exception framework so what you
see on the screen right now is basically
the a snapshot of the exception
framework of java and you see it has a
long hierarchy of different classes here
this is also an inheritance hierarchy
just to give you context and the whole
exception framework hierarchy starts
with a class called throwable so
throwable is is the class which is the
root or the parent class of handling all
types of exceptions and errors and
that's where the next differentiation
comes exceptions and errors java treats
these two things differently and i will
go in detail as to what is an exception
and what is an error but let's first
understand the hierarchy further under
the exception hierarchy you see some
exceptions like i o exceptions which is
an exception which comes when something
goes wrong in the file writing or file
reading or the file handling operations
then you have sql exception which comes
whenever you are talking to the database
writing sql queries and something goes
wrong you also have class not found
exception which comes when a class is
not found in the in the run time or in
the or at the time when the class is
being loaded in the jvm and then you
have also run time exceptions which are
like arithmetic number format and there
are a lot and lots more of this type of
exceptions as well on the right hand
side you have the error type and then
you have some errors like jvm error
memory error and framework error so now
coming to the differentiation between
exception and error
exception is a type of problem which
can be recovered in a program from which
the program can be recovered which the
developers should handle so exception is
a type where the developer focus is the
developer is responsible to make sure
that none of these exceptions occur in
the program and if these exceptions
occur in the program then the developer
has the responsibility to handle these
exceptions properly we will look at the
examples of how the developer can handle
these exceptions on the right hand side
is the error type where the developer
does not have any control you cannot do
anything if the jvm has an error or if
the underlying memory of the computer or
the jvm memory gets an error or the the
whole framework or the java itself
library itself has an error you can't do
anything about that and those are the
kind of problems which go into the
category of error that's why java has
created these two different categories
one is exceptions which is the
responsibility of the developer and
other is error which are not the
responsibility of the developer and in
fact developer cannot do anything if
this happens so this was a quick tour to
you to what kind of the exception
framework is present in java do read
about this framework in detail in the
java docs as well but just to extend
this understanding further we'll have a
look at some examples of the exceptions
and how these exceptions occur so with
that i'm going to switch to the eclipse
ide and i have created bunch of classes
to show different types of exceptions so
let's go through the first class which
is named as simple exception demo it has
a main method it has a variable of int
type the variable name is data and what
i'm doing here is i'm dividing 100 by
zero so if you see this carefully you
know that this is going to result in an
infinite value you cannot divide any
number by zero and java also prohibits
doing the same because it doesn't make
sense to divide anything by zero so if
you run this particular line if you
execute this particular line this is
going to throw a runtime exception these
are the runtime exceptions remember so
let's try to comment rest of the code
and let's quickly try to run this so i
run this program and there you go i got
an exception which says exception in the
thread main main is the main thread with
the exception type is
java.lang.arithmeticexception
and this is the exception type divide by
0 and it will also give you the line
number at which the exception happens if
you click on this it will directly take
you to the exact line at which the
exception happened and this is you know
if you see now this helps the developer
a lot this
information which is printed here is
called exception stack trace and you can
look at the stack trace go to the last
line and this would be the line from
where the exception actually originated
if you click on that particular line it
will take you exactly at the place where
the exception might have occurred and
then you can look at the line fix the
code and rerun the program to see if the
exception is gone that's why i said that
developer has to handle this exception
now as far as handling these exceptions
is concerned i am going to cover that in
the next session but in the in this
particular session we are just going to
focus on the types of exceptions and how
they occur this was an example of
arithmetic exception where we are trying
to divide something by zero let's take
another example let me uncomment this
particular line of code and comment back
this one so here i am creating a string
a but the string is null and null means
nothing it's it's a it's a void
reference it has nothing in it and now
if i try to do some operation on this
particular string so remember a is null
and whenever you are trying to operate
something on a null object java is going
to throw an exception because you can't
operate on null because null means
nothing empty it is it is a dummy thing
so you cannot do anything on this
particular null reference and if i run
this program i get an exception which
says null pointer exception
java.lang.nullpointerexception
and it will give you the exact reason
cannot invoke string dot care at int
string dot this is a string type string
dot care at int because a is null so it
will give you the exact reason as to why
this program failed and then again if
you click on this particular line it
will take you the exact line where the
problem is and then you can fix the
problem maybe you need to initialize the
string properly to make sure that this
error doesn't occur so these are all the
runtime exceptions which the developer
has to take care of which the developer
has to fix
to make sure that the program runs
smoothly if they don't handle it the
program is going to fail and the program
will actually force them to fix because
the program will not run unless they fix
those exceptions now these are the
examples of runtime exceptions you can
also create these kind of exceptions
which are called checked exceptions
runtime exceptions are also called
unchecked exceptions you might hear this
term as well some some people use the
term runtime exception instead of
unchecked exception and use both of them
interchangeably so runtime exceptions
are also called unchecked exceptions and
these exceptions are called checked
exceptions why do we call them checked
and unchecked is because
these exceptions are something which you
do not have to explicitly specify in
your program in this program i did not
have to explicitly specify this
particular because i don't know if this
line of code is going to result into a
null pointer exception or not but these
exceptions are something with java will
force you to handle let's look at an
example of this
so i have created one more class which
is named as checked exception demo and
i'm doing some file operations basically
reading a file writing to a file etc i'm
using some classes of java named as file
reader and some methods like readline
and close and if you see the moment i'm
trying to read a file
this line has a
has a red marker there's a compilation
error if you scroll over it it says
unhandled exception type file not found
exception so java is forcing you to
handle this error this particular
exception because file not found is a
checked exception so if your expression
your line of code is throwing a checked
exception then java will force you to do
something about it it will not compile
the code until you either handle this
exception or you re-throw this exception
again how do we handle this is something
which we will cover in the next session
but you can you can always re-throw this
exception but you have to do something
about it you cannot just skip it so what
i can do if i don't want to handle this
is i will pass on the responsibility of
handling this exception to the callee
program so whoever is going to call this
main method has the responsibility now
to handle the file not found exception
because i have just thrown it i've just
passed it on i've just passed my
responsibility to the colleague and you
can do similar thing here as well if i
go here you see it says unhandled type
exception i o exception and if you
remember i exception is here it is a
checked exception so i can do one more
throws here comma v and now
if i just resume the import whoever is
calling the main method has the
responsibility of handling the file not
found or i exception you can also handle
it like i said or you can just add
throws clause to the method signature
and then the caller has the
responsibility to fix or handle the
exception so this is how the checked
exceptions work remember in the
unchecked exception in the runtime
exception
we we can see that these two lines do
throw exceptions but there is no
forced way by java to tell us that i
have to fix it because java doesn't care
about unchecked exceptions at the
compile time it will only encounter
those runtime exceptions at the run time
that's why they are called runtime
exceptions but checked exceptions are
compile time exceptions and you have to
fix them handle them or throw them right
at the time of compiling the code so
that was about checked exception now
there's also a possibility that you can
create your own exception if you want to
so for that i've just created a very
simple class here called my exception
and the way you create your own custom
exception is by just extending your
class with exception class you just
write this extends exception and you can
write a default constructor or a
parameterized constructor whichever
makes sense for you and this is your
exception class ready to use and you can
just invoke this exception explicitly
remember whenever you are creating your
custom exception it is by default a
check exception so your program has to
handle it for example if i go back to
this particular class and if i do this
let me just comment all of this code now
and remove the throws clause as well so
if i go here
and i'm saying
throw new my exception my exception was
my class so i'm explicitly throwing an
exception which was my custom exception
and i again get the error if i hover
over it it says unhandled exception type
my exception so i have to handle this
exception or i can just throw this
exception and let the caller handle it
so this also works so this basically
builds our understanding that broadly
there are three different types of
exceptions which we work with there is a
runtime exception which is also called
unchecked exception which happens
because of developers mistakes in the
program like this one then there is a
checked exception
which developer might not be responsible
for creating the exception but developer
has to handle it and there are some
classes in java which throw those
checked exceptions like file not found
exception and i exception whenever you
are working with file handling
operations java will force you to handle
those checked exceptions or rethrow
those checked exceptions using the
throws clause similarly the third type
is when you create your custom exception
type and custom exception types are also
checked exceptions by default and
whenever you are explicitly throwing
your own custom exceptions you again
have to either handle the exception
within your enclosing code or you can
just re-throw the exception and let the
caller handle it so this is a quick tour
of different types of exception and
including this exception hierarchy and
let's get started with exception
handling in java using try and catch
blocks so in the previous session we had
a look at the scenarios where an
exception can occur how do we see that
there's a runtime exception or there's a
checked exception or there's an
unchecked exception or there is a custom
exception
now
we did not talk about how to handle
those exceptions
and now we are going to focus on the
handling part
so whenever you have to handle those
exceptions
the way java provides for that is using
the try catch block
so try catch block is basically a bunch
of syntax which you have to follow to
handle different types of exceptions in
your programming code
and the syntax of the try catch block is
pretty straight forward
you write try and you put curly braces
and then you write whatever code
which might
throw an exception you don't know that
but it's always safer to enclose your
code in a try catch block so that you
know that if an exception occurs in the
try block
then you can handle it in the catch
block
so it's a it's always considered a
better practice to enclose your
application code in a try catch block so
that you can handle the exceptions so
you put this try block
and write write all the suspicious or
non-suspicious code which may or may not
throw an exception inside the try block
once you have done the dry block part
then comes the catch block part
so let me go to the catch block
so this is how the syntax look like once
you have written the try block then you
write catch
and you put braces
and you write the exception type
which this block of code might throw or
the exception type which you are
interested in catching you might not be
interested in catching all the different
exceptions but only a few ones based on
your business requirements so whatever
exception type you want to catch
you are going to catch it like this
and if an exception occurs in the try
code
let's say you have specified an
arithmetic exception here and if any
line of code in the try block throws an
arithmetic exception
then this catch block is going to catch
that exception and then inside these
curly braces you can decide what to do
with that exception
whether you want to lock that exception
or whether you want to re-throw that
exception whether you want to
embed some error code or get an error
code out of it or convert that exception
into a business or custom exception of
your own choice so it's up to you what
you want to do with that but catch block
will be able to catch that arithmetic
exception
similarly you can specify as many
exception types to be caught as you want
and keep adding more and more catch
blocks
remember that these catch blocks work in
a in a sequential fashion
so if an exception occurs here it will
first go to this particular block to
match the exception type
if it didn't match then only it will
move to the second type
if it did match the first type it is not
going to execute the second type so that
is how the try catch block work
you can see an example here that if the
code here is throwing an index out of
bond exception then it is going to be
caught here
and we are just printing the index out
of one exceptions message
if it is throwing an io exception then i
can do this so you can keep adding
different checked and unchecked
exceptions in the catch block
you can also catch more than one type of
exception with one exception handler so
rather than writing these multiple catch
blocks individually you can combine
these exceptions together if your
logic of processing
both of these exceptions is the same
remember if the logic of processing
these two exceptions is the same
logic means whatever you write inside
these curly braces
so if that code is going to be the same
for both of these exceptions then why
bother writing two catch blocks
just write one catch block like this
use the pipe operator to separate
different types of exceptions and write
the common code which is going to be
applied if your try block is going to
through an io exception or an sql
exception
so that depends upon you
that's the second piece
the third piece of the try block is the
final block so we talked about the try
block we talked about the catch block
now there's a finally block as well
remember this is finally and not final
the finally block is used
together with the try catch block
when you want to perform some cleanup
operations
imagine you are opening up a file
handler
in the try block you're doing something
with it and then you want to just
close the file handler irrespective of
the fact if there was an exception in
the try block or not because even if
there was an exception the file handler
resource is going to remain open and is
going to consume memory in your
application you might you don't want to
do that similarly if you opened a
database connection inside your try
block
irrespective of the fact of what happens
in the try block you always would like
to close the database connection
and you can write that closing code in
the final block that's the purpose of
the finally block that you can write the
code
inside the finally block which is
supposed to be always executed
irrespective of the fact whether an
exception occurs or doesn't occur
so now we have built a good
understanding of what is the try catch
what is what is the try block catch
block and the final block now if you
just put it all together
this is how it is going to look like
that you write the try block you do
something inside the try block
then you write the catch blocks
after that you write the final block
you can write the finely block without
the catch block as well remember that if
you do not have any exception to catch
but you have some resources to close or
free up after executing the try block
you can skip the catch block and just
right try finally that is also possible
with that understanding let's switch to
the ide and let's look at some example
so i have a writer helper class
which is having a method called write
list i have a try block here
and this try block is basically
initializing an error list
adding an item to the error list
and then i'm accessing list dot get one
remember when i added this particular
value let me make it tend to make it
more understandable
when i added 10 to this particular list
this goes to the index 0 position
and here i'm trying to access index 1
position
which does not have anything
so in such case it might throw an error
because there's nothing at least not get
one so this is my method where i put the
try block code and then because
i don't want to end up in a position
where i get an index out of bound
exception index out of bonds exception
comes if you are trying to access an
index
which is illegal which is does not
having any value so i'm putting a catch
block and catching the index out of
bound exception
and just printing the message of the
exception
and then i'm for just for simplicity i'm
showing a final block as well though i
do not have any resource to close here
but this is just to show you how this
looks like in the code
this is just to show you that i'm
putting i'm printing assist out here
this is what my method is and if i go to
the main class
the try catch demo class
i'm creating an object of the
writerhelper class and calling the
writelist method which we just walked
through
let's run this program and see what
happens
okay so first i get this statement
saying entering try statement so if i go
here
i call this method
the execution goes inside the try block
and i get the sis out which says
entering try statement
then i try to access the second
element in the list because the position
is 1 this is going to index 0 and i'm
trying to access index 1. there is
nothing at index one so i get an error
saying index out of bounds exception
index one
out of bounds for length one
because the total length of the list
currently is one because there's just
one element and that one element is
sitting at zero and not 1.
so i get the exception
which is the index outer bound exception
but the index outer bond exception is
caught by my catch block and the system
dot error dot println is something which
gets executed
and i get this particular
line this particular line
from
this
line number 17
and then irrespective of the fact
whether an exception occurred or not my
final block always gets executed
let's fix this and see if the final
block gets executed even if there is no
exception so now accessing get 0 and
let's see what happens
yep i access the element 10 no exception
but the final block still gets executed
so this is to assert our understanding
that the final block will always be
executed irrespective of the fact
whether there was an exception or there
wasn't
now you can also nest different try
blocks if you want to
let's look at an example where i have
multiple try blocks so you can initial
you can write a try within a try within
a try if you want and you can go as deep
as you want but remember the more
indentations the more hierarchy you
create the program is going to get more
and more complex so always remember
to have that kind of trade-off
so i write multiple try blocks i
initialize an array i print
added 10 obviously array 10 does not
exist because this array has just four
elements so this is bound to through an
index out of bound exception and i'm
catching that exception immediately in
the catch block this is the exception
printing assist out and just to
re-throwing the exception you can also
read through the exception by just using
the throw keyword
remember this throw is different from
the throws keyword which comes in the
method signature this is just to throw
any exception from your code
so this is array index outer bond
exception for this try block
then i have another array index outer
bond exception for this try block
which starts from here block two
and then i have another catch block for
the block one try block
so you can see it is already getting a
bit complicated where i have multiple
hierarchies but you can do that
so this is what is happening in this
particular program now let's try to run
this and see what happens and try to
decipher the output
okay so at first i get this particular
line which says
array index out of bounds exception in
block 3.
what happens here is that this line gets
executed
it throws an array index out of bounds
exception
at line 13 that array index out of
bounds exception is caught which was
generated from this line
and then we go inside the catch block we
execute this is out this is what you see
here the same sis out and then we re
throw the exception
if we read through the exception
the exception goes to the enclosing try
block
the enclosing try block is this one
there was an exception re-thrown from
this try block and now it has gone to
this try block
and now
this try block block 2 will try to see
if it can catch this array index out of
bound exception
yes we can catch it
so it can so so the block 2 again has a
catch block which catches the array
index out of bound and it prints assists
out here which says exception in block 2
which we see here
and it again rethrows the exception
and if it rethrows the exception so now
the block 2
now the block 2 is re-throwing the
exception so this whole code
is now re-throwing the exception if this
block 2 is re-throwing the exception it
goes to block one just going one
hierarchy up
and then it sees if it can handle the
exception in the catch block
of this block one so yes the block one
try block also had a catch exception
which said array index out of bound e4
and here it just had a sys out
so if i just bring back the output
yes we do get this a particular
exception printed here which says array
index out of bounds exception in block
one this is what you see here
and this is where the exception just
stops going propagated because i'm not
re-throwing the exception from this
particular catch block so that's where
the exception ends the reason you see a
hyperlink here is because the text
the text which i have printed here
exactly matches with the name of the
exception so java is pretty smart in
that case if you use the exact same name
exception it will link it to the
matching class name in java which is
pretty cool
i also have a redundant cache block here
which does not have a try block this is
just to show you that you can write a
catch block without a try block but it
doesn't make sense it is of no use so i
can just remove this particular catch
block and the program still will compile
fine
so this was a quick demo to show you how
you can use try catch and finally blocks
and when would you use the final block
and if you want you can use a nested
hierarchy of try blocks and you can
rethrow
the exception from within the catch
block only to be caught in the outside
or the outer or the enclosing block so
this is all i want to cover in this
particular session let's get started
with equals and hash code in java
this is probably one of the most
important and interesting concept in
java and extremely extremely popular
when it comes to java interview
questions
so let's cover this in detail
to understand why we need equals and
hash code and what equals and hash code
is all about let's first understand the
object class of java remember i'm
calling it an object class and not just
an object
object is a class as well in java and it
is the super super class of any class
you create in java so anything you do in
java any class you create it will
automatically be inherited by the object
class
object class is the super class of any
class created in java
and if you look at this documentation
and if you come here you will see that
object class
defines this equals method which
indicates whether some
other object is equal to this one or not
and it also
defines a hash code method which returns
a hash code value for the object
so let's understand both of them one by
one
first of all let's establish that this
these methods have their concrete
implementations
available inside the object class
but how do you do that and how do we how
does it come into effect
remember when we talked about hash set
and i said that hashtag will maintain
uniqueness automatically
how does it maintain uniqueness
automatically
it is because of the equals method
implementation which it inherits from
the
object class
that's how it maintains uniqueness
and if you remember i also told that
you can do
you you can maintain uniqueness in a
hash set if it's a built-in data type
like integer or string or float or
double etc
but what if you are trying to create a
hash set of student objects
then java does not know how to perform
equality on two student objects because
student is a custom object java doesn't
know how to run equality and that's
where equals and hash code comes into
picture
so the contract is that whenever you are
creating your own custom objects
and you have a need
to perform equality on those objects
you must override the equals method
in your own class
you have to override that if you do not
override that then two student objects
will be compared based on the reference
and not based on the actual object
values
we will see all of that with the help of
an example
another thing which says that whenever
you are overriding equals
you should also override hashcode method
reason is because hashcode is also used
in certain collections and we will cover
that in a while but let's just focus on
equals first
and let me switch back to the eclipse
ide
where i have a student class again it's
a very familiar class which we have
covered in other lectures as well
and i have three different properties
here roll number name and address
i have a constructor and i have setters
and getters
now if i go here
and i create three different
objects of the student class
you see i have created three different
objects
the student object has a role number one
named john and the address is the same
one
second object has a role number two
and the name john
and the address is the same as this one
and third one again has a different role
number but the name and address is the
same it's a hypothetical situation
so let's do one thing let's make this
roll number as one as well so now these
two student objects are exactly
identical
so what happens if i compare john with
john two
by looking at naked eyes these two
objects look exactly the same so john
equals john 2 should return true
let's run this program
but we get false
the reason we get false is because the
default implementation of equals is
being run
on the on comparing the student objects
because java still does not know how to
equate these two objects why you are
getting false because these two are
different references java created a new
memory location somewhere and put this
object created a reference drawn to it
then java created one more new object in
this line and created new reference john
2. so these two
different references are pointing to two
different memory locations of the
objects though their internal values are
same but their memory locations are
different
that's why you get this particular value
as false because these are pointing to
different memory locations and that
brings me to the hash code contract
you need to
override the hash code contract as well
along with the equals to make sure that
your equality runs perfectly
let's go back to the student class and
let's fix this problem because we can
see that these are identical objects you
don't want to store the same student
twice in your database right
so you need to fix this
so i go back to the student.java
and i have commented this equals method
and let me uncomment this now
so what i do that i override
the equals method
and the equals method contract looks
like this where you supply an object
which is in which is a foreign object
and now you need to compare this foreign
object with your current object of the
student class which is this
so at first you need to run this
particular condition which says are
these two objects
these two references that this reference
and the obj reference pointing to the
same object if they are pointing to the
same object then
this will return true and then we will
say that the object is that that
equality holds true because both are
pointing that doesn't hold true if this
doesn't hold true then it moves on to
line 50 and it runs a condition saying
that
is obj null or
obj.get class is not equal to this dot
get class
get class is a method which will tell
you the class type
here we are checking is the obj class
object is of the type student or not if
it's of different type let's say vehicle
or something then then definitely they
will not be equal
and we can directly return false so
that's why i'm checking that it should
not be null
or
the class types should be matching if
these two conditions are if either of
these conditions are holding true then i
return false and i say that objects are
not equal
so i've covered this condition where
both of the references are pointing to
the same object i covered this condition
where the class types were not matching
or the obj itself was null then then we
return false
if we pass all of these sanity checks
then we do the actual comparison
before doing the actual comparison i
need to do this explicit casting
so i cast the obj object into the
student type
if you remember that's it this is how we
did this this casting for other data
types as well
once you have converted this obj into
the student object
then you need to define your own
business logic based on which you are
going to define uniqueness
so how are you going to uniquely
identify a student in your application
will govern this logic
in this particular example i'm saying
that i am going to identify a unique
student based on its role number
so even if two students have exact same
matching details but if their role
numbers are different then these are two
different objects for me but if two
objects have are having the same role
number and even if they have a different
name and address i am going to say that
those two objects are duplicate so roll
number is the is the condition on which
i'm defining
uniqueness equality and duplicity
so i define this and say if the roll
numbers are equal then the object is
equal objects are same basically or
duplicate and if the roll numbers are
different then these two are different
objects
good so far coming back to the main
class so now i have the same role number
here
let me change the name just for fun and
address as well
so i have a different name and a
different address but the role number is
exactly the same
remember we have defined the equality
condition based on the roll number
and here we are comparing if john is
equal to john 2 or not
so let's run this program
now i get true the reason i get true is
because this equals method is is used
to run this equals comparison
so this establishes how we can use the
equals contract to maintain uniqueness
now i also said that whenever you have
you are defining the equals method you
also have to override the hashcode
method
and to understand why do we need
hashcode as well let's go back to how
hash map works
remember in the hash map or let's say
even hash set in the hash set you have
to maintain uniqueness now java
maintains uniqueness using both equals
and hash code
hash code is nothing but a memory bucket
in the in java's memory where your
object is stored it's basically a memory
location
so every object has a hash code and that
hash code is the actual memory footprint
where the object is stored
and whenever you are dealing with hash
set or hash maps you will be required to
override both of these methods
let's understand how this works
so if you have a hash set and you are
trying to insert an element then first
java will use your equals method
definition to check if an object similar
to the object being inserted is already
present in the hash set or not
if it finds an object it will basically
flag that this is a duplicate object and
it will not insert it
let's understand how an object is
fetched from hash set
let me open a hashtag example
just to
give you some sort of a visual
representation of what i am talking
about
so if i go to my hash set example in
in the collections package somewhere
and let's open a hash set demo plus yeah
so when we were doing these insertions
though this is this was a string object
so it was the java already knew how to
use the equals and hash code of it but
if it was a student object and you were
doing multiple
ad and then when you were actually
fetching the element or you are doing
that contains
then how does it work is basically first
it is going to calculate the hash code
of the object let's say you are saying
hashset.getb
or
hashtag.getjohn1
then it is going to calculate the hash
code
of your john 1 object
hashcode is a memory footprint and
hashcode and the way it is going to
calculate the hashcode is going to be
based on the definition which you have
provided
so the definition which you have
provided this hash code will be run to
calculate the memory footprint
and then that particular memory for java
will go to that particular memory
footprint and see
if there is an object present there or
not
now java has a memory location right and
there can be multiple objects stored at
that particular memory location this is
possible in java so if there are
multiple objects present in that
particular memory location which was
calculated based on the your hash code
implementation
then java is going to run the equals
method to find the exact matching object
so just to try to visualize this if i
try to visualize this let's say you have
this memory locations
and let's say your hash code came up to
memory location 2
and then at 2 memory location
you had multiple objects obj 1
obj2
obj3 etc this is possible
multiple objects can point to the same
memory location so if this happens then
java is going to use the equals contract
to compare your john 1 object with obj 1
with obj 2 and with obj3
this is where the equals will come into
use so you see the both hash code and
equals are being used here to point to
the right memory location and that's why
i said that hash set and hash maps are
where equals and hash code will come in
full force where you will be required to
implement this and it's a good practice
to always override the equals and hash
code in your application whenever you
are creating classes the reason is that
you don't know when and where these
classes will be stored into a hashtag
collection or a hashmap collection so
it's always a good idea to
have equals and hash code being
implemented and when you implement hash
code the rule the thumb rule is that you
should use the same parameters which
have been used in the equals contract
in the hash code contract as well
the reason for that is what if you used
here let's say you use name here and you
use roll number here then two different
properties are being used to
find memory location and uni and the
uniqueness
and remember this logic which i just
gave you here both hash code and equals
are working together to find the right
object so if you are going if you make
any mistakes in defining the equals and
hash code or if you made any mistake in
defining the symmetry between equals and
hash code then you may get unpredictable
results
how you define your hash code
up to you but make sure to use the same
properties which you have used to define
the equality always keep this consistent
to avoid any unexpected results
you can also do this just say return one
and every and what happens what will
happen that when you use this particular
student class in a hash set all the
objects are going to be stored at a
single memory location
and then this particular situation will
occur where you will have a single
memory location and all of your objects
will be present at that memory location
and when you are trying to fetch
anything the hash code will always point
to the same memory location and then
equals will make sure to find out the
right object you are trying to fetch
from the hash set
so this is all about equals and hash
code which i wanted to cover in this
particular lecture do read about this in
detail there are tons of articles
available on this particular concept
because this is a very important and
popular concept
both from implementation perspective and
from interview perspective
and that's all we are going to cover in
this particular session let's get
started with comparable in java and
before we go there let's understand why
do we need comparable the need for
comparable comes from the requirement
whenever you have to sort your
collections so to understand that let's
move over to the java docs to understand
how this works
so the basic idea is that you want to
sort your collection
and to do that java provides you with a
method called collections.org
you just provide you just supply your
list or your collection inside the sort
method and all the elements or objects
inside your collection will be sorted
based on the natural sorted ordering
this holds true for built-in data types
but what if your list is of type student
objects then again the same constraint
applies that java does not know how to
sort student objects
it knows how to sort strings and hints
and floats and doubles because those are
built-in data types but student is a
custom type and java doesn't know how to
sort it
and to solve that problem java provides
an interface
called comparable
so comparable is the interface which you
need to
implement
from your class whenever you have a need
to sort your objects or of your class
type
so this is the interface which your
class needs to implement this interface
provides a single method which says
compare to
and it provides the foreign object and
then you need to compare this foreign
object with your
current object
so let's go back to the java class and
understand how do we work with this
comparable interface
so again i have used the student class
for the sake of continuity and i have
the same properties as roll number name
and age but this time i say implements
comparable of type student this is a
generics type we are we will be covering
generics in a bit more detail in this
whole in this whole series but the basic
idea is that you define that this
comparable interface will only work for
student types to define the type in this
particular construct which we also call
a generic type
so you do this and the moment you do
this java will force you to provide the
implementation of the compare to method
which i have provided here
so the way this
implementation works is you have a
foreign object here but this time this
foreign object since i have defined this
as of type student so if you the moment
you do this
java will ask you to override this
method and using eclipse ide if you
overwrite this
then you will get this signature
automatically let me show you this how
this works
so if you do this you will get an error
here and if you click on this balloon
it will say add unimplemented methods if
you double click on this
you will see a comparative
implementation here
and this is exactly the skeleton which
you see here
by default it says return 0 but i'll
just come back to that in a while
so this is how this method came up here
and once you have this signature
available then you need to provide your
implementation on how do you want to
sort the objects
remember you need to define your your
logic here so again i would like to sort
my students based on the role number
which is the natural sorting order for
me for the student objects so this is
your custom
sorting logic which you which you can
call as natural custom logic sorting
order for your student objects so i want
to sort them based on roll number but
you see i've done a strange thing here
i've done a minus here so what i'm doing
is that the current object's roll number
minus the foreign object's
roll number
so if this value
comes as a positive number then this
this object is going to take priority
this is going to be
sitting before the student
if this result returns in a negative
value then this object will come first
and
this will come second so the student
object will come first and this object
the current object will come second
and if this returns zero
then it means both of the objects
deserve the same priority or the same
order priority and any one of them can
come after the other so the basic idea
is that if this if this results in
greater than 0 then the current object
is going to take precedence
if this is going to return in a negative
value then the foreign object which you
are supplying here is going to take
precedence and if this returns in zero
then any one of them can take precedence
so you need to define your compare to
logic in the compared to override
implementation
once you have done that let's understand
this with the help of an example i have
created a comparable demo class which
has a public static void main method and
i create an error list and i create
three different student objects
first student object is named as john
second is jane and third is tom
the first has a role number of three
so john has a three role number of three
jane has a role number of 1
and tom has a roll number of 2.
so if my compared to logic runs
perfectly then jane should be coming
first after after i sort this collection
after i add these three elements into my
list and once i sort this collection
then jane should come first
tom should come second and john should
come third
based on my natural ordering ordering
custom logic which i have implemented in
the compare to method and that's what
i'm doing here
after i've sorted the list i'm just
printing the list
by using the for each construct of the
streams api
i'm just printing the name to see which
one comes first and which one comes
second
so let's run this program
and this is how it looks like so jane
comes first because she had a roll
number one
don tom came second because he had a
roll number two and john came third
because
his roll number was three
so no matter how many times you run this
program you're going to get the
collection in the same sorted sequence
and this is happening because of the
compared to implementation which you
provided here
now
if you
comment this implementation
let's see what happens and i remove this
implements comparable as well from here
i just create a simple student class and
now i try to run the sort
now you see that you get an error here
and if you hover over this balloon it
says that the method sort in the type
collection is not applicable to the
argument array list of student
java does not know how to sort this so
it will force you to provide a sorted
implementation
and the moment you provide comparable
implementation here
and if you go back to the main class the
error is gone
so this also will force you to provide
your comparable implementation
now you can use this sorting for any
kind of collection sorting as well and
whenever you are doing this always make
sure to provide the compare to
implementation and remember that
contract which i gave you about greater
than zero less than zero and equal and
that's all i'm going to cover in this
particular session let's get started
with comparators in java in the previous
session we talked about comparable
where we said that whenever we want to
implement a naturally occurring sorting
order where you just say collection.sort
and you sit back and relax
if you have provided they compare to
implementation you would expect things
to work
but what if you have a custom sorting
requirement
let's take a hypothetical scenario where
you created an application
and your application has a student
object and you created a collection of
student objects and now you have
different consumer applications let's
say you have a payroll application you
have a attendance system you have an
examination system you have another
extracurricular activity system and all
of them want to get the student
collection but all of them have
different sorting requirements
payroll wants to have the sorting based
on the roll number
attendants want to have the sorting on
some other mechanism extracurricular
application want to have the sorting on
some other mechanism
so how do you implement custom sorting
or multiple sorting logics
for your collection
and that's where comparators comes into
picture
comparator is again an interface as you
can see here in the signature
and this interface provides you the
flexibility to define your own
custom sorting logic multiple times so
you can create multiple comparator
implementations
and each comparator implementation will
focus on a particular sorting order
so that's that's the basic need of
sorting so remember whenever you want to
sort the object in an order other than
natural ordering or ordering or you want
to sort some object that don't implement
comparable so whenever you have these
kind of conditions always think of
comparator
apart from that always think of
comparator when you have to provide
multiple sorting implementations on the
same collection
so let's see how can we do that with the
help of an example
so here again i have the same student
class
and i have the same properties
currently by default i have provided a
comparable student implementation which
is exactly the same as we covered last
in the last session
and
if we use this particular implementation
you we create an arraylist we created
multiple student objects
we added them to the list and we called
sort
so what happens if i just comment the
new code
and if i just run this particular code
remember the sorting is happening on the
roll number so here roll number one jane
will come first roll number two tom will
come second and roll number three john
will come third
but then you had one more application
which wanted to have the sorting based
on the age of the student so these are
the age values of the students and some
application wants you to provide the
sorting implementation for the age now
age is a custom sorting logic which you
need to provide
and whenever you have that kind of
situation create a comparator
how do you create a comparator
like this simply create a class
name your comparator anything
try to end it with a suffix comparator
so that you know that this is a
comparator implementation and then you
say implements comparator of the class
type
this is what you need to do and the
moment you need to you do this it will
force you to
override this compare method
remember the comparable interface
provided compare two method
where you supplied the just the foreign
object
it its name was compared to
with single object
in comparator the name is just compare
and you have two objects here student
one and student two let me just call
them student one and student two for
simplicity
one and o two look a bit weird
so i've just refactored this one and i
will refactor this one as well
so i have student one and student two
and this is an age comparator so i want
to apply the sorting logic based on age
simply put whoever has whoever is
younger should come first and whoever is
older should come later in the
collection once i sort it
so let's see how this sorting logic is
implemented
this is a single line code so let me
just put braces around it so that it's
more easily readable you can write it
without braces as well if you have a
single statement inside the if block or
else block
but you can always write it like this
and let me just
format this as well
okay so this is the compare
implementation the first logic which i
have run is saying which says that if
the first student's age
is less than the second student's age
then return minus one
similarly
if the first student's age
is greater than the second student age
then return plus 1
and if both of the students age are same
then return 0.
so this is your custom logic and this is
where you need to define your logic and
remember this will also govern whether
the sorting is going to be ascending or
descending
so for example if you have provided that
student
once age is less than student two's age
then written minus one then this is
going to maintain the natural sorting or
the ascending order sorting
now if you want to have a descending
order sorting
just change these values saying that if
this is less then return
one and if it is greater then return
minus one and this is going to run the
sorting in a descending order fashion
now so it depends upon what kind of
sorting order you want and based on that
you can define the values but the
default is always like this that
whenever the first object's value is
less than the second object value
return minus one
and if the first object's value is
greater than the second object's value
then return plus one otherwise return
zero
minus one means this one this one will
get precedence over this one
so this is how you have provided your
age comparator
going back to the main class
and uncommenting the other part of the
code
here i have called the sort method
where i want to sort the list
but since i want to supply a custom
sorting operator or a custom sorting
comparator here
i need to
provide that comparator object here
so remember the age comparator which you
created here you just need to provide
the comparator you need to tell java
how to sort this particular list
if you do not tell java how to sort this
java is going to look for the comparable
implementation in the student class
and it will sort the student objects
based on the compare to implementation
provided inside the student class
but if you want to have more custom
control over sorting then you need to
tell java how to
do that sorting and if you see this is
an overloaded representation this is a
method overloading example as well where
the method signature is same but just
the number of arguments are different so
this is how you provide your custom
sorting you supply your comparator now
you can create multiple comparators you
can com create another comparator based
on let's say name you can add one have
one more property here create one more
comparator so you can have as many
comparators as you want just keep
creating them and keep supplying them
individually one by one in the sort
method you can just duplicate this
and add one more comparator
so this is how you are going to have
more control and if you have multiple
consumer application
call multiple sort methods supply their
corresponding comparator and you will
get the sorted collection
so here i am just printing the list
based on the age comparator sorting
and these are the objects so let's see
how this works
and understand the output from the
beginning so the natural sorting order
is something which we have already
covered which was done based on the roll
numbers
so jane comes first
tom comes second and john comes third
and this is how you get this this
particular output
now coming to the age comparator you pre
you print this particular statement
which is coming here
and then you print these values
so let's see how the edge comparator is
working
the youngest here is john so john comes
first
then we have tom who is 20 years old so
tom comes here and then we have jane
who is 21 years old and jane comes in
the last
so we can see that our age comparator
has fired here and it has sorted this in
an ascending order
now let's flip the values
i'm going to change the values here
and now it should work in a descending
sorting order for the age comparator
so let's run this application again and
now you see jane comes first
who is 21
then tom comes who is 20 and then john
comes who is 18 so now the age
comparator is working in a descending
order
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to have a look at a
project which will cover all the
concepts which we have talked about so
far let's get started with working
through a particular project using all
the concepts which we have learned so
far
so in this session we are going to focus
on a particular project
and the project we are going to focus is
is about an atm application
so you might have interacted with
different atm stores in your cities
where you go in you insert your card you
enter your pin and then you can view the
balance you can withdraw some amount you
can also deposit some amount from the
atm
so we will try to look at it from that
perspective and we will see what kind of
different uh java and oops concepts we
can use to build such atm application
this is not a super versatile
application but this is just to give you
the idea of how to use those oops
concepts to build a simple or a complex
java application so let's start from the
options menu class because that will
give us the understanding of what kind
of functionality i'm using
and here you will use that
i am using different concepts which i
have taught you so far in this
particular series
so for example we are using the i o
exception we are using the hashmap class
we are also using a scanner class which
is used to take input from the command
line
so this option menu class is extending
the account class and i will come to the
account class in a while but let's see
what this option menu class is doing
this particular class has uh it is using
a decimal format money format class
which is to denote what kind of
format of money you have
then we have a hash map which is storing
the couple of
records of account number to pin mapping
so we create an map and inside the get
login method
we add couple of entries to the map
here the first entry the first integer
is pointing to the customer number
and the second integer is pointing to
the pin of the account of this
particular customer number
so
if we call the get login method this
method will insert the data
after that it will ask the customer to
enter the customer number which has to
be one of these two
if you provide any other value then
there should be a logic in the
application to reject the input
so whatever a customer number the
customer inputs we pass that inside this
particular method called set customer
number
again i will come back to that
and once you have provided a valid
customer number then this method is
going to ask you to enter a pin number
and remember i told you this is the
customer number to the pin number
mapping so whatever customer number you
select from here
you will be providing the corresponding
pin number and again if you provide an
invalid pin number you will get an error
so that will all happen inside this try
block and
if you enter any invalid characters in
the pin number or the atm
customer number then you will get an
exception which i am writing inside the
catch block
this is all what we have seen so
far after the successful enter of the
customer number and the pin number i
fetch those values from these two
methods again i will talk about what
these methods are doing and again i'm
doing some basic validation checks but
things get interesting in this method
so what we covered so far was the get
login method let me close this method
here
so we covered the get login method the
second method which is defined in this
particular class is the account type
so here that we will ask the once the
customer has provided the customer
number and the pin number we will ask
the customer to provide the account type
this application supports two different
account types which are checking account
or a savings account so whatever so the
customer has to choose one of them again
we will be taking the input from the
command line using the scanner class
and then i'm using a switch case if the
customer entered one then i will execute
some code for the checking account which
is defined here in the case 1
and if the customer entered 2 then the
case 2 will be executed
and if the if it enters 3 then i will
exit the application by just printing a
cis
so here i'm using the switch case
construct to provide different options
to the customer
there's also a default case specified
here which says invalid choice
so this is what is happening in the get
account type method
the next method is if the customer has
used the option one
then we call the get checking method
so let's go to the get checking method
which is the next method which is
defined in this particular class
so if the customer has selected a
checking account then we provide the
following functionality to the customer
which is the customer can view the
balance
customer can withdraw the funds
customer can deposit the funds to the
checking account or they can just exit
the application
and again i'm using a switch case here
based on the customer types one
two three or four the corresponding case
block will be executed for example if
the customer wants to view the balance
then this block will get executed and i
call the get account type method
if the customer selects the
to as the withdraw fund then get
checkings with withdraw input method
gets called
and then get account type gets called
similarly if the customer enters three
then we deposit the fund and for that
also i have defined a method i will go
to the definition of these methods as we
go along but right now we are just
building the framework
so the get checking deposit input method
will be called whenever the customer
selects the option three
and for option four we just exit the
application
so this is what is happening in the get
checking method
now if from the account selection if the
customer selected second option which
was savings account then we were calling
get saving method
so this is where the get saving method
is defined
and again it is following the exact same
format as we saw in the get checking
method
where we present the following options
like viewing balance withdrawing the
funds and depositing the funds in the
savings account
and i have some methods defined here for
example get saving withdraw input
get saving deposit input
so we define the switch case here based
on the customer's choices here
and that is what is happening in the get
saving method so let me close this
method as well and that's all what is
defined inside the option menu class
so we ask the customer to enter the
customer number the pin number from this
get login method
then based on
that we provide
the customer the options to choose the
account type whether they can choose the
savings account or the checking account
and based on that whatever account type
they use we call the get checking or get
saving method and inside this method we
provide the customer
the other options to either withdraw the
money deposit the money or view the
balance
that is what is happening inside this
option menu class
now let's go to the account class and
all the methods which we saw here will
be provided a definition in the account
class
you also see this option menu is
extending the accounts class so an
inheritance concept is being used here
let's go to the account class now
so this is the account class where i
have defined some private member
variables like customer number so now
you will be familiar with the customer
number pin number which i just described
and also with the checking balance and
the savings balance
you can also divide this account class
into two child classes where you have a
savings account class and a checking
account class
but for simplicity i've kept it to one
class
i'm initializing a scanner input which
will be used at multiple places and then
i have the setters and getters for these
four
member variables so you see set customer
number get customer number
if you remember this set customer number
was called in the option menu class if i
go back to the get login
once we ask the customer to enter the
customer number
we call the set customer number
which gets called here
similarly
we call the set pin number
which gets called here
similarly once we have said that we then
we were fetching the values using the
get customer number and the get pin
number
and that has that is also defined here
in terms of the getters
get pin number and get customer number
similarly we also have the getters for
the checking balance and the saving
balance
member variables
we do not have the setters for them
because they are not technically setters
but we have to calculate the balance
it's not a simple setter where you can
just return the value
so now let's look at some of the
business functions of the account class
how do you deposit how do you view the
balance how do you withdraw the balance
etc
so you see these two methods
which are specifically when the customer
is trying to withdraw the money from
their account
and these methods are basically called
internally by other methods so we will
come to that let's just understand that
we have two methods for calculating the
withdrawal amount or executing the
withdrawal transaction
for the checking account account and the
savings account
similarly i have two more methods here
which are calculating the depositing for
the checking account and calculating the
depositing for the savings account
and then we get the the bigger methods
which are using these calculation
methods so i define four calculation
methods so far
calc checking withdraw
calc saving withdraw calc checking
deposit and calc saving deposit
basically withdrawing and deposit for
both of the classes
and then we have these business
functions called get checking withdraw
input
and get saving withdraw input
get checking deposit input and get
saving deposit input
so these getter methods are something
which were being called from the option
menu class if you remember if you go
back to the option menu class
and if you chose the checking account
you get these options and let's say you
chose option 2 which was withdraw funds
or option 3 which was deposit funds then
the corresponding methods which were
being called were get checking withdraw
input
and get checking deposit input
and this is the exact same method gets
checking withdraw input
and get checking deposit input
so if you see what is happening inside
this particular method is couple of
sysouts
then we
take the scanner input amount and we
convert that amount to the double
after that we check
if the amount which the customer wants
to withdraw is smaller than the checking
balance or not and i'm running this
condition to check that
if the amount is smaller than the
checking balance
then we call the calc checking withdraw
method
which was defined right here
remember i told you that these four calc
methods will be used and this is how
they are used so here i'm actually
subtracting the value so whatever amount
the customer wants to withdraw
subtract that from the main balance and
then return the new main balance
that's what you do right if you have
thousand rupees and if you want to
withdraw 500 you subtract 500 from
thousand and then you send back the
remaining balance
so that is what is happening when we
call this method and then we print the
new checking account balance
that is what is happening in the get
checking withdraw input method
similarly if you chose option 3 which
was
depositing funds to the checking account
then get checking deposit input gets
called
and it is defined right here
get checking deposit input and here
instead of subtraction
we are doing the addition
so here i'm again doing a condition
check that the current balance plus the
new amount which has been supplied by
the customer from the command line the
total sum of it should be greater than
zero
what if the customer entered an amount
minus 5000 i should not allow that
so that's the reason i'm putting this
condition in place and if
the current balance plus the new amount
which is supposed to be deposited to the
account the sum of it is greater than
zero then call the calc checking deposit
method
and this is where the calc check deposit
method is present and where i'm just
doing present balance plus the new
amount and returning the new balance
that's all which is being done here
and you will see exactly similar logic
running for the
savings account as well if you look at
the get saving withdraw input which is
used to withdraw money from the savings
account so i take the input from the
command line and i run a condition check
that the amount which the customer wants
to withdraw
should be less than the current saving
accounts balance
if yes then call calc saving withdraw
method
which is defined here where i subtract
the amount from the current balance and
i return the new balance
and similarly you will see the exact
same functionality in the get saving
deposit where we add the money instead
of subtracting the money
and this is all what is defined in the
account class
so we talked about the option menu class
we talked about the account class and
now we have the atm class which is the
entry point which basically initializes
the option menu class and calls the get
login method
remember get login was the first method
which asked you to provide the customer
number and then get login called the
method to choose the account type and
the account type methods then called the
method to choose the option to withdraw
deposit or
exit so now we have built a fair
understanding of what is happening in
this application so let's run this
application
so i just ran this application and let
me bring the console here
it's first asking for a customer number
so i will go to the option menu class
and i will
pick up one of the customer number which
i have hard coded here
so i will provide that customer number
and hit enter
then it asks me for the pin number
so remember you have to provide the
correct pin number corresponding to the
customer number
so i'm taking this pin number just
copying it and pasting it here
then
this whole code got executed
and then it called the get account type
and the get account type method provided
you with these options which you see
here on the screen so based on what you
select the case block will get executed
and let's say i want to go for a
checking account so i press one
and i hit enter
once you select the checking account the
case one gets selected and it calls the
get checking method
and the get checking method again
provides you with another menu view
withdraw or deposit or exit
so let's say i want to deposit funds so
i press 3
and hit enter
it says the current balance is 0
and enter the amount you want to deposit
let's say i want to deposit 500
and i hit enter
you get the message saying the new
checking account balance is 500 and you
have successfully deposited the money
and that is what i did for the checking
account now let's try to withdraw
something from the ticking account so
you again get back the same option
because inside the get checking method
we call the once we have successfully
done the business operation we again
call the
account type method to display the menu
again to the user
so let's see again select the checking
account class
and this time i want to withdraw the
funds
remember i've added 500 there
so let's say i want to withdraw so i
choose the option 2 as the choice
current balance is 500 and it's asking
me the amount you want to withdraw from
the checking account
so i enter let's say 100 and i hit enter
when i do that the new checking account
balance becomes 400 so the 100 got
subtracted from the 500 and the new
balance is shown to your screen
you can do exactly the same thing for
for the savings account as well
and let's also run a negative condition
so i again select the checking account
and i want to withdraw the funds i
choose the option two
current balance is 400 and i i would
like to withdraw a thousand
what happens
if you do that we get a message saying
balance cannot be negative and this is
coming from the checking method which
which is defined here so what is
happening that i wanted to withdraw the
funds from the checking account
and here get checking withdraw
input.called
here
this condition was checked so the
checking balance was
and the amount i wanted to withdraw was
thousand so 400 minus thousand is not
greater than equal to zero so it jumped
into the else block and it said balance
cannot be negative
so this is how you can also build some
error conditions in your code which are
mandatory and which should be built
otherwise your application will have lot
of bugs
we can also exit the application so if
you just type three
and hit enter
you will exit from the application and
will again call the login method where
it will again ask you to enter the
customer number
so this is how you can run this
application and this is this was a
simple use case for you to show how you
can use the different object-oriented
concepts like classes objects methods
setters getters
switch case etc to build the application
with the correct business logic
and this is all i want to cover in this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to have a look at
another interesting core java project
just to build our understanding more
better about the core java concept let's
get started with working through a code
java project
using all the different oops concept we
have learned so far
so in this example we are going to have
a look at a calculator application and
this calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition subtraction
multiplication
and division
so let's see how do we build that app
so in front of me right now is open
domain class
so i have a main app class here which
has a public static void main method
and the first thing we see is a read
input class which is calling a read
method
so if you go to the read input class
it has a simple static method here which
is the read method
and it is using the scanner class
if you remember i talked about the
scanner class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user
so
we initialize the scanner class and we
start taking the inputs and whatever the
user inputs in terms of the expression
let's say the user entered four plus
five or whatever
that whole expression gets sent back
into this
input line
as a string
and that comes back here in that input
expression
once we have captured the input
expression the next thing we do is
divide the input expression
in the numbers and the operators
basically an expression would be either
something like
4 plus 5
into 3
divided by 2 let's say
let's say the user entered this
expression so this has either numbers
or operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string api
the string class basically
and this split method is going to split
the numbers and operators into two
different string arrays and here i'm
providing the split expression that
split at every time you encounter one of
these symbols so this when you execute
this particular statement it is going to
return a numbers array
which will be
created based on this expression so you
will get an array with 4 5 3 and 2.
and similarly in the
operator array you are going to split
or pick out the elements every time you
receive a number so this operator array
is going to hold this plus sign
this multiply sign and this divide sign
hope you get the understanding that we
are just splitting the whole expression
into two different arrays
where first array is holding only the
numbers and no mathematical expressions
and second array is just holding the
mathematical operators and no numbers
and we'll see why we need to do that in
the upcoming lines
once i've created the string array i
just want to
store or convert these string arrays
into a queue
so i convert this
array into a list by calling the array
dot as list so this expression is going
to return a list
and then i'm going to
convert this normal list
into a linked list
and then going to store this linked list
into the queue of numbers
and i'm going to do exactly the same
thing for the operator array as well
converting this into a generic list
converting that generic list into a
linked list
and then storing this linked list as a
queue
so i have an operators queue and i have
a numbers queue both of them have been
stored into a queue now and then i am
using the poll method
if you remember the poll method of the
queue is used when you want to fetch the
first front element the head element of
the queue so whichever element is
sitting at the head of the queue will be
taken out the moment you call the
whole method
so i fetch the first
number from the numbers q
so in this case 4 will be fetched
here
in this variable
and after that i run a loop
on the numbers q
and i'm going to run this
particular loop till this particular
queue
is not empty if you see there's a
negation here so i am going to pick up
numbers one by one from this numbers
queue till the number q becomes empty
and inside the loop
i do this exact same poll operation for
the operations queue so this operations
queue is holding all these mathematical
operations like plus star and divide
so i'm going to pick the head of it so
in this case plus will be picked up and
will be stored in this variable called
opr
and then i am going to run a switch case
on this opr
basically as i told you in this
particular calculator application we are
supporting four operations which are
addition
subtraction multiplication and division
so i define a case for each of the
mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here
and for each case i'm initializing a
class if it's a plus sign then i'm
initializing the add class
if it's a minus sign then i'm
initializing the subtractors
for multiplication i have a class called
multiply and for division i have a class
called
divide let's have a look at what these
classes are containing
so if i go to the add class first of all
it is implementing an interface called
operate
and this operator interface has just a
single method called get results which
is accepting a variable argument array
if you remember i told you that you can
also use a var arg array this is called
a arg expression this means that this
numbers will be an array of arbitrary
length it can be a one element array it
can be a two element array it can be a
four element array or whatever you
supply
but it is still going to be a fixed
length array but the length is going to
be dependent upon how much argument you
supply to this particular method
so that is what this interface operate
is doing it just has one method declared
which is called get result which is
accepting an array of numbers so
if the add class is implementing the
operator interface then it has to
override the get result method and here
it is just doing a summation of all the
numbers which have been supplied so if
you supply four numbers it is just going
to add up those four numbers and return
the sum
and
the exact same kind of logic or similar
logic will be seen in other
operate classes so if i go to the
subtract class
it runs the exact same operation but it
subtracts the values
if i go to the multiply class
it is also implementing the operate
interface and in the get result it is
just multiplying all the values
similarly in the divide class
it is also implementing the operator
interface and it is dividing all the
numbers one by one
so it's doing pretty much the same thing
in terms of the
expression and the logic
the only difference is whether you are
using an add operation or a subtract or
multiply or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well
and let's go back to the main app now
now you also see that i've defined a
reference of operate here and each of
the switch case block
i'm assigning the object type to this
interface reference so i'm using the
concept of dynamic binding which we
talked about when we talked about
interfaces
that we can also do dynamic binding
where we can assign an object to an
interface type
and the object type will depend upon the
expression
so once we have filled that based on the
case
while
filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially
then we go to the next line outside the
switch case block which is to pick the
next
number from the queue remember we
already did one poll here
so as per this example 4 was here in
this res
and now when we do this number dot poll
again
5 will be picked up because that will be
the next head of the queue
so we pick up 5 here
and then we call operate dot get result
now this get result will be called based
on the expression which was encountered
first in the queue
again looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be plus
so the expression was plus so the
operate type object is of add type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked
and it is going to sum four and five
this rest is holding four right now
based on what i described here
numbers.poll
and this num is holding the
the second operand basically
basically 5 here so 4 plus 5 gets
evaluated here in this case
and then it again goes back here and it
checks if the number q is
now empty no it is still not empty
because we still have 3 n2
left there so
again it does the operations dot poll
and it picks up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiply sign it will go here and
it will initialize the operate interface
reference as the object of multiply
class
then coming here it will do a numbers
dot poll
and this time the numbers.poll is going
to pick up 3
so 3 will be picked up here
and then the current value of result
which is already 9 4 plus 5 was 9 the
current value of result will be updated
here so rest will be 9 here and num will
be 3 here and when you call
operate.getresult
the multiply classes get result will get
called and it will say 9 into 3
which will become 27
it will again go back here to this
particular line and it will check again
if the numbers queue is now empty no it
is still not empty because we still have
one element left
then it pulls
uh the queue of the operations
where the expression divide is present
there which is the only element left in
this particular operations queue
and since we have the opr value as
divide
this case block gets called and the new
divide class gets initialized the divide
class basically gets initialized
and
we come here and we do numbers.poll
now the last number which is available
in this queue is 2 which gets picked up
here
and then we again call operate.getresult
this time since the operate object refer
object operator reference type was of
divide class type so when we call
operate dot get result the divide
operation or the get result method of
the divide class
basically this method
will get invoked
and
it will divide the current value of
result which was
4 plus 5 9 into 3 which was 27
so it is going to divide 27
by
2 which was the last value of the
numbers dot poll it is going to execute
27 by 2 and whatever value it gets it is
going to store a value back into the
rest variable and then it is again going
to go back here
and again going to check the condition
if the numbers queue is
not empty but now the numbers q is empty
because 2 was the last element so it is
going to come out of the loop and it is
going to print the final result
that is how this whole program is
working
now let's try to see this in action and
we'll try to execute the exact same
expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
star
divide 2
and if i now hit enter
i get the value as 13.5 which is exactly
what we ran through because 4 plus 5
will be evaluated first which will
result into 9
then 9 into 3 will be 27 and 27 divided
by 2 will be 13.5 exactly
so this is how this whole program is
running where we first take the inputs
and then we divide the input into
numbers and operation arrays or in fact
queues
and once we have those queues built up
then we pick up the first number
and we keep running this loop till the
numbers q is not empty
inside the while loop at each step we
pick up the first expression or the
operator we check what is the operator
whether it is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator
and whatever kind of operator we have we
initialize the corresponding class of it
and then
we
fetch the next
value in the numbers q and then we call
the get result based on the expression
and whatever result we get from the get
result we store it back into the rest
variable so we keep updating the rest
variable at every step that's the reason
the result of 4 plus 5 gets stored in
the rest and next time you are calling
the get result for a multiply operation
here the rest value is 9 now and it says
9 into 3 again in the next time the rest
value will be updated to 27 because we
are storing the result back into the
result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lot more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs etc also
looking at or putting some conditions
around the exception handling handling
the divide by zero scenario etc which is
not here but this is just to show you
the basic idea of how you can build
simple to complex cli applications using
the core java concepts
now with that we have come to an end of
day 4 of software development i hope the
session was informative and interesting
on day 5 of software development we
raised the bars and dive deep into java
where we get to learn the advanced java
concepts and also the java enterprise
edition
if you have any queries related to any
of the topics discussed in the previous
session then please feel free to let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be happy to
resolve all your queries
until next time thanks for watching and
don't forget to subscribe to stay tuned
for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you